Hello, everybody!
Hello!
Buddy!
Welcome!
Oh, welcome!
So, um...
We have a server dedicated to our...
By the way, the sun is setting, by the way.
So...
Oh!
I'm going in!
Oh my God.
Why are you out here?
Oh, thank God.
Because there were zombies around!
I'm literally...
I ate some zombie meat, so now I have...
Wait, what do you mean?
Now I'm okay.
I can't see your heart!
Yeah, you're right, you're right.
So, um...
Yeah.
So, this might be the fastest death, because it's already night.
I mean, we could dig a hole.
In the water?
I mean, we're literally right...
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
I'm in cinematic mode here.
Okay.
We gotta find a hole.
We gotta find...
Okay.
We'll find...
We could find a village, I'm sure.
Just avoid the zombies and everything.
Hey, guys!
Welcome to our hardcore Minecraft playthrough.
Yay!
So, midnight, we're talking...
Min apparently didn't realize what it meant when I said, like, hardcore Minecraft.
We stream until we beat that.
I knew what you meant.
No, no, you were like, so what do we do if we die during the ender dragon fight?
No, no, no, I was just like...
And I was like, we restart.
Like, what do you mean, what do we do?
What do we do when we die in the ender dragon fight?
I was just like, you know, I was just like, oh my gosh, oh my god, I found a village!
Oh my god, there's a village!
Okay, okay, okay, I knew we were gonna find a village.
See, I told you.
I knew we were gonna find...
I told you.
Gamer instinct, I'm literally eating away.
No, you were like, this is literally 50-50, it was a life or death.
You were like, well, we die, we die.
No, I was totally... I know I did not say that.
I'm asleep, get your own bed, go...
I'm shutting the door, this is my home and I'm living here.
Okay, okay, I'm sleeping now too.
Oh my god, we already found beds, guys!
Yeah, we're doing so well.
It's so easy.
We already got our beds for the Minecraft.
Hardcore.
Yeah, easy.
So, we were inspired by...
Oh shit, I refreshed my game.
We were inspired by the Kai and Spice Show Speed playthrough they did months ago where they...
I don't know, have you watched the playthrough, Mint?
No, I just... I don't even know who those people are.
Okay, so I was inspired by them and then I told Mint, let's do it.
Anyway, so I was inspired, I was watching a bit of it.
And it took them like 20 plus days, by the way, Mint.
It took them 20 plus...
In real time?
Yes, in real time.
They literally, like, they would go to bed, wake up, play Minecraft, and then die.
Go to bed, wake up, play Minecraft, die.
And then they kept doing it until they beat the...
I think we're better than them.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
I was like, we must be better.
Like, we have to be better than them.
There's no way it's gonna take us...
That's why we gave ourselves one extra day.
We gave ourselves one extra day to see if we could beat Minecraft.
I think we could beat... Okay, like, where...
Do they even play Minecraft?
Do they even know anything?
Like, I don't... I don't know, that's the thing.
I just saw that it took them 20 fucking days to be there.
Wait, I need food.
Is there not food in this village?
Like, where are the food in this village?
Did you take all the food?
I'm looting!
What have you been doing this entire time?
I'm dying.
I'm literally dying right now.
What have you been doing this entire time?
I was trying to introduce the rules!
I was introducing what's going on.
Oh my god, how am I... I'm dying from fire.
Oh my god, wait, I could actually die in a sec.
You just spiked some damn food!
I'm fine, I'm fine.
You didn't even loot everything.
You're not even that great at looting.
I left you one house.
Oh, thank you.
Wow, I'm so fortunate.
Yeah, I left you a house for you, you know.
Wow.
Do you have any more food?
I only have two potatoes.
Oh, that's all they had?
Yeah, they have two potatoes and two bread.
I need more.
Trade me.
No, I'm gonna go here.
I have twelve emeralds.
I have a pumpkin seed.
How am I missing a health?
How are... because I don't fucking know.
What did you do?
I don't know.
Give me the fucking bread!
I'm eating!
This is a team game!
Get your own!
The moment I go kill myself, you have to restart the server.
And you lose everything!
You lose everything!
Look, just for yourself!
You can't eat the berries!
You cannot eat the berries!
Yes, you can!
You can eat the berries!
What do you mean you can't eat the berries?
Oh, wait, you can.
I told you!
I realized I just needed a piece of sky.
Yes!
See?
What are you collecting men in here for?
Collecting men?
What are you doing?
What the fuck are you doing?
Why are you collecting them like that?
People can see my stream and what I was doing.
They know I was not doing any of that.
Wait, can they actually... wait, did they do this themselves?
I think so.
Wait, oh, those are some freaky... freaky men.
This is a freaky village.
Yeah, this is a freaky village that you found.
Also, take their torches.
Oh, yeah, you're right, you're right.
Okay, so how do we... I forgot how to do the Ender Dragon.
It's been a while.
You're like the Minecraft expert.
I've beaten them like twice.
I was there too.
Actually, I watched a guide.
You watched a guide?
It was like, so you want to survive in Minecraft hardcore.
Kind of guide, and I watched that.
Oh my god, why am I lagging a little?
It's Minecraft.
Oh, it might be my resource packs.
Oh my god.
It could be.
I don't know.
It could be the resource packs that I downloaded.
So I wanted to download...
The reason why we were waiting was because I was downloading resource packs to try and replace...
Yeah, it was always Doki's fault.
To try and...
Okay, that is not true.
That is not true.
When has it not been true?
No, no, that is not true.
The last time we had a collab, I knew I wasn't the reason why we're late.
What, like yesterday?
Yeah, that was not my fault.
I was actually on time.
Why were we late?
I don't even remember.
Because some people...
Because of the...
Oh wait, it was my fault because I chose the Tuesday.
I chose Tuesday at 3pm.
Also, the sound doesn't sound okay now.
You're over here, okay.
Alright, so what's the plan?
Should we start mining for diamonds?
No, Doki, no!
Why not?
We have to first start...
I'm trying to steal their ore.
Are you lagging that bad?
No, I'm trying to fucking...
Cut a tree so I can get stuff.
Oh my gosh, you should have looted better.
I thought you were a gamer.
I was freaking telling...
Oh, I cared about our fans.
Because I was worried that they were confused.
You have to be able to explain things and game at the same time.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Because I wanted to be like...
Okay, my god, I didn't even put music on.
That's how angry I am.
That's why I'm angry.
There was no BGM.
It was just other silence.
I had to listen to her fucking voice.
Get used to it!
Oh my god, to fucking play this for like hours.
I'm literally gonna see you in like three days.
What do you mean three days?
However many days it is.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
So people thought that like...
You know you were on your schedule like Saturday.
People thought that we were actually gonna meet up on Saturday.
And then on my schedule it's like three different things.
How the fuck is she gonna do an off clap while she has this, this, this and that.
Sorry everybody, I made this a little whoopsie poopsie on my schedule.
Wait, so what are we supposed to do?
Okay, so first we gotta like get regular iron.
So basically, I think the best bet would be if we go into the mountains...
And we get the iron.
And we like...
Like the ones that aren't in the...
You know how you can find iron?
Not in the caves?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, so you're scared then.
I'm not scared.
You're scared.
You don't wanna...
I'm literally trying to survive.
You don't wanna dig down.
You're scared.
I'm not scared.
We need the...
Then dig down.
Straight down?
Yeah, straight down.
Why don't we need to find a mountain?
Just dig down.
Okay.
Okay, I'll dig down right now.
Yeah, do it.
Alright, hold on.
Let me make a little...
Let me make a... Hold on.
I gotta make a shovel.
Yeah, let me help you.
You want me to dig down?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, dig down.
I'm going.
Hold on.
Come on, are you fucking scared?
I'm not.
I'm trying to...
Are you scared?
Let me make a... Wait.
Oh, there it is.
Where's my shovel?
Oh, wait.
I need sticks too.
How do I make sticks?
Oh, there we go.
Alright, come on.
Alright, dig down.
You too.
I'm hoping you...
Hey, what are you doing?
Come on.
Dig down.
Your turn.
We're digging down.
Wait, I need to make a shovel too.
Oh, now you need a shovel.
Oh, yeah.
No, I don't.
I don't.
We'll just use your shovel.
Yeah, yeah, no, no.
You dig.
You have a shovel.
Yeah, go.
Yeah, okay.
Let's go.
While you do that, I'm gonna raise your volume a little bit more.
Okay, okay.
I'll talk louder.
Alright.
Keep going.
Oops.
Sorry, accident.
I don't have a pickaxe either because somebody was like...
Oh, I have one.
I have one.
I have two actually.
You wanna make me a pickaxe then?
You wanna make me one?
I don't think so.
Oh, okay.
So, I guess I don't need to dig then.
I guess I'll just use the crafting table.
You'll just use your hands.
Yeah, I'll just use my hands.
That's fine.
Use your hands.
Oh, oh, oh.
That must have been an accident too, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, you're so clumsy.
I know, I know.
You're so, so clumsy.
Oh, I can't reach anymore.
I can't reach anymore.
Oh.
I think we're safe down here.
Oh, what the hell?
How'd you get there?
I don't know.
I guess you didn't dig hard enough.
I'm digging down.
You keep digging my blocks and...
Yeah, sure, I will help.
It shows that you're too afraid to dig down.
No, no, because somebody won't let me fucking make a pickaxe.
Come here, come here, come here.
No, I'm making a pickaxe right now.
No, no, no, I'm making...
Oh, you are?
Oh, how are you making one?
How are you making one?
Because I don't...
Come here, come here.
No, I don't remember the recipe!
There you go.
I just gave you one.
I just gave you one, okay?
There you go.
No!
No, you did.
Oh, wait, you did.
I'm trying to make a fucking...
A stone pickaxe.
Why are you giving me a...
Oh, because I didn't have stone, because all I had was wood.
Come on, dig down, little baby.
I'm gonna make...
Why aren't you digging down?
I'm gonna make a stone pickaxe, because I wanna win Minecraft, but somebody here is playing around.
Wait, how do you make a...
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Oh, how do you make what?
A stone pickaxe?
Dig down.
Come on, keep digging.
I'm literally catching up.
I'm making a stone pickaxe.
I'm making a stone pickaxe right now.
I'm literally catching up to you.
Okay, I'm already further, way further down than you.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah.
I hope you drop right into lava.
I hear a zombie.
Oh, we're close, yeah.
I'm gonna go right into that first.
Oh, hey.
We literally had like a perfect run so far, and we're just ruining it.
By the way, I already got iron.
I'm done here.
Oh, you got iron?
Oh, me too.
Oh, I got a whole...
I got a whole bunch of it.
I'm already done with my job.
Alright, so furnace.
We need more iron.
Oh, not diamond.
How do I...
Oh, wait.
There's the...
We do need this though.
We need to eventually be able to craft.
Yeah, I'm making furnaces.
Oh, wait.
We need coal.
I forgot.
I forgot coal existed.
Yeah, idiot.
She doesn't know about logs, you guys.
Oh, my God.
Now, I do.
So now, I don't need to get coal.
Are you out?
Did you leave?
I have what I needed.
Why are you still doing that?
Why are you...
Why are you not digging down with me?
I thought we were gonna go find some...
I already got...
Oh, wait.
No, that's copper.
You said you wanna go find diamonds.
You didn't even get iron.
You got copper.
I guess we gotta reset the run.
Alright.
Wait, do I need to leave first?
No, I just...
I'm dying.
I'm resetting the server.
I forgot that you were...
You were down there.
Why would you forget?
Because I covered up the hole.
You tried to kill me.
And then, you literally fell into your own trap.
No, I didn't try to kill you.
I was trying to make stuff.
I was trying to make something.
So, I covered up your hole because I had to make something.
And I forgot you existed down there.
Can I go in now?
No, I need to restart the server.
Oh my god.
It's gonna take forever.
Okay, okay.
I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
That was a test run, guys.
Yeah, it was just a test run.
Even though we had a perfect setup, it would've been so good.
I had, like, the starts of iron.
I had...
We found a village that had everything we needed.
It was just too good.
It was just too easy.
I got...
I just wanted to make it a little bit more exciting.
Now, where are we?
Oh, I'm in a tree.
What the hell?
We're in a tree.
Where are you?
Oh, I see you.
There's sheep here.
Wait, where are you?
Kill him, kill him.
Alright, let's go.
I don't know if I fall.
I'm afraid of falling.
Just fucking fall.
I'm gonna...
No, I'm gonna jump into the water.
I'm gonna fucking beat up the tree real quick.
Oh my God, I'm a gamer.
Oh my God, you guys.
Oh my God, parkour civilization right here.
I jumped for the beef and I made it.
I'm gaming, I didn't lose a single heart.
Oh my God, me too.
I didn't lose a single heart either.
This is our first run, guys.
This is like the actual start of the run.
Yeah, yeah, this is where we started.
The last one, we were testing the server out.
Exactly.
She was lagging, you guys.
Yeah, I was lagging, I was lagging.
I chose a server that's closer to Mint because I figured she needed more.
So because of that, I'm ticked, sadly, I have to...
She's closer to Mint.
It's an America server.
It's so far from Canada.
Oh my God, it's so far.
It's like an ocean.
They're not even connected.
Yeah, there's like an ocean that divides me from America.
That's how far she is from me.
What the hell?
There's a jungle over here.
Wait, where are you?
In the jungle.
The mighty jungle.
The lion sleeps tonight.
Do you know the lyrics?
Yeah, it's from Lion King.
What do you mean?
Why are you just following every time I say it?
Where are you?
Wait, Doki, can we get a parrot?
What are you gonna do with the parrot?
It's just gonna die.
No, it's not.
Not if we protect it.
Oh, there's a drown here.
Wait, is this like a monument thing?
Oh, it might be.
Be careful.
Wait, what is this?
Where are you?
It's like... There's like a thing here.
Oh, I see a pirate ship!
That's where we can get iron.
What's over here?
Oh, dig for treasure?
Okay.
Wait, you found a map?
No, the people were like, dig for treasure.
I don't think they know what they're talking about.
Oh, I see a drown.
I think he's gonna come and get me.
He said this for me... possible treasure.
Oh my God, wait, maybe I can get diamond before you.
Oh, I found a buried treasure map.
It might be where mine is.
Maybe, actually.
Am I gonna die?
I'm gonna die here.
I'm not gonna do this.
Wait, where even are you?
Where did you go?
I'm at a pirate ship.
I just said.
Where is the pirate ship?
Oh, ship.
Sorry.
Oh, wait, there you are.
Okay, you were just there.
I'm in the pirate ship.
The pirate trip.
Is there anything here?
Not really.
Did you get anything?
I got some carrots.
That's good.
We need food.
Oh, whoops.
I'm gonna die.
I'm dying.
You're fine.
Don't be a pussy.
I'm dying.
I literally lost a heart.
Oh my god, this is literally a chest filled with moss and rotten meat.
I know, it's terrible.
That is terrible.
Look at this bad pirate ship you found.
This pirate ship sucks.
I know, right?
Why did you choose this spawn, Doki?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me Google a seed for us.
Best hardcore Minecraft.
Is that what you want?
I think I'm actually gonna die.
Does the little baby want an actual... Wait, how many hearts do you have?
None of your business.
There's a drown literally next to us, by the way.
Yeah, I know.
I saw him.
You're fine.
See, he even had carrots.
Punch me.
See if I live.
Oh, shit.
I'm gonna die again.
Wow, man.
How could you just die like that?
Wow.
I thought you were a gamer.
Oh, my gosh.
I can go down below now.
Now you can check.
Wait, there's bees here.
Wouldn't it be funny if there was a village right next to us?
Oh, my God.
Wait, I'm gonna see.
Wait, is there an actual village anywhere near us?
Um...
Not that I see.
Oh, so this was a bad spot anyway.
It was a bad spot.
You guys, we need a better seed than us.
That's why we died.
We were like, you know what?
This seed was pretty bad.
New seed.
We just keep dying until we get some fucking village and those ender portals next to us.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Someone in my chat was just like, VOD gang, you can skip this stream.
On to the next stream, part two.
You just go to part two at that point.
Alright, restarting the server.
Restarting.
You know, I'm gonna put text here.
How many deaths?
Is that what you're putting?
Yeah.
You're putting how many deaths for each of us, right?
Like, Doki one death, Mint one death.
Yeah.
But my death was caused by you, so...
No, no.
I guess it was Doki two deaths, honestly.
Oh, my death was caused by you, so technically it's one-to-one then.
It's one-to-one.
Alright, you can save the server.
It was one-to-one, technically, if you think about it, because my death was caused by you.
What are you talking about?
That is the ultimate cope I've ever heard of in my entire life.
Oh, yeah?
Says the person that was like, hit me, see if I die.
Who said that?
I didn't think you'd actually do it.
What do you mean?
You said hit you, so I was like, alright, okay.
Yeah, but like, you were really impressive.
If Mint says jump, I jump.
If Mint says...
If she tells me to jump off the cliff, I'll jump off the cliff.
If she tells me to hit her, I'll hit her until she dies.
Oh, another similar one.
Alright, got me by some logs.
Now I understand why it took them 20 days.
Wait, I see... I see a plains.
A savanna, that's a good place to find a village.
Oh, we can have a desert village.
Okay, I'm grabbing some wood again.
How many times will I have to grab wood for us?
For us?
Yeah, for us.
This is a team game.
I am playing Minecraft 2.
Okay, where are you?
Oh my god, there's a baby horse.
Wait, where are you?
Where did that sheep go?
Where is the savanna?
Over here.
Where's over here?
Use your eyes.
I am literally using my eyes.
I'm climbing up a fucking mountain right now.
Why are you climbing?
That's the opposite direction.
Oh, you could have said that.
You could have actually said that.
I have eyes, so I was able to see it.
Well, clearly we weren't spawning in the same... Oh, I see the savanna.
Oh, you know how I saw the savanna?
I climbed a mountain.
Yeah, but I didn't have to climb a mountain because I have better eyes than you.
Well, clearly you spawned in a better location where you could see the savanna.
Because I spawned on a tree where it was covered up by all the other trees.
I spawned in a tree too.
We have equal rights.
I don't think so.
I live in Canada.
In Minecraft, everyone is equal except the server mod.
Let me get some food for us.
Yeah, I'm killing sheep.
Me too.
I'm killing sheep and pigs.
I wish that was a taffy bar.
I'm about to kill a pig.
Oh, there he goes.
I see you.
Let's get a yoink your crafting table.
No, you won't.
Okay, usually there's villages in this area.
Okay, I'm killing the sheep now.
I mean, what good does this mean if we can't cook it?
We can literally burn trees for that.
That's the whole point.
MrBeast is now controversial, so we have to burn all the trees that he planted.
Take back what once he planted.
Take it all back.
Oh, I see another portal, actually.
Oh shit, you see another portal?
Yeah, I'm really good at seeing things.
I'm pretty sure you just have better... Oh, there's chickens!
I literally even told you my FOB...
There's so many chickens!
She asked for my FOB, guys, and I was like...
Yeah, you guys wanna know what her FOB was?
You guys wanna know?
It was at 75, and that's default.
Is it default?
Yeah, that's default.
Well, that's good.
What is yours then?
No, it's not!
I'm on 85.
I was like wondering... I was wondering if I should do it higher or not.
My chat was like, damn, lol, your FOB.
Does mine look bad?
Guys, what does your chat say about your FOB?
Oh, is it bad?
90 minimum?
I think I used to have it at that.
I think you just forgot to change it.
I think I forgot to change it when I...
Yeah, when you re-bought Minecraft.
Oh, I found an armadillo!
Wait, is this copper?
Yeah, that's copper.
Why didn't you say anything?
That's my chat's fault for not saying that.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, it's your chat's fault.
Oh, you're gonna blame your chat?
Yeah.
That's fucked.
Of course I would.
I would never drag loons.
I would never blame you guys.
Uh-oh, there might not be a village here.
Okay, I'm making... Oh, wait, this is not it.
I'm gonna make some sticks.
I'm making progress.
You're making sticks and I'm making progress.
Come on, Doki.
Oh, yeah, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
Tell me, please.
I'm searching.
I found a village.
I literally just found a village!
Oh, please.
Enlighten me.
I'm stuck in a cave.
Oh, really?
I thought you found a village.
That doesn't sound...
I did.
Okay, I'm good now.
Alright.
Look at that.
I made an advancement.
Have you made an advancement?
Okay, caveman.
You're literally the one in the cave.
I have a bed now.
What do you have?
What are beds for?
Like, you can't respond.
It's the day.
It's literally the day.
We can sleep through the night.
I accidentally... I lost my stuff because I forgot...
Like, if you mine copper and iron with a wooden pickaxe, you don't get anything.
Are you bragging?
I don't know what you did.
No, I'm blaming you for my shortcomings.
Okay, now I can craft.
Now I got copper.
Why are all the doors open?
This is weird.
Maybe they can open their own doors.
No, they don't do that.
Yes, they do.
They have their own free will.
Are you trying to say the villagers don't have rights?
Yeah.
Wow.
I need better food.
Oh wait, I have an apple.
I like how you don't even tell me where the village is.
You just left.
Oh yeah, the hay bales.
Yeah, for food.
Yeah, you gotta make the bread.
I told you I made progress.
Yeah, but this is literally a team game.
We have to make progress to get there.
Is this a team game?
I can't tell anymore.
What do you mean?
We're trying to work together to get to the fucking...
Whoa, what's that?
Oh, I saw the armadillo you found earlier.
The worthless piece of shit.
What do you mean?
What do you do with an armadillo?
What can you do with an armadillo?
You can make dog armor.
Yeah?
The dog is still gonna die if you take it out to...
No, he's not if he has the armor.
Oh wow, there's also a jungle over there.
Alright, let's see.
I think it's a jungle.
I passed your armadillo, but I still don't see you.
Just keep going.
It's pretty far actually.
Oh, I see the village.
I see it.
Oh, my food galore.
There's so many pigs.
There's so many of them.
Alright,
nice.
Well, this village is not great just because it doesn't have like a...
That's fine.
I'm just trying to get meat right now.
It doesn't have any stuff like the wood or the stonesmith people.
I'm just gonna grab some wood.
Wait, why do I need stairs for?
I'm just gonna grab wood.
I'm gonna destroy this home.
Where are you?
I'm destroying this one man's house.
He'll never be safe again.
I'm grabbing... I'm stealing their food supply.
This village is literally gonna die out.
Nice.
We deserve it.
Why would you build a village here?
Yeah, this is a terrible location.
You know what?
If I had... Do I flint?
No, I don't.
That was my previous life.
Oh, I do.
I do.
I have flint and steel.
You know what to do.
For some reason, I feel like we've done this before.
Death to the village!
Raid the village!
Raid it!
Oh shit!
I'm inside!
Oh my god.
You fucking... We're gonna die.
I'm actually gonna die.
You fucking whore.
I'm gonna die.
Oh my god.
I almost died too.
Wait.
Oh my god.
I'm actually... I'm like one and a half hearts.
Here.
I'll give you some.
Here's some.
I can't even get up.
I can't even...
Use the pickaxe you made.
I can't even... I can't even get out.
Hold on.
Dig this part.
I just need you to dig...
There you go.
Okay.
Nice.
You know, you could just...
I don't have any tools.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Let me fucking...
Let me grab some trees and build a furnace real quick.
Let me...
You can just sleep.
It's fine.
What do you mean?
I can just sleep.
Sleeping doesn't do anything regarding health.
It doesn't... Oh.
I thought I gave you food.
Hold on.
Come here.
Okay.
Wait.
Do you have bread?
You can make your own bread.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
How fortunate of me.
I gave you half of what I have.
How fortunate that I was given the privilege to make my own bread.
Time to go to sleep.
Sleep, ducky, so we don't die.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm sleeping.
Yeah.
I'm sleeping now.
Alright.
Nice.
Let me make my bread.
Good morning, Minto.
Okay.
There you go.
I got 64 bread.
Let's go.
Wow.
See?
It's still burning.
How do you make the bread?
Wait.
There's more hay here.
You didn't finish farming all of this.
Oh.
Whoops.
Oh, it's my bread now.
Yeah.
It's your bread now.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
We can't die.
This is actually a good run.
We can't die now.
Is this a good run?
Yeah.
We have all the bread in the world.
We can't die now.
Food was like the one thing I was most afraid of.
So now that we have all the food in the world, we should be good now.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to find a cave.
I have so much food.
Dig down.
Alright.
Fine.
I'll dig down.
Yeah.
Where are you?
We're gonna dig down together.
We are?
Yeah.
What do you mean?
You said you were going to go explore and I am the bread maker.
When did I say explore?
When did I say those exact words?
I am the one who does everything above ground and you do everything below ground.
Oh.
You know it'd be faster if we both did stuff together, right?
You know that would be faster, right?
We could protect each other from dying.
Alright.
Here.
Let's sit down.
Wait.
Where are you?
I'm right behind you.
Oh.
Hello.
I need stone.
Let me get some stone.
Let me...
Alright.
While you do that, I'm gonna get some cough drops real quick.
I'll be right back.
Are you good?
She's coughing, guys.
She's coughing baby.
She's like a freaking coughing baby.
Don't steal this.
What the fuck?
She can't believe she stole that from me.
She's literally AFK and she's still stealing from me.
This is messed up.
How is it possible?
What were you doing?
Why were you saying it was messed up?
I'm stealing.
I'm stealing the stone from the people.
First time?
No.
It's still messed up though.
You literally burned somebody's house down.
And this is your lie.
This is your lie?
You burned someone's house down and this is your lie?
Yeah.
You cared about, like, somebody's stone.
Rather than a villager burning to death.
I'm having a change of heart.
I'm literally having like a...
You're changing?
What's that movie where that guy goes through the Christmas ghosts?
Oh my gosh.
A Christmas story?
A Christmas story.
Yeah, it's happening to me.
Yeah, but these are Scrooge and, like, the villagers are Little Timmy.
Yeah, the ghosts of Christmas past, present, future are all coming to me.
Oh my god.
You're stealing the stone.
And Little Timmy is not gonna make it for Christmas.
Oh, it's a Christmas carol.
You didn't correct me on... Yeah, it's sad.
Which is... Well, there's... Okay, well, Christmas people need to be more original then.
Oh, but... Christmas, so, like, are we wrong?
Yeah, it's basically the same.
Yeah, it's literally the same thing.
Can I make anything out of the mossy tree?
A Christmas story is the one with the leg lamp?
What the fuck is... What?
The what?
Someone was like, that's the leg lamp.
I'm like, what the fuck does that mean?
A leg lamp?
Leg.
They said leg.
Leg... Leg mod?
Someone was like, why don't you have a mini map mod?
I was like, I'm not making this game easy.
No, what are you talking about?
We're gaming.
Yeah, we're gaming.
Alright, I'm ready.
Are you ready now?
Uh, yeah, probably.
Alright, let's go.
I'm gonna actually cut the... Get more wood just in case something happens to us.
I wanna go see the jungle.
That's not part of the plan, Mint.
The jungle has nothing to do with the Ender Dragon.
What if there's pandas?
The jungle has nothing to do with the dig.
It's time to dig.
You know your place.
Alright, we dig.
Okay, we're digging for real though, right?
Yeah, yeah, for real this time.
No more...
I think we have to find a way to... We have to dig in like a ladder.
No, we don't.
Or like a staircase.
We have to come back out.
We can just... We need... We're not gonna go back to the same area.
We get our stuff and then fucking dig up.
Oh, typical Mint.
Letting me do all the work.
Hold on, I don't have a shovel.
We don't need a shovel.
No, we don't.
Just jump down.
You have a compass.
You dig mine and I'll dig yours.
Alright.
We're so efficient.
This is teamwork.
This is real teamwork, guys.
I feel like digging our own hole is a lot faster than what we're doing.
Oh, hold on.
Mine just broke.
Oh my God.
Here, let me make here...
Here, put your crafting table here.
Okay, thank you.
Wow, it feels like...
Oh, hey, coal.
Nice.
Okay.
We got coal.
Nice, nice.
Okay, we got coal now.
Oh my God, this is a lot of coal.
Nice, you have a...
Oh, hey, what about digging my hole?
I'm sorry, coal is just much more important.
I'm still digging coal out right now.
Okay, I'm digging coal.
I'm digging coal.
We're digging coal.
We're making progress.
Alright.
Great job.
Oh, wait, we're synced.
Oh, never mind.
We're synced almost.
We're almost synced.
Why is yours a little faster than mine?
I don't know.
Maybe I'm just more efficient than you.
It's because I'm like...
Oh.
It's because I'm clicking you.
I'm clicking you instead of holding.
Yeah, I'm still...
Oh, there we go.
Yeah.
Come on, come on.
Dig me.
Oh, that's what it's called.
That's copy.
Yeah.
Alright.
Hey, don't hop.
Oh yeah, what's going on?
Oh, we're synced up again.
Where's our cave?
Where the fuck is our cave?
There has to be at least one cave.
I hear a zombie.
Oh.
We could get the diamonds.
Wait, I think we might be close to that.
Oh, I hear a zombie to our left.
I hear a zombie, yeah.
Yeah, maybe we should dig left.
Our left?
Wait, that's our right?
Are your earbuds on there?
There you go, there you go, there you go.
No, I think your earbuds is wrong.
This is left.
Kill him!
Where is he?
Oh my God, I can't even tell.
Oh my God, I might die, I might die.
You gotta kill him, I might die.
I actually might die, I actually might die.
You have to kill him.
You have to!
I'm bleeding you.
What do you mean you bled me?
You did not did it!
I was literally fighting him.
You were in front of me.
What do you mean I was fighting him?
If I had attacked him, I would have killed you.
You hesitated.
No, I didn't.
You literally had to kill me.
If I had attacked him, I would have attacked you and you would have died faster.
You literally had a chance to fucking hit.
I saw you hesitate.
I saw you look at him.
I was attacking!
You looked at him before you attacked him.
That was your fault.
That was your...
I'm blaming that on you.
That's a mid-death number three right there.
Wait, are you saying mid-death number three?
Why am I at three?
You know why.
You...
Doki 2.
What do you mean Doki 2?
Doki is coping.
You literally...
I've never explored...
Okay, you go first then.
When we're at a cave, you go first.
I...
What are you talking about?
You go first.
I literally went first and then I attracted the baby zombie.
We didn't even have any iron for a shield.
I went first.
It's all on you.
How is that on me?
I went first and I was like...
Alright, there's the cave.
I could hear it because I was like...
Oh, turn left.
There's a cave on the left side.
And then I turned...
I dug the cave hole for us.
And then I went to explore first.
I went to brave the wild for you.
All I hear is...
Okay.
Anyway, you log in now.
This is good.
This is a good biome.
Alright, time to hit the trees again.
Hit the trees.
Hitting the trees.
Alright, what if we get a shield before we dig down?
Okay, yeah.
That sounds like a better idea.
Why didn't you come up with the idea earlier?
I...
You know, my genius hits me in funny ways.
Did chat tell you that?
No.
I knew that because I watched the video on how to prepare for...
How to prepare for Minecraft hardcore.
Oh, so you cheated.
So you cheated before the stream.
How is research cheating?
So you researched...
Oh, no.
It is cheating.
It is.
You're trying to find the most optimal route instead of, you know, letting it happen.
No, did I still have to do it all on my own?
It's still my own skill work.
Yeah, Ms...
Let's go to the jungle.
Yeah, the jungle probably wouldn't have killed us.
Yeah, did the video tell you to go to the jungle?
Did it tell you to go to the jungle with the most optimal route?
The jungle probably has really great secrets.
Like what?
I don't know.
That's why we...
I don't know their secrets.
We could've gone to...
You don't fucking know the secrets.
You watched the video.
The video was not gonna tell us everything.
The video does not hold your hand.
Then what the point was the video for?
It's a video guide.
Where are...
Oh, there you are.
Come over here.
I see you.
Oh, there's a fucking cow.
This is the first time I saw a cow.
Fucking...
Eat up this cow.
In my hands.
I'm so tired of chopping trees.
I'm so...
It's Minecraft.
It's literally Minecraft.
Just get used to it.
I'm so...
I'm so tired of punching trees.
This is literally what you do in Minecraft.
I'm so...
I'm so over this...
These fucking trees.
This wasn't your idea.
So it's been 44 minutes, but Min's volume okay so far.
Okay, I just didn't think that Min would cause me to die so many times.
Guys, can you believe this?
This coping is absolutely ridiculous.
I think the fall really did her in.
She's just...
Oh, I just killed this sheep's...
Killed this sheep's mom right in front of him.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Little baby sheep just ran up to his dead mom.
It's so sad.
Oh my god.
It's like a Disney movie right there.
I know.
I just caused...
I just made the Lion King.
You just caused Bambi.
You're welcome, everybody.
Oh, the Lion King?
Yeah, because it's a better movie.
No, it's a better movie.
Are you trying to say Bambi is not a good movie?
I'm just saying...
Can we agree that the Lion King is a better movie than Bambi?
I guess if you're a furry.
Yeah, I'm in.
That's your opinion.
That's a certified Doki Bird opinion.
I wonder if there's any villages.
I'm searching.
I'm getting...
Alright, there has to be another village, right?
Usually, this biome is good.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, you know about all that, too?
Wow, she's a game.
Yeah, she played a lot.
Alright.
I'm digging.
I'm punching more trees.
I'm punching so many trees.
Alright, I'm gonna look for a village, too.
I'm running out of...
We need to get food soon, too.
I know.
Well, I have...
I have...
Some raw meat.
Yeah, I do, too.
But I think I'd rather just find a village and, like...
Get, uh...
Steal their food and pillage them.
Yeah, just steal the food and pillage them.
It's just...
Why do our own work when we can rob others of their work?
I know!
They already did the hard part.
Yeah, exactly!
That's what pillaging is for.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, look at the Vikings.
Oh, there's some coal here.
I mean, the Vikings knew what's up.
We just...
Let's just ignore all the other bad stuff they've done.
But, like, other than that, they thrived.
They had the right idea.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, I'm advancing.
Are you sure there's...
I'm fucking trying to find a village.
So am I, and I found other things along the way.
And you dug a fucking rock.
Congratulations.
I got coal for us so we could cook our meal.
I mean, we have trees.
Trees do the same thing with less resources.
No, it's actually more resources.
With less effort getting the resources.
We're at the end of the...
There's a really big cave here.
Oh, shoot!
It's okay, you'll be fine.
I am trying to find a village.
I don't think I'm gonna be fine.
Oh, shit.
Okay, Mint, just die now so we can restart this.
All I wanted was the coal.
I will know she lives here now while I try to find a village.
I think I'm good.
Okay, good.
I'm far, far.
What is far, far?
I kept going forward.
You went into the cave, I went forward.
Wait, did you see me go into the cave?
No.
Then how do you know where I am?
Because I saw you and then you disappeared.
I assumed something happened to you.
I'm almost out of food.
Or out of... wait.
Okay, I'm gonna have to eat the raw beef.
Eat it.
Just cook the raw beef.
You have the coal.
You have rock.
Where is the...
Oh, you're right.
What do you mean?
You literally advanced to the stone age.
Is this terracotta?
I think I'm the luckiest gamer ever.
Wait, why are we at terracotta?
Where?
It's terracotta.
Wait, no.
What is this yellow sand?
Red sand?
Yeah, it's terracotta sand.
Yeah.
Why is there fucking terracotta?
I don't know.
Or mesa.
Oh, the mesa biome.
Not ideal.
Not ideal, because I'm here for the fucking village.
Bad spawn.
Bad seed.
Hate this seed.
If only somebody didn't fucking protect me from the zombie... the baby zombie.
Did you say didn't protect you?
If only somebody...
If only someone did not protect you.
Oh yeah, sorry.
I mean somebody did protect me from the baby...
I'm already delusional.
It's been like an hour already.
I'm already... I'm already done.
We haven't made... We've made zero progress.
We haven't even...
We can't get past to the... to the... to the cave section yet.
Where is the village?
I'm still... I'm still...
Oh, it's okay.
I found... I found like a corrupted nether portal.
At least we got that.
That's good.
We're gonna die.
The sun's gonna go down and we're gonna die for real.
We mean we're gonna die.
Oh, okay.
Actually, I am gonna build my furnace.
I'm gonna have real food.
I don't... It's not even... The sun is still up still.
Nevermind, I don't have enough stone.
Okay, I found a... There's stone all around you!
Where are you?
How do you know there's stone all around me?
I thought you said you dropped into a cave.
No, I've... I've got out of there.
I've been searching for a village.
Oh my God, at least I got golden carrots.
How the hell?
Oh, from the...
The corrupted portal, yeah.
Oh my God.
Yeah, well, I got my food.
I'm gonna create my house in here.
Maybe.
Okay, furnace.
Furnace.
Is that your new house?
Is this where you're gonna live now?
Yeah.
Why do you act like you know where I am?
It's freaking me out.
I mean, I can see you.
Where?
Yeah, I can see you right now.
What am I doing?
You're freaking trying to make a furnace.
No, I made the furnace.
Give me a CV, you're full of shit.
No, I saw you make that furnace.
No, you didn't.
Yes, I did.
Okay, what am I doing right now?
Right now?
Yeah.
You're just walking around.
No, I'm not.
You're so full of shit.
You...
You got paranoid for a second.
You got paranoid.
Yeah, but you are just a liar.
You can't gaslight me for too long.
I call you out.
What are you doing then, huh?
I'm making food and I'm preparing for the night.
The sun is... Oh, it's going down.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, it's going really way down.
It's going way down.
Oh, this is a little bad.
Yeah.
What do you mean one of us, huh?
What are you doing?
I'm digging.
I'm making a little hole.
What are you doing?
I'm doing the same thing.
Uh -huh.
I doubt it for some reason.
It's because I'm in the water now.
I'm doing the same thing.
Are we just going to spend the night in the hole?
Is that what we're...
I don't want to.
I think I can make a bed because I got some...
Wait, let's see.
Oh, I can make a bed.
Wait, how many do you need for a bed?
I forgot.
Three wool.
Okay, let's see if I can do this in time before the...
Before they come in.
I'm asleep.
I'm ready for bed.
Okay, I'm asleep too.
Okay.
Before the zombies get here, do it before the zombies come up.
I'm asleep.
Okay, thank God.
Alright, everything is fine, guys.
Everything is fine, guys.
Everything is fine.
We know what we're doing.
Yeah.
One of us knows what we're doing.
Guess which one it is.
I made a bed first.
I'm just saying.
But your initial plan was to dig a fucking hole.
You literally was like, I'm going to dig a hole.
I made a hole in the mountain.
In the side of the mountain.
What are we going to do in the side of the mountain?
What are we going to do there?
What does it benefit?
I'm finding coal.
I already have coal.
How many?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
You have to count your coal.
Because I'm in front of coal right
now in the blocks in front of me.
You can't just count what's in your inventory?
Oh my God.
I'm literally in front of coal right now.
Okay.
I'm got to be in the stone age so I can farm this.
Oh yeah, watch this.
We should probably meet up.
Coal.
Woah.
Look at all this coal in front of me.
Wow.
Guys.
How do I get out of this?
Alright, first one to find the village has to tell the coordinates to the other person.
Okay.
I'm going to be lazy then.
I'm not going to do anything.
Oh yeah, you're going to have to travel to me.
Yeah, okay.
Would you rather travel?
I could just...
If I find the village...
I might find it first.
If I find the village first, you have to fucking find me.
And I could just sit on my ass just waiting for you at the village.
No, you would have to gather everything at the village.
No, I don't have to.
No, I don't.
Why do I have to?
This is a team effort.
Why did you find the village?
What do you mean?
Is it only my job to find villages?
Yes, it's a team.
Oh, what happened?
It's a team game.
We got to find the village together.
Oh, and now you want to find it together, huh?
Oh yeah.
No, I said the first person to find a village...
gets to make the other person travel all the way there.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, I found so much coal.
Me too, I found a lot of coal.
I've just been mining coal.
It would be a shame if one of us dies after all this hard coal I just mined.
We're gonna live, we're gonna live.
Right, everybody?
Oh shit, I almost died.
We're all gonna live, right?
We're all gonna live!
I think if we die...
Someone...
We have to have a chat sacrifice.
We ban one person?
We ban a person, yeah.
For every death.
You can't unban them though.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I found some iron!
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, where am I anymore?
I don't even know where I am anymore.
I don't even know where I am.
Oh, I found iron, but it's in the water.
So that's too much effort.
Hey, come on.
Come on, you gotta put in the effort.
I'm gonna mine something that's not in the water.
Did I get it?
Oh my god, I'm walking backwards now.
I'm back to the mesa biome.
Where is the mesa biome anyway?
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
Well, guess you'll never know.
Okay, I made it out with one single iron.
Oh, I found a village.
What, really?
I don't believe you.
No, I literally found a village.
I literally see it right...
Wait, is that a village?
Or is that a temple?
Oh, it's a temple.
I found a temple, yeah.
Wait, is the temple better?
No, well, I mean...
You can get stuff in there.
Oh wait, there's like traps there.
Right?
Yeah, well, there's... Okay.
I wanna... I have to show you how to do it, or else you'll die.
Yeah, I think I'm gonna die.
Oh, you are gonna die?
Okay.
I think I'm gonna die from TNT.
Well, I guess, good luck trying to find this temple.
I don't even know where you are.
Exactly.
I think I'm far away from you.
I think you went a different direction than me.
I think so, too.
You never saw the Mesa biome.
No.
I'm still in the... What's it called, biome?
The what biome?
The sand?
The desert?
I never... Wait, there's a desert biome?
Oh my god, I went too far.
It's not a temple, guys.
It's not a temple.
Wait, you never...
Okay, I definitely went too far.
Where did you go?
I don't know.
I went to a place where there's a desert biome, and I never left.
How do I get around this?
Okay.
We should have just died.
Our other seas were so much better.
We had...
We had actual villages, like, within seconds.
We had actual good seed, and then Mint fucked it up.
And then she fucked it up for the rest of...
Yeah, you!
Oh, I found a jungle.
Did you ever find a jungle?
No.
I found, like, an above-ground mineshaft.
Oh, yeah, you're definitely in the Mesa.
Don't go in there.
Don't do it.
I found a real village.
I found...
Now I'm actually for real.
I found a village.
It's in front of the...
It's in front of the above-ground mineshaft.
Wait, what's the key to find coordinates?
What?
To show coordinates.
What is it?
Alright, I'll give you my coordinates.
Wait.
Okay, there you go.
Oh, I got obsidian!
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Alright, you gotta come over to me.
You gotta leave that jungle.
A deal's a deal.
You gotta leave.
A deal's a deal!
No!
I don't want chocolate!
I wanna fucking kill the ender dragon!
What if that includes...
Oh, yeah, the two-for-one deal.
You get chocolate and an ender dragon.
Yeah, exactly.
I would be surprised if we would make it to the ender dragon on this seed.
I think we can do it.
Alright, get over here!
Get out of the fucking jungle!
Hold on, and I'm looking around.
Uh-oh, this goes to a dark wood.
I swear to God, if you die after I try...
I've worked so hard getting here.
I swear to God.
Wait, where are you at?
You didn't even send me your coordinates, you idiot!
My coordinates is...
Type it in the chat!
X -471.3 I'm not gonna pay attention to this.
Alright, someone in the chat's gonna type this out.
X-471.336 X-471.336 X -471.336 Alright, someone in the chat will type that out.
Your chat's smart.
Oh, she's quite smart, you guys.
I'm getting more...
Oh, this is actually good if I can get some bamboo.
Bamboos are good.
Where the fuck are you gonna do a bamboo?
It's wood!
You don't need wood!
There's so much wood around us!
Like, what do you need more wood for?
It's easy wood!
Oh my God, you don't need more wood.
You don't.
I watch the video.
And how come after watching the video, we died four times?
Or three times?
Okay, what are the secrets?
Aren't you supposed to tell me what the secrets are?
Aren't you supposed to help as a teammate?
We have to make shields.
So we gotta get iron.
Okay.
Find iron in the village.
Loot them for all they're worth.
I am trying to find iron.
What was the coordinates, guys?
Oh my God, the little babies are fighting.
471.
471?
Seriously?
Oh my God.
411.
Your chat isn't even typing the right coordinates.
Negative 411.
Oh my God, I took a fucking screenshot.
411.
Oh wait, it was 71 because I moved.
Oh my God.
Negative 410.744.
278.330.
I forgot I can move.
Oh, X is negative?
Oh my God.
That's like the first coordinate.
How did you get confused with the X?
It's the first thing I read.
You have a bed, right?
Yeah, I have several beds.
I'm literally in a village.
Type in chat, it's easier.
No, she has to work for it.
Oh, there's a cat here.
She doesn't want to work as a team, you guys.
If I die, it's all Doki's fault.
Yeah, I fucking found the village for us.
And we had a deal.
I found the village before and you blamed me.
So I guess whoever finds the village first is the person...
No, I blamed you for not fucking protecting me.
I hope we die in this run.
I'm going to fucking jump off the cliff right now.
And we're going to restart this.
You're going to get to the village.
And I'm going to get that cork gun.
You'll make it a spectacle.
All the villagers will be watching you.
Don't do it, don't do it, don't do it.
Wait, you guys, what was the coordinates again?
What were the coordinates again?
I got us a ton of hit.
I'm eating, I'm having dinner.
At twilight.
471, 304.
I have so much worthless shit in my inventory.
Let's sleep, can we sleep?
Sleep, please, before the zombies come.
You're not asleep, you're not asleep.
You're not asleep.
Maya, I'm working so hard for this group.
I have so much resources right now.
Oh yeah, what?
What do you have?
I have meat.
I have lots of stone.
I have lots of food.
I have lots of coal.
Yeah, do you have iron?
I have one iron.
Lots of resources.
Well, how many iron do you have?
I don't need iron.
I have a golden...
I have a golden pickaxe.
I have a golden pickaxe with mending on it.
I have a golden...
It's literally the same as iron.
It's the same as iron.
It has the same stats as iron.
No, it doesn't.
It breaks sooner.
Not mine, because it has mending on it.
Okay, you're going to get experience.
I want to see that happen.
I bet it's going to last longer than your fucking iron pickaxe.
It actually will.
I want to see you dig down with that thing and be like...
Oh no, it has mending though.
It does.
That's right, it does.
Yeah, the mending doesn't do shit unless you have...
It doesn't do shit unless you have ways to...
Like an experience bar.
Exactly.
I'll wait until it's night time.
In the cave, huh?
In the cave, exactly.
Where the fuck are you?
I'm in the mesa biome.
I'm almost there.
Oh my god.
I'm going to make sure you get here, and then I'm going to jump off this roof.
I think I went too far.
You were at 400?
Yeah, negative 410.
But it was like 300.
I think I went too far.
Oh my god, chill out.
We are just stuck together as a team.
You walked away first!
You can't say that when you literally walked away first.
You literally...
You started off by walking away from me.
No, I'm just...
I get things done.
I'm ready to go.
Oh yeah, you get things done?
Where was the village that you found?
I have found two villages so far, and you found literally one.
Okay, get off your high horse.
You didn't find that village.
Yes, I did!
I found all villages so far, except this one.
Yeah, the hardest one.
You got the easy...
Yeah, because you wandered off first, so of course you'd find the easy villages first.
That's like, you know, when you kill a level 1 player...
You basically did like a level 1 strat.
And I...
I was doing a level 30 area.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Who told you that this biome would have a village?
Oh, every biome has a village.
Except for snow.
No, actually no, snow does.
Never mind.
Every biome has a village.
Yeah, but this one usually has a village.
Yeah, what's the percentage?
What's the percentage?
I don't know, I just have a magic mind.
Oh, so you're just...
You're basing it off of...
Not even science, off of magic.
That's not even science.
You're not even basing it off of science.
It's off of belief.
Yeah, my belief is what I know.
You believe in the Minecraft gods.
I believe in magic.
In a young girl's heart.
She believes in the heart of the cards, guys.
The heart of the cards.
I literally own Exodia, okay?
Oh my god, where the fuck are you?
I'm coming!
No you're not!
I'm just waiting here.
I don't even need to do anything anymore.
Did you get everything from the village?
Yes, I got everything.
Did you get all the torches?
Yes, I got all the torches, yes.
What else did you get?
I got all the hay.
What else was there?
What was in the boxes?
It was nothing.
It was books, it was...
Books and...
What's in my inventory?
I don't even know.
Oh my god, it's not even this biome.
What do you mean it's not even this biome?
It's a sand biome one.
Oh, did you go to that nether thing?
Yeah, I did.
I did.
Okay.
Is she telling the truth, chat?
I did.
I want a different bed.
I want a green one.
There's greens here.
I know, I'm grabbing them.
Oh, you're here?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I see you.
Alright, are you ready?
I left some hay for you.
Oh my god, this guy is fucking the sheep.
What?
Oh, okay, they're done.
I'm glad I wasn't here to witness that.
We're in New Zealand.
What?
I'm sorry, New Zealand.
Hey, you didn't get all the torches.
There's literally torches in here.
There's torches all around.
I left them for you.
Did you get all the torches?
And you said, yep, I got all the torches.
I left them for you.
You're a liar.
You're lazy.
You were here for so long.
No, I was not lazy.
I left them because I was being a considerate teammate.
I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna leave these torches for a minute.
I bet she'll need them too.
You didn't get any of them, did you?
No, I did.
I have 50 torches in my inventory.
50 torches?
Yeah.
I have 51.
Chat, is this real?
52, 53.
You don't deserve any of these torches.
I'm taking them back.
I'm taking all of them back now.
You deserve them.
You can put all of them in the caves then.
We gotta get iron before we go into the caves.
No, we don't.
We just go in the cave to get iron.
Don't we need to get the iron so that...
No, we don't.
I believe in us.
I don't.
We died two times.
One time was in the cave.
One time.
The other time I slipped.
You slipped?
Oh, so finally it's her fault.
She finally took the blame.
I slipped because you didn't warn me about the giant...
I think we gotta get some iron.
Where are you?
Where did you go?
Kill the iron golem?
He'll kill us first.
We're too...
Wait, no.
Not if we stand up and kill him.
Like, stand on these pillars.
We need...
What's it called?
What?
We need armor.
No, we don't.
Yes, we do.
We'll find armor in the fucking caves.
Why are you so scared?
Why do you mean we need...
We'll find it in the caves.
Do you think armor just grows in caves?
No, we find the iron to make the armor in the caves.
Why are you so scared?
Because we've died three times.
Yeah, but that's not my fault.
You guys...
I think we...
I feel like we need like a poll.
Who's in the right here?
What kind of poll?
I feel...
You feel...
This is the...
This is the run.
If we die in this run...
Everyone will make fun of us.
We...
I don't want them to make fun of us.
It will take us 20 days.
Where are you?
Where did you go?
I'm gathering...
I'm gathering torches.
Okay, are you ready?
Okay, we can head straight and see if we bump into a mountain.
Does that satisfy you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you need bread?
Eventually.
No, just take the bread now.
Here, I'm gonna throw it at you.
I'm gonna make it ring.
Make it ring!
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, did you not mean to throw it at me?
I accidentally threw like the entire...
That's fine.
I have another stack.
Yeah, don't worry about it, everybody.
We're good.
Okay.
I believe in us.
This is the run.
Wouldn't it be funny if we find...
If we find...
Frogs before we find...
Iron?
Oh, that's the temple you were talking about, right?
No, that's a different temple.
Oh.
Oh, yeah, teach me how to do this.
Yeah, yeah, I can teach you.
Okay, it's really delicate though, okay?
Okay.
Do you want me to be in there?
Do you want me to go inside?
You can watch from a distance.
Oh, I can watch from above.
There might be someone in here, so...
Get your stuff out.
Alright, I'll watch from here.
I'm giving you cinematic mode right now.
Alright, hold on, I need my torches.
Okay, I'm gonna torch this up a little bit.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm watching.
Okay, I like to start from the one over here.
Can you see?
Yeah, yeah, I can see.
You can?
Alright, so I like to come in slowly.
Okay, so this is where...
Yeah.
You have to start making your...
Okay.
And what happens?
And then I get to the bottom and I win.
And I get all the treasure.
Okay.
But you have to disable the button before you do anything.
Did you get the button?
No, I'm making my way to the bottom.
Wait, can you dig some of the parts above us?
So I can have a better view?
No, I can't do that.
But I can't see anything.
You'll see.
Hold on, can you see?
Wait, I'm almost there.
I'm almost there.
No, I can't.
There's literally...
Okay!
Oh, yeah, you can't see.
Hold on, I'll come back up.
Okay, just dig around here.
So I can have like a view.
You can come in now, actually.
Oh wait, did you get it?
So we need to put a bed in here.
Oh, armor trim!
Okay, so a zombie might fall here.
So I'm gonna...
What do you mean a zombie might fall?
Because it's night time.
Okay, I'm asleep.
A zombie might have fallen into our heads.
Oh, enchanted!
Oh, a sata!
Oh, we need gunpowder.
I'm just gonna grab gunpowder for the sake of it.
Oh, we need string?
Um, I don't know.
I'll grab some bones.
Actually, we do.
We need to make a bow and arrows, probably.
We don't need copper, right?
No.
Okay, I'm getting that out.
Uh...
I'll take the string.
Alright, I think I have too much stuff.
What's the fire charge for?
Will we need that?
No.
I don't think so.
Okay, I'm gonna dig my way out of here.
There's stairs.
There's literal stairs.
I've created.
Where?
Actual stairs.
No, you didn't.
Yes, I did.
You didn't.
You have to keep creating them.
Exactly.
I'm trying to create the stairs for us.
Just place blocks.
Oh my God.
Like that.
I did it.
Yeah, you did it.
Thank you.
Taking my torches back.
There's a creeper in front of us, by the way.
No.
And he's like, oh wait, he disappeared.
Oh no, he's over there.
He walked away.
Alright, get over here.
Come on.
We gotta find your iron.
Where's the creeper?
That's a cactus, idiot.
Looking for you.
Yeah, you wanna call me an idiot again?
You wanna go up to this cactus?
Go up to the cactus.
Come on.
Kill him.
Why are you not doing anything?
He's aggravated.
Good job.
You did nothing.
You did absolutely nothing.
You're a coward.
You're a little chicken.
A coward would've ran away.
I was there.
I'm taking two steps back every two seconds.
I was a journalist.
I'm here to record.
I mean, I...
I covered wars, you know.
What war?
What was your favorite war?
The war...
The Great Creeper War of 2024.
That was my favorite.
I think that's the temple.
A mini temple, right?
There's no such thing as a mini temple.
Wait, but you could dig under that.
Oh, that thing.
That is just a water fountain.
I think this is another temple.
Let's see.
You know what would be easier?
We just dig down.
Wait, what's wrong with this one?
I think that's the door.
I think you just spawned in incorrectly.
Dig down.
You want us to restart to succeed?
You're the one who suggested it!
You're the ones like, you know what's easier?
Digging down.
Why don't you go in?
What do you mean?
Do you want to do that?
There's nothing important there.
Yes, there is.
I'm going to watch you do it now.
Let's restart to succeed.
That's fine.
No, you have no confidence in yourself.
Let's restart to succeed.
You think I saw what you were doing?
What are you talking about?
I was doing the same exact thing.
I couldn't see what you were doing.
All I could see was this.
Oh, you said you could see.
I could see until you went down.
Come on, scaredy cat.
Come on, come on.
You know what?
This run was going on for too long anyway.
No, you got this.
Just dig stairs.
Dig stairs and make sure nothing touches the button.
That's all you got to do.
Yeah, yeah.
Are you scared?
No, I'm not scared.
I just think that I know I'm going to fuck it up.
There might be iron in there.
What are you doing?
I'm digging stairs.
What do you think I'm doing?
Oh, okay.
I couldn't tell.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because that was what my perspective was too.
Oh, you disappeared.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now you know how I felt when I...
I'm too far from the hole.
Should it be like here?
Yeah, you got to like...
Kind of be on the inside of it.
Kind of remember how my stairs were?
No.
Good guys.
This is what I have to deal with.
My gold pickaxe died.
Okay, come back up, Doki.
My gold pickaxe broke.
Let's just keep going.
How long did it last, Doki?
It lasted...
Like 10...
Yeah, I know.
Oh,
we found a village.
Okay, nice.
Oh, there's a cave next to it.
Yeah, I was going to say, it's right next to a cave.
Yeah, we could just...
Oh my god, we could.
If we can find some iron.
That's all we need, right?
That's all we need, yep.
These villages suck.
I know, these sand villages are so poor.
No wonder they live in the desert.
I got nothing here.
I just get bread and books.
It's like they're focused more on like survival and water.
I know.
Than actually having anything.
It's like they hate items, but they just, you know, only think about...
Like, you know, the bare necessities to win.
Yeah, exactly.
It's ridiculous.
Oh, I got a lot of bread though.
Yeah, there's a lot of bread in this village.
That's all they do.
They just want food.
Yeah, what is up with that?
What's wrong with them and food?
I don't understand.
I don't get it.
It's like they're losing...
Oh wait, there's sheep too.
Okay, there are two sheeps.
There's two sheeps.
There's one sheep.
Oh, I didn't think that way.
Oh wait, I have a saddle.
Oh, you got it.
Nice.
Where's the camel?
He's around.
There he is.
Okay.
Can we both ride it?
Oh my god, we can.
We can.
Wait.
Do we have to befriend the camel?
No, we can just ride it.
Alright.
Oh yeah.
You're driving it.
Wait, how do we change POV again?
F5.
Oh my god, look at us.
Alright.
We don't need a water bucket.
We can just use a boat and drop into the cave.
Oh, that's true.
But what about a camel?
He would die.
Wait, jump down the cave with a camel.
Will we die with him?
Okay, time.
This is a science experiment, everybody.
Does he act like a boat?
This is a really important question, everybody.
This is a really important question.
This is really important.
Don't land on the lava.
Do not land on the lava.
You guys, all I see is 07s.
I'm not seeing anyone telling me an answer.
Yeah, we need to know.
Is the camel like a boat?
What if we jump down with a camel?
And we do MLG gaming and we get off the camel before it hits?
Do we get the same fault?
Does physics work?
Camel is not a boat.
Camel is not boat.
You know we would've done it if they didn't say anything.
Whoa!
They all wanted to watch the science experiment.
They were all curious about the science experiment we're doing.
This camel is so fucking slow.
Why did we waste our saddle on this camel?
Because we wouldn't ever get a...
Let's be honest, we would never get a...
Oh wait, I can jump.
They're like a horse.
Yeah, they're pretty nifty.
Oh my god, I can jump.
What's the point of having camels in Minecraft?
They're cute, I think.
Do they do anything?
Oh, they can swim.
They cannot swim.
No, they cannot.
The camel was gonna drown.
I'm going over to this nether portal.
I'll be back.
I'm taking the camel with me.
To the nether portal?
Yeah.
The camel keeps running away.
He doesn't want to go.
I'm heading over.
Here I am.
I thought we were trying to find a mountain.
Yeah, we need to find one.
We just need to find iron.
We might as well go this way.
Follow me and the camel.
Hold on, I'm making bread.
I have so much bread.
Why do you need more bread?
I just want to make bread.
I'm running out of space.
Wait, don't push me.
Don't push me.
I have all the power.
Look at this.
What is that?
I got golden armor now.
I thought you said gold sucks.
It does, but it's all I got.
Let's go onward.
You know you can run.
Just run with the camel.
Okay, you do it.
Come on, here we go.
That's running?
Actually, he's pretty fast for a camel.
Wait, he can't swim.
No, he can.
Just walk.
And then we just climb back on.
What do you mean climb back on?
You climb back on.
Oh my god.
Just keep climbing back on.
Keep going.
We're almost there.
Okay, we need to sleep.
Time to sleep.
Good night everybody.
Why is the camel walking back?
He'll be fine.
He's in the water.
That's right, you can never leave camel.
You're part of our gang now.
That's a mountain.
We're still in the desert.
We might find some though, let's go check.
In the desert?
Maybe, I don't know.
Oh my god.
We're never gonna leave this god forsaken land.
There's no iron here.
There isn't, it's just sand.
I see, I saw some other stuff in there.
No you didn't, it's just sand.
Come here, come here.
I saw, I really did.
No you didn't, you're just seeing things.
I don't see it.
You gotta take your meds again.
You haven't taken your meds.
Get over here.
We can look at the side of this mountain.
It's not even a mountain, it's just sand.
It's a car, I saw a car.
We gotta get out of sand land.
Okay, okay.
Well if you would slow down.
Oh my god, you're literally faster than this camel.
You're literally...
Wait I wonder, you should run.
Run as the camel and see if I can catch up.
Wait, how do I run?
Do I just press space bar?
No, it's...
Like, you're running.
Like, you're normal running.
No, that's shift.
Why can't you run?
Yeah, shift.
No, shift is crouch.
Oh, no I have my keybinds different.
Oh my god, he's sitting down for me.
He's just surfing.
You know, he's like surfing on the land.
Wait, what?
I'm on top of him.
He's like sitting down while surfing on the land right now.
What?
Oh my god, it's like we're surfing.
What are you talking about?
I think you're lagging.
No, we're literally surfing.
We're sand surfing.
What are you talking about?
Okay, speaking of someone taking meds...
No, I think I accidentally ate something wrong.
I might have ate some of the wild mushrooms up here.
Oh, you ate the beef, but it wasn't cooked.
You have like probably a cow brain disease or something.
Oh, there's coal up there.
We don't need coal.
Yes, we do.
We don't need it.
I'm panning out.
Why?
Don't leave me.
We need the coal.
I'm panning out.
It's a lot of coal.
Oh, it was the rotten meat.
Oh no.
Get back here.
When's the last time you hydrated?
Oh, that's a good question.
Look at her go in the water.
Look at her go.
I'm gonna drink the water in this ocean.
I'm gonna drink all the salt.
All the salt water.
You can go crazy with that, you know.
I know.
Yeah, sure.
Yeah, we should do that off the collab.
Off the collab.
I love it.
Until we go crazy.
Viewer's discretion is advised.
Don't try this at home.
Wait.
How do I make this?
Wait, I think we're getting out of the sand land.
Oh, I can only make one.
Why is there more sand in front of me?
How is there more sand?
Oh my god.
By the way, I went forward.
Yeah, I know.
I saw where you went.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm just gonna keep going forward until the sand stops.
You could wait like two seconds for me to catch up.
I'm pretty sure the camel is slower than actually walking.
It might be.
Where are you?
Did you go in the water?
I crossed the ocean.
Wait, how did you do that?
I don't know.
Yeah, I just keep walking.
I told you the strat.
We keep walking until...
I'm here.
Okay.
What do you mean you're here?
I crossed another area.
Wait, I don't think you know where I am.
Am I going the right way, guys?
I am at...
195 and counting.
Negative 195.
Yeah, I'm going up.
I'm going up.
Oh, did you hit a jungle?
Wait, what?
There's a jungle?
Oh, you went the wrong way.
No, I'm going towards 195.
I'm at negative 195.
You're at the wrong way.
There is no jungle here.
Why am I always finding jungles?
I'm at negative 20...
20...
04350.
Okay, but you know what happens when someone is lost?
You literally stop moving, okay?
Why don't you ever stop moving?
You're the one that's lost, not me.
Are you still on the camera?
Yeah.
I've never stopped being on the camera.
What's your Z position?
350.
321.
Okay.
Stop laughing!
I have to go in like a diagonal.
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm gonna make a peepee tower.
I'm gonna do it.
Okay, make a peepee tower.
Do it.
No, that's a waste of my resources.
You can destroy the peepee tower.
Once you make something.
Okay, I made the peepee tower.
What if I fall over the peepee tower?
Hold on.
I'll find you first.
I made a peepee tower.
Where are you?
What's your coordinate?
I didn't move.
Tell me your coordinate.
Your chat can retell you the coordinates.
Chat, what's the coordinates?
What's the coordinates now?
Oh, your chat was listening.
My chat says no, we cannot.
They're not helping me.
Minus...
2003...
and 327.
327?
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Alright, I'm on my way.
Which side are you on?
Left or right?
I'm coming probably...
Well, probably from your left.
Okay.
I'm looking left.
I'm looking for the peepee tower.
Thank god these birds aren't real so they don't swoop in and fucking stab me.
What birds are you talking about?
I have birds in my resource packs.
Oh, what?
What are you playing?
I gotta eat.
What do you see around you?
Is it all sand?
I see birds.
It's all sand.
You don't see any trees?
No, I see cactuses.
Where the fuck did you go?
Wait, you're at 20...
You're at 2000 what?
Negative 2003...
327.
Oh, shoot.
I'm not even at 2300.
Okay.
I see trees to my right.
Wait, are you still in the forest?
No.
What was the other one?
327.
I'm gonna go to the forest.
I went the wrong way.
I got rid of the peepee tower.
You're on your own.
I'm going to the forest.
I'll meet you there.
Wait, oh, the jungle?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The jungle...
The mighty jungle...
The lion sleeps at night...
All the
way...
All the way...
We're not okay anymore.
It hasn't even been two hours.
We've made zero progress.
We still don't have iron!
Yeah, we don't have any iron.
I'm at 460, negative 2077 now.
460?
Yeah, negative 20...
Oh, I see you!
Wait, where are you?
I'm swimming.
Hold on.
Oh, I see you.
I'm gonna go to this other side anyway.
Okay.
Go back.
Keep going.
This camel is so fucking slow!
Okay, I'm going.
Oh my god.
Get over here, camel.
I'm going ahead.
Alright, fuck this.
We're leaving this camel.
We're leaving him.
I'm taking my saddle back.
You can take your saddle back?
He's not in his biome.
He's gonna die.
I took him to the forest and now he's not in the sand anymore.
He's gonna die!
Oh my god, it's gonna be too cold.
It's like...
It's gonna be like the winter nights.
He deserved it.
He should've been faster.
He was pretty fast.
No, he wasn't.
We're literally traveling faster than him.
You just don't know how to run.
I know how to run with him.
Go back.
Grab the camel.
I'll give you the saddle.
Oh, now.
Oh, you're just gonna leave him like Mario?
To his Yoshi?
You're just like...
You're the one who rode him all the way here.
If anything, he thought that you were his mother and you're abandoning him now.
Yeah, it's because he had daddy issues.
You're the mother!
You literally said I was the mother!
Okay, okay.
Where are you?
Oh, I'm right here.
Another thing we can do is we can find a...
A pirate.
A sunken ship.
And then...
We should sleep.
Oh, yeah.
Alright.
I'm gonna get rid of this bed.
Alright, yeah.
We just need one bed.
It doesn't matter anyway.
Because we can't respawn.
Yeah.
Alright, I'm ready.
So, let's be on the lookout for sunken ships.
And we can find iron and stuff in there.
Why don't we just find a mountain?
I feel like a mountain would be easier.
Okay.
Well, we can use the boat to get to the mountain.
Can we get in the water too for iron?
I don't think...
I feel like a ship, we can see it easily.
Just go forward.
Straight forward.
Okay.
Forward ho!
We'll find...
We'll clearly find a mountain, right?
Okay, ship or mountain first.
Which do you think will come?
I think a mountain.
Okay.
I'm ready.
This is peaceful.
Yeah.
You know what?
Maybe we should work together more often.
Somebody here keeps, you know...
Doing it's own thing.
I think...
Honestly, it's been...
Our chats that are pitting us against each other.
That's so true.
Especially like...
Dragoons.
Wow!
Especially...
I don't wanna name names.
I know a couple of wisps.
That were doing some things too.
Oh yeah.
Weren't your wisps being like...
I'm not gonna tell you where the coordinates are.
My dragoons would tell me the coordinates if I asked them.
Actually, they probably...
I think wisps hate me.
Suckin' ship!
What?
Wait here.
Is that a suckin' ship?
Yeah, but it's not very big.
So you don't need to come in.
But you just wanna keep all the iron to yourself.
There is no iron.
You just wanna keep all the iron.
You literally said, suckin' ships have iron.
Not always, sometimes.
Oh my God.
Get in here.
Get on your new shoes.
Alright, you have to keep on lookout of the suckin' ships.
I'm not looking.
Okay, I'm on the lookout.
Oh hey, there's a drown area here.
Oh yeah.
Wait, do those areas have...
Yeah, do they have like stuff?
That's like a hidden temple thing.
Those are...
Oh, there's a drown there though.
I don't think we have enough...
We wouldn't be able to stay under the water for long enough.
It's not worth it.
Oh, okay.
You have to like dig for the chest.
Oh, I see.
It's like treasure hunting and stuff.
I wanna give them just dig down.
We could do that.
I feel like...
Oh hey, there's turtles.
Look at the baby turtles!
Oh my God, that's so cute!
Oh my God, he's shambling.
Oh my God, a seagull's gonna come in and fucking eat him.
Oh no.
Yeah, that's true.
We can't touch him, it's mother nature.
Yeah, we can't touch him.
It's like those like...
nature documentaries who like...
let things happen...
despite what happens.
Yeah, cause they're like, oh, we can't...
interfere.
That's us.
We're not bad people.
It's literally in the rules.
We're not bad people?
It's called circle of life.
Yeah.
There's a lot of drowned around here, so just go.
I'm going, I'm going.
Even though we've lost like 70% of like...
some of the species.
Why are you staying against the...
Cause I'm trying to find a mountain!
We're also trying to find treasure ships, right?
I mean, I guess.
Look, I just had a dragoon come into my chest!
And I'm a dragoon and I'm sabotaging Mint.
What do you have to say about that?
I bet he's not even a dragoon.
Who was it?
Call him out.
What's his name?
I remember every dragoon.
You know every single one?
Yeah, I know every single one.
Their name is...
You're just making up a name now.
Quantum Twin Spark.
No, that is definitely a dragoon name.
No, no, no.
Quantum Twin Spark?
Sounds like it.
If they're really a dragoon, they're gonna cry.
Hey, come back.
Oh yeah, Quantum Twin Spark literally came to my chat...
and said...
Did he super chat you too?
Yes.
I'm a wisp and I'm sabotaging Doki.
He's playing both teams!
He's playing, he's not even...
Oh, he's a wisp-goon.
Wisp-goon!
Maybe it's not dragoons or wisps.
It's the wisp-goons.
I wanna watch us both fail.
They want this stream to go on forever.
Yeah, they want it to go on for two...
They want it to go on for a month.
They want us to break their record.
The longest Minecraft?
The longest hardcore Minecraft.
Okay, we have to...
We can't die.
We've been on the seed for way too long.
For how little we've done.
How little progress we've made.
It's time to dig into a mountain.
It's time.
I'm getting off this boat.
Why is my...
Damn, two hours in and still no iron?
That's a record!
Because somebody refused to dig down!
Someone here doesn't want to dig down!
I was advocating to dig down.
There's a mountain in front of me.
Every time we've dig down, we've died.
That's two times!
Where'd you go?
I am at...
Minus three, three, seven, six...
One, five, nine, eight.
What the hell did you just say?
Your chat must've heard.
Let's just go to the mountain.
I'm literally at the mountain!
Already?
Yeah, there's a mountain in front of me.
I'm good in there, I'm walking.
Oh my God, I hope we're...
I hope we're looking at the same mountain right now.
What the...
How did that...
How is there just coal on the ground?
Oh, because...
I didn't have room in my inventory, that's the stuff I dug.
Oh.
I was like, that's weird.
That is weird.
I'm on this mountain.
I see you, I see you.
No, no, no, stop, stop, stop!
Freeze!
Stop!
In the name of...
You don't know the words.
No, I know the words, but I don't want to bait people.
Oh, so true.
I know exactly who you're talking about.
I think I'll try harder to get that out of me.
Hey, hey, I'm digging a hole, I'm digging a hole.
Oh, you're gonna dig a hole?
Yeah, we're digging into the mountain.
I thought we're supposed to...
Fucking farm around the mountain.
This isn't the right kind of mountain, but it's okay.
We can dig inside.
Oh, my God.
Come on in, come on in.
Where are you?
Hey, hey, look over here.
Okay, okay, I'm here.
I'm putting a little torch there.
Alright.
It's time.
I'm digging this side.
I'm gonna dig the other side.
What side?
This side.
Are we digging down or just digging around?
What is iron usually at, guys?
I don't know.
I'll put torches, too.
Oops.
My thing broke.
We're surrounded by stone.
Hey.
Lower?
We gotta go lower?
Oh, okay.
Okay, we gotta go way lower.
Here, I'm gonna start.
Here, come to my hole.
And we'll start digging the hole.
My head...
My head right now.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm trying to remember how to make sticks right now.
I'm...
Two planks.
I'm struggling at the moment.
Planks on top of each other.
This has been too much Minecraft.
Two planks.
This was your idea.
I'm just reminding you.
This was both our ideas.
You were like, that's a great idea.
That's a great idea, Doki.
Let's do it.
You...
Said that you wanted...
We're inspired.
You were the one inspired.
Yeah, and then you were like, wow, that's a great idea.
We should totally do it.
Oh shit, there's so much.
Wait, do we keep going down?
Yeah, keep going down.
What's the coordinates?
We gotta get to five.
Where are we at?
Like 70.
I'm gonna dig down.
I'm digging down.
I can't.
I'm gonna dig down.
You're digging a stair though, right?
Don't fall down.
Okay, how do you get back up?
I'm at 50.
We'll find out later.
Okay.
I'm still getting more...
Cold.
I hear...
Is that a creeper sound?
There's a creeper.
Creepers don't make sound though.
What's...
What's that?
What does...
What does that mean?
Oh, it's an Enderman.
We found an Enderman.
Oh, we need those.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my God, there's so much coal here.
Do you have a lot of wood?
Yeah, I do.
Let's throw this away.
We don't need this.
What are you throwing?
Sandstone.
Oh yeah, we don't need that.
Oh!
What did you find?
Oh, thank God I didn't dig down.
I found a very, very deep cave.
I picked the right...
Oh my God!
If I dug down one more time...
Guys, my duty is the stairs.
I'm stair duty.
There's only one more.
If I dug one...
This is good enough.
Oh my gosh, I almost just fell into your hole.
Wait, am I...
There's no way, guys.
There's no way.
What biome am I in right now?
No, it's the dripstone cave.
Someone was like, oh my God, you're in the deep dark.
That's the dripstone.
Oh, no, yeah.
You know when you're in the deep dark.
It's got the glowy stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't believe it.
I literally stopped just at the right time.
You guys, no sabotaging.
My chat is trying to have me sabotage you.
What?
Why did you go silent?
No, I'm just curious on how you're gonna do this.
I'm building stairs.
Yeah?
It's fine.
You messed this up.
How did I mess it up?
There.
Oh my God.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
It's literally one more block.
If I did one more block, I would have died.
Oh, it looks so easy.
Oh, no.
What will happen if you just...
Let's keep going and we'll find iron eventually.
Should I cover this up?
Oh, never mind.
Don't go this way.
Let's go this way.
Why does it keep getting more and more dangerous?
Because we're living on the edge.
I don't like the edge anymore.
I feel like if we dig down, we're gonna...
This is what happens when you dig down.
This is what you wanted.
You wanted to dig in the mountain.
Oh, there's so many endermen.
There's so many endermen near us.
Why is there so much copper?
Where are the fucking iron?
Where is the iron?
What are we at?
Oh, we need to go further down.
Yeah, but down is death.
This isn't the right mountain.
We need to go to the mountain.
Wait, I can make another stair here.
Oh, okay.
Go, go, go.
I need to throw some stuff away.
Too much copper.
Cobble, cobble, cobble.
Okay.
We can't sabotage each other because we want to get out of here.
No, we can't.
You guys, this is the real thing.
We're not restarting.
This is where we're gonna...
make it.
Oh my God.
He's like right next to us.
He's like right here.
Oh, that was me.
He was like literally right here.
Yeah.
What corner are we on now?
Don't worry about it.
Just keep going down.
I feel like we're gonna be going down forever.
I told you it's not the right type of mountain, but it's okay.
Why didn't we just find a hole?
Wouldn't a hole be easier?
Mint, wouldn't a hole be easier?
Why didn't we just find a hole?
Why did you make me dig a mountain?
Okay.
I got an eerie noise.
Yeah, I think that was the Enderman.
No, it was not.
Okay, we're almost close to where Iron...
Okay, now I think we can...
just like tunnel.
Alright, your turn.
Time to go forward.
Wouldn't monsters spawn behind us?
Because we just left it, you know...
Yeah, that's a potential risk.
Okay, you know what?
We like it risky.
Oh, I hear a skelly man right next to me.
Oh, that means we're like...
Okay.
How does that mean we're okay?
That means we're like closer to the ground now.
You know, we won't fall to our deaths.
Okay, I'll go right side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hear dripping.
Oh, Iron!
You found Iron?
I found one.
Iron!
I mean, you know...
One is something, I guess.
Yeah.
I'm tired of these stone pickaxes.
We'll get there soon.
When will we...
When will we hit it big?
When will our streamer luck kick in?
Oh wait, I already made a furnace.
Okay, well, I have an extra one.
Oh.
For when we wanna cook the Iron.
Actually, I could probably cook the Iron.
What's that?
Nothing.
We'll go this way now.
Why is that boarded up, huh?
Why don't you check it out?
Come over here.
You wonder why it's boarded up?
Alright, come over here.
Dig it.
Oh, there's nothing here.
Come on, dig another one.
Oh, I see.
Did you...
That's your torch.
You see it?
It was your torch.
Are you just gonna abandon it?
Oh my God, creeper!
Now you know why I abandoned it.
Yeah, but I got your torch back.
Oh, thank you.
My 53rd torch.
Insane.
It's important.
Every torch matters.
This is hardcore.
Every material is precious.
I'm in another area.
What do you mean another area?
Where are you going?
What does that mean?
Nice.
Just one?
No, I found four.
Four whole irons.
Okay.
Yeah, where's your four iron?
I have currently in my inventory...
Five, six...
Seven...
Eight...
Nine...
Ten...
Eleven...
Oh my God, no, I had to count past ten.
Thanks, Elmo.
Did you see the Sesame Street Twitter account?
Got super...
Like...
Emo?
Cookie Monster and like...
All the Sesame Street accounts were like...
It's okay, guys.
If you're having a bad day...
They were being like those...
Self-help Twitter accounts.
Oh.
I found an area.
Oh, I found Lapis.
Yeah, me too.
Wait, hold on.
I'll make sure I don't die.
Is Lapis important to us?
Um...
Actually, yeah.
I think we should get it...
For when we need to enchant stuff.
Okay.
Oh, you're right.
We should get that.
Yeah, they were doing like self-help tweets and stuff.
And like super encouraging stuff too.
I like Elmo's Twitter though.
Yeah, Elmo...
Yeah, but it was like all the Sesame Street.
All of them?
Yeah, all of them.
It was like Cookie Monster too.
And then like... Sesame Street, okay.
Yeah.
Sesame Street's going through it.
Wow!
Did you almost fall?
No.
There's a...
There's a little zombie cutting over.
He's not happy.
Little zombie.
Okay.
I'm gonna get a sword.
Why is there so much copper in here?
Oh, he's blocked by the...
Sword.
He's blocked by my little torch.
Oh.
I found a big area.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm gonna grab Lapis.
Oh, look.
I killed my first monster.
I'm gonna get the Lapis too.
Can you get it with the stone?
Huh?
Oh, okay.
Nice.
I didn't know if you could get Lapis with the stone or not.
Yeah, I can.
Wait.
No, I can't.
Oh.
Yes, you can.
Oh, wait, wait.
Okay, I didn't use... I didn't...
I have too much in my inventory.
We don't need raw rabbit.
Uh... I'm gonna...
Actually, that's food though.
That's true.
I need to clean my inventory.
Should I make a shield?
Can you eat glow berries or no?
Yeah, you can eat them.
Okay.
I'll just eat the glow berries.
We don't need copper, right?
No, we don't need copper.
Okay, so I can throw those away.
Alright, I'm gonna start smelting my stuff.
Me too.
I need to start smelting these as well.
I have a lot of iron.
Alright.
Let's make a shield.
And we'll make a good sword.
Alright, and I can make armor.
Okay, let's...
I mean...
Where's my... Okay, there's my chest.
There's my crafting table.
Furnace.
Get rid of this bamboo.
And then...
Iron age happening.
Oh my god, we're doing it.
Oh my god, we're in the...
We're expanding!
We're doing it!
It was worth it!
I don't need this gravel.
Oh my god.
We're actually...
We're actually doing it.
We're gonna make it out of here!
Maybe.
They didn't believe us.
I know.
They thought we were gonna die here.
This is literally the run.
This is the run.
I knew that was gonna happen.
Alright, we're safe.
We're still safe.
Okay, uh, where...
Okay, um...
I'm gonna make my shield first.
Okay.
Where did I put my crafting table?
Did I leave it over there?
I don't know.
Okay, I can fight him.
Shield!
Yeah!
I have my shield too.
We're gonna make it.
Okay, I'm gonna make a sword.
Okay, this skeleton needs to fucking be able to aim.
I did it!
Wait, what did you get?
I killed a skelly!
Oh, you got the thingy.
I got the shield, yeah.
Okay, nice.
Alright, now...
Now I'm gonna make armor.
I'm making... oh, I should make armor first.
I want the iron pickaxe.
Actually, I should get iron pickaxe first.
You're right.
No, no.
Get armor first.
No.
It's too late.
I didn't listen.
Iron pickaxe.
Wait, do I not...
Wait, what?
Why is it not working?
Do I have too much stuff in my inventory?
I do.
There we go.
Oh my god, I have too much stuff in my inventory.
What do I not want?
What do I not need?
I don't know, but they're all important to me!
Oh wait, why do I have another bed?
I don't know.
You went down here.
Oh, I see your name.
You're very far away.
I don't know where I go to.
I go to too many places.
I don't know.
Oh, I see you.
I'm here.
No!
Oh yeah, the copper!
Okay, oh hey.
I'm gonna throw away the copper.
I have like 31.
Oh look, there's more lapis here.
Yeah, I'm trying to make armor right now.
Okay.
Okay, I don't need my golden hoe.
I have my hoe here.
Will this kill me?
Yeah.
Okay.
I need an iron sword.
And I'm gonna throw away my stone sword.
And I'll throw this here too.
I don't need the emerald.
And then...
Yeah, you don't need that emerald.
There's more to our left.
More over here?
Yeah.
Oh yeah, I can make... No, I feel like I'm wasting wheat... Wasting space.
For the wheat?
Yeah, they're saying, oh, you can make like wheat off of the hay and stuff, but I waste too much space there already.
Well, if you have the...
If you have it turned into bread, then it's, you know... Yeah, but then I'll get too much bread.
It's good to have bread.
No, it's too much bread.
There's a limit to how much bread you can have.
There's a limit.
Okay, I need shoes and... Alright, let's get iron.
I need shoes and...
I already have a lot of armor.
Let's see, where's my bread?
Wait, where did I put my bread?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, did you go down?
Yeah.
Alright, I'm here.
Wait, what was the purpose?
The dripstone makes it so annoying.
That's true.
What was the purpose of going down here?
I don't know, to find iron?
Here?
Do we need more iron?
Yeah.
We do?
We have to have a plethora of shields and... We just need one.
No, you don't.
It'll break.
It will?
Yes.
Oh.
Oh, I should make a bucket.
Oh yeah, you can.
Oh yeah, I'm gonna go make a bucket.
Yeah, make a bucket.
Did you leave all your stuff up there?
Yeah.
We're gonna come back to it, right?
We're not?
Are we?
I don't know.
Okay, you're right.
I'll bring it back to me.
I'm gonna wait until it cooks and then I'll come back.
We also gotta get to the diamond, so I guess we can start diamond hunting.
Oh yeah, we might as well start now.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna bring this out here.
Wait, where are we at?
25.
Okay.
So if we find iron...
I'm gonna strip mine for iron a little bit more.
Okay, what's the coordinates for diamond?
It's like...
Wait, it's like negative...
Alright, let's go.
Let's dig down.
It's time.
Hold on, I need more iron.
We can get iron while we're digging down.
It stops showing up though.
No, it doesn't.
It shows up with the diamond.
It doesn't?
When did it change that?
It used to.
No, it stops showing up.
No, it doesn't.
No.
Oh, well then, I'm...
Alright, let's start digging down.
Alright.
Also, I don't know why you're listening to me.
I know less about Minecraft than you.
I don't know, I'm just...
I'm just vulnerable, maybe.
Wait, where did...
Where did you go from?
I don't know, I'm trying to find where you are.
Did you go...
Did you keep going forward?
Where did you go?
Where are you?
Did you go down?
I see you.
I'm heading back to you.
Oh, I see you.
Why did you go all the way over there?
Why would I go there?
Where did your name go?
Oh, nevermind.
I'm here.
Okay, we can go down, and then we can just...
Alright.
Oh, there's more.
Hold on.
Alright, they said it was less of a chance, but that doesn't mean we won't get it.
We might as well.
Okay, I'm grabbing coal.
Alright, I'm digging down.
Oh my gosh.
I forgot to look at my computer yesterday.
Wait, it's starting to rattle again.
Wait, what?
My fan is like all messed up.
Oh, look.
See?
I told you.
I am right here.
It's just that easy.
Where are you?
I just dug down.
Are you like actually digging down?
Yeah.
I dug down.
I dug down next to you.
Wait, where am I?
I dug down right next to you.
Okay, I'm digging down again.
Okay, I'm digging down.
I'm digging down.
What's the coordinates for diamond?
Like, negative 50.
Okay, just...
We are at...
We are at 14.
Yeah, we gotta go.
We gotta dig.
Alright, how bad would it be if I...
If I just dug straight down?
Like, is it worth the risk?
Um...
Is it worth it?
A seasoned Minecraft person would probably say don't do it.
But...
Are we seasoned?
No.
Get over here.
Are you willing to risk this ride?
Yeah.
Get over here.
You know what that means.
Oh my God.
Alright.
Wait, that's an Enderman.
That's an Enderman next to you.
I think down is like an actual death pit.
Wait, let's...
Okay, wait.
Let me double check.
Wait, I think there's lava next to us.
I think I heard lava.
No, I hear the Enderman.
No, no.
It's...
Is this my music?
Is it my music?
I can't tell.
There's no lava.
Okay, it might be my music.
Alright, you ready then?
To risk this entire run?
I dig yours, you dig mine.
Alright, ready?
Wait, I need a head start.
My pickaxe is gonna die.
No, I'm gonna be the one who dies first.
It'll be your fault if I die.
You're the one who's digging mine.
I agreed to this.
You agreed to it.
You're the one who's digging my block.
You said...
Alright, you wanna just do it?
Yeah.
Yeah, I need to make...
Can I have some iron?
Do you not have any iron blocks?
I have one left.
Go make your own iron.
I only have one iron ingot.
Go grab your iron ingot.
It's already burned!
How much do you need?
How much is a pickaxe?
It's like two.
Okay, then give me one more.
Alright, that's an I.O.U.
right there.
Yeah, you need to give me two more.
Oh my God.
That's an I.O.U.
right there.
Sure, yeah.
Alright.
Okay, one second.
It's almost done.
We are at...
Minus ten.
We still have 40 more.
Again, I'm making my pickaxe.
I'm gonna eat real fast.
Yum yum yum yum.
Oh yeah, me too.
What if a creeper just falls on our head because we didn't put any torches above us?
I don't think they...
I think they're smarter.
I don't think they fall like that, right?
I don't know anymore.
I don't know.
We're at negative 11.
What if we just strip mine from here?
No, it has to be negative 50.
It said negative 50, right?
I think so.
They do fall in harder difficulties.
Well, we're at hardcore.
Hey, what the hell?
You're trying to sabotage me.
No, I'm not.
I'm literally trying to fucking dig.
You literally attacked me.
No, I didn't.
I was digging.
You just stood in front of the hitbox.
That's why...
You stood in front of the hitbox.
I didn't move.
I literally just left click.
That's why I didn't attack this audience.
I didn't move.
Okay.
Where are we at?
We're at negative 29.
Hey.
I don't get an extra one.
Why are you so scared?
Jump down.
Come on.
What are you doing?
What happened?
I thought you wanted to...
You're such a fucker.
You're actually such a...
I hope it is a hole and we have to do this all over again.
I hope...
I hope it's a hole.
I hope it's a fucking hole.
I hope it's a hole and then we actually dig to lava.
We're at negative 50.
Oh shit, are we?
Oh shit, we went too far.
No, we're good.
No, now I'm negative 50.
It's not exactly negative 50.
Yes, it is.
That's the whole point.
That's the whole point, yeah.
Oh no.
What happened?
There might...
Okay, we need to do this one together.
We need to do this one together.
Why?
It's a mine shaft.
Oh my God, okay.
Let me make staircases real fast.
Yeah.
We gotta actually work together here.
Oh my God, okay.
We're gonna die in that mine shaft.
No, we're not.
We're gonna die in this mine shaft.
I fucking believe in our deaths.
We need redstone?
No.
Okay.
I'm never gonna find a dog in mine.
Do you have a good sword?
I have an iron sword, yeah.
Alright, let's go.
And let's loot.
Alright.
Do you want me to come with you?
Yeah, no, we gotta stick together.
We gotta watch each other's backs.
You're scared.
Um, maybe.
I like how you're saying, yeah, we gotta work together and you disappeared.
Wait, wait a minute.
You gotta keep up with me.
I'm trying to put torches for us.
Oh, I got a lot of that.
Oh, there's some iron.
Yeah, there's iron right here, nice.
Um, I'll get rid of that.
I'll keep the little berries for food.
I'm gonna name time.
I'm putting some stuff away from this area.
Uh, you know what?
Since we're here, we have to go back to the same area anyway.
I'm gonna put a furnace here.
Okay.
And start making some stuff.
Alright.
Oh, hey, nice.
Oh, wait, gold.
We don't need gold.
Wait, we do need gold.
For the piggies.
Wait, why do people give gold to the piggies again?
What do you get?
You can trade with them and sometimes they give you potions.
We need like potions of fire.
Potions?
Can they give like ender pearls?
Yeah, they give pearls.
They can give pearls, they can give potions and then they can give...
Wait, did we come this way?
Oh, this is the way we came from.
Wait, there's one over here.
Right here.
Yeah, we gotta get down here.
Cool.
You could make a staircase.
Yeah, but...
But what?
Yeah?
Why didn't you?
I wanted to do it the cool way.
The harder way?
You mean the harder way?
The cooler way?
The harder way.
The cool way.
Where I look cool, like I'm fearless.
Chat, did you think she looked cool?
Yeah!
Did she look cool?
Just jumping down?
Yeah!
She looked so...
Oh no, there's a spider!
She looked so cool!
Wait, where are you, Doki?
I went up.
This is the entrance to the mineshaft.
The coolest.
Yeah, see?
I think I look cool.
Oh, maybe that's the spider I'm hearing.
Diamond!
Let's see if there's more...
Congratulations on your one diamond.
You needed that.
Oh wait, I ran out of torches.
Two diamonds, actually.
Wait, why do I have two chests?
Did I accidentally grab your chest?
You grabbed my chest?
Yeah.
Oh sorry, there's none.
I forgot.
I forgot you got nerfed.
Says you!
Oh my god!
Calling the kettle black?
For real?
Says you!
I remember when somebody was spamming Doki.
Laughing at Doki board.
I fucking remembered.
You know, someone at a fan meet gave me a cutting board.
Literally with your face drawn on it.
Wait, what?!
And the letter said, don't tell Doki.
But you know what?
I think I will!
But you told!
Yeah, I think I will!
Because it's my ammunition now.
You can't trust her, guys.
Look at that, she told.
Where'd you go?
I don't fucking know!
Says the guy who owns an actual...
Why did you give it to Mint and not me?
That's the thing I'm wondering about.
Why did you give it to her?
If it has my face on it?
I don't know.
Control your words, you goons!
Was that a mending book?
Oh yeah, we need to do...
Like, actual things, don't we?
No, sweeping it.
Actually, this might be good to have.
Where'd you go?
I'm scared!
I don't know, actually.
I'm all by myself!
Actually, I think I fucked up.
What do you mean you fucked up?
I don't know where I am!
Where can I go even deeper?
No, don't go deeper!
I'm scared!
What happened to sticking together?
I don't know, you walked off the other way.
Oh, I see you.
Oh, let's go down here then.
No, I went there.
I went all the way... I explored all that.
Oh, all of it?
Okay.
Did you explore all of this way?
I mean, there's torches here.
I didn't go any further than this though.
Okay.
We gotta find our original way back.
Because I put a furnace there.
I know where to go.
I would like to have my furnace back.
I have another furnace.
I know, but I put furnaces.
I was making stuff from there.
There's a spider in here.
I can hear him.
Alright, let's go.
It must be like a... what is it called?
A spawner then.
Oh my god, that's a bat.
Oh, I'm out of torches.
I've been out of torches for a while.
What?
Why did you do something?
Yeah, but I've been...
I've been using my one torch to light my way.
I have more torches.
Where am I?
Oh, diamond!
Actually, where am I?
What is this role reversal here?
Wait.
I've waited for this moment for a long time.
Oh, there's a creeper over here.
You wanna get him?
Sure.
Hit and run.
I like how you ran so far.
Well, I'm giving you extra room.
Yeah, sure, sure.
Oh, I'm stuck.
I can't...
I hear a spider.
Yeah, I hear him.
I think he's like somewhere in here.
There's a spawner here.
Here, hold on.
Watch my back and I'll make more torches.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
I'm gonna start putting stuff away.
I'm right here.
What happened to watching my back?
Take some torches.
I was.
Take these.
Alright, nice.
Put that here.
Oh, what was in here?
I feel like we don't really need a torch or anything.
Oh my god, where the fuck...
I have five whole diamonds.
Only five?
Well, we don't have fortune pickaxes anymore.
This is bad.
I think if we...
If we mine to the left, we'll find the spawn...
Maybe it's here.
Maybe that's where the spiders are spawning.
The spawner is... Oh, yeah.
Oh, that's where I found diamonds.
To here?
Are we... No, we have gone down here.
See, there's a torch.
Wait, hold on.
Have we gone across before?
No, it doesn't look like it.
But I wanna check the...
Oh, hey, wait.
Look.
See, that's where the spiders are.
I don't know if we have gone down here.
I'm sure we have.
Look over here.
Look over here where I am.
Oh, what the fuck?
Where did he come from?
Over here.
What the fuck?
I didn't kill him though.
He's still down there.
That's fine.
Get your shields up.
What is he gonna do?
Climb up?
I'll be very impressed if he does that.
I'll be very impressed.
I still hear the spider, but I don't...
There's nothing here.
I'm pretty sure the spider is like...
Oh, there's a zombie here.
I hear a zombie too, yeah.
Yeah, I just killed him.
No, there's a different one.
Wait, I can actually go down?
Oh my god.
Did he climb up?
My turn.
Oh my god.
Where did he come from?
Wait, why are you laughing?
Oh, I found the spider.
He was guarding the diamonds.
All I'm saying is...
I have four now too.
Oh my god.
I have five, not four.
But you had to mine several times for five.
If this is a team effort, it doesn't matter how many we have as long as we...
I mined one square for that diamond.
I think there's more spider here.
Or... Oh yeah, there is.
Spider!
There's nothing here.
I got him.
Is this where the zombie was?
Alright, I think we...
We got all the mine...
I think we explored the mineshaft fully.
I'm pretty sure.
Wait, where are you?
I'm exploring the mineshaft.
Wait, where did you go?
Where are you?
I don't know.
Well, find me.
Oh, I see you.
How do I find you?
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, we haven't gotten here.
I'm gonna die.
Hold on, I gotta eat.
Why are you so close to dying?
We don't need gold.
Yes we do!
We can get enderpearls!
I swear, if we get...
I swear to god, if we like...
If this clutches our run, I'm gonna remember this.
I'm...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna remember this if this fucking clutches our run.
You're gonna remember this?
Yeah, I'm gonna remember this.
English is not my first language, so you're...
It's not a first language thing.
It's literally a mumbling thing!
Remember mumbling this?
There's more over here, by the way.
English is my first language, by the way.
But it made you feel bad.
Not even a little bit.
Because of you.
Should we just strip mine here, then?
I guess.
No, I need to go back to the furnace.
Oh my god.
Forget about your furnace, I have two furnaces!
No!
But it had meat in it!
It had all the coal!
It had all of it in there!
Okay, fine, let's go back.
You said you knew how to go back!
Not from here.
Shit, I don't know.
Wait, I think I do know.
Okay, from down here.
You said we were gonna go back!
And I believed in you!
I don't actually know where you left it, though.
I don't know either.
What do you mean you don't know either?
Was it before the mineshaft?
Yeah, no, it was the mineshaft.
But it was the first mineshaft area.
Oh, there it is!
See, I told you!
Okay, now we can leave.
Oh yeah, two, right?
Okay, I'll just wait for you two.
Actually, let me...
I'm gonna put some stuff...
We don't need gunpowder, because then we don't need TNT, right?
I mean...
I guess technically not.
Unless we want to get netherite, but...
No.
That's too much work.
Do we need netherite to fucking fight the ender dragon?
We can just fight them with diamond!
Yeah, I guess so.
We can just do it with diamond.
How do you open a book?
What do you mean?
You need a thingy for it.
You need a thingy?
Yeah, like a library thing.
So you have to have a thingy to open...
To write in it too?
Yeah, you can't open it or do anything with it.
Oh my god, I knew I can't read.
I'll never be able to read.
Okay, let's go back downstairs and do the strip mining.
Oh my god, you're scaring me!
Oh, this is where you got your diamond.
Well, let's go keep... This is a good diamond area then.
Yeah, yeah, so we just strip mine.
Strip mine.
Alright, nice.
This is it.
This is where we're gonna find all the diamonds.
We're gonna find diamond, we're gonna be so...
We're gonna be so rich and everything.
You know what?
I'm gonna use that diamond I have now...
And craft a diamond pickaxe.
I'm gonna do it.
That's such a waste.
What do you mean?
We literally...
That's the whole point.
The point is to have the diamond armor.
Why don't we just keep using the iron?
You crafted it, didn't you?
It's important!
It's gonna do...
It's gonna do so well.
I'm gonna find the remaining diamonds for you.
You'll see.
You're gonna see.
I'm gonna prove you wrong.
Prove me wrong.
You'll see.
I'm gonna show you all.
Show you all.
Didn't they add a new enemy?
They did?
No, they didn't.
I thought they did.
What did they add?
I don't remember what it's called.
I don't...
Chat, what was it called?
Oh, it's a new biome?
Yeah, like a slenderman thing, right?
What?
The fuck are you talking about?
Not the warden.
The creaking?
Yeah.
Is it in this?
A certain cave biome.
Wait, is it in this one?
What's this one?
Is it in this snapshot?
Or like...
Deep dark!
You got the deep dark?
I'm in the deep dark!
How the fuck did you find the deep dark?
It took us...
Well, I don't know.
It might not be a...
It might not be a city.
Wait, no.
You can tell if it's a city.
F3.
It tells you the biome.
No, it says my biome is deep dark.
Oh.
If you dig down, that means we're in it.
Are you gonna dig down?
Should I dig down?
Okay.
Are you gonna do it?
If we find a warden, we are actually for sure in it.
What do you mean, we?
Oh, wait.
I'm at bedrock.
Wait, I'm at bedrock too.
I've been digging bedrock.
I was trying to dig bedrock.
I couldn't tell.
I couldn't tell that I was bedrock.
I was like, wow, this is some hard ass rock right here.
You're wasting your...
Your newly diamond pickaxe.
I was like, wow, this rock is so hard to dig.
This is really deep dark.
There's no skulk at all.
Maybe I dig down or above.
Maybe it's above us.
Yeah, I think it is.
Because we're too far deep for...
We're too far deep for it to be.
Yeah, it doesn't matter for us.
Yeah, we don't need...
I don't think we need it, so...
I don't think there was anything there that requires us to...
To...
What was it?
To use the deep dark.
It would probably just be a flex to say that we survived the deep dark.
Technically, I'm surviving the deep dark right now.
Survive the deep dark in hardcore.
I'm surviving...
Oh, diamond.
Whoa.
Hey, I got diamond too.
See, I told you the investment.
Like, two.
Yeah, how many did you get?
I got like five.
Oh, okay.
I'm at eleven now.
I have eleven diamonds.
Oh, okay.
I mean, I got my diamond pickaxe.
Actually, I think we do need that for like obsidian.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah?
Oh, so my investment was like...
Corrected.
Barely.
I mean, we could have found obsidian.
We could have also like made it without the obsidian.
Sure, sure, sure.
Are you crying?
Are you okay?
Oh, man.
Why would I be crying?
I have my diamond pickaxe.
My good investment.
Wait, we could just use the bucket.
Wait, that's actually smart.
That's what I'm saying.
You use the bucket to like make it without...
Yeah, do you know how to do it?
Do you know how to do it?
I actually don't know how.
Yeah, exactly.
I actually think I'm stupid with that.
I never looked it up.
Wait, your video tutorial didn't tell you how to?
No.
I told you, they don't hold your hand.
They're like, you're gonna figure this out.
We'll just give you hints on what to do.
Wait, I need to go up.
Let's see.
How the turns of tables, right?
I feel like we need to be at...
Isn't 54 like the optimal?
I don't know.
I'm at negative 58.
You're at 58?
Is that almost better?
Yeah.
This sounds like Cope, huh?
Oh, I don't think I'm at the right level.
I'm gonna remember this.
I have!
I have remembered it!
These people are gonna remember what you...
We have remembered it!
At least mine went viral.
People always remember the first time, not the second.
This is my first time.
It's gonna haunt you for years.
How many diamonds do we need, guys, for a full armor set?
How many?
I'm surprised I haven't hit any of them.
Oh, I hate this eerie sound.
It's so creepy.
33?
I don't feel like I've been digging for the rest of my life.
We need 30.
Someone says 24.
Okay, people are gaslighting me.
You're whispered gaslighting you, but my dragoons instantly told me the correct amount.
Oh, but we also need a sword.
I think they meant it with also the sword.
Right?
We need the sword too.
Is that lava?
No, that was several people!
There were several dragoons that said it!
Oh, you don't even see my chat.
How are you gaslighting me when you don't even see my chat?
Wait, do you have a crafting table?
Yeah, I do.
I have two.
Can I have one?
Oh, I think you stole mine.
I didn't steal it.
You lost yours.
I'm running back to you.
I don't even know where I am.
How far are you?
You're going down one hole, right?
You're just going down a single hole?
Did you not hear when I said I hit bedrock?
You can keep going!
No, you can't!
I'm just going straight!
Is that incapable of you?
Are you incapable of going straight?
Oh, hey, look.
I found...
Whoa!
I found five diamonds.
That's right.
Five.
No.
No, you gotta find me first.
I'm literally right behind you.
Oh, hey.
You stupid crafting table.
That was a stack of six diamonds?
Look at that.
How many do you have?
Seven.
And if I include the three diamonds I used to make my diamond pickaxe...
That would be like ten.
Yeah.
That's rookies numbers.
Yeah, what do you have?
Eleven?
Like the plus one that's apparently better?
Yeah, eleven.
I didn't take it?
I didn't take it.
See, you lost yours.
And you're like...
You stole my crafting table when you didn't even take your crafting table in the first place.
I can't see.
You don't put any torches down.
It's pitch black down here.
Yeah, I don't need torches.
I literally have a torch in my hand to light the way.
Why waste resources when I can just light the way with my torches in my hand?
I can't wait for a creeper to spawn right up behind you.
Oh, yeah?
Do it.
Do it now.
Spawn in now.
I ain't scared.
I ain't afraid of no ghost.
Yeah, I ain't afraid of no ghost.
There's literally a ghost right beside me.
I'm gone.
I'm long gone.
She's not scary.
I am scary.
You're not.
You're not fucking scary.
You've never scared anybody in your life.
Yes, I have.
No, you have.
Name one.
Yes, I have.
You want to watch me scare him right now?
Yeah.
I'm graduating.
Forever done worse.
That's it?
It's a joke, guys.
It's a joke.
They're all sad now.
They're all really spooked right now.
They're like, wow.
They're like PTSD.
Too far.
It's a joke.
JK, JK.
She's a monster.
I scared you guys.
Halloween's over.
Am I getting redstone?
Okay.
Yeah.
When you get redstone, does it give you experience?
Yeah, it does.
Yeah, then mine it.
You don't have to take it.
Just mine it.
Why should I?
I'm already level 11.
Because we need it to enchant our stuff.
We need more experience.
Fine.
I guess I'll do it.
I'll do anything with this bamboo.
You can make sugar.
Wait, no, that's not...
That's sugar canes.
You can make paper.
I'm making sticks.
I'm making...
I'm strip mining.
I'm stripping.
That's like the short form for strip mining, right?
Yeah.
We're all stripping.
You're stripping, I'm stripping.
Will it be enough?
I wonder.
That's strip mining.
Is that what it means?
We're stripping.
We're doing it.
We're stripping so fast.
Oh my god, I'm gonna go crazy.
I swear, if we fucking...
If we die during this run, I swear to god...
I don't think I can do this again.
What are you talking about?
We're so much more experienced now.
I don't think I can start stripping again, man.
I hate this.
Actually, I don't mind the stripping, because...
You don't mind the stripping?
It's really...
It's kind of relaxing to just...
Yeah, especially when they give you super chats while you're stripping.
They don't do that.
So you're stripping for free?
It's like a hobby.
It's like a...
It's just...
It's just a stress reliever.
It's like a hobby.
I'm just like...
Do it for experience.
I lose myself in the stripping.
I don't think about it.
My mind just goes blank.
Before I know it...
Ah!
Mint, I swear to God.
Mint, please.
I swear to God, I can't...
I can't keep stripping, Mint.
I'm okay.
I've hit lava, but I'm okay.
Thanks, guys, for the dollar bills.
While I'm stripping.
Yeah, where's your dollar bills?
Oh, hey!
Have you hit diamond, Mint?
Have you hit diamond?
Everyone remembers the first time.
Nobody remembers the second time.
Yeah, that's why people always remember...
our first experience.
It wasn't my experience.
This is all original right here.
This never happened before.
Actually, you know...
I never played Minecraft, you know.
Yeah, you never played Minecraft before.
Then how come you knew so much...
about stripping?
Thanks for the dollar bills, guys.
I really appreciate it.
I worked so hard.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for the dollar bills.
I'm stripping.
Well, it's not a hobby anymore.
They're paying you.
No, it's...
What is it called then?
It's called...
Oh, I don't know.
Do I need to get a...
Oh no, do I need to LLC this strip?
Oh no, now you gotta...
make sure it's taxed properly.
Gotta add the GMT taxes, guys.
That's the Canadian tax.
YouTube's not gonna like this.
They're already pressing the button...
on banning our accounts at this very moment.
Banning accounts?
What did we do wrong?
We're just stripping.
Yeah, we're stripping.
We're stripping for ore.
For money.
For money, guys.
It's not legal.
We're just strip mining.
It's not legal, guys.
It's not against your TOS.
Did you just say it's not legal?
It's not illegal.
Oh, not illegal.
Yeah, yeah.
We're just strip mining.
Oh my gosh.
Did you see like the...
Twitch TOS about like...
VTuber hips?
I thought that was funny.
Well, I mean, it fucking sucks, but like...
I thought that was funny because like...
I played like Nikkei.
I got sponsored for Nikkei.
And then I was like, you know, the girls.
But it's not a bad...
It's like a game character.
Yeah, yeah.
We're not real, though.
We're not real.
What if we were in a game?
I made a game.
And we were in a game, too.
Technically, we're video game characters.
Yeah, we are video game characters.
I mean, we're not Twitch streamers, but like, technically, like...
If we were, we'd be fine.
Yeah, we'd be fine.
We'll be within TOS.
Yeah.
Someone was just like, my mom asked me what I am watching.
Because we keep saying we're stripping.
We're Minecraft friendly VTubers.
We're playing Minecraft.
Yeah, we're playing Minecraft.
Don't worry.
Just say like...
Just say it's like the new name for mining.
You know?
I don't know what strip mining is.
That's like not a Minecraft thing.
Yeah.
It's not.
Do you think mining was invented in Minecraft?
I can't believe it, guys.
Mining was invented in Minecraft, everybody.
Oh my god, you're right.
Oh my god, someone was saying I'm watching miners.
No, guys, don't say that.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
Uh -oh.
The bit is getting too dangerous.
Okay, all right, guys.
All right, show's over.
Show's over.
We're closing down.
The bit is getting too dangerous.
We're changing businesses and hobbies.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
There's so much redstone.
How much do we need again?
For redstone?
No, like diamond.
Diamond was...
I hear zombies next to me.
27?
I think.
Well, 24 is for the armor and then it's 3 for...
Oh my gosh, I hate...
24 for armor.
Okay, I already have the boots.
You made boots?
Yeah, I already made the boots.
I'm almost done.
That's a bit of a stretch.
Well, I'm almost...
That's like 1 out of 4.
That's 25%.
It's not even 50%.
Do you have any boots?
I don't think so.
I don't think you have diamond boots.
I haven't made diamond anything.
I'm saving until I have the full...
Exactly.
Full set, baby.
And then a zombie is gonna get you.
Why are you wishing death upon me?
I'm not wishing death upon you.
I'm trying to tell you that you're not playing it safe.
I don't even have pants on right now.
Are you streaming in public?
I'm in a cave.
I mean, your wisp is here.
Surrounding you.
Where are the ghosts?
I mean, they're ghosts, so you can't see them.
Do you think ghosts can see other ghosts?
Yes, we can.
How do you know that?
Have you seen another ghost?
Yes, I have.
I've seen many ghosts.
Who?
I met George Washington.
Oh, yeah?
What does he look like?
He has...
What's his middle name?
Oh, so you didn't actually, like, meet him.
You didn't really...
Okay, Doki, what's my middle name, huh?
I don't know, I haven't met you.
That's next week.
I'll know your middle name next week.
This is like a phone call.
This is a phone call.
It's not like I actually met you.
It's like...
It's like a seance, you know?
Good amount of diamond and redstone all together.
Oh my god, I hit level 15.
Let's go.
Just level 15?
What level are you?
16.
I'm level 16.
Wow.
Remember when you were saying that about my...
When you had 11 diamonds and I had 10?
Okay, fine then.
Yeah.
I remember.
Now I'm level 16.
Wow, now I'm level 17.
Good for you.
No, you're not.
I'm level 16 plus infinity.
Oh, yeah?
I'm level...
I'm level 18 and my dad works at Nintendo.
This is Minecraft!
Who cares if your dad works at Nintendo?
I care!
Minecraft is on the Switch!
Your dad doesn't do anything with Minecraft.
You don't know that.
What if he works in the Minecraft division for the Switch?
You're saying he works at the mines at Nintendo?
Yeah.
It must feel like it.
We know how JP companies are.
I think Nintendo is alright though.
Comparatively speaking.
Yeah.
No, was it Nintendo?
Wasn't there an article of one of the...
Wait, we need Lapis, right?
Yeah, and we also need sponsorship, so...
Okay, yeah, you're right.
I love Nintendo.
Let's go, Nintendo!
I have like more than a stack of Lapis.
Do we need more than one stack of Lapis?
I have almost two stacks.
Okay, I have almost two stacks as well.
Yeah, so I think...
It really depends on our RNG.
I love Nintendo, guys.
Flip it and chip it.
Oh my gosh, I don't want to do this again.
Doki, we can't die.
Why are you saying that to me?
We have to make it.
Are you trying to imply something?
We have to make it to the Ender Dragon.
I don't think I can strip mine again.
I can't strip mine.
I can't go back to stripping, Min.
How did the other streamers that you were inspired by...
How did they do this?
It took them...
It took them 20 days, Min.
I don't think that they are the...
I don't think they are like the...
The goal of like...
Are we doing it right, chat?
Are we doing this right?
I don't think we are.
I don't think we're meant to even have diamond.
I think they're like...
Are we though?
We could do this with iron.
Wait!
What if we built snowmen?
Like, you remember?
Oh yeah!
We need to find the ice biome and just farm snow.
Okay.
That won't kill the Endermen, I think.
It won't kill anything else.
Yeah, no, it would hit the Ender Dragon as well.
Does it?
Yeah.
Make an army of snowmen?
Yeah, yeah.
Pretty sure that works.
Snowballs don't do damage.
Wait, what the point was to make snowmen?
Why did we do that?
Yeah, why did we do that?
Why did we do that then?
I think you're the one that suggested it too in the past.
No, it's not!
Don't put this on me!
Why did we do that?
Oh, it was to stagger?
They can only hurt...
Blazes.
But we didn't even do that for the Blazes.
Oh my god, we gotta find the fucking fortress.
No, we don't need a...
We need blaze rods.
It's fine, we did a fire resistance potions.
We'll be fine.
Will we though?
Probably.
Will we be fine?
Where's your name?
I don't even see your name anymore.
I don't even know anymore.
I've been stripping for...
I've been stripping my...
I don't wanna go back to stripping.
Guys, I can't.
I can't do it again.
I need to turn down the music a little.
I'm going a little crazy.
What's your music?
It's just like a free BGM channel.
Called BGM present or some shit.
I think I ran into your...
It's in my...
It makes the fight easier.
Also, we weren't crazy.
We weren't crazy then.
Crazy?
I was crazy once.
They locked me in a strip mine.
A mine full of strippers.
I wish.
Oh my gosh.
What if we find the...
What's that thing?
That new thing.
The what?
The crippling?
The crinkler?
Whatever the fuck that was.
What's that thing?
The trials.
The trials?
The fuck is that?
How many things did they add since I last played?
It's crazy.
Minecraft is crazy now.
The scruggly?
Oh, I hear a skelly.
Where am I?
No skelly, please.
What if I like...
What if like...
I grabbed that moment again and then redubbed it to like...
Change redubbed it to names.
What?
You know the first moment?
Oh, yeah.
And I redubbed a name so the moment can live on.
What if we...
We dub over the names and then we also refilm it.
Because our skins would be different.
No, we reanimate it.
We can make the whole environment look the exact same.
Oh my god, you're right.
We can just do it in creative mode.
Just react it.
We can do it.
What is it called?
The react videos?
When they...
It's fair use, guys.
Fair use.
We can just...
We're just like...
It's like a very famous moment that happened in Minecraft.
Yeah, yeah.
It's like a parody.
We're making a parody.
We're not claiming we own it.
We're just trying to parody it because it was such a...
It was such a famous moment in the internet.
It's so viral.
It's transformative.
It's transformative, exactly.
Like even...
What's it?
Squackity knows about that moment.
Everyone who plays Minecraft knows that moment.
What was it called?
Even ThomasInnit knows about it.
ThomasInnit.
Yeah, it was TommyInnit.
TommyInnit.
It's YouTube history.
It's literally...
It's a tribute we'd be making.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're making a tribute.
Exactly.
Oh my god, I'm going crazy.
I have 23.
I'm almost there.
Wait, actually, I have it.
I should be able to make a full army.
Wait, how many do you have?
I only have 15.
What the heck?
Nothing's changed.
Clearly, nothing has changed.
I'm at least finding more.
I didn't even acknowledge it.
Because I was like, surely...
Surely, she's finding stuff, right?
I'm not finding anything.
That's unfortunate for you.
I was finding it at first this whole time.
Okay, to be fair, you mine faster because you have a diamond pickaxe.
Are you trying to say that was a good investment?
Is that what you're trying to say?
I'm saying you invested...
Wait, what I did there, where I got a diamond pickaxe, and you're like, no, don't do it.
Good is subjective, okay?
Good is subjective.
I'm just slow because I have just only iron.
Are you calling me...
Okay, now you're making fun of me for being poor?
That's so messed up.
That's how the world works, baby.
I'm just trying to make my way through this damn poor world.
The rich gets richer!
That's why you gotta learn now.
I can't believe you still don't have...
I can't believe you have 15.
Okay, well, you know what?
You're just gonna have to keep digging because you're gonna wait for me.
That's fine.
And then I'll get more...
Damn.
You can't break the cycle.
I swear to god, if you die after everything, I'm mine all the way till...
Till I have my full armor.
I swear to god.
Do it!
We'll do this again.
No, I'm fine.
I'm looking.
I'm doing it again.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Go kill yourself right now in Minecraft.
If I come back and you're still alive, I don't know.
Okay.
Is she gone?
What was that?
Guys, did you hear that running?
It was like a...
Wait, what was that?
Was it me mining that first?
Actually, I don't know.
Guys, I almost have enough.
I almost have enough diamonds.
The crinkler.
That wasn't...
That sounded different.
No, there's a skeleton right there.
I think he's on the other side.
Are you actually gonna die?
I heard running.
Running?
Wait, that's not in the game.
I don't know.
I think Herobrine's coming for me.
Oh, thank god.
I think Herobrine's here for me.
It's all...
You just had like a Halloween mod on.
This entire time.
Yeah.
Oh, skellies.
Okay, I think I'm about to hit...
Have you got any new diamonds since...
Since then?
Since 15?
Are you still at 15?
I'm... Yes.
What happened?
I'm strapping and also there's someone running after me.
Oh my god, what's that sound?
Eerie cave.
Where the fuck did I put my crafting table?
Oh, right here.
I didn't pick it up.
Scary.
Scary cave.
What do I wanna make?
Oh yeah, I wanna make an iron pickaxe.
My other pickaxe is almost dead.
How do we get to the crinkler?
What biome is he in?
Yeah, what is the crinkler?
I don't even know.
Yeah, I don't know.
The only thing I know about the crinkler is what you just told me.
He crinkles.
He just crinkles.
He's behind me.
Wait, do I have one rail?
Oh, I do.
I have one singular rail track.
Wow.
I'm gonna go crazy.
I'm so mining because somebody still doesn't have 24.
I'm trying!
I'm mining!
Are you though?
Are you really trying?
I am!
I'm mining!
Oh, I'm gonna find your...
Okay, I'm gonna find where your hole is.
Then what?
You're gonna steal my diamonds?
No, I'm gonna help you!
You'll steal my diamonds from me and then you'll be like...
Oh, I have all the diamonds.
That's what you'll say.
I don't wanna be stuck in these mines anymore.
You're not welcome into my hole.
You're not consenting.
Stay out!
I better not see you.
I don't know where you are.
I don't know either.
I've been in this one area.
If you just keep going forever, you'll eventually get there.
My great-great-grandchildren are gonna be in this one mine.
Okay, but we gotta get more levels too, so...
I'm at level 18!
How many more levels do we need?
Do you know how much it costs to level up stuff?
I don't remember how much!
No, I don't!
Do you remember?
It costs a lot.
How much is a lot?
Like 50.
There's no way it's 50.
It's a lot, I promise.
There's no way.
It's not 50.
Fucking...
Having backseaters in my chat, telling me how to dig.
Oh my god, good.
I don't know, mid!
You're at 15!
I don't have these backseaters!
That's all I'm saying!
I got to 24, and I don't have these backseaters right now!
We don't!
We need more than 24!
Doki!
Oh my god, I want...
I want...
I have 3 extra.
What more do we need?
Wait, what do you mean you have 3 extra?
I have 3 more.
I have 3.
I made all my...
I had more than 24.
Oh, wait.
How much is a sword then?
Wait, I can make a sword right now.
I can literally make a sword right now.
You didn't say that!
I'm digging.
I'm digging too.
I might as well make another diamond pickaxe.
Might as well use the last 3 to make a diamond pickaxe.
Oh, fuck it.
I'm going to do it.
I don't know how long I'm going to be trapped in this mine.
I don't know how long I'm going to be trapped in here.
Might as well make another diamond pickaxe.
I'm going to go mad.
I'm going to get mad strip disease.
Are you done?
Yeah.
I'm done.
Guys, I know it's been like 3 hours, but whole Mint was not too quiet.
Because sometimes she hits the green instead of the yellow, so I got a little worried.
Oh, now...
Now what?
Now you finally made armor?
Yeah.
Gotta miss them.
Oh my gosh, I keep clicking the wrong thing.
I'm like auto...
Thank god I didn't.
Don't die!
Someone said you could be a little louder.
Oh my god, no, don't say that.
It's been 3 hours.
She could have been a little louder 3 hours ago.
I don't know.
I don't know what's wrong with my discord.
I really don't.
Yeah, like I have you like...
Oh my god.
You apparently could have been a little louder.
That's not my fault.
Yes it is.
There's something wrong with your discord.
You changed the setting.
I didn't change anything though.
I have to get the diamond pickaxe.
What?
I'm going fast now.
Okay, I upped her a bit more, guys.
So I hope it's a lot better now.
No, you're like barely in the yellow.
Am I like quiet on my stream?
No, you're not.
You're not quiet on your stream, it's just...
You did something to your discord...
That like...
Made it so that it's...
Like, I don't know what...
Something with your setup...
But all my settings are... I've sent you my settings.
They're all normal.
Yeah, but like...
There was a time where suddenly it was just different.
Where you're like super quiet for everybody on discord.
And I don't know what you did.
I don't know what?
I didn't do anything!
Discord's trying to sabotage me!
I don't know what you did.
I didn't do anything.
That's what they all say.
Alright.
My diamond pickaxe is about to break.
This is how long we've been trip mining for.
Mint.
My diamond pick...
Yeah, I guess finally.
We've been mining for like an hour plus, I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure I've been stuck in the...
I haven't seen daylight in like 20 years, Mint.
Wait, how do we get out of this?
We just make a fucking...
ladder staircase.
How did your bird take up?
We've always done that before.
Okay.
I wish we had fortune.
Me too.
I wish a lot of things, Mint.
I wish...
I wish you'd get more diamonds.
Like at this point, now it's just sad.
This is just sad now.
Hey, I'm doing my best, okay?
Are you?
You could've made a diamond...
If you were doing your best, you could've made a diamond pickaxe.
I made one!
Now, after an hour and a half...
It doesn't matter how long it took me.
Yes, it does!
It could've been over!
We would've been out of the mining stages!
Don't you want this to go?
How long do you want this stream to go?
I will cancel my other streams...
if you're gonna do this.
Wow.
That pickaxe is about to die?
Well, good thing I have enough for another pickaxe!
Oh my god, that was...
Oh my god, that was lava.
Okay.
YouTube streams can only go up to 12 hours.
That's why we'll make a part 2!
Yippee!
Yahoo!
Do you have a lot of iron?
I have...
20.
Okay, we might need more for...
Shields.
Okay.
That's 5.
Yeah.
Part 2 is still in the mines!
At one point, it doesn't turn into a joke.
It's not my fault that my luck is very bad!
If it was luck, you could have made a diamond pickaxe!
At that point, it's not luck, it's a skill issue.
Okay, time to make my fucking...
another diamond pickaxe!
Let's fucking go!
I don't even have fucking...
I need to make another stick.
Alright, here we go.
I'm going down a different direction now.
Alright.
I feel promising this way.
Good for you.
We don't need redstones, right?
No, we don't need redstones!
Okay, I've been in the mines for so long...
I keep forgetting what we need and what we don't need now.
All I see is just cobblestone.
What if this was beating Minecraft?
Like, what if the mine...
That's Minecraft!
Oh yeah, you're trying to say...
Do you know the worst part, Mint?
The nether is supposed to be the hardest part out of this.
The nether is supposed to be the hardest part.
Supposed to be.
All we need are...
We need some green mushrooms to get rid of the hogs.
We need some...
We need some lava to kill hogs.
Oh, we're good!
We need some potions.
We just gotta go find a village with a potion place thing.
And we're good.
Okay.
Yeah, and what if a ghastly comes up to us while we're crossing the...
A ghastly?
What game are we playing now?
Oh, sorry, I have a Cobblemon mod on.
What if, like...
What if, you know, the ghast comes in and goes...
And then, like, we fall into the lava.
What do we do?
What if we don't do the shields in time?
What happens?
What if I don't do it in time?
What if I don't do this in time?
I mean, I can't.
I don't know what's gonna happen if we die on this run.
I don't know what's gonna become of me.
I don't know what's gonna happen to me.
Because then we have to do this all over again.
This specific part of the run.
At that point, I'm not even gonna...
I don't even wanna...
At a point, we might as well just do it with Iron.
I don't care anymore.
She's really losing it, guys.
She's so weak!
It's only been hour three!
You're dead already!
You're weak!
You're dead!
You're literally a ghost!
So what does that have to do with it?
You don't care about dying, because you're already dead.
Yeah!
Join me!
What do you want me to say?
The strip madness is getting to me.
Oh, it's already hit.
It's already hitting.
How much more can you take?
Are you still at 15?
You're still at 15, aren't you?
I just found three more diamonds!
And you're still...
I'm doing my best!
I'm gonna find your hole.
I'm gonna find your hole and dig that hole.
I'm fucking coming back.
Let me dig this.
Alright.
Give me your coordinates.
No!
Find my hole!
Give me your coordinates!
I'm coming over.
I'm running over now.
You don't even know where I am.
Oh my god, there's so many holes.
There's so...
There's so many holes.
I'm surprised no monsters spawn into any of these holes that we've created.
Honestly, I'm surprised too.
Wait, but seriously.
How much more can you take?
I think this is your hole.
No, this is my hole?
Oh wait, this is the hole I dug with lava.
Okay.
Unless that's my hole with lava.
How many holes with lava did you find?
Wait, did you leave a...
I just need to know.
Did you leave a hole unattended with like lava?
Yeah.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Like, did you leave a hole where like...
I could accidentally walk into?
Where there's...
Where it's a pit?
I don't think so.
Okay, alright.
Alright, that's good to know.
Okay, thank you.
I think I want to just find one more.
Okay.
I'm gonna try and find you right now.
Oh my god, how long have I been digging?
This does not stop.
What?
This...
This doesn't stop.
Holy shit.
I dug a lot.
No, I'm still at my hole.
Oh.
Damn, Doki, okay.
Okay, I found your hole.
I'm pretty sure you have torches.
Torches, okay.
Oh, you left this.
You left the redstone.
Yep, precious experience.
You need the experience!
Oh, the experience, yeah.
Okay, you put torches in your hole, right?
Not all of them.
Alright, this has to be your hole.
I didn't put any torches in mine.
Okay.
Oh my god, this is a long ass hole.
Oh.
Okay, you must have one.
Go into the right one, I've changed a couple times.
Okay.
Which one?
This is the one with lava.
What the fuck is this?
It's what?
Mine is so much more straightforward.
It's so straightforward.
Like, what are these?
Oh my god.
Oh, did you find my...
I found your cross section.
Oh, no, no.
I ran into your hole.
Ran into my hole?
Yeah, at one point I ran into your hole.
Yeah, but you were in the cross section.
Wait, why did you stop here?
Why did you go back here?
I just wasn't feeling it, I don't know.
Oh my god.
You stopped before you hit it big.
You're like those gamblers.
What?
Keep going then.
Did I hit it big there?
Did I miss out?
Alright, I'm gonna do it.
Wouldn't be funny if you missed out.
Maybe I did.
Wouldn't be so funny if you missed out.
I'm gonna keep digging.
I'm gonna dig this hole and see if you missed out.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm digging.
I'm digging the hole you fucking stopped at.
I mean, if you eventually get to something...
It has to be within like 5 hits.
5 hits?
Yeah.
5 hits, so you're like, you know...
You're like changing the rules then.
What?
No, because...
That's the meme.
You hit it big right before you get to it.
It's not like you hit it big after like 50 hits.
That's just anybody doing that.
No, no, no.
It means you gave up too early.
You just gave up so easily.
No, no.
That's not the meme.
That doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter because you're the one that gave up.
But anybody...
I didn't give up.
Who was the one that made the full set of armor?
Who was the one that made the...
I stopped digging because I finished my task.
Oh, what is this?
Among Us now?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
At least I finished it.
I finished my goal.
Somebody hasn't finished their goal.
I just want to find one more stack.
Okay?
God.
Hello, Redstone Doe.
I'm almost at level 20.
Me too.
What's your level?
19.
Just like you said.
I'm almost at level 20.
I don't know.
It could be level 18.
Oh, so you're at level 18, huh?
No, I'm level 19.
I just thought you weren't good enough to be level 19.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
How much more do I have to dig?
I don't know.
I'm digging your hole right now.
Why is it that I'm the one that's more sane than you?
Because I know we're gonna die.
I know.
No, we have to beat this eventually.
I know this is not the run.
I know I'm going...
What do you mean this is not the run?
You're still the young optimistic.
You're still young and optimistic.
But I know.
I know we're gonna be doing this all over again.
I know this isn't it.
Is it because I only have 15 diamonds?
I know that I have to repeat this all over again.
Right?
Well then you can find all the diamonds and just give them to me.
Since you have better luck.
I thought this was a team game.
I thought...
Clearly I'm not doing well enough.
I found diamonds.
I found diamonds in your hole.
Okay, but that was like 20 minutes later.
Oh my god.
It doesn't matter.
It was so long.
It was not right there.
Six.
Six diamonds in the hole you gave up on.
Six diamonds.
You gave up.
No, no, no.
This is to teach you a lesson to never give up.
You gave up.
I'm still going.
I didn't give up because I'm still here and I'm still digging.
How many times did you change?
How many times?
I'm going to go find another one of your pathways that you fucking gave up on.
Okay, do it.
Come find me.
You'll never find me.
I'll never find you.
I'm so fucking lost.
I don't even know which one was the hole I dug and which one was...
That could have even been your hole then.
It could have even been your hole.
No, it's your hole.
Hey, Min.
Why do I have some wisps ratting you out in my chat?
I'm going to dig up.
I'm going to start digging up.
Somebody has a full set.
I'm going to dig up.
I'll meet you up on the fucking surface.
I'm going to meet you on the fucking surface, you fucking whore.
Oh yeah, so loyal.
So loyal.
No, it has to be the dragoons coming over to see how much I have left.
It has to be the dragoons coming over to see how much I have left.
It has to be the dragoons.
I'm fucking going.
I'll see you up on the surface.
No!
I don't know where my... what's it called?
Dragoons would never...
No, the dragoons are the ones that ratted me out.
No, dragoons would never...
How dare you guys.
Dragoons would fucking never do that.
Who snitched?
Give me names.
Give me names right now.
I know all my wisps.
I'll be able to know.
I'll be able to...
Oh yeah?
Alright.
Let's see.
Who was it that snitched?
Eragon Battleborn.
That's a dragoon.
No, no, no.
You know what?
I bet it's even a wisp goon.
Oh, they're the worst.
You know what?
This person, they're not even a member.
But I bet they're a member in your chat.
Check if they're a member in your chat.
Eragon, show up on Mint's chat right now.
I want to see if you're a member.
I want to see.
Eragon was not a member in my chat.
They're not a member.
They're a gifted...
Oh my god, you have a gifted member?
Show yourself, Eragon.
I can't see them.
Stop gifting memberships.
They said I'm an SSRB.
What is that?
SSRB?
Are they a member?
No, they're not a member.
Okay, okay.
They're like an inside job.
Oh, they're a fan of Botan.
You're not even watching.
We're Indies.
Get out of here.
It was a Psycopse.
It was a Psycopse all along.
What's so sad is that they wouldn't even say like, Yeah, I'm a fan of you.
Not even for the bit.
Oh my god, we're at minus 26 right now.
You're at minus 26?
I think the worst part...
Oh my god, I hope we dig up to the fucking...
Not to the mountain.
I hope we got out of the mountain area.
Well, once you get to...
Something, just dig.
Over.
Okay, I don't know if I'm in the mountain, though.
That's the thing.
Oh wait, I'm gonna start taking my torches back.
Are you not digging up?
No.
I guess I could get some.
I could've done everything.
I'll dig eventually.
I'm waiting for you in the surface.
You're only prolonging your torture.
Your torture?
I'm fine.
You're only prolonging...
You think you're gonna be fine, Tia?
What do you mean by that?
You think you're gonna be fine.
And then we're gonna do like 20 more of this.
And then you're gonna be like...
Oh my god, Doki, why did I...
Okay, I'm getting to a safe spot.
What did they say?
Why are you saying LOL at them?
Wait, what?
I don't know.
Where did I dig to?
Is this another cave?
Don't die.
You better not die.
You have diamond armor.
You're good.
You don't want to prolong this?
What happened, man?
I thought you wanted to do more mining.
No, we're still playing.
I thought you loved mining.
Oh, you left some...
Some sweet, sweet...
Experience.
Oh wow, there's a lot here, actually.
You left all the redstone.
Redstone.
Oh no, not the fucking redstone.
Oh no.
Doki.
It's okay, I have diamond armor.
You're alive.
I just took a creeper hit in the face.
But like, I'm...
You have a shield?
You also have a shield?
Yeah, but I have my pickaxe and torches out.
But it's okay.
I'm scared to go up like this, man.
It's okay, everything is fine.
I took a...
Creeper shot to the face.
But it's okay.
You're fine, probably it's fine.
I took two creeper hits in the face, by the way.
Why don't you use your shield?
You know what, I'm not scared anymore.
I literally took two creeper...
I took two creeper hits in the face and I'm okay.
That's why we get the armor.
See, you were like, oh, I wanna do this with iron.
No, no, no.
Look at that.
This is why we do things with diamond armor.
Duh.
Oh my God, I thought that was a creeper again.
I don't know.
I'm seeing things now.
I'm seeing things, guys.
I wanna leave here.
I'm sick of mining.
Oh, now you're sick of mining.
Oh, you're so sick of mining now.
I hate mining, it's boring.
Oh my God.
I don't even know where I am.
Witch giggles?
Oh shit.
Okay, I might be in trouble.
Wait, do you have subtitles on?
Yeah, of course.
Oh, I should have that.
I should have that too.
Yeah, you should have that.
Where's the subtitles at?
Chat settings?
No.
I don't remember, guys.
Accessibility?
Oh, there we go.
That's a good idea.
Okay, I gotta get out of here.
I'm at negative 42.
You're at negative 42?
I'm at 33.
I'm in a bad spot.
Oh my God, there's a witch right next to me.
Oh shit.
Wait, am I like... Shouldn't I be in the surface now?
I'm at 33.
You're probably... We're in the mountains.
We're still in the fucking mountains?
Probably.
Just dig to the side.
I'm gonna dig to the side.
Actually, 33 is not very high.
Maybe...
Wait, I found... Wait, there's like...
Not found, there's like dirt in front of me.
Oh, see?
Then you might be good.
Might be close then.
Nevermind, the dirt stopped.
The dirt stopped.
Oh, surface is at 60 plus.
Keep going.
Oh, God.
Fucking... Okay.
I'll keep going then.
Maybe I'm good.
Maybe I'm okay.
Oh my God.
Oh, I'm gonna...
You're gonna what?
I'm gonna cry.
You won't like it...
When I cry.
That's so mean.
Then it'll be too real.
It'll be too real.
I'll cry.
Okay, that's another room.
Oh my God, no.
Get me out of these stupid ass rooms.
Oh my God, I hear the witch still.
How do you still hear the witch?
I'm trying to get out of here.
I'm digging around.
I'm strip mining again.
Oh, diamond.
You're still strip mining.
I'm trying to get out of here.
I'm trying.
Your grandchildren will live in these mines.
It's okay, I got a lot of diamond here.
It would be a shame if you died.
Maybe...
You know what?
I'm just gonna build a staircase.
Oh, yeah.
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
Nevermind, nevermind, nevermind.
Oh, look at that.
I'll see you in the surface.
I'll see you on the surface.
I'm almost there.
I am at...
62.
I don't wanna be in here by myself.
Then maybe you shouldn't have been...
Maybe you shouldn't have fucked with me, man.
Maybe you should've pretended you didn't have any diamonds on you.
You should've come found me.
You said you were going to.
What happened?
You lied.
I keep hitting... I just keep hitting cave.
That's karma.
That's actually karma.
Little by little.
I can't always hit a cave.
Right, guys?
Little by little.
It'll be a shame.
What, you want me to die?
I will.
Do it.
I asked you.
I don't want to.
I knew you wouldn't.
I'm a ghost.
I'm already dead.
I want to appreciate life.
You don't appreciate life.
You just want me to waste my...
I don't appreciate life.
I'm almost there.
Calm down.
What number?
20.
I'm at level 20.
Why are you at 20?
I'm at level... I'm talking about leveling.
No, I was talking about...
I'm at level 21.
Oh my God.
Well, I was testing you.
I was actually level 22.
Okay, let's from now on...
No lies.
That's a fucking lie already.
What do you mean?
No, we're teamwork.
We're teamwork.
Make the dream work.
Let's not lie, guys.
And I didn't lie.
I just didn't tell you...
how much I had.
You assumed every time.
I literally asked you.
I was like...
How many do you have?
And I was like...
Do you still have 15?
And you're like...
I'm in the surface now.
I'm at the surface.
I'm literally... I'm here.
I'm almost there.
Oh my God.
No, you're not.
What number?
I'm at...
2.
Didn't you just say you were at 20 earlier?
Didn't you tell me so you lied and...
No, I said negative 20.
Oh, I hit not big rock.
Okay.
Or the regular rocks.
This will go so much faster now.
Do you have a bed on you?
A bed?
Yeah.
Okay, it's almost night.
Yeah, you gotta sleep now.
Okay, I'll sleep.
I'll sleep.
I'm sleeping.
Why aren't you sleeping?
Oh, there you go.
I'm sleeping.
Also, you didn't say negative 20, by the way.
You said 20.
W.
Might I remind you...
You wanted to do this collab with me.
That you were very excited to do this.
I am.
I'm still excited.
Are you not excited?
You're the one who's crying.
I'm so excited.
Let's see.
I'm at...
11.
I'm almost there.
I'm at...
I was at 101...
To get here.
We're on a mountain.
You might not be, actually.
You might have dug further away from me.
I think...
Wait.
What's your...
X and Z?
Hold on.
Oh, that was water dripping.
I'm at...
Negative 3558...
And 1771, but I'm having to change it.
3558.
Guys, remember that for me.
Well, I'm digging, like, not up up.
I'm digging through...
I'm digging, like, what's it called?
A staircase.
Wait, what's your Z again?
Guys, what's your Z, guys?
What's your Z?
My Z?
I don't know.
Hold on.
1771.
Okay.
I need to go this way then.
Yeah, you're far.
No!
I threw away my bombs!
Could've grabbed a dog.
You could've grabbed a dog.
I'm afraid I'm towering from here.
What if there's someone up there?
Oh my God, you're so far.
I'm scared.
Okay, I'll do a little bit.
Oh.
Yeah, you might not hit the mountain, because you're really far.
I am?
Yeah, you're far from where I dug up.
Okay.
Oh God.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
I'm just gonna...
It's fine, we can do here.
First, I'll grab the iron.
Alright, I'm heading over.
I can staircase from here.
I'm heading over.
I'm heading over to where you're gonna show up.
I might be different though, because I'm staircasing.
Are you not staircasing, like, the same direction?
I have to switch, because I just hit a big cave.
Okay, what's your number now?
I'm heading towards...
Numbers.
1767.
No, I'm still heading the right way.
1767, okay.
Okay, you might actually dig a mountain.
Oh, you are on top of a mountain.
You're in the mountain.
You're in the big ass mountain.
I'm at 34.
I'm climbing, it's 99.
It's 99.
You might need to get out of that.
I'm climbing, I'm climbing too.
Oh, shit.
Stupid ass cave.
You're actually...
Oh, I see the surface, kind of.
Okay, yeah, you're literally on top of a mountain.
On top of a mountain.
Jesus.
By the way, you gotta dig 133.
If you wanna get it.
I'm at 47.
I'm close, I'm close.
I'm close, I'm close, I'm close.
I'll wait for you at the top of the mountain.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, where are you at?
I'm at 1757.
1757.
Let's see.
17, yeah, I'm at 17.
What's your X again?
What's your X?
I'm at 3579.
Are you right there?
Guys, what was the Z again?
What's the Z?
Are you right on top of me?
Oh, it's okay, I'm at 60.
I'm almost there.
Yeah, you're definitely almost there.
I'm playing the game.
Why does it get higher?
Wait, what's your X and Y?
I'm not telling you anymore.
What do you mean?
You're gonna make fun of me.
I'm almost there.
I can feel it.
You can feel it?
I'm over halfway.
What's your Y?
If I keep stopping to tell you, I won't keep digging.
Nice, I got lots of coal.
This is a lot of coal.
Holy moly.
Oh my gosh, there's so much coal here.
That's insane.
There's so much coal.
Okay, I'm level 50 now.
What?
Okay, I'll give up.
Why are you giving up?
What?
I don't even need to do what I was doing.
I still have a long way to go.
I'm almost there.
Oh yeah, that's why I'm not telling you my location.
Because that's what you'll fucking do.
Do what?
You'll sabotage me.
How would I sabotage you?
You already sabotaged yourself.
How would I sabotage myself?
You already sabotaged...
You'll find out.
You'll find out when you get to the top.
Oh, is it night time?
No.
That's not it.
What?
Oh, am I underwater?
You'll find out.
You'll find out when you get to the top.
How much are you adding to the top of the mountain?
I don't need to.
What do you mean?
You don't even know where I am.
Yes, I do.
No, you don't.
I don't need to.
You don't even know where I am.
Alright, what's your why?
I'm not telling you anything.
I can't do anything with a why.
You have...
You have sneaky people who are telling me...
Telling you where I'm at.
I need you to tell me where your why is.
I just need to know your why.
The why is different.
The why is what level you are at.
I'm at 90.
Alright.
Gosh, I thought I was about to fall.
What trap have you set up for me?
I have no trap!
I actually...
I don't need to do any trap with what you're doing right now.
Someone came and snitched!
I
don't believe your lies.
I don't need to do any tricks.
Yes, you do.
No, I don't.
You wanna know why?
What I was doing?
I thought, well, it'd be funny if I placed more blocks above.
But like...
And then you told me you were at 30.
And do you know how high this fucking mountain is?
It's a lot more than 30.
It's like 130.
And I didn't even say I was at 30.
Yes, you did.
And that's when I knew I didn't even have to do anything.
I'm gonna come out and you won't know where I am.
Oh, I know where you are.
How do you know where I am?
I know what you are.
This entire mountain fucking covers a lot of blocks.
Yeah, but you don't know exactly where I'm gonna come out on the mountain.
Yes, I do.
Do you see my name?
I don't see you.
I don't even see your name.
Because you still have to dig!
I'm digging!
You still have a long way to go.
Guys, how much do I have to go?
What's the top?
Where are you at?
You're the one who's just like...
I'm so tired of digging.
Please, why won't you just dig out?
Oh, and now look at you.
Look at you.
Oh, you're not even that high.
Oh my gosh.
You're so dramatic.
140 is not that...
I got out at 66.
I had to climb up this mountain to get to where you are.
Um...
Okay, we have an actual problem.
What's the problem?
Sleep.
So...
My pickaxe just broke and I don't have a crafting table.
Do you have a bed?
Yeah, I have a bed.
Okay, put that bed down.
We have to sleep in.
Oh, I can only sleep at night.
Yeah, it's sun is setting.
Sun is setting.
It won't let me sleep.
Not yet, it's setting.
It's not that high, she says.
By the way, I'm sleeping.
I did too.
Yeah, so...
I guess I'm stuck here.
Oh my God, give me your coordinates.
Oh, we're stuck here?
That's fine.
Hold on.
Saving private minutes.
Wait, hold on.
I'm pretty close.
I could punch my way to freedom.
Okay, do it.
There we go, guys.
I don't have a crafting table.
Oh my God.
Oh, I could've just put that in there.
Oh my gosh.
TNT?
Okay, I'm gonna do the TNT method.
Uh-oh.
Spooky sound.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, I have the flint.
I have the flint that will make it...
I swear to God, if you blow up...
and get knocked back into your fucking hole...
I might die.
Probably not.
Alright, 07s, get ready, guys.
07.
This might end up being her fucking...
gravestone at this rate.
Oh,
this sucks.
Do you need me to save you?
I have to punch into the wall.
Do you need me to dig down?
Um...
Yeah.
Alright, what are the coordinates?
Negative 3587.
And then 1693.
Oh my God, why did you...
Oh my God.
1693.
Yeah, I went a little far.
Okay, okay, and then negative 35...
Oh my God, okay.
It's just a couple blocks.
Okay, what's your why?
I see you, I literally see your name.
Oh my God.
What's your why?
Just look down, you'll see me.
I can hear you digging.
I just need to know how much I need to...
You can literally punch his dirt!
Oh my God, it's...
It's stone where I am!
Oh my God.
It's literally stone here!
Dig up, dig up once.
Wait, can you come get me?
Can you come get me?
I made a deep hole, dig up once.
No, I'm stuck.
How are you stuck?
Just use your hands!
Use your hands and climb up.
I digged a hole.
I can't hold on.
Oh my God.
Wait, did you place it again?
What the heck?
I was gonna explode it so that I could get through.
Oh my God.
Hold on, I'm coming through.
Hold on.
Oh, I see you, hi!
Oh my God.
Dig up, dig up.
Hold on, I'm going up.
Oh wait, hold on.
I guess I'll leave him.
Wait, where is it?
Is it night time?
No.
I'm going, I'm going.
This hole sucks.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Do you want me to make a better hole?
I'm sorry.
My rescue mission is not good enough for you.
Oh my God.
You wanna see how high this fucking mountain is?
Look down here.
Hey, you know what?
It's good that we dug a lot.
What if we found the place that we have to put the enderpearls in?
Alright.
Now we gotta get to the nether.
I have lots of gold.
Yeah, now we gotta get to the nether.
I have lots of gold too.
Alright.
Oh wait, hold on.
I'm gonna burn my stuff.
Do you have any obsidian?
I have three on me.
No, I don't have any.
Actually, I really need to punch trees.
I'm gonna go punch this tree over here.
I'm gonna get my furnace too.
I'm gonna make some gold as well.
I'm gonna punch this tree over here.
The single tree on this mountain.
I feel like we should make like a mini house.
Just to put our stuff.
When we find lava, we should make a mini house.
Make more than one furnace.
Wait, no.
Why do I have cobble?
Oh wait, I'm so stupid.
Wait, what happened to my crafting table?
Oh, I fucking broke it.
I never picked it up.
I'm about to make one.
I just want to make another furnace.
Oh, why?
Because I have a lot of stuff to burn.
Oh, me too.
I want to get rid of all of it now.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna throw away my iron stuff.
No, we need the iron stuff.
Yeah, you can throw away your stuff.
Yeah, I don't need my iron sword.
We need the actual iron though.
Why?
For shields.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And water buckets.
I'm planning on doing that.
Wow, the daylight.
Smells good out here.
Wow, I forgot what that looked like for a sec.
Someone just said a spawn point.
That's so funny.
I think they forgot what hardcore meant.
We're never coming back here.
Oh, I can make a lapis blocker.
Right, guys?
Wait, I actually...
I have enough for a lapis blocker.
I have two stacks though, so it's not like...
Of lapis?
I have three stacks.
I have tons of lapis.
How much is a block?
Lapis block.
It still takes two.
I don't need these two lapis.
Here, give me the lapis.
Here, have the two.
Oh, wait, I still don't have enough either.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
Oh, it's no point.
Are you okay?
No.
What else is around here?
I'm not okay.
Did you find any villages while...
No, I just waited on the mountain.
No, I didn't see any villages while I was waiting for you.
Oh, this isn't a house.
This is you trying to...
Trap me in the mountain.
Yeah, and then I gave up.
Because I realized how high up you were.
I was like, there's no point.
There's no point doing this.
There's a point to everything.
No, there's not.
Minecraft.
Oh my gosh, I almost fell in lava.
Oh, wait, we need that.
Okay, I'm gonna make a bucket then.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
There's some lava here.
Wait, actually, no, we don't need...
I mean, we can do it in the...
In the ocean.
Actually, no.
Actually, I'll grab water.
Wouldn't it be easier to just get water?
So you have to make it...
It's like...
You have to make it a certain way so that it actually turns into obsidian...
And not into cobblestone.
Well, if it's like lava itself...
Where are you?
Are you gonna make the lava?
We need a lava pool.
So like, I need to get water and then...
I need two buckets of water, right?
Regardless.
We need to make like...
No, we can use the lava pool to do it.
So I just need the water.
Yeah, but we need lava for protection in the nether.
What?
Why don't we just mine the obsidian?
I mean, if we get the pool, then we can mine the obsidian.
No, it'd be easier to just...
Make it...
We just pour water to get the bottom first.
And then mine and create the...
Okay, okay.
Let me grab water first.
And then...
I'll just pour water in it.
And then mine it and then we just build off the three blocks.
To make the thing.
Okay, you'll understand when I do it.
We need water first.
That's kinda hard to get on top of the mountain.
Yeah, but the lava pool is...
I can just climb back up.
What else do I need?
Oh, let me just get the...
Burn the rabbit meat now.
You know that if...
Okay, so...
You know how to make it stop being...
Blowing lava?
The lava block itself.
If the lava is like the main...
The main source, then it should be fine.
Why don't we just find a lava pool?
And then mine from it then.
Isn't that the lava pool?
Didn't you say there's a lava pool back there?
No, it was a little tiny thing of lava.
That's it.
Okay, nevermind.
Oh my gosh, you made it seem like...
I thought you meant...
No, this is...
Miscommunication from somebody.
I wonder who...
Fucking gave me the wrong information.
Who could it be?
I mean, we could go back into the mines.
No, we're not going...
We're not going back into the mines.
Okay, we gotta sleep.
That's my bed!
No, it's not!
I don't have a bed now!
Get out of my bed!
There we go.
Why do you have a blue bed?
Because I wanted a blue bed.
Well, I called dibs on this color for...
I saw you take it!
I literally saw you take it!
This is why we can't have nice things.
This is exactly why we can't have nice things.
Okay, we're gonna go find...
We're gonna go find a lava pit.
Alright.
There's tons of them in this forest.
There should be, yeah.
Alright.
Oh, look!
That looks like lava down there.
Where?
In that big, big cave.
I'm not gonna go to the caves and make the fucking nether stuff.
Why not?
My god, do you wanna die?
What do you mean, why not?
Oh, don't go down.
That's how you die!
Oh my god, you're...
Just fall down.
We literally have diamond armor, just fall.
I don't wanna take any damage.
I don't wanna damage my armor at all.
Just fall down, we can repair it.
We have so much diamonds to repair it.
No, I'm not wasting my diamonds to repair it.
We gotta get mending.
Maybe.
We're not gonna have time to get mending!
Why not?
Oh my god, we're gonna have
to...
Okay, alright.
Alright, I'm calm.
We gotta get at least the projectile stuff.
And we gotta also get...
Slow falling potions.
And we gotta get here...
Oh, I left my bow.
Oh my god, there's trees everywhere.
There's trees everywhere.
There weren't trees in the caves.
There's trees everywhere right now.
I'm literally farming trees now.
I'm still in the caves, mentally.
Oh no, the cave madness.
She's just standing there.
Why is she just standing there?
I'm mentally in the caves.
I was switching my items.
My god!
Oh, there's pillagers here.
What?
Where?
Right behind me.
Where are you?
I'm literally...
Wait, where are you?
See, this is why we can't make a good team.
There you go.
Watch out, he's right behind you.
Just come at me here.
Just run, it doesn't matter.
He doesn't matter.
He literally does not matter.
Don't kill him.
Run away, don't kill him.
I know, he'll start the raid.
Yeah, we have to not have a raid happen.
Okay, wait, give me a second.
I need to put my shield on.
Where did my diamond sword go?
He's coming for me!
Oh my god, they're coming for me!
Wait, where did my...
Where did my diamond sword go?
Oh, I never...
Did you not make one?
No, I did.
Oh my god, they're still coming for me.
Wait...
Did I throw it away?
Did you throw it away?
I think I...
Oh, I never made one because I made my pickaxe.
I'm just gonna kill him.
I'll drink milk.
He dropped something.
Wait, what was the potion he dropped?
Bad omen 3, you can drink that.
You have more experience with that.
Wait, you have a bad omen now?
No, I gave it to you.
Wait, you drink it?
Oh, it's not like automatic now?
Interesting.
You don't get bad omen from killing anymore.
What?
That's crazy.
Yeah, yeah, you dropped it as a potion.
You're the one that killed it.
No, I saw that.
No, but you picked up the potion, that's why I asked you what did he drop.
What the heck?
Oh, interesting.
Wait, what was your plan again?
Oh yeah, to find lava pool.
Yeah.
Where's your fucking cocoa beans?
We'll go this way, I feel like...
Wait, where are you?
I'm in the water.
Wait, where did you go?
Did you go in the jungle?
I'm not in the jungle!
Oh, there I see you.
I was gonna go that way too.
That's why I was like, wait a second.
Apparently, it's for use in the tricky trial dungeon.
Whatever that means.
That's the trial dungeon, right?
The thing I talked about before?
Oh, it's that?
Wait, what is that?
I don't know what it is.
How do we use it in that?
Yeah, what does that even mean?
Oh my god, rip everybody's farms.
I see a village!
We don't need a village anymore, right?
Oh wait, nevermind, it's not a village.
It's a nether portal!
Oh, we can use that to make it!
Use that to make the thing.
Just take away the corrupted areas.
Yeah, yeah.
And you have your flint, right?
Yeah.
Okay, alright, we can do this.
Alright.
Oh wow, it's almost nearly complete too.
Okay, we can do this.
Get that corrupted.
Oh wait, we just need one!
I have one, I have one, I have one.
There you go.
I don't think there's any corrupted areas too.
Wait, I think it's not corrupted.
Yeah, I think we're good.
Okay, lighting up.
Okay, let's put...
I'm gonna make another chest.
I feel like...
Let's put away stuff we don't want to take to the nether.
I'm gonna put a crafting table here.
Chest.
I'm gonna make another chest for us.
Get rid of this.
Um, I don't think...
Okay, I'm gonna make some...
Oh, make a gold helmet?
Yeah, yeah, that's what I'm gonna make.
But I wanna make some...
I'm gonna make some bread.
Um...
There we go.
And then...
Helmet.
You can just put it in the chest.
Okay.
I'll put the stuff I don't need in the chest.
We don't need all that coal.
We don't need all this flint.
We don't need the lapis.
I don't trust you with my diamonds, so I'm gonna put it in my inventory.
Hey!
I mean, what?
What's gonna happen if we die?
We're not...
Don't say that.
That's what I'm saying, though.
You were like, oh, I'm just gonna put my diamond in my chest.
Why?
Because if we die, we die.
Because if we come back and then my diamond is gone, then I know why.
No, but the only reason you put your diamond away is if you die.
No, the only reason I put my diamond away is because I don't want you to fucking take it from this random chest that isn't locked.
Yeah, you're...
Donkey comprehension is not comprehending.
Alright, are you ready to go into the nether?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Get a pickaxe?
Wait, why?
I don't have one, actually.
What happened to your...
Oh, yeah, because you broke it.
Yeah, you broke a pickaxe.
Hey, I was using that.
Okay.
Alright, so from here, now we have to...
We find...
We survive.
We have to find a fortress.
Yeah, we gotta survive and...
Alright, I have some...
We gotta feed pigs too for enderpearls.
How many enderpearls do we need?
Um, we can...
Chat, how...
You know what, I didn't ask you.
Chat, how many...
Chat, how many enderpearls do we need, chat?
We need 12, but how many is it...
14 safe?
14, okay.
At least 12.
Make a diamond one?
Okay.
Diamond pickaxe.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Stop pushing me!
I know that.
I literally can see you pushing me.
Stop!
Ow!
Alright, are you ready?
Yeah.
Here I go.
I'm going in.
Alright.
I'm going in too.
Please don't be a jungle.
Okay.
Could be worse.
Not that bad.
This could be worse.
It's not that bad.
There's a pig on a chicken?
Chicken?
How did a chicken get in here?
Are you taking the court?
Yeah, I want the experience.
Oh, this is...
Okay, be careful.
Oh my god.
How did he get the chicken in here?
Wait, there's blue fires now?
Yeah.
What does blue fire mean?
That's like a different biome.
Oh.
That's the soul fire.
Oh!
Okay.
There's no hoglins around here.
But we maybe should...
I don't know what to do first.
I'm just gonna go this way.
Where did you go?
Up?
Here, here.
Oh, you're going up that way?
Okay.
I don't know, I just feel safer going up.
Wait, that's the chicken.
Where are you?
Oh, no, I see you.
Yeah, I'm here.
I guess chickens were originally in hell.
Sounds about right.
Birds are from hell.
Yeah.
As a fellow bird, I agree.
I know.
Alright, I got the nugget.
Oh, there's a Shriner down there.
We don't need him.
He can live here for all I care.
Yeah, I'm sure he wants to otherwise.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
When you take him out...
Oh, there he is!
There's a pig!
It's time to feed you.
Okay, take...
Take the gold!
Let him observe, let him observe.
Observe, observe.
Oh, no, the guy's over there.
What did I get?
I got obsidian.
I got three obsidian.
That's cool.
It's not like we don't need that anymore.
Oh, he's taking it, he's taking it, he's taking it.
Feed him.
There's another guy up there.
I'll go to him.
Yeah, you go to him.
I'll feed this guy.
What the fuck did he...
He gave me gravel?
I gave you gold, sir!
And you gave me gravel?
He gave me fire...
Oh, my God, he's useless.
He's actually useless.
Oh, he's right near me.
He's next to me, he's next to me, he's next to me.
I try to ping, I try to ping.
I press middle mouse button.
Oh, he's looking at me.
Oh, God.
What do we do?
Oh, he's right by the...
By our...
By our portal, even.
What an asshole.
He gave me leather?
Your guy sucks.
Oh, did he give you anything good?
He gave me blackstone.
I haven't talked to him yet, because of the...
The gas.
Okay, come here.
Hey, come here.
Oh, my God.
He keeps giving me blackstone.
I keep getting...
I keep getting gravel and blackstone.
Oh, he gave me...
Boots.
Enchanted boots.
Oh, please.
I don't need this.
He just took my...
The boots and put them on.
He stole your...
He stole the boots.
Oh, I got nether... Oh, you don't need nether bricks either.
Hey, hey, hey, come here, come here.
Yeah, yeah, take that.
I got fucking... Oh, my God.
Give me something good.
I don't need blackstone or...
How is this big?
Special arrows.
I got that too.
This is the worst gacha I ever had.
Oh, I got iron boots.
He gave me fucking iron boots.
Soul speed, okay.
I'm just gonna give him the whole thing.
Here you go.
I'm losing the gacha right now.
I'm not doing well with this gacha.
I'm not...
I'm ditching this one.
I'll give it...
Do you have better gacha?
What did he just give me?
I can't tell.
My inventory is full.
You have better gacha?
You gave me string?
Here's my last gold.
Oh, I gave him a gold.
Oh, my gosh.
Did he just drop it?
What did he give me?
He gave me another stack of string.
This is kind of bad, Doki.
I think we're in trouble.
I got...
I got some soul sand.
Come here, come here.
I didn't get anything.
Oh, God.
Oh, shit.
He came out of nowhere.
I see him.
Oh, my God.
Oh, there's two of them.
They're looking at you.
Sir, I have one more gold.
Sir, please.
I have one more gold.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Please, just one ender pearl.
I have my last...
Don't I have any?
Why gravel?
I don't have a bow.
Why?
Do you think they'll see me if I go down there?
Oh, my God.
Wait, where are you?
I'm afraid to deflect.
Okay, um...
What's the plan?
I'm a little scared.
Of what?
Of dying.
Of the lava.
What do you mean?
Oh, he's looking at you.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna die.
Doki, doki.
Doki, I think I'm dead.
Okay.
I'm just on fire a little bit.
Oh, God.
I would be so sad.
How do we deflect them again?
You just hit it with your sword.
Okay.
Like you're playing b-ball.
Alright, I got this.
I mean, baseball, not b-ball.
I can do this.
Alright.
Why are you scared of deflecting?
Because I'm not good at it.
I've only done it once.
Okay, I'm ready.
Look at me.
Why is he always looking at you and not me?
Where are you?
Yeah, he's right there.
But he's not looking at me.
I don't know.
Wait, we didn't get the portal.
Wait, wait, wait.
Portal coordinates.
No, I got the portal coordinates.
How do we wanna go?
Where do we go?
It's literally right down there.
No, I meant like where do we go to try to find the fortress?
Wherever we can.
I don't know.
Fortresses are random.
Wait, I think I see one right over there.
Wait, really?
Unless that's just built strangely.
Let's just go.
Let's just check it out.
Also get magma cubes because we need...
We need magma stuff for...
For what?
For potions.
Oh my gosh.
Get out of the way, Piggy.
I have a fire charge.
How many fire charges do we need?
No, it's magma.
It's not fire charge.
It's a magma slime.
Who hit me?
Not me.
I think it's the...
It's the magma.
Okay, I give up.
The guy is too close.
So if we go over this way...
Where did you go?
Follow me.
Up here, up here.
We're going around this lava.
We're going around it.
Just go up it.
Be careful of the other lava though.
Here we go.
Why are we so close to that lava?
Why do we have to...
be right next to it?
I don't know.
We don't have to be next to it.
It's fun.
I don't think it's fun.
You're getting closer to the lava than me.
This pig is right on you.
Leave us alone.
He's our biggest fan.
Where are you going?
Here.
We're going up.
What do you mean?
I'm up.
What are you doing?
Where are you?
Just kidding.
I'm doing the wrong thing, I guess.
My fire texture looks really good.
I guess I was doing the wrong thing.
You were doing the wrong...
You're always doing the wrong thing.
I think I didn't actually see one.
Maybe it was just a strange texture.
No, I thought it was one in the distance.
Is that not it?
What is that over there?
What?
Oh, it's just like little...
little trees.
We don't want to go in there, though.
That's where the big pigs are, right?
Yeah, we hate those guys.
We'll just...
We'll just go back here.
Okay.
We might as well.
There's no other way to go.
We'll grab some mushrooms in case.
Is there any pigs around?
I'm gonna grab this gold.
I don't think I see any.
I'm checking.
Watch my back.
I'm watching.
There's nothing here.
There's literally nobody next to you.
Okay.
You're so safe.
You're so safe right now.
Okay.
Alright.
Cool.
What can I throw away?
Soul speed, go away.
Do we need soul sand?
We don't, right?
No.
I'm gonna throw away the gravel.
And...
The crying obsidian.
Hey, why were you so far away?
What the hell, man?
What do you mean?
I was scouting you out.
I had to be high ground.
Oh, there's gold right here.
Nice.
Watch out!
No, no, no.
Oh, okay.
The zombie guys are safe.
Wait, do they get mad if I farm their gold?
Yeah.
Wait, they do?
Yeah, they get jealous.
No, they don't.
Oh, we can get...
Hey, what the fuck, man?
Grab a blue mushroom.
Wait, what for?
And then, we can also probably...
They scare away the big hogs.
Oh, they do?
See?
You're a Minecraft expert.
We can also probably...
How do they scare them away?
Do we just take it out and be like...
Be gone.
Oh, really?
But Warp Forest is good.
This is where all the endermen are.
We can just farm endermen here.
Where are they?
I see one.
Look at it.
Look at it right now.
Look at him.
Where is he?
I'm gonna look at him.
Do you see him?
Yeah, I'm looking at him.
He's not angry.
Look at him closer.
Okay.
Maybe let's build a little house.
He's not angry.
I'm gonna build something.
Look at me.
Look at me right now.
Yeah, I'm looking at you.
Do you think this is good enough?
Oh my god.
Get under here, Doki.
Get under here.
He didn't like it.
Oh, I looked it in his eyes.
He was not happy.
Okay, you didn't drop anything.
You guys, I got the portal coordinates.
I don't know why you guys are like, rip the portal coordinates.
I literally got them.
Alright, we did it.
See, I ain't no coward.
I looked at it.
No, he didn't drop any.
Oh, shit.
He didn't drop any.
I don't think fortune would have mattered.
Don't fall here.
There was a hole right there.
I know.
This is kind of a bad spot.
Hold on, I'm gonna pick up shop.
Pick up shop?
We're gonna move shop.
Yeah, we're gonna move shop.
I'm gonna go this way.
Maybe we should have got fire resistance before we did this.
Maybe.
Oh, yeah.
I told you.
Just a maybe.
Where did you go?
Make a shop.
There's so many endermans here.
Okay.
Shop where?
I see two.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's shop time.
Shop time.
This is it.
This is where we set up the family business.
Let me know when to look.
I'm ready.
Don't look yet.
I'm ready to look.
I'm gonna look.
That's your...
If you feel safe.
Where's the second one?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, I see one.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Oh, God.
Where did he go?
He's dead.
Okay, I got a little worried.
Now we have to worry about a gas tool.
This is not the place to set up shop.
Oh, my God.
I hear him crying.
Why did you do it again?
There's literally a gas on the run.
I'm gonna look at him.
I'm gonna do it.
Where is the gas?
He's like all the way over there.
How do we make a bow?
Do we have enough stuff for it?
I have string.
A boat or a bow?
A bow.
I can.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my God.
Yes.
Am I looking at him?
Okay, do something about it.
I don't know.
Where did he go?
Oh, he's not happy.
Kill him.
I don't know where he went.
Just stay under the rocks.
He'll come back.
He's just staring at me.
Oh, my spectral arrows.
That's right.
You guys are so smart.
Hello.
What you gonna do?
Pussy?
Yeah, that's right.
What you gonna do?
Nothing.
Yeah, that's right.
He's stuck there.
Was he actually stuck?
Yeah, he's stuck down there.
Dummy?
Yes.
Stupid.
Where did he go?
He disappeared.
I hear the gas again.
I don't see him.
I don't either.
The guy has...
20-20 vision.
Oh, my God.
He's right here.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
Nothing.
Why aren't you under the...
Stay under the 2x2.
Oh, he's right here.
He's on it!
I got enderpearl.
Okay, nice.
First enderpearl, everybody.
We got a first enderpearl.
First enderpearl.
Oh, my God.
Let's figure this out.
People make this look so easy.
I don't know where that ghastly is.
And it's scaring me.
Stop calling it ghastly.
I like ghastly.
I don't like these guys.
You see the minecraft...
The minecraft movie version of them?
No.
Oh, wait.
Maybe I did.
They have, like, hair.
Ew!
They're, like, made out of...
Skin and stuff.
Shut up, guys.
Wait, let me...
You can't pause the game in minecraft.
Don't use these blocks.
They suck.
Why not?
Because if a ghast gets us, they can blow them up.
They can't blow up other things.
They can't blow up clobble.
Yeah, clobble.
I have one.
Hey, what the hell?
I'm trying to find the ghast!
Mine...
Minecraft movie...
Ghast.
This is what they look like.
They look so ugly.
They're, like...
Made out of skin and, like, hair.
And it looks so weird.
Did you send it to me?
No, not yet.
I'm trying to find discord.
Where did my discord go?
Wait, where is it?
Oh my God, he sounds so close.
Oh wait, here it is.
Oh my God, I see him!
Oh my God, he's really close.
Oh my God, if we were still over there, we would've been dead.
Alright, this is what they look like.
Hold on, I'm trying to fight this guy.
Wait, you're fighting?
Oh, he's too far!
What the hell?
Wait, where are you?
I'm right here.
I'm right next to you.
You're not.
Ew!
Oh my God!
Why'd they make them look like that?
They're made of skin.
It's skin and there's like a little bit of hair on it.
Okay, so the gas is like...
where I'm looking.
It's like that direction.
Oh, we don't have to look there.
We can just go forward.
We made the bridge.
We might as well just go forward.
We'll find more Endermen.
Where are the Endermen?
Oh, I see one!
We're setting up shop!
Set up shop!
Wait, where do you see him?
Where is he?
They're all over there.
I'm looking!
Do you see him?
He disappeared.
Oh no, he's right there.
I'm looking!
I'm looking right at him!
I think I got him.
Alright, nice.
This is so dumb.
Another one!
You said there's another one here?
I thought I saw one.
I thought I saw two.
No, there's one.
You guys wanna see the ugly thing?
Hold on.
Just google Minecraft movie gas.
Yeah, I'll save it.
I'll risk my life for you guys.
I'm destroying a shop.
I'm gonna go find another Enderman.
Oh!
What?
Setting up shop.
The shop is set up.
I found two.
I'm gonna eat meat before I look.
Gotta be hungry first.
Yeah, I'm looking at you.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm looking at you.
What you gonna do?
Yeah, what you gonna do?
I wanna look into your eyes.
I ain't scared.
Wait.
Why isn't it aggroing?
Alright guys, this is what they look like in the movie.
Wait, he...
Wait.
Nasty.
I'm looking.
Yeah, I'm looking at you.
I think you're ugly.
That's right.
Oh, oh.
He baited me!
Wow!
There you go.
He ran away and then ran...
360.
He baited a 360 at me.
Oh, he dropped one too.
He dropped one.
I got three.
Okay.
I can't tell if I aggroed that one or if she did.
I can't tell either.
Wait, there was two.
The other guy despawned.
No.
I'll look around too.
There's two here.
Nice.
Okay, I'm gonna keep that shop.
Keep the...
Shop is set up.
It's like our little food truck.
Yeah.
As soon as you see one, just run.
Look and run back to shop.
Is he following me?
I turned around!
Oh my God.
Oh my God, is he chasing me?
Never look back.
Did he drop one?
I got four.
Yeah, he dropped one.
Well, we're getting lucky.
We're getting lucky with him.
I don't know if he spawned.
Come here.
Drop your goods.
I don't know.
He didn't.
Oh, come on.
It's just me.
Oh my God.
That guy looked at me and then he like...
and then looked and then ran.
Oh, it's probably because he was aggroed on me.
No, no, the other guy.
I found another Enderman.
Don't look back.
I look back.
Oh!
Yeah, get him in the back!
Yeah!
You're in the wrong neighborhood!
We'll take you out.
No, he was broke.
Okay, I need to stop attacking him.
He was fucking broke.
It was a broke boy.
There's a really big drop here.
Look in the trees too.
I'm way too confident with jumping around.
I know.
I'm like, whoa, there's no holes here.
Oh, I think that's just a normal Skelly.
Oh wait, or is that an Enderman up there?
Oh, that's an Enderman.
Is it too far?
Look at him.
Look him in the eye and ask if it's too far.
Oh, he disappeared.
Oh, maybe it was too far.
He was really far.
It's a 50% chance to drop.
Oh wait, I see him!
Where?
Oh, I see him too!
He's really far.
Why is he all the way over there?
I think it's too far.
I don't think he wants to play with us.
No.
What is that?
Was that ambiance or was that an Enderman?
What?
I don't see any near us.
We should just move on from here and see if we can find a fortress.
But we need the Enderpearls.
Yeah, but we're gonna find more Endermans later!
We have 4 out of 12.
The fortress is the more harder...
Like, if we survive the fortress, then it's fine.
Like, if we spend all our time trying to get...
Look!
I think we need to leave and get the fire potions before we go to the fortress.
I think that's our best plan of action.
No, you're 100% right there.
I thought about it, I was like...
No, I think we're gonna fall into...
I think we're gonna fall in that lava.
Wait, what do we need for fire potions?
We need the magma cubes, but...
We might be able to, like...
We can leave that.
Wait, but how do we find the magma cubes?
Oh my God, there's a ghast.
Be careful.
I'm gonna deflect him.
Watch this.
Okay, do it.
I'm gonna watch this.
But if he hits you and, like, you don't deflect...
And, like, it explodes around you...
You might fall into the lava.
I won't watch this.
Do it.
Okay, um...
I thought you said just hit it!
You do!
I don't think so.
Okay, why don't we stand together...
And maybe one of us will hit it.
I don't wanna try that.
I wanna go.
You know what?
I think I can do it.
Just trade with the pigs?
Oh wait, I actually still have more gold.
Wait, I do too.
I can craft...
I'm gonna craft my gold.
Oh yeah, here.
I have 50.
Take these.
Yeah, I have some too.
I'm crafting too.
What did he give me?
I don't even know.
Oh, I think he gave me soul sand.
Here, take that.
Mister.
Blackstone.
I'm crafting.
Wait, did he steal the nuggets?
No, I got them.
Alright, gotcha time!
Wait, why didn't he...
He didn't give me anything.
Did I take it?
I don't know.
I don't know what I have in here.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't think it was that.
Okay, he's giving me gravel.
He's giving me fucking gravel.
Oh wait, wait, wait.
I got soul speed 3.
What the fuck am I gonna do with soul speed 3?
Yeah, he gave me that too.
This sucks.
Hey, throw them over here, mister.
Don't look that way.
Oh my god, I hear another guy.
He gave me more...
Oh shit!
Oh, you did it!
Was that cool or not?
That was pretty cool.
I can do it again.
Hold on, there's two of them.
Do it!
Yeah, that's fucking right.
Oh, he can't aim.
He can't aim.
Oh, he's aiming at you.
That means I can gotcha.
What if I try?
I'm gonna gotcha.
Did you hit it?
Only you hit it.
I didn't.
What did he give me?
Unless I can't see.
This is like all destroyed.
What is that?
Oh, it's iron nuggets.
I guess that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh wait, is that netherite bricks?
No, is it iron bricks?
Or the...
Just the...
What is that?
Oh, it's nether brick!
Wait, that's good!
Wait, he actually gave you nether brick?
Yeah!
Oh, I hit him big!
I gotcha!
Isn't nether bricks good?
Yeah, there's a...
That's what you need to make the netherite.
Yeah, isn't it?
Oh, no it's not.
You're fucking with me.
Oh, it's not.
It's nether brick.
Oh...
I thought you meant it was netherite brick.
Oh, I thought it was nether...
I thought that meant netherite.
Because it says nether in it.
So I was like, oh, that's cool.
You wanna find another guy?
Yeah.
His payout, his gotcha rates were a little too high.
A little too low.
It was like 0.01%.
Hey, hey, hey!
Yeah, that's right.
Come down here.
Go buy gravel.
Yeah, work for us.
Here.
Go, take the gold.
Yeah, take that.
Take that gold.
What did he give me?
Sometimes I don't know.
I know.
Sometimes I can't tell what I'm already doing.
That's gravel?
I don't want that.
Oh, I got the nether brick.
Yeah, that's the one I threw away.
Yeah.
I got more gold here though.
Gold nuggets.
Oh, don't do it in front of him.
Don't do it in front of him.
He'll get angry.
No, he didn't.
He didn't look.
Oh, I think it's because he's busy with the...
Yeah, as long as I throw it...
in front of...
Alright, come on.
Come on.
I wanna kill him so bad.
Oh, I got...
Oh, I got fire resistance!
I got fire resistance!
Nice!
What did he give you?
It's more gravel.
Alright, we got fire resistance.
Alright, let's head back.
Okay, yeah.
So, we need to kill magma cubes, but how...
We can't kill them though.
We need to find magma cubes for more fire resistance.
Unless we find for more gold.
And just keep gacha-ing.
Can we just keep gacha?
That might be an option, yeah.
Because I feel like magma cubes are harder...
for fire resistance.
For where we spawned in?
Yeah, maybe.
Alright.
It's time to just gacha.
I love gacha.
I love...
Wait, where did I leave my chest?
Oh, over here.
Over here.
I love...
gacha.
I threw away my mushrooms.
Wait, why did you throw away your mushrooms?
Because I didn't know we needed anymore.
We need them!
Okay, I'll go back in.
It's right there.
I'll go in.
I might be able to kill some more endermen on the way.
Like that guy.
Come here.
Wait, did you get trapped down there?
Oh no, he's not.
I'm just throwing away stuff right now.
We don't need obsidian anymore, right?
I don't think so.
Okay, goodbye obsidian.
Wait, chat.
We don't need obsidian anymore, right?
I don't know why I asked you.
Oh my gosh, I'm not doing very well.
Oh, enchanting tables.
Wait, we need a chanting table for obsidian?
Oh yeah, that's true.
I knew I should listen to chat was a good idea.
I can't English anymore.
Every single enderman I've killed has not dropped anything!
My mind is mush right now.
Alright.
Alright, Pikki.
It's time.
Let's go gambling!
I don't know where it's at.
Where?
I don't do this to me.
Why are you still pondering?
Oh my god, he's right there!
Are you kidding me?
Grab the gold.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh my god, he just fucking keeled over in front of me.
I kill him.
We need soul sand because I'm throwing away soul sand.
I don't think so.
Do we, guys?
It's too late.
It's gone.
I hate... I hate...
Goodbye, gravel.
I hate ghasts.
I hate them.
Goodbye.
He gave me two stacks of gravel?!
This fucking bitch!
He sucks.
Oh, I'm out of space.
No!
Oh, okay.
There we go.
What if I just take this gold in front of you?
Come here.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god, you do get mad.
You do get mad when you take gold in front of them.
I told you!
I know, but I didn't believe you!
Oh my god, they're all gonna keep attacking us now.
No!
Just this one guy.
See?
I think if you kill them in front or not in front of other guys...
No, I didn't touch him.
I didn't touch him.
Okay, okay.
We should be good then.
I called your bluff and I was wrong.
Why would I be wrong?
I don't know.
Sometimes you're wrong.
That's a lie right there.
Okay, I have one more gotcha.
Oh wait, these are the wrong ones.
Okay, I need...
It's these guys?
Actually, it doesn't hurt to have more of them, I suppose.
Let's go gambling.
Okay, I'm gonna give it to that one guy that didn't like me.
Because I'm gonna bribe him.
So he'll like me.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, here you go.
Do you like me now?
See?
He likes me now.
I see a magma cube.
I can get down there.
Oh no, he stopped.
Oh no, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't know.
I knew I did it again.
I did it again.
I went gambling.
I'm sorry.
With your life.
Gambling with your life.
Oh, I got an enderpearl.
Yay!
I don't know why I keep gambling.
I have a problem.
Okay, there's a bunch of...
little endermen around here now, so...
I'll keep getting them.
Okay, while you keep doing that, I'm gonna keep gambling.
Okay, I have some more gold.
I have a problem now.
I have enough.
Come here, come here.
You too.
Both of you.
Oh no!
Wait, what happened?
I knocked the enderman off the side...
and I think you fell into the lava.
You did this.
You killed somebody today.
Wait, it says enderman screams.
He's still around somewhere.
Okay.
Enderman?
Let's go gambling.
Oh, he's down there yelling at me.
Oh my God.
He knows what you did last summer.
I got a magma charge.
Come on, what else do you have?
I have...
Oh, it teleports before it hits lava.
That's what they said.
Okay, well come here.
I have one more gold piece.
Come on, I know you're rich.
I see what you're wearing.
I know you have the money.
Don't be...
Don't be holding out on me.
God damn it, he gave me fucking leather.
He held out on me.
Both of our gotcha luck is so bad.
Well, I did get fire resistance, so...
I don't know.
I got one pearl.
Here, I'm gonna give it to you.
Hold on to it.
Where are you?
Okay, we have five now.
Yeah.
Five out of how many?
Oh wait, I can use the leather to make books.
Oh, we don't need books.
Guys, we can just get it by farming the...
the fortress.
The big fortress.
What are you talking about?
They're saying we need books for enchanting table.
But we don't need it.
Actually, we kinda do.
Okay, well, I dropped like seven stacks of...
I think like a stack of leather.
Into the...
Into the flames.
So, we don't anymore.
We don't need them anymore.
I got another enderman.
I baited you.
I baited you into my trap.
Why did you have to fall?
Goodbye, soul sand.
I don't need you.
Let's see.
Stronghold library?
Oh, yeah.
That's what I mean.
We'll get the books from the stronghold.
True.
We don't need the leather for it.
Strongholds are not scary.
How long is your potion for?
Three minutes.
That should be enough.
Well, we still need...
What do we need for the slow falling, everybody?
What do we need for the slow falling?
Slow falling.
Oh, that guy disappeared.
For real.
What happened to him?
He gave me leather bricks again.
Oh, phantom!
Okay, so we have to not sleep.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Yeah, that's fine.
And we stay up for the enderman too.
Maybe we'll buy more enderman.
Maybe, yeah.
Or we die by skelly or creeper.
There's no way we die.
We have like...
We're full diamond...
Sorry, my brain is not working.
We're full diamond armor.
I'm not okay.
You're losing it.
I'm fucking losing it.
I'm gonna jump into the lava.
Someone stop me.
I'm fucking heading straight to the lava.
I'm gonna take the jump.
I'm gonna take the jump!
Don't do it!
Enderman!
For us!
And we're done.
It's over again!
Why can't I get any pearls?
How do we get home?
There's no pearls here.
Guys, why is my luck so bad?
This is why I don't gamba.
Let's go gambling.
Okay, I'm okay, guys.
It's been four...
Okay, five hours.
That's five hours too many for Minecraft.
What do you want me to do?
I'm waiting for you right now.
I'm waiting for this Enderman to come get me.
Alright, I'm heading over.
I'll help you.
All in all, this isn't the worst spawn, I suppose.
Come up here, buddy.
Come up here.
He's fallen.
Where is he?
He's down there.
What are you looking at?
He's down here.
Where?
Literally down here.
Oh my god.
I swear if he comes back up and smacks me into this lava pool...
No, he's aggroed on me.
I'm looking at him too.
Just use your arrow.
He'll dodge it.
You can't shoot an Enderman with an arrow.
I'm not gonna waste my arrow.
You don't know that.
How do you know that?
I've done it before.
Maybe it's just that one guy.
He'll dodge and TP up.
Yeah, do it.
Just TP up.
What?
Up?
Yeah, he'll dodge, but he'll TP.
Oh.
But it's a waste of a spectral arrow.
Oh, nevermind.
There you go.
What do you mean?
You were hitting me instead!
Yes, you were!
I don't get Ender Pearl.
You were hitting me instead!
It was the Enderman.
Literally my thing was on the Enderman right here.
This is what I did.
That wasn't me.
That was not me.
Pull up the VOD!
After this stream is over!
We need the receipts!
After this stream is over, pull up the receipts right now!
Clip it!
Time stamp this moment!
And we'll know.
We'll know in 12 more hours.
We'll know in 12 hours.
We'll know in 12 hours if that happened.
How do we get back?
Where's home?
It's gotta be...
Okay, be careful.
Don't go that way.
It's gotta be this way.
Because...
We didn't go to the...
We came from the side.
Do you remember which side it was?
Because I don't.
I have the coordinates in case we need it.
I think this is the moment where we need it.
I remember that sand over there.
Why did we not put any torches to tell us where we went?
I did a little over...
Yeah?
There's a gas, be careful.
Where?
Oh, it's over there.
Oh my God!
No, don't say that.
Now I'm freaking out.
Now I'm panicking.
I'm panicking, Min.
I'm panicking right now.
I'm freaking out.
I'm freaking out right now, Min.
I don't know, I'm freaking out.
He's aggroed on me, you have no reason to freak out.
What if he looks at me?
Okay, I think he despawned.
Yeah, he definitely did.
He just disappeared on my screen.
Okay, cool.
Oh shit, where are we?
I don't know.
Oh, you have the coordinates.
Is it down here?
I'll get the coordinates.
Okay, I'll get the coordinates.
It's on the other side.
From here, I think.
Yeah, because it was past that lava.
Yeah, yeah, it was past this lava.
Yeah, yeah.
Is there any bees around here?
I'm mining, I'm mining.
I found the hole we made.
I'm not scouting, by the way.
I'm literally in our hole.
Alright, I'm going back to the portal.
Hold on.
I'm getting more gold.
This is for us.
I'm heading over.
I only got 17.
Oh my God, how do we...
How do we jump down from here?
How does this work?
I'm so...
I'm coming.
Oh, there's too many holes.
There's so many holes.
Alright, this is the right hole.
I'm just gonna fall.
I think I found it.
Oh.
If I get out of the nether and like...
And then I see...
Made Mint dies.
Are you out of the nether?
Yeah, I'm out.
I'm out, but it's night time and I'm gonna sleep.
Oh, I can't sleep, so...
Good luck with that.
You might... You actually would be safer probably in here.
Yeah, that's true.
Maybe it would be safer.
Maybe.
Until I'm out.
Back to the portal I go!
Oh shit!
Doki doki!
Where are you?
I'm okay!
Where did you go?
Where are you?
Where are you, Mint?!
Everything's fine!
That did not sound fine!
That's...
Okay!
I'm okay!
I...
Things were not okay for like...
a good...
30 seconds, but I'm okay.
What happened?
I was doing my...
job as the gold collector.
Yeah?
Oh, so you were being greedy.
What the heck?
What do you mean greedy?
This is for the gacha!
What happened?
Oh shit!
I heard that.
Oh shit, it's fine.
Are you okay?
No, I'm not okay.
I can't do baseball.
I told you not to try the baseball.
Where's the...
I thought it'd be...
Bam!
No way!
How did I miss?
Bam!
What?
How?
Go, go, go!
It's okay.
I'm okay.
Nothing bad happened.
That was literally what happened to me.
I'm not playing baseball again.
I'm not playing.
Oh, so you got greedy with the baseball.
You got greedy trying to play baseball.
How do I get over there?
Oh, I'm on the wrong side.
Are you still not here?
I'm over... I literally saw you...
Bouncing around.
Oh, he's on you.
He's on you.
Oh, thank God.
I had PTSD right there.
Don't let him blow up our nether portal.
I might die.
Or maybe not.
Maybe not.
Oh, he's still on me.
He's still on me.
Where is he?
I can't get him.
All I have is this sword.
I know.
Try to aggro him and I'll try to shoot him.
I'm looking at him.
I'm literally looking at him and he's not looking back.
That's not how it works.
Why do you want me to aggro him?
I don't know.
Okay, he's not looking at either of us now.
He's just chilling.
He's just waving his little feetsies.
It doesn't matter.
He's waving his feetsies.
Where are you?
I see an arrow.
I took one of it.
You did?
Yeah.
Okay, I'm running.
I'm coming over.
Come over here right now.
We're not fucking around no more.
We're not fucking around.
Alright.
It's night time.
He's like right behind us by the way.
He's literally right there.
The ghast.
Oh, I'm out of the nether.
I'm out too.
I mean, we wanted to be night anyway, right?
Oh.
For the phantoms, right?
Yeah, but ideally, we would have like a place to, you know, be safe at.
Okay.
Like there's skellies everywhere.
Alright, pussy, let's do it.
Yay, yay, yay.
Alright.
Someone's a coward, so I'll do it.
Alright, someone's a little coward.
That's all I'm saying.
Okay, we gotta do a marker.
Okay.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Okay, we'll make a peepee tower here.
Okay.
Okay, mark this coordinate because we have to come back here.
You mark it.
What?
Chat, mark it.
I feel like I'm gonna die.
I marked it.
Why didn't you jump into the water?
I'm scared.
Okay.
I'm scared I'll miss.
What if I...
Oh, I'm sorry.
I just didn't want to fucking die by fall damage.
That's even labor than wanting to not die by skeleton and creeper and enderman and literally everything.
Witches that come after us.
Literally, majority of our death was from fall damage.
Literally, that's the majority of our death.
Majority?
That's Jessie.
No, no, no, no.
Our death, guys.
Majority of...
Wait, what are we trying to find again?
I don't know.
Ideally, we want to find a village.
Wait, for what?
Armadillo.
It's so cute, isn't it?
What?
You hit me.
No, I didn't.
The armadillo did.
The VOD!
Check the VOD in 10 hours!
Wait, why do we need to find a village?
What was the point?
Well...
For...
Yeah?
What was it?
The brewing thing.
I don't know how to make it.
Oh, the brewing stand?
Yeah.
Wait, where did you go?
I'm where the armadillo...
Oh, you went far.
Wait, I didn't even go anywhere.
Why are you just taking off on your own?
I thought you were beside me.
Why aren't you moving?
I am moving.
What are you talking about?
Why were you still at the armadillo place?
No, I was looking at something in my inventory.
Stone and blaze rod.
Yeah, see?
I don't want to waste a blaze rod on the...
The potion stand.
Why do we need blaze rods again?
For the...
Things to activate the...
The end portal.
We actually do need them.
Let's go straight.
Straight?
Yeah.
Here, I'm gonna make a boat.
Alright.
I have crafting table.
Oh, I just made one.
Oh, you could've asked.
You could've spoken up.
You could've asked.
Oh, you're not gonna bring the crafting table you made?
No, I am just thinking about it.
There's trees everywhere.
Oh yeah, and then you're gonna be like...
Oh Doki, I broke my pickaxe.
I need somebody to help me.
I don't have any wood.
What?
That's gonna happen.
That might happen.
If that happens...
I'll just die and then we'll restart.
What if we did a run...
Where it was not only hardcore...
But you could only make one of...
What the hell?
Does he have anything?
Yeah, he might have stuff.
He might have trading stuff.
No, he doesn't have anything.
Oh my god, you're actually worthless.
They're gonna spit on us now.
It's fine.
Now you have no owner.
Hey!
Now they'll just die here.
Yeah, they'll die here.
Yeah, they're domesticated so they can't live in the wild.
They're gonna come back like Alan Wake.
You killed my owner!
Oh yeah, this is a hit and run.
That's right.
What are you gonna do?
Fucking kill us?
They could.
They were just bad enough, maybe.
Oh, my chat is just so...
Sad, making me so sad right now.
Wait, why?
They just keep saying a hawk tour.
Yeah, they said that too and I ignored them.
I'm not here to encourage this behavior.
I know.
I don't understand why that meme is so popular.
I don't...
I don't think it's funny.
I think it's one of those things where it's easy to get people to say it.
You know, like...
Like, you can...
Kind of like with the mic memes and all, you can get people to say them easily.
Yeah, but that's clever.
The other one's not as clever.
Like, it's just...
And then, like...
I admire the girl for milking that shit so hard.
Oh, my God.
She went crazy with it.
There's Halloween costumes.
I was like, how do you make Halloween?
You saw the Halloween costumes?
How the fuck do you make a Halloween costume?
You don't!
Yeah, but it's in spirit Halloween.
I saw pictures of it.
And then there's like podcasts.
There's videos.
There's like...
She got signed a million dollar kick contract.
And everything.
What?
Yeah, she signed a contract to stream exclusively on kick.
And like...
A lot of the contracts are a million dollars and stuff.
She is a business woman.
Right there.
I honestly...
I didn't know who her agent is.
Like...
I want a Halloween costume.
A spirit Halloween.
Yeah, but you have to lose all your dignity to get it.
Okay, like...
Not like that though.
You have to lose your dignity to gain the spirit Halloween costume.
Is it worth it?
I'm gonna email spirit Halloween and be like...
Do you want to make me a Halloween costume?
I'll say something dumb.
All you have to do is open your mouth.
That's everyday.
Yeah, it's everyday.
Do you think we'll ever go back to our nether portal?
I have the coordinates.
It's so far.
It's a five million dollar kick contract?
Not even a million dollars?
Five million?
I've never like...
I don't think I even...
Oh no, I did watch the original video.
I watched the original, how she got popular.
I've never seen anything else about her.
Is she actually funny?
Is the podcast any good?
I think she just has a country accent.
She's like...
Yeah, she has like a very heavy southern...
Did we make that?
What is that?
Did you make that?
No, I didn't.
I broke my peepee tower.
What the fuck is that?
It's a false peepee tower.
Ignore, ignore.
Wait, what?
What is this spot?
Don't go towards the jungle.
I think there's not really...
I feel like she's just a...
Like an inside job.
Oh, one of those...
Like she's like a plant.
Yeah, she has to be an industry plant.
I don't think so.
I don't understand.
She's like mainstream, so it's like...
Am I not normie enough?
Maybe I'm not normie enough.
Where do I go?
Your turn.
You were literally in the front seat.
They made a change where if somebody gets off, you're pushed to the front.
Oh, okay, okay.
I have no idea who you're talking about.
Google...
What is it?
It sounds French.
I'm not going to lie.
Make it sound like a grandpa explaining it.
We're going to get that.
You're going to get that.
It's actually quite elegant.
It's a simple thing.
Anyway, google that.
She's everywhere.
Oh yeah, you can't miss her.
Yeah.
There's a savannah.
Yeah, maybe there will be a place.
But usually it's the plains ones that have the...
Actually, no.
There it is!
Village!
I knew it.
Someone's like, wait, I get it now.
It is funny.
No, it's not.
It's because we made an actual funny joke over it.
We fixed the joke, everybody.
We fixed it.
That's why you guys find it funny now.
It's not our fault that we're so funny.
Oh, there's another saddle here.
We're just natural comedians.
Oh, this village kind of sucks.
Yeah, this village does suck.
Oh my gosh, the people in the savannah don't know how to fucking cook.
I got some bread and that's it.
I don't think they have it in the savannah.
Well, we have to sleep in this village anyway.
Yeah.
There's melons.
Melons!
Oh, I see you're going over there.
Yeah, I'm just trying to see if there's any more chest.
There's bread, but that's it.
I'm in the bed now.
You can sleep now.
Okay, I'm getting in the bed.
Get up, mister.
Too small.
Too small of a village.
My 5 million dollar contract.
I won't take it.
I just like to have it offered.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't know, actually.
I don't know.
5 million dollars is a lot.
It is a lot.
I don't think though I would want a contract to exclusively stream.
Yeah, I feel like...
No, I'd be like...
I'll take it, but like...
You know the xQc contract where he sometimes streams on kick, but not exclusively?
That's what he does.
Oh, I know.
But he got paid more than 5 million dollars.
He got paid like 50 million dollars or something.
I think we can leave this place.
Yeah, we can leave this.
Wait, wait, wait.
Back to the boat.
Yeah, boat time.
I don't know.
I know like...
I don't know if you got this offer on your YouTube channel, but like...
My YouTube partner manager was like emailing me and calling me...
Asking me if I wanted...
Yeah, no, they called me on my phone too.
Yeah.
And they were asking me...
If I wanted to...
Oh yeah, no, xQc was 100 million.
Yeah, sorry, I low-balled that.
What?
That's insane!
He got 100 million dollars to stream...
Not exclusively on Twitch.
I mean kick.
Basically, he can stream on kick sometimes.
Not all the time.
But he can keep his Twitch account.
Wait, am I going the right way?
I don't know.
But like...
They called me and was like...
Oh, for your VODs that got...
Restricted to R18...
Which was my one VOD, which was the FNAF VOD.
Because I was like...
Apparently I swore too much in that video.
And it got R18 gated.
And I think it's because I was like...
Hoar, hoar, hoar, hoar, hoar.
Oh, I heard about that!
Yeah, they thought you were saying...
They saw I was saying hoar.
And I was singing it a lot.
And...
Yeah, I'll grab the boat.
And so they were calling me.
They were like...
Oh, hey, we were wondering...
For your VODs that got R18...
We're trying this new thing.
And basically, it's like...
Since R18 are limited ads...
Yeah?
They're like...
Oh, can we put gambling and smoking and drinking ads on your videos?
For R18 videos?
I was like...
No.
Because apparently you can get a lot of money from that.
Because it's...
You know, casinos pay so much.
And I was like...
No, that's okay.
Do you get that money?
It's ad revenue.
But then you get ad revenue from...
Because when it's restricted, you get...
You tend to not get ads and stuff.
Oh, there's a preset!
There's a preset right here!
Oh my god, we did it.
Chat...
Reddit, we did it.
We did it.
This might be the shortest hardcore session...
That streamers have ever done.
Right here.
Right here, right now.
Okay, we still need the blaze rods.
Anything else they got here?
Just pillage them.
Loot them.
I think we looted everything.
Their villages are so terrible.
I don't know.
Maybe because they're poor.
Maybe...
Oh, they have a better furnace here.
Oh, that furnace?
Nice.
How did you get inside?
Oh, there you are.
What do I not need?
You wanna grab it?
Do you have room?
I do.
I can get rid of the one iron nugget.
And the sweet seed.
What else can I get rid of?
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of the nether break.
And...
This.
We need an enchanting table.
I mean, I have obsidian for enchanting.
Yeah, we need books, but...
Why did...
I should've kept the leather.
Wait, no, it doesn't matter.
Because we don't have paper.
Yeah.
How do we wanna do this?
Do we go back into the nether?
And risk it now?
We have to find a...
I feel like...
I think at this point, we got...
Wait, how many...
How many enderpearls do we have?
I have 6 enderpearls.
I think...
I was gonna say it would be maybe more worth it to just go find a new ender portal.
But...
Or make a new one.
We left all our stuff back there.
I didn't leave my stuff.
I left a lot of my stuff in that chest.
Wait, I don't even know what I left there.
Then you won't miss it.
You won't even know.
What if it's important?
We can go back.
Chat, chat, was it important?
Chat, no, I have the boat.
Chat, was it important?
Because I don't remember if it was important.
Do we need sugar cane?
Do we need paper?
Yeah, that makes paper.
But we need a lot of it.
We're gonna need a ton of it.
Then it's easier for us to just find bookcases.
I think so.
More pillaging, maybe.
Alright.
Here we go.
Why are you swimming?
I literally put the boat down.
Oh, I didn't know.
I didn't see.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's lapis blocks.
I left all the lapis blocks there.
Oh, okay.
We do need this.
Yeah, we do need this.
It was like a stack of lapis.
Okay.
How do we get back?
I don't know.
You had the coordinates.
Doki, I'm gonna give you the coordinates, and you're gonna guide us, okay?
Okay.
Okay, I gotta get the polterpolter.
Alright, so the first part, we weren't able to get that done.
Okay.
Okay, it's...
Negative four...
One, one, six...
Negative four, one, one, six...
Our chat, write that down.
Chat, write that down.
Why can't I send a message?
Why don't you just look at chat?
Why can't I send a chat message?
I don't fucking know.
This is your server.
Oh, maybe I didn't give you permission.
Lol.
Wait, what does it say when you try to send it?
It says, cannot send chat message.
Lol.
Bad.
Unmuted.
Wait, why can I send chat message?
Oh, I think you have to...
Your account might be like...
It's like a...
It's not the server.
It's like...
Your account got marked...
Am I marked as a baby?
Yeah, you're marked as a baby.
No!
Why did that happen?
I think you're marked as a baby.
I don't know.
Wait, how are we gonna do this?
You have the coordinates.
I gave them to you.
What was the coordinates, chat?
Yeah, chat.
Chat never lies to her, apparently.
Chat, what was it?
I'm just gonna keep going.
Negative 4116.
And?
You never gave me the Z.
Yes, I did!
No, you didn't!
I remember you said the X only.
And then you were like, why can't I write it down?
Oh, because I was typing it.
Negative 4116.
And then 1576.
1576.
Okay, negative 4116.
Negative 4116.
Keep going.
I'm going.
Negative 4116.
Okay, you're the one navigating.
And then 1576.
Oh yeah, that's the fake one.
Yeah, we're close.
Okay, what do you need?
Is there anything else you need?
Okay, while you roll that boat, I'm gonna feed my dog.
What?
I gave you those coordinates so that you would guide me.
Negative 4116.
I gave you the coordinates so that you would guide me.
1576.
Negative 4116.
You're fine.
I'll be right back.
This is...
Who is pulling all the weight here, everybody?
I want everybody to remember...
That it is I...
Mint Phantom...
That has been pulling all the weight...
In this collab.
I'm getting us back to that.
I've been telling her all the information.
I'm getting us back to our tower.
And I'm doing all of this.
Should I break the boat?
Let her drown?
I don't think she'll be back in time to save herself.
Guys, if we...
There's enough sabotage.
If we die, we die...
Natural causes.
Natural causes being...
Like a ghast.
Though, I will...
Build a...
A thing for me.
And have her face the...
Consequences of...
I think I'm going the right way.
She will have to fight for herself.
Against the night time terrors.
Drowning is natural.
It's beer o'clock.
Uh-oh, it's starting to get real dark.
Doki!
I don't know if I'm going the right way.
I haven't checked even a single one time.
Oh, so you're gonna try and kill me, huh?
I didn't say that.
Oh, you're gonna try and kill me.
I said that I will leave you to...
Yourself.
When the night time comes.
Oh, you're not even gonna try and protect me.
I see.
Am I in the right direction?
Wait, negative 4116?
Yeah, maybe.
What do you mean maybe?
Is that what it is?
Get off the boat, we need to sleep.
We need to sleep.
Okay.
The baby now about wanting to sleep, huh?
Oh, okay.
We don't need to sleep then.
Negative 4116, 1576.
I'm asleep.
And you still slept.
Alright, get over here.
Come on.
Hop on my boat.
So which way do I need to go?
1576 is the...
Negative 4116.
Do you think we can ask this guy for directions?
Sure.
Hello sir, do you...
Yes, Min was gonna drown you by breaking the boat.
I didn't say that, my chat suggested that.
You know who said that?
What?
Your favorite guy, Aragon.
This guy has no loyalty to anybody.
He's a professional snitch.
Oh my god.
He has no loyalty.
He's a professional snitch.
Guys, he's not even a wisp goon.
I know.
Is it an SSR?
Yeah.
SSRP.
SSRP?
What does that mean?
Supersized roleplay?
I can't believe supersized...
Am I going the right way?
Negative 144...
Stop telling me numbers and tell me directions.
I thought you were okay.
Oh my god, okay.
We're negative 49?
I thought you had your coordinates out.
No, that's why I gave them to you.
To be the navigator.
Get out.
Get off the fucking phone.
Get off the phone.
You're not allowed to speak.
Okay, while you direct, I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Okay.
Oh my god, we're way too ahead of going.
Oh my god, what was the coordinates?
Negative 4116.
Oh my god.
Where did she end up going?
Like, we're at 700.
Oh my god.
How do we get the 700?
How do I get out of here?
Okay, it's this one.
Try to reduce the numbers.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This...
How did she fucking get 600 coordinates away?
She just followed the coast.
What if I let her drown here?
What if I let her drown?
How's my GPU hitting 100 too?
Like, what is wrong with...
Oh, this Minecraft is too beautiful.
I think it's my resource pack.
Alright.
No, it's the right way.
Oh, 15...
Oh my god, it's 1576.
Oh my god, I'm fucking...
I'm losing it right now.
I'm reading them numbers wrong too.
Guys, no, you don't understand.
I'm losing it as well.
She took us so far that I fucking... I didn't even know where I was going at that point.
I've lost track as well.
Does this go down?
Which way goes down?
This way?
This way.
This goes down.
This way goes down.
Okay.
Okay, that way.
Okay, we figured it out.
Sorry, I got, like, very lost.
She was getting further and further away from our destination.
Oh my god, what did I end up getting in my fucking inventory?
My god, where did she take us?
Where the fuck did she take us?
Where did you take us?
I'm following the edge of the world.
I thought me seeing the numbers was like...
I thought you had your M3 out.
No, that's why I gave you the numbers.
What do you want me to do?
Left?
Right?
Like...
Yeah, basically.
Oh my god.
I could hear you screaming while I was walking away.
From my headphones.
I don't even know where you took us anymore.
I'm trying to figure out this pathway.
Okay, I remember the savannah.
It's not the wrong way.
It's not the wrong way, guys.
I'm just trying to navigate this fucking hellhole that Mint took us through.
What were the coordinates again?
Negative 4, 1, 1, 6.
Alright, get off the boat.
Get off the boat.
We're fucking...
We're gonna walk now.
We've lost your...
Alright, here we go.
We're gonna walk.
4, 1, 1, 6 and...
What's the Z?
1, 4, 1, 5, 7, 6.
Oh, we're going the wrong way then.
Oh, this way.
Okay, this way.
We're not.
I was going the right way.
This way.
Yeah, my way.
Oh my god, there's so many bunnies here.
My way.
No, my way.
Where are you?
I'm going my way.
We're both going the same direction, I assume.
Because we're both at the same coordinates.
Yeah.
Oh my god, are those cows on trees?
What are they doing up there?
I see you.
No, they're cows on the cliff.
They're cows on the cliff.
We're just having a good time.
Yeah.
Just like us.
Guys, she's gonna try and strangle me in a couple days.
Oh shit, I'm going the wrong way.
Why are you going the wrong way?
Oh my god, that was close!
I gamed over that.
Alright.
That's probably how I got lost in the first place.
Oh, now you have your F3 open.
Wow, when we're not using the boat, you have your F3 open.
Well, I can't drive and look at the F3 at the same time.
Oh yeah, guys, remember, don't Minecraft and drive at the same time, guys.
Don't read and drive.
Aragon gave you a good report.
Oh yeah, what did he say?
He said you were good.
You were a good girl.
That's what he said.
Was I not a good girl?
What was your death threat against me?
I'm fucking taking the boat out.
I don't think you should phrase it like that.
Alright.
What was your death threat against me?
I'm taking the boat, goodbye.
Wait, what do you mean you're taking the boat?
Why are you taking the boat?
Where are you?
We're gonna both be, make it to the same place anyway.
Okay, I'll just be a little longer.
Wait, what's the coordinates again?
4-1-1-6 1-5-7-6 1-5-7-6 So it's here.
1-5-7-6?
1-5-7-6 I thought it was 1-100-6 I thought it was 1-100-6 I thought it was 1-100-6 I was gonna...
I was gonna...
Well, we know.
Okay, alright.
Oh my god, can I take this bird home?
Did you go to the jungle?
Are you at the jungle?
I'm about to leave the jungle.
I literally pulled a Patrick Star.
Why didn't you guys say something sooner?
I bet they were.
Oh, I see the doggos again.
What was the coordinate?
Negative 4-1-1-6 I found the portal.
1-5-7-6 1-5-7-6 Oh, I'm a little far, okay.
I'll be there.
Oh my god.
Can I have the boat?
There's trees everywhere.
Was that something you said to me?
I was like, oh, you didn't get the boat.
Oh, there's trees everywhere.
That's literally what you told me.
I'm getting stuff to make books.
Just in case.
I'm doing my part.
I got my boat.
I was hungry.
I haven't had dinner.
I'm hungry.
We gotta sleep soon.
Okay.
Do we need to go back to the nether?
Probably to find a fortress.
Alright, I'm gonna put my stuff away then.
In this thing.
I'm gonna give you the spectral arrow.
I'm putting it in the chest so you can take it.
Okay, yeah, I'll use it.
You have the bow anyway.
Why don't you make a bow?
Just make one.
It becomes apex then.
I guess.
Oh my god.
Wait, okay.
I'm going to sleep.
I'm going to sleep too.
I'll go sleep.
Alright.
Where's my string?
Bow time.
Alright, I made my bow.
Nice.
I'm gonna put away...
I'm gonna put away some stuff.
Sugar cane, dirt, my water.
I don't need the water yet because the enderman hits the nether and water doesn't work.
Yeah, we only need it for the fight.
Yeah, and then...
I'll put the string away.
I'll put the soul speed.
I'm taking a bike.
Do we need the boat?
Do we need it?
I'll pick the boat.
Just in case we fall.
Put the charge.
I took the blast furnace.
I put away the obsidian.
Oh, that sounds nice.
I haven't had dinner yet.
Let's have it later.
It's kind of late for dinner for me.
Oh yeah, you're not west coast.
What did I want to...
Oh, my brain is short circuiting.
Oh, I see the PP tower.
My brain isn't working anymore.
What did I want to make?
What did I want to make again?
No, I have the spectral arrows.
What did I want to make?
Guys, what was it?
I don't remember in my head.
There's a lot of sheep around here, so I'm going to murder them.
Oh, wait.
Gold bars.
Yes.
Let's murder sheep.
Down with sheep.
Alright, I'm ready.
Why are you already dying?
I'm ready.
What do you mean already dying?
Hold on.
I'm going to put my stuff away first.
Alright.
You're not even here.
I am.
No, you're not.
I see you.
I don't see you.
Oh, I thought you meant next to me.
I thought you were at the chest.
Yeah, I'm here.
We're putting the lapis away, right?
Yeah, we don't need it now.
Oh, I guess I could've thrown that out.
Let's grab some food.
How much food do you have?
I have a lot of hay.
Bread is not fast.
I think we need something faster than hay.
We're fine.
It's fine.
I have golden carrots.
There's a bunch of sheep right here.
How many?
Enough for me.
Okay, that's you.
I have lots of bread, but...
I need more substance.
I'm a growing girl.
I'm pretty sure you stopped growing.
Oh my god, I almost fell into this hole.
Careful of holes.
Oh no, I'm gonna fall in.
No response to that?
I'm taking my aggressions out on the sheep.
No.
I'm gonna get a mod.
I'm gonna get my own resource pack.
Where every sheep has a doki bird face on it.
There's some fucking Napoleon complex right there.
Sorry, some of us are not born to be stretched out.
Some of us...
Some of us have short moms and dads.
I'm 5'2".
What do you mean?
You're only 5'2".
And you're giving me shit.
Well, I...
I remember looking down.
That's all I'm gonna say.
I'm gonna wear my tallest shoes.
When I see you.
The blast furnace.
You want me to put it up now?
No.
The blast furnace only works for...
It only works for...
What's it called?
I have leather too.
Wanna use it?
What?
Blast furnace.
I'm putting a blast furnace here.
Just in case.
Wait, does it not work on me?
Oh, it doesn't.
Yeah, it only works on stuff.
Like I took all...
Oh wait, there's another furnace here.
I was gonna say.
I only took one.
I'll put the meat in here too.
Oh, the furnace is so slow.
You can...
Guys, this is not about how perfect the stacking is.
You already saw my inventory.
It's not great.
Yeah, we're here for...
For survival, not style.
Yeah, this is survival.
I put the ender pearl away too.
Okay.
Oh, it bothers you?
Don't worry.
I'll make it worse.
I can make it...
I can make it worse.
Oh my...
Oh yeah, my gold.
Gold.
More gold.
Gold, gold, gold.
How many gold nuggies do you have?
I have eight.
Do you have more?
I can make another gold bar.
Here you go.
Okay, I have four bars now.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, sorry.
Oh my god, that sounded like...
That sounded like when the experience...
When you get the experience.
Alright.
One last meat.
Alright, nice.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm ready to go to hell.
I'm ready.
Oh my god, my helmet is not doing so hot.
What are we doing again?
Find the fortress, right?
Right?
Is that our goal?
Yes.
Alright.
I'm gonna make another shield.
Okay, what's the...
Oh, my shield is okay.
I have not used it.
I'm just having one just in case.
Because, you know, there will be a lot of blocking from the...
What's it called?
As well.
For the gas?
Not the gas, the blazes.
Oh, you're right, you're right.
Are you farming trees?
Yeah, I'm gonna get another tree so I can...
Alright.
I'm gonna wait here.
And contemplate my life.
Good night!
How did I get here?
Alright.
Alright, I'm ready.
You don't get burned if you...
Block it with a shield?
I think so, yeah.
Unless they changed that in the update, but it didn't used to be that case.
It's been a while since we fought blazes.
I know, apparently they've changed so much.
Yeah, I mean, they have camels now.
That's fucking wild.
Okay.
I played during camels.
Oh, okay.
So you have no excuse.
What's some potions for the fire?
Do I have gold helmet?
Yes, nice.
Gotcha time!
There's some gotcha!
It's gotcha time!
This is a dangerous area to do gotcha.
What are you gonna do?
Kill me?
Oh my god.
Gotcha!
Got more arrows.
Nether wart?
Oh, I have a nether wart.
Oh no, sorry, I have warp fungus.
Oh, what's the nether wart?
Is that the brown one?
Oh my god.
Is it soul speed again?
God damn it.
It's soul speed again.
What the hell?
He gave me a water bottle.
This guy sucks.
Stay hydrated!
Stay hydrated, guys!
He gave you string.
Yeah, and you're giving me string?
That's literally the string he gave you.
Oh my god.
He gave you gravel.
Yeah.
Come on, I have more.
Come on.
Wait, did I take it?
Let's go gambling.
Did you take it?
No, you took it.
Let's go gambling.
Pig snorts enviously.
Well, yeah, to be fair, water is rare in the nether.
That's like his diamond.
Oh, there's two.
You didn't give both of them at the same time.
Come on.
Oh, he gave me a firetruck.
A double whammy.
What did he give you?
Oh my god, I got leather at least.
Oh, that's good.
You have more gold?
Come here.
Yeah, I have three more.
Throw another one.
They're greedy.
Oh my god.
I missed.
I know, it's really easy to miss.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
What's the drop off?
Oh my god.
Okay, there you go.
I got it.
Okay, I figured out the drop off.
I figured it out.
I don't even know what they gave us.
I figured out the drop off.
Blackstone and gravel.
Oh, okay.
Because I got it.
Boo!
I'm throwing it away.
Okay.
Alright, let's find this fucking stupid fortress.
Alright, you lead.
Me?
Yes.
Okay, hold on.
Yes, because if we die, I can blame it on you.
Sure, I knew that would be the case.
Yeah.
It's good that you know.
Wait, so these are the ones that we need.
Are these the ones?
They are red mushrooms.
No, they're not.
They're red mushrooms.
He's shooting at us.
Where?
I don't even see the guy.
Just go up.
He's right behind you.
That's fine, let's just go.
Oh my god, this area sucks.
Alright, I'm climbing up.
Me too.
What about these ones?
Those are the mushrooms?
Oh, they're not the mushrooms.
I'm confused.
What the?
I fucked up.
Um, I can't help you.
Is he following me?
Oh, he's still following me.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Please.
Oh, he stopped.
He stopped.
Okay.
Oh, let's just keep going, I guess.
It was just a prank, bro.
I'm sorry, bro.
Maybe we should go back.
Oh, this is so bad.
What's the easiest way to find a fortress?
There's no easy way.
We just go.
Wait, is he still angry?
What did I do to you?
Did you take his gold?
No.
Here, let's just dig through here.
You get lucky.
This sucks.
Okay, hold on.
It's all about luck, isn't it?
I think so.
I'm just gonna climb up.
I'm putting a thing here.
Oh my god.
I hear him.
What if we dig into lava?
We don't do that.
We be very careful.
We keep our distance.
What if I'm not lucky?
Where are you going?
Gold.
He doesn't know.
He's already aggroed.
How does he know?
Do we have to go up?
Go up?
Yeah, because it's a mountain.
It was a mountain.
I saw it.
We have to go up.
I don't think we have to go up.
I just went across.
I'm digging up.
You can go across.
I dig up.
Don't dig up.
It's a full lava.
Wow.
I thought it was...
I don't know.
I thought it was a mountain.
I thought it was a...
Why are you down here?
Because we're going through.
Okay.
Hold on.
I learned my lesson from before.
I learned my lesson.
Hold on.
Wait.
Do you have nuggies?
Yeah.
I learned my lesson.
Okay.
Let's just keep going this way.
Because we're about to get to another soul area.
So it might be in here.
I heard like gas.
Hold on.
I'm going to put some torches down.
As a way to find our way home.
What's that sound?
Is that gas?
The meowing?
Yeah, it's a gas.
He's like...
Yeah, that's what he does.
He's nasty.
Yeah, now imagine him being all filled with skin and...
The skin and like little hairs coming out too.
Wait, where is my...
How did you get over there?
This is where my hole's at.
Why are you above me?
Hold on.
Don't follow me.
It's too late.
I'm going to not listen.
We're going down through here.
What if I dig up again?
You could die.
Wouldn't that be a shame?
It sounds like you want to not do this.
Or rather you want to do this forever.
It took us 5 hours to get to this point.
I don't know how many hours it's going to take us forever.
This is why it took other people literally 20 days.
20 days.
Oh, I'm in the soul sand.
This might be good.
Oh, I hear a gas.
Nevermind, that's not good.
We can fight him.
He'll disappear eventually.
Oh my god.
I hate them.
Meow.
Where is he?
Oh, there's the bones.
Look at all these bones.
Yeah, we're in the bone zone.
Who the fuck is this guy?
I don't know.
I hear him, but I don't see him anywhere.
He might be above us.
I don't want to leave until he's gone though.
I don't think he's going to go away.
I don't think...
I don't hear them anymore.
I don't either.
I think we're good.
Yeah, we're good.
Can we go down?
Yeah.
Okay.
No.
Go to the jump.
We can build a ladder.
Staircase.
We can try.
Oh, oh, oh.
Hold on.
There we go.
Okay, we can start from here.
Oh, okay.
We'll start from here.
Okay.
I was already making my own, but okay.
Oh, just kidding.
Alright, that's fine.
This is why you don't dig underneath you.
Did you see the ghast?
No.
Have your shield ready.
I don't see him.
Have your shield ready for bone zones as well.
For bony fellas.
I learn sometimes, chat.
Bony fellas are on the...
I think he's actually above us.
Because I don't see him anywhere.
Hold on.
I want to put another...
Torch.
Oh!
Oh my god, double.
That's double?
That's so messed up.
Wait, I don't see him.
He's above us.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
Oh!
Are these the...
Where are these?
I don't know where you are.
Oh, they're the crimson roots.
Where are they?
There's so many white stuff above us.
I can't tell what is actually...
How do you not see them?
I don't see them.
I don't know where you are.
Where did you go?
I went straight.
I see you.
Look, I'm here.
I'm here.
We can't
run in this area.
That's right.
I'm better.
I know the drop-off.
I know the drop-off now.
That's fucking right, guys.
I know the drop-off.
It only took me...
A little bit.
Took me a little bit to learn.
The sand sucks.
Yeah, it does.
I'm gonna get the gold here though.
Okay.
Get over here.
Run, run, run, run!
Oh my god.
That didn't help much.
That's a lot of lava.
Just keep going.
You literally find one single thing.
That was such pain.
You were right!
Yay!
Gold time!
I put one block in attempt to help.
I can see that one block helping.
I was gonna do more, but...
It started coming out.
It started flowing faster than I expected.
What am I doing?
I just wanted the gold!
Be careful.
Let's go back up.
Oh, there's one more gold here.
Nice, alright.
We can go from here.
We don't need the bones for anything, right?
I don't think so.
I wanna see if I can get a dog.
I'll grab one.
Oh wait, I already have...
Oh no, that's for bone meal.
I don't fucking need that.
Oh yeah, you can't turn the...
big bones into bone bone.
But what about bone town?
How am I gonna get to bone town?
Wait, how do we get down?
I don't know.
Wait, there's a fortress?
Where?
Is that it?
Is that a fortress?
Oh, you could use the bow.
Wait, we have the bow.
Oh, you're right.
Use the bow, use the bow.
It won't sing, I'm blind.
What if below us is fire?
Can you check?
Wait, is...
We're good, we're good, we're good.
Oh, we got one guy.
Nevermind.
Oh, come on.
I just saw somebody be like...
Can't believe she's blind.
And another guy was like, there's a fortress.
So I was like, oh what?
Did we get one guy?
Oh, I see this magma cube that's just...
Yeah, but it's so far.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna head straight.
Just gotta get lucky.
Wouldn't be fucked up if like...
Uh...
The fortress was like literally the other direction.
Yeah, that'd be kind of messed up.
That'd be so messed up.
Yeah, that would kind of suck.
Yeah, that would really suck, guys.
Oh, there's a ghastly.
No, why are they...
Why do they spawn everywhere?
I feel like the new update made them spawn...
Wait, what?
That should've hit.
Sometimes it's...
Oh, there you go.
Oh, yeah, it's hidden.
Oh, shoot.
Why?
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
You got him?
No.
Oh, now I have, yeah.
Oh, I almost went forward.
Oh, my God, I almost fell in there, too.
Holy...
Oh, my God.
Oh, I almost went back.
Don't do it.
I almost jumped back in.
There's a skelly in there, too.
I felt extra wild today.
Only today.
I could've closed that hole up, but I decided not to.
I feel extra crazy.
Oh, my God.
She's crazy.
She's wild.
She's gonna do something wild, guys.
I think this is the worst part.
Trying to find...
Yeah.
How do people... How do speedrunners do it?
They just get lucky, I think.
Are you firing?
Oh, I see what you're going for.
Yeah, because I don't want him to fucking shoot his arrow and I go...
Set seed?
No, that's boring.
Yeah.
I know some of them don't do set seed.
I think they, like, reset over and over again until, like...
Oh, they know what they're getting.
Or, like, they get a good thing.
Yeah.
Oops.
I'm good.
I mean, that's what speedrunners do.
They do it, like, a million different times until it works.
Do you have more arrows?
Yeah, I have spectral arrows.
Do you want them?
Yeah, I'll take some.
Oh, there's another ghast over there.
Yeah, that's why, yeah.
Alright, nice.
I'm gonna eat some food.
Oh, IRL?
Yeah.
Holy shit, there's so many soul sand.
Oh my god, how are we gonna get it?
Oh, this is so scary to get across.
It's literally lava.
Straight up lava on the other side.
Oh.
I don't know if we should cross that.
I don't know, it's a little dangerous.
With ghast spawning, I wouldn't.
Yeah, so where should we go then?
I don't know.
Oh, I think we...through the walls.
I feel like maybe that direction?
The right side?
That's the way we came from.
Isn't that?
I thought we came from the back.
I don't remember where we came from.
Like, I think if we just dig this way.
Alright.
We can just dig on through.
I was like, it would be silly if we make a bridge across.
Yeah, it would be pretty silly.
It would be so silly if we did that.
Yeah, let's just dig.
Stand far away.
As you do.
Are we never making it back?
Oh yeah, that's probably a problem, right?
No, we'll get back.
We have the coordinates.
Oh yeah, we have the coordinates.
We're fine.
Yeah, we're fine.
Alright.
Oh, you want me to dig?
You want me to do it?
Yeah, you can do it.
Switch.
Wait, hold on.
Let me set up my setup.
For optimal.
We don't have obsidian.
Oh my god, this gas.
There's so many.
I know.
Oh shit, watch out.
Nevermind, I didn't even need to warn you.
What do we do?
What do you mean?
Oh, okay.
I continue onward.
So brave.
She's so brave, guys.
I know.
I'm so brave.
Oh my god.
She knows what she's doing.
I'm tabbing out.
You're tabbing out?
I realized there hasn't been music for an hour.
I just realized music stopped for an hour.
Alright, I'm back.
Welcome back.
Where are my torches?
Oh, there it is.
My chat's probably going insane though.
It's been the same song for five hours.
You've been using the same song for...
Yeah, sorry guys.
Do you want a different song?
Sorry, too late.
They've already...
They've already Stockholm Syndrome'd themselves with this song.
Probably.
Oh, this is very dangerous.
Oh, skele-man?
Engassed.
Where?
Oh, that's a bastion.
That's not a skele-man.
Wait, that means we're close.
That's the fortress enemy.
Does it mean we're close to what?
Isn't that a fortress enemy?
I don't think we're going into the bastion.
I don't think it would be wise.
They will actually kick our asses.
What?
They don't care that we're wearing gold.
Wait, aren't they the black skellies?
No, no, no.
Wait, what's a bastion?
That's like the stronger piggies.
Oh!
Oh, I thought you were talking about the black skellies.
No, please, not me.
Please, not me.
Oh, fuck.
Uh-oh, Doki, I'm in trouble.
Oh, wait.
That's not my thing.
I'm trying to figure out the drop-off.
I got it, I got it.
I gave all my arrows to you.
I was like, why isn't it shooting?
I'll give you some of the arrows.
Okay, let's split on this one.
Oh, my God.
I didn't realize you didn't have any arrows left.
I thought you were talking about the black skellies.
I thought that's what they're called.
I thought... No, I wish that that was them.
Where'd you go?
Right here.
Grab my sword.
Oh, shit.
That's right, shoot that arrow.
That's fucking right, you stupid idiot.
Where are you at?
Right here.
Look up, look up, look up.
Look up.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I got you.
There, I got you.
You hit any?
Is that the arrows you shot?
Are those the gold arrows you shot right there?
Is that...
Yeah, I'm gonna kick him.
Oh, there you are.
You know what?
You were closer.
Oh, it left a tear.
Oh, that's good.
What are the tears for again?
Potions, right?
Maybe, I don't remember.
I don't remember.
I know the tears were good for something.
Some sort of potion thing, yeah.
There's a scary sound.
Where did we go?
Oh, regen potion.
That's good.
That's a good thing to have.
Do we need soul soil?
Do we need that?
No, I don't think so.
So many things I don't know we need.
Where do we go, guys?
Where do we go?
Oh, unlucky.
We're in the fortress.
I don't even know where we are.
I'm gonna kill the skeleton.
This guy looked at me funny.
There we go.
Yeah.
Let's block on over.
Oh, there it goes.
Why did it fall?
Oh my god.
Why is there so many of you?
I think they...
Oh my god.
Wait, what is...
I shot the pigs!
Oh god, Doki, they're all coming for you!
I don't know how I shot them.
There's another ghast.
Watch out.
This can't be it.
There's two of them!
Oh my god.
This is so bad.
Just run.
I'll try to take care of the ghasts.
I got one.
Where are you?
I killed the other ghast.
Oh, you got him?
You're running?
Oh my god!
I'm okay.
No, I'm not.
I'm not okay.
I think all we have to do is kill these guys...
away from other pigs and we'll be fine.
I don't...
Oh my god.
I don't know how...
I don't know how I aggroed him.
No!
There's another ghast.
There's a ghast in front of me!
I don't know if I can take them all.
Can I get them?
I'm gonna start shooting them.
Oh.
I'm gonna use up all my spectral arrow.
I'm just letting you know that.
Wait, wait, wait!
Don't do that!
I have 15 left!
Here I'll start attacking too.
Oh,
I hope...
Oh my god.
Use your shield!
I am!
Oh my god.
I'm coming!
There's a ghast still.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Eat, eat, eat.
Oh, there's two ghasts.
Oh my god, please.
Why are there so many ghasts?
What did they do?
Why did they up the nether so much?
This is so messed up.
Oh my god.
Watch out, Doki.
It's like literally right behind you.
Oh my god.
There's another one?
He's still spawning!
We need more arrows.
We don't have enough arrows.
Yeah.
I'm trying to figure out the drop-off for this guy.
Oh my god.
I can't item.
I can't.
Oh, I got him once.
Oh my god.
Is he closer than I expected?
Where is it?
Oh my god.
Let's just get out of here.
I hate this area, man.
I hate this area.
This area sucks.
Oh my god.
Get his ass.
This area apparently has more spawns for Ghastlies.
What?
Why?
I thought it was...
That's what they've been trying to tell us this entire time.
They're like, get out of there.
Ghastlies love this place.
But I thought they loved the red area.
Okay, we can't go that way because that's to the bastion.
And they will, like, mog us.
It'll be so bad.
Oh, here.
Oh my god.
Another one!
We need to get out.
It's so sad.
How do we get out of this?
I don't know how we got here in the first place.
Red area has the pigs.
I killed him.
Okay.
Alright.
We just gotta get out.
Just gotta get out.
Oh my god.
Another one spawned in.
I don't know how... Do you have the coordinates?
How do we get here?
Okay, hold on.
How do we get out of here?
Just run this way.
I don't know.
I think a bridge would be...
Maybe the easiest way.
A bridge in this area?
That's what I don't know!
We're in the red.
Let's just explore the red area.
Let's just explore.
Let's never go back.
Never go back.
We learned our lesson.
I don't wanna go back.
Red area is better.
Oh my god.
Just leave.
Oh my gosh.
I can trade.
Trade.
Just give me stuff.
Oh thank god.
Spectral arrows.
Maybe he'll give you more.
I have leather right here.
You have leather, right?
Oh yeah, yeah.
I'll take it.
Did he give you anything else?
No, they gave me spectral arrows.
There's more right here.
That they didn't pick up.
I like to only give them one at a time.
Because they end up missing a bunch.
Oh my god.
I would make him a hole if he...
I know, like, he takes it and then runs off.
I know.
Like, he's stupid.
Oh, they gave me more arrows.
Nice.
We both need that.
I'm gassed.
I'm going to become the Joker.
Leave us alone.
It only takes one bad day.
Yeah.
Oh, the fire resistance!
Fire resistance!
We have two now.
How much is that?
Three minutes.
You got it, right?
He gave another one!
Oh my god.
This is a lucky gacha.
I can only carry one fire resistance.
I can't stack up.
Oh, no, no, they don't stack up.
Unless that was the one he...
The one that you...
No, no, no.
I got the second one already.
He gave bricks.
Where did he go?
Uh, he's here.
I think he's all out.
Oh, nevermind.
No, I have more.
Okay.
What's that sound?
Do you hear that?
The gassed?
No.
Did you hear the sparkles sound?
Oh my god!
Are you fucking...
Are you fucking serious?
I hate them.
I hate these guys.
With every fiber of my being.
I hate them so much.
Oh my god.
Let's just leave.
Okay, okay.
I don't want to deal with them.
They can have this area.
They live here.
I don't care anymore.
I don't want to deal with them anymore.
It's a tactical retreat.
It's so tactical.
I don't see a fortress.
Oh, this is a different biome though.
Nice.
This one's not as bad.
There's just a lot of lava and sometimes magma cubes.
Yeah.
That's not that bad.
I hear him.
You always hear them.
You close your eyes and he's there.
You close your eyes and he'll always be there.
You guys hate the basalt ones?
Why?
Is it because they're annoying to get through?
But we need to go.
We need to venture forward.
We need to find the fortress!
But we're...
Which way?
Don't dig up!
What is wrong with you?
But there's gold.
Yeah, it's fair.
Someone's like basalt equals parkour nether supply station.
That's true, yes.
I don't think so.
I mean, we got the boat.
I think we gotta go through the basalt.
We're good at parkour.
Maybe we go down.
I'm drinking my lava resistance.
No!
The primal no.
Don't do it!
Not yet!
Okay, why don't we get boat and row down?
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Boat and row down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Alright, my life is in your hands.
Wait, are we good?
Is there anything down there?
Oh shit, that's really close.
Wait!
I don't know if...
I'm drinking my fire resistance.
No, don't do it!
I don't think we should do it.
Do it, no balls.
I'm drinking it.
Doki, we would've made it.
Doki, look at this!
You fucking idiot!
I didn't drink it, you fucking idiot!
Okay, then we're fine.
I take it back.
I retract my statement.
Does the baby give you gold?
Oh, he does!
What do you give us?
Baby?
Little baby?
What if he's stupid and gives us really great stuff?
He just took it!
Kill him.
No, don't kill him!
There's no other guys around.
We can kill him.
You do it.
Kill the child.
There's a guy right next to you.
He's a zombie.
I got it back.
There you go.
You killed a child.
I don't care, it's about survival in this mod.
He got scammed!
I took it, he just looked at me.
He was like, yeah.
Thanks for that.
The mean present.
I thought he was gonna be like, I don't know what's worth good stuff in this mod.
Since I'm a baby.
I thought that's what he was gonna do.
He was like, wow, these nice ladies gave me some money.
So sweet.
And then you just killed him.
Yeah, and I'll do it again if he steals your stuff.
Watch out.
Watch out, children.
She's gonna do it.
She ain't afraid, there's a hole here.
Oh, I keep getting tricked and thinking I see a fortress.
We'll never find the fortress.
No, we will.
We have to or else we don't beat the game.
This is our personal hell.
This is our nether.
This is our silent hill.
I'm just looking for my wife.
I'm just looking for you.
I'm looking for the fortress.
The fortress.
The fortress for my wife.
What is that in front of me?
No.
How many fortresses are in the nether?
Alright, I'm going up.
Maybe we should go to the right to avoid the...
Avoid what?
The basalt area.
There's only basalt here.
No, I mean to the other direction.
This way?
Or this way?
Alright, let's do it.
I'm building up.
Nothing bad happens when you build up.
I don't know if that's true or not.
I like how everyone in my chat was like, I suggest you avoid Basalt.
Oh, he has all gold.
Surely he's rich.
Oh my gosh, royalty.
He's so fucking rich.
He's rich.
He gave me blackstone.
He gave me gravel.
There's more.
Oh, he gave me arrows.
Wait, me?
I took them?
Yeah, it's fine.
He gave...
Iron chunks.
Yeah, that's fine.
I'll take it.
Oh, more gravel.
I got an obsidian.
I took the obsidian just in case.
Yeah, we need obsidian.
And there's more obsidian here.
You can take this.
Almost went through that.
It's not deep, it's okay.
Okay, where do we go?
Okay, I'll...
Take the lead.
Oh, hold on.
Can we go down here?
I think we might be able to boat this one.
Oh, maybe not.
Here's the boat.
No, no, not yet.
Here it is.
No, I don't think we can.
I don't think we can.
Let's dig through here and then we can probably dig out on the other side.
I think I need some gamer subs.
Guys, can you use my gamer sub code, Doki Bird, to get...
Stop digging!
Stop it, please!
...to get 15% off of your next order.
Or is it 10%?
I don't remember.
You remember it, right?
It's either 10% or 15%, but it works.
Do you still get sent stuff by them?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
I get so much stuff.
Every promotion they do.
I think that's for all creators, too.
We get everything.
We get the clothes, the...
Okay.
The clothes and the gamer subs.
Everything.
Yeah.
No, I haven't withdrawn my money.
I have to do that.
Guys, use the creator code, Doki Bird, Doki Bird, to get 10% off.
But you guys know what we both have?
That's the same thing.
Our Phantom Thief concert!
Concert!
We have...
I almost said...
Did you almost say that person?
We have some special guests that are still unannounced.
Special guests.
Special guests that are unannounced.
They are definitely unannounced.
Very unannounced, very secretive.
I can't say it.
Oh my god.
I'm like the Tom Holland.
Tom Holland.
But it'll be fun.
We'll be in full 3D.
Oh my god, how did you know I was gonna say Jerma?
Oh my god.
Isn't this the big picky area?
Yes.
This is the big picky area.
Your favorite area.
I don't see any of them.
I do.
I see one right there.
Oh, I see him.
That'll be fun.
No, I see him.
He's on the far right.
I saw him.
I looked him in the eye.
Maybe the fortress is across that.
Oh, we're gonna be really...
Maybe.
Our shields will be super needy here.
Okay, I believe in us.
Let's go in.
We gotta make sacrifices.
And I have warped fungus.
Okay, I'll just say that there's a lot of lava over there.
What if that's above us?
We're at 91.
That's kind of high, right?
Oh, that is high.
I don't know.
Oh, we climbed the trees.
Parkour.
Wait, we can just go around it, right?
I'm on the tree.
Oh, why are you going inside?
Oh, you left a bunch of...
You left so much gold here.
Did I?
Yeah.
Oh, I have 64.
That's why.
Okay, I'm grabbing it.
I'm gonna make some gold then.
Okay, I grabbed it.
Come back.
Give me a sec.
I'm making gold.
I don't see anyone around.
Alright.
Is there anyone up here?
Hello?
No?
Okay.
Alright.
Where are we going?
I think we can go around it.
Alright.
Oh, the fortress is across that.
Well, we'll go around it.
Here, hold on.
I have more gold nuggies for you.
Alright, yeah, I need some.
Oh my god, that guy.
You didn't notice, right?
You didn't see anything?
Well, does he... No, he's okay.
I mean, we can give him the gold now.
Yeah, give him the gold now.
Go over there.
Give us stuff, please.
We're so desperate.
This is a safe area, so...
It's quartz.
This guy is snorting enviously.
Piglet snorts enviously.
Oh, the child is jealous.
I was like, what the fuck is that sound?
Why did he make all those noises?
Yeah, I was like, what?
I was like...
I was like, that happens?
What was that?
That was impressive.
I've never heard that sound before.
Oh, he gave me more arrows?
So if you need some, let me know.
Oh my god.
Only does the nether bring us together.
This is the only time we wanna work together.
We're finally working together in the nether.
We've never worked together until now.
We have one common enemy, and it's the nether.
Oh my god.
I just realized my game volume might be really loud.
Has my game volume been very loud?
I don't know.
She gave us two ender pearls!
Let's go!
Three ender pearls!
Whoa!
Oh, it was okay?
Okay, that's good to know.
I was scared there.
I saw it, I was like, wait, that's a lot.
That's really high.
How's my audio been?
Is it quiet?
Is it loud?
I don't know anyway.
Is this obsidian over there?
Or blackstone?
Where?
Oh, I think it's blackstone.
I picked up something.
I don't know what I picked up.
I don't know anymore.
I don't...
Okay.
No, I don't want blackstone.
Oh, they're freaking out again.
They're freaking out.
They're jealous again.
Oh, what are they?
What the hell?
They're dropping like...
What is this?
Soul speed?
We don't need that.
Oh, we don't need that.
What's the other one?
That's iron.
Oh, that's my iron?
Are they both soul speed?
I think so.
I think they always bring out soul speed.
Is this also soul speed?
Yeah, it's both soul speed.
Alright.
I'm ready to leave.
Onwards.
Alright, let's try and go around this...
heckin' forest.
I hate this thing.
Okay.
Yay.
What's the song that they've been listening to 24-7?
It's my original song, so they better like it.
Uh...
Actually, we can probably build a bridge over this way.
Alright.
Oh, never mind.
I just heard a gas.
Never mind!
I thought we were safe!
They're to our left.
The gas, it's above us to the left.
Oh, you know what that means.
It's time to go through your favorite forest.
Where is it?
He literally spawned inside.
He...
He's right there.
He's right there in the cubby hole.
There's a cubby hole?
What are you talking about?
If you go straight, you'll see him.
You wanna look at him?
Come on, I'll show you.
I'll show you.
Keep going straight.
Just go straight.
Straight here?
Yeah, just go straight.
There he is.
There he is!
He is in the cubby hole!
In the cubby hole!
I told you.
You didn't believe me.
Oh my god.
Oh, I flung it back at him.
You didn't believe me.
I told you.
It was in the cubby hole.
Oh my god, I keep... Stop moving!
You hit the fucking...
Bro, you're pretty good at baseball.
I got you.
My turn.
Ouch!
Okay, nice.
Did you drop anything?
I don't know.
I'm taking your arrows though.
Yeah, I'll take my arrows.
Alright, it's time to go through the forest.
It's time to go through the forest.
No, not the forest!
Oh my gosh.
Into the thick of it.
As we all know, that musical was very...
It was a very happy musical.
Why are you going up?
I'm going to climb the trees.
Oh, okay.
We're climbing the trees.
You can't climb the trees.
Yes, they actually can spawn up here.
Yeah, they can spawn here.
Don't say that.
I will say it.
Then they'll start spawning in the trees.
And then it's your fault.
Have your shield up.
Where are you?
I'm in the trees.
I'm in the walls.
You're right below me.
Oh, you're actually that high?
Oh, I see one.
Where?
Oh, I see you.
If I stay high ground, they can't get me.
If I stay up here, they can't get me.
Cinematic mode.
Let's go.
If we die in this run, we have to do all of this again.
All of this again?
Just every single seed.
What if we get like the best seed?
You know, and it's like super lucky.
All of this again.
What if we get like a seed that like...
Is that the fortress over there?
Where?
Over there.
What is those vine things?
Vine things?
Do you see that?
That's the blue area with all the Endermen.
Okay.
It's just an island.
That's the blue area.
I thought they were like, I don't know, chains or something.
Lamps or something?
Chains from the fortress.
I don't know.
I'm just trying to be...
have like some optimism like these days, but now I'm just...
I'm a soulless husk right now.
Now I know why there's so many ghasts here.
They're all people who are trying to play hardcore Minecraft.
But they couldn't find the fucking...
They couldn't find...
The fucking...
The fortress.
I'm gonna...
Excuse me, sir.
Should we take the boat down here?
Oh, um...
Wait, I'm just checking out the area first.
Right here.
Right here where I'm standing.
I think this is the perfect boat area.
Might be.
I'm gonna come with you.
Oh, gosh.
I'm putting the boat down.
For anyone going to bed, good night.
You can...
You can check the VOD time in the morning.
Oh, there you are.
Alright.
Wait, how do I get up to you?
Alright, ready?
No, I'm not even by you.
I know.
Alright.
Oh my God.
Why did you position it like this?
Are you ready?
Yeah.
This is our only boat.
Hey, come on in.
I know.
Wait, let me double check.
Okay, this is actually...
This is gonna be crazy if we make it.
I can't see very well, so...
Here we go.
This is a 50-50.
If we make it, it'll be fucking wild.
Oh my God, thank God.
Alright, anyway, turn around.
I don't like this.
Oh my God.
We could've landed down there.
There's two pigs in our boat now, so I'm scared.
Oh, what the hell?
These guys are such freeloaders.
I don't know if I wanna hit that.
No, we need this boat.
We need it.
You hit it.
I already experienced my first pig invasion.
Use the pig.
Wait, am I getting...
No, I don't wanna get one guy.
Should the pig be good?
Oh, I have a lot of wood.
Do you have a crafting table?
Okay, we can just make another one.
I put it next to the boat.
Abandon ship.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Okay, um...
A boat.
Okay, I threw it.
Is it yours?
Grab it.
Okay, I got it.
Hold on, I gotta eat.
What's the plan?
I think the...
We can go through this forest.
This is just the one with all the endermen.
We go to the right.
Don't look at them.
Oh, watch out, because there is a guy down there.
Hold on.
Oh my god, another ghast?
Are you kidding me?
Why are they all here?
Why are they here?
This is so unfair!
They literally spawn in every biome.
Give us a break.
Why did they make this biome harder?
Why did they make Nether harder?
I don't understand.
I don't understand!
There's a hole.
There's multiple holes.
There's a lot of holes.
Oh shit, I think I just aggroed a guy.
Wait, maybe not.
Maybe I'm safe.
I thought I aggroed him.
There's multiple holes.
Watch out not to aggro a guy.
Or be ready to build your own shop.
Why is there so many?
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Don't be careful when you're looking down, because you could accidentally look at them.
I know, I know!
Oh my god, I don't want to accidentally look at you.
You're so ugly.
I think the Endermen are cute.
They're literally on this Tumblr sexy man list.
Wait, are they really?
I think so, aren't they?
How do you know?
How do you know that?
Oh, you heard it?
From who?
I don't know.
Someone was an expert at it.
Who?
I don't know.
I thought they were.
Aren't they?
You don't know.
Aren't they on there with like...
What's his name?
Slenderman?
They're basically Slenderman.
I mean, I guess you're right.
Yeah.
Is there a fortress here?
My back is actually starting to hurt.
Is there a fortress over there?
Wait, is that a fortress over there?
No, I can't see.
I don't know.
Everything looks like a fortress to me.
Everything looks like a fortress.
Now I can't distinguish between what is a fortress and what isn't.
They all look like one to me.
Yes, I think it is!
Where?
Where are you?
Just follow me.
Oh, there you are.
I don't know.
I don't know what I saw.
I don't know what was it.
What did I see that I thought was a fortress?
I don't know.
I don't...
I don't see one.
I saw a gas.
I don't think it was.
I think even...
the chat's eyes were freaking out too.
I think even chat was seeing things.
It was like we're in the Sahara Desert and I saw a mirage.
A mirage?
I saw a mirage.
This is the freakiest bridge I've ever built.
Because it's next to a gas.
A gas?
Yeah, there was a gas in front of us.
Where are you?
Wait, where did you go?
I don't know.
I was looking at...
I was looking for the fortress and you disappeared.
No, where did you go?
Wait, wait, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
Build up, build up.
Look up.
I'm gonna build the freakiest bridge.
I'm gonna build the most freaky bridge.
I don't... I look up and I see a tree.
Just go up.
You see my name tag?
I don't see your name tag.
So go up.
Just go up.
Oh, there you are.
Are you sure this is a good idea?
It's not.
I'm seeing things now.
It's not a good idea.
Are you sure this is a good idea?
You know what I think is even a worse idea?
What?
Get in.
Okay.
I'm getting in.
Get in.
I'm in.
I trust you.
I really don't trust you, but I'm trusting you.
Here we go.
Get that boat.
Look to your right.
Hold on.
I can't grab it.
I have no more room.
Look to your right.
Yeah, that would've been...
Everything could've went wrong.
Yeah, probably.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
I'm living life by the edge now.
We need to make progress.
And to make progress, we have to take risks.
I'm going through another sickness now.
I'm going through another sickness.
This is just...
This is the minds all over again.
Doki is so weak-minded.
She breaks so easily.
Write that down in your notes, everybody.
I'm gonna mind break.
She mind breaks easily.
Oh, that's not good.
I don't have any more bricks.
I have some.
Alright, it's your turn to make bridges.
This is your job now.
Well, just start mining some because I'm almost out too.
I mean, I do have other blocks, but I was gonna save them.
I'm gonna mine some too.
Yeah, just mine some random ones.
Just get like a full stack.
Truly, this is...
We're not going back home.
Well, I have two obsidian.
So if we get however many we need more, then...
We're never making our way home.
We never had a home.
Doki, we never had a home.
Yes, we did.
We had that lapis blocks.
Think about our lapis blocks.
We can get back to those once we're on the surface.
We can get anywhere we want to.
It's so far!
It's okay!
Oh my god, Crasher, thank you for the 15 gifted.
Thank you.
For our misery.
How far out is the fortress?
This is so unlucky.
I'm ready to just die and just restart the nether.
No!
We'll have to get all the diamond over again.
Please, god, no!
Getting the diamond is the easy part of this raid.
I lost you.
I know you're behind me, okay?
This is a cursed seed.
We should have known when we couldn't find a village.
No, I found villages!
Oh my gosh, imagine the first one we got was like, oh no, no, we're back in the blue area.
Doki, we're back in the blue area.
If we go left, if we go left, if we go left, it'll be fine.
It's the forest!
Oh god!
If we go left, it'll be fine.
Where'd you go?
I'm in the forest.
I'm in your favorite place.
How'd you get in there?
Which way?
Oh my god!
Right here.
I'm okay.
I'm right here.
I'm down.
Nevermind.
Oh, I see you.
I'm right here.
Hi.
It'd be so funny if we get pushed off the edge right here.
It'd be so funny.
We have our potions.
I'm gonna drink it.
Don't do it right now.
Stop.
I'm gonna fucking drink it.
Don't do it!
Why are you gonna do it?
I'm gonna die anyway!
I'm doing real parkour moves right here.
Come on.
Don't you wanna be a parkour master?
Okay, nevermind.
Don't go this way.
Don't follow me.
Where did you go?
I'm here.
I'm down.
We have to make a bridge.
Yeah, we have to make a bridge.
I have two blocks for this bridge.
Did you not mine more?
Mine 20.
I thought that was okay.
I told you to get a whole stack.
A whole stack!
Has it actually been three hours?
I don't know.
It feels like three hours at this point.
We were in the mines for two, I feel like.
It's been a six hours stream.
How long?
Oh god, six and a half.
We're not making any progress!
Oh my god!
I'm not making any progress!
I don't understand!
Uh oh, there's big piggies here.
Oh, he's angry.
Oh, he's coming up.
Oh shit, he's here.
Oh wait, he's actually coming up.
They try.
Where are you?
Next to the big piggies.
No, they're blocking the big piggies.
Oh, I see you.
I'm down here with the piggies.
I thought you were scared of the piggies.
Yeah, I hate them.
They're fine with shields, honestly, but...
Oh, here he comes.
Here he comes.
Here, I'll put the mushroom down.
Oh yeah, nice, nice, nice!
Put the mushroom down!
Yeah!
Yeah, get scared dummy!
I got another one!
Yeah!
Scared of a little mushroom!
Stupid!
You're so stupid.
There you go, here's another one.
Eat your mushrooms!
Eat your veggies!
That's right, eat your veggies!
Okay, I have more mushrooms for us.
Oh my god, this is just hellish.
This is actual hell.
This is...
This is the real hell!
Who invented Minecraft?
Who invented this?
I'm gonna go back in time, I will prevent I will prevent Notch from selling Minecraft to Microsoft, so the nether would have never been... Wait, what was Minecraft?
Was the nether from Notch or from Microsoft?
I don't know, actually.
That's what I was gonna say.
I don't know if this was Microsoft's idea.
I don't think they have any ideas.
Guys, who is it?
I need it.
Oh, it was Notch.
Of course, Notch would fucking do this to us, of course.
Sit down.
There's some dirt.
It's okay.
Oh my god!
Okay, we're fine.
I got the boat.
We are not going...
Yeah, it'll be fine.
Okay, that's fine.
Yeah.
Oh my god, of course you make me do it.
Are you in?
Yeah.
Okay.
We're fine.
I have the mushroom too, in case things go wrong.
I have them.
Grab the boat.
I don't have any room.
Okay, we go... I feel like we should go forward.
Okay, what's forward?
It's like here.
There's no other way.
There's no other way in this hell.
It's really hell.
Are you okay?
Yeah.
No, I'm not okay.
No, me too.
Oh my god, don't fall.
Actually, come down this way.
I think this way is easier.
Parkour.
Oh my god.
Why can't we find one?
Just...
And then we have to...
survive in the fortress.
I feel like, at that point, we'll be okay.
We were ready.
There's already some here.
There's some pink ones... or blue ones here.
I can't even get colors right.
We can kill him.
Oh, no.
We're running.
No, I don't.
No.
Boom!
Were you a Costco guy?
Yeah.
That's a...
What do they say?
I don't remember what they say anymore.
I don't know.
Where'd you go?
I'm over here.
Where did you go?
I went left.
I see you, I see you.
Boom, baby!
Bring it on!
Boom!
Oh, I see you, I see you.
Because the other end is a dead end.
Nothing's a dead end when you can...
Oh, shit!
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Boom!
I got him.
Nice.
Yeah, nothing's a dead end when you can pick...
Vine pick through it.
It's fine.
Okay, okay, okay.
That's what you say.
Boom!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my God.
No, don't come here.
Yeah.
Wait, does he not hit you even if there's a mushroom there?
He's too afraid.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Okay, this is a dead end too.
We have to mine!
There's no such thing as a dead end!
Boom, baby!
We have to mine too!
10 gifted, that's a 5 out of 5 booms.
5 out of 5 booms.
Booms.
Come down this way.
See, look, you've conquered your fear of the big piggies.
No, I just hate this area.
I just hate everything.
I had no fear!
You conquered it!
The only thing I hate is no fear!
You did it!
Oh my God.
That's a 5 out of 5 booms, baby.
We're Costco guys.
Of course we love the nether.
Minecraft guys.
Of course.
Of course we trade.
What happened?
That was so scary.
They almost knocked us into the lava.
I just need you to know, they almost knocked you into the lava.
I saved us.
Boom, baby.
Bring in the boom.
Hoglin growling.
Okay.
He comes back!
On the positive...
More fortress spawns on the positive side of the X.
Did we go the wrong way?
What are you talking about?
I think that's cap.
We're at negative 1,000.
I think they're being stupid.
That's not true.
That can't be true.
Don't say that.
Because we're at negative 1,500.
We have gone so far.
So far, we've definitely been in the positive.
Oh my God.
They almost knocked you into that lava.
I'm just saying.
I had my shield up.
Boom, baby.
Oh my God, and a gas.
It is true.
Speedrunners don't use that.
Okay, guys.
Don't...
Why didn't anybody tell us this at the very beginning?
Guys, look.
This is not our fault.
You guys could've told us that.
We're going west.
People were like, just go east-west.
We're going west, so...
Just mine on through.
Of course we're Minecraft guys.
We love trying to find the fortress in the nether.
Oh my God.
Please stop.
If it was just a stream that was just like...
Don't give in trying to find the fortress.
That's one thing.
But no, we have to find the fortress.
We have to survive the fortress.
We have to leave the fortress.
We have to go to the end.
We have to fight the ender dragon.
Boom, baby.
I gotta find boom.
No, apparently Google says it's true.
I don't...
Google says that you can...
Yeah, yeah.
You're like, I filled that hole because that was a hole there.
I know.
Thank you.
Because Google says what?
Google says that like...
What was it?
It's a thing that says you can eat it, but it's like a bandage or whatever.
Oh yeah, because of the AI thing.
The Google AI shit is like so wrong.
Put glue on your pizza.
I don't feel so good about this area.
Oh, the dressing.
Yeah, it says the dressing you can put in your salad and then it's also a bandage.
I see.
I think we can make a bridge here.
Alright.
Or we could go up.
Do you wanna go up?
But we're at 47.
47 where the fortress is?
I don't know where the fortress is.
Guys, is 47 a good for a fortress?
Double chocolate cookie.
Boo.
Now I can see why hawk tool is funny.
Do we build up?
You wanna build up?
I don't know.
What do you wanna do?
Build up or go straight?
I think we go straight.
Alright, let's do it.
Just keep going west.
Eventually we'll hit it.
We either fall to our deaths or we fucking hit the jackpot.
Oh my god, the lava is glowing so much.
It's so beautiful, Doki.
It's calling for us.
I'm like a moth to a flame.
It's calling to us.
Take the jump.
Do it.
Your chat will think it's so funny.
Don't you guys want to make content?
You know you love content.
Take the jump.
Oh my god.
I'm getting sleepy.
Just give up right now.
Just give up.
Start a new seed.
A new seed will surely be easier than this one.
Maybe the next seed will be easier.
Start over.
Start over again.
Go through the mines.
Strip mining was so much easier than this.
Don't you just want to do it over and over again?
Just keep doing it.
Keep doing it.
Keep dying.
Restart.
Why is the forest so far?
I don't know.
That's why I hate this area.
Because it's hard to navigate and it's huge.
I didn't know last time we were here it wasn't this big.
We're in unknown territory.
We've been in unknown territory for like forever.
Like when does it start becoming known?
When does it start becoming known?
When?
Where did you go?
I'm in front of you.
What's in front of me?
Just go forward.
Oh, I see you.
I did the bridge.
This is the most painful.
This will...
Nothing ever would turn me off of Minecraft.
Why is there so many?
It's the worst biome, I'm telling you.
You can't see shit.
And also, it goes on forever.
I didn't know.
You were like, let's go through the forest.
You hate the forest.
It's so fast.
I was thinking like, what if...
What if...
There's a baby in front of you.
Baby is gonna be scared.
Oh, I got the mushrooms.
I killed him.
Yeah, I killed the baby.
That's fucking right.
Look at that.
Oh, he's running.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
That's right.
You're scared of your vegetables?
Yeah, get scared.
That's right.
Your mother is dead.
We killed her.
What the hell?
Alright, where do we go?
Onwards?
Oh, gosh.
Go away, little baby.
Go away!
We're gonna fucking...
kick the baby again.
We're still headed west.
We're still west.
What's the worst that can happen?
Are you okay?
I don't think okay is the right word.
Go west.
Eventually, if we keep going west, something will hit.
Why would they make it so that more fortresses spawn in the positive?
When does it circle back?
It has to circle back eventually.
I don't think you can circle back.
Why?
So we just turn around?
We gotta get obsidian.
Make another obsidian.
I don't know anymore.
Where are we?
Apparently, the x-axis thing was before 1.16, so it's old news.
Oh, thank God.
We're just unlucky.
One fortress can spawn every 432x432 chunks.
Oh my gosh.
We're fine then.
We can just keep going.
Just keep going.
Your chat was trying to feed us wrong information, Doki.
Your chat was saying the same thing!
No, it wasn't!
Which way?
You give us the seed so we can look it for you?
No!
We're not cheating!
We're not cheaters!
Come on.
I'm here.
We're not cheaters.
We're here.
Yippee.
We have integrity!
Take that.
Oh wait, be careful.
Actually, maybe don't.
Too risky.
Wait, did you see the piglin snorted angrily?
He didn't notice though.
We're inside.
I think we'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
He'll get tired.
I'm tired.
No, you're not.
If we die, you gotta stay up.
If we die...
If we die, you gotta keep going!
Yay!
Hold on, I'm gonna go to the side and see if there's any fortresses.
There's another...
There's another forest.
Let's see if there's any fortresses yonder.
Oh my gosh.
Fortress please!
How the fuck did a chicken get here?
What the hell?
How is there another chicken?
Is that fortress over there?
Where?
Over there.
Is this another mirage?
Am I looking at a mirage right now?
Everything looks like a fortress.
Is this a mirage?
I don't know.
Keep my render distance the way it is because otherwise... What is that?
Let's start selecting him.
What's what?
It's just land.
It's more land.
There's a ghast behind us.
Oh, I see him.
I'm not ready to deal with his bullshit today.
Oh my god!
I got him.
I locked in.
Can you believe Doki wanted to start this later in the day?
I didn't realize.
Wait, is that...
Is that the fortress over there?
Stop!
Do you want to go?
We can just build a bridge.
We can just build a bridge all the way there.
Come on.
Let's go.
We can build a bridge and see.
Is it that over there?
It definitely is not, but we can go check.
I'm just...
I'm just trying something here.
I'm trying...
I'm trying something!
It's like somebody wants to just give up!
You're yawning.
You're a west coaster!
She's going crazy!
She has nethering madness!
And you call me weak-minded?
This is my first breakdown, okay?
Okay, I actually think we should build over there though.
Because going over lava, it's high risk but high reward.
Oh, it's true.
You're so right.
We build a double bridge.
Wait, do you have enough things?
You do?
Where should we go?
I'm drinking fire resistance.
No, you're not.
Only drink it if you start falling.
I'm not gonna get it off in time!
Here I go.
Here you go.
Into the thick of it!
My fingers get sweaty.
Okay, you have to tell me if I'm gonna back into a lava thing though.
Just say stop.
Yeah, just tell me though.
Tell me to stop.
If I start going.
Looks like a bastion?
Oh my god!
Oh, it is!
No, I literally told you that earlier!
No way, that's a freaking...
We found two bastions but not a fortress!
This is so unfair!
I thought the bastions were the big piggies.
They're the most dangerous part.
But there's more piggies?
All those guys in there, all those guys will kill you.
They don't care if you're wearing gold.
Yeah, they just attack.
How do we keep...
Let's go left.
I guess we go left.
Do you think it's the same one?
I don't think so.
There's no way.
Did we go back?
No, wait, I think it is.
Do you see those blue flames?
Is that the bones?
We've gone too far for us to have made a circle.
Okay, turn around.
Turn around.
No.
I'm too sick of it.
I hear you're going left and right.
Oh my God.
Oh, we made out just in time.
Holy shoot.
Oh my God.
Let's just keep going through the wood.
I don't care anymore.
I got the mushrooms.
We have nine mushrooms.
I'm too sick of it.
Why is he chasing after you?
Okay, that's weird.
Okay.
We're still going west, everybody.
Turn it to the west.
See this?
Bam!
Ha-ha!
He thwarted fool.
Now we have to get past him still though.
Boom!
Run!
Double choke!
But,
where'd you go?
I'm gonna...
Oh my God.
I'm gonna crack.
It's okay.
Everything will be fine.
I got him.
I think...
I can go for you.
I'm too sick of it.
Where'd you go?
Oh my gosh.
Where are you?
I'm here.
Keep going.
Keep going straight.
I got cabin fever.
All I see is red.
All I see is red everywhere.
I don't understand.
I don't even know what fortresses look like anymore.
I feel like it's just a myth.
It's just a myth.
They aren't even real.
They were invented by big crafter.
Big crafter.
Big crafter invented...
Made them...
Oh my God.
They're turning the pigs gay.
Wait, I think we should stick to...
We should stick to the edge where we see the big pool of lava.
Okay.
Also, look how big the...
Look how big...
What?
What are you even saying?
Look how much forest this is.
I know.
That's why I hate this modem.
I hate this modem so much.
They're turning the pigs...
Gay in the lava.
Oh my God.
Bastion is like tempting, but...
It's not our goal.
Oh my God, please.
If there...
I went to heaven, but if there is a God...
Please.
What the hell?
Who just yelled at me?
Where are you?
Oh, I see you.
I'm checking.
I'm being on the lookout for...
For fortresses.
Into the thick of it.
Oh
my God.
Where are we?
We're in the thick of it.
The music is gone.
Just like my sanity.
Why does your music keep disappearing?
It's a YouTube playlist.
Oh, did you put on Minecraft music or something?
No, it's like the thing where if you leave it on...
Like you leave your playlist on unintended...
It like pauses it because they're like, are you alive?
Oh, it does the Netflix thing?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It does that.
I don't know if I should...
I'm running out of blocks.
It's so shiny.
I just want to jump into it.
It'd be so funny though.
I'm gonna do it.
You could continue on without me.
No, you're not.
I'm gonna do it.
Wait, why are you going that way?
Do you believe?
I can't see your POV.
I don't believe.
I'm gonna drink the fire resistance.
Don't take it!
Here we go.
Oh, you made it.
I thought you said you didn't see me.
No, I see you.
No, I don't see where you...
I didn't see where you were gonna land.
It looked like you were gonna land into a lava.
Oh, yeah.
No, there was a chance.
Okay, let's split up, gang.
We've already split up.
Let's split up.
No, that's the worst idea.
One of us will die.
Then we'll do this all over again.
We're gonna do this all over again.
How much...
Probability is me.
Okay, how much do you think we would owe chat if we told them that we didn't want to do this anymore?
No, we have to!
We're not quitters!
Mint.
Mint, you got this.
You knew the time commitment.
Okay, where are you?
I'm coming back to you.
I'm in the air.
You probably could see my little bridge.
My sky bridge.
Oh my god, you made a fucking sky bridge.
Mint, it's time to get the gamer subs out.
It's time.
It's time to get the gamer subs out.
Are you actually?
I will drink the gamer subs if you drink the gamer subs.
I have so much gamer subs.
I think I will actually have gamer subs for like five years.
Exactly.
It's time.
Are you gonna go get some?
I'll get some when we meet up.
When we reconvene.
Okay, come to me then.
Where are you?
I'm in the thick of it.
Then come to me.
I told you to stay along the edge so we could see if we see any.
You know I don't know anymore.
I'm trying to not die.
I see you.
You do?
Okay, I'm gonna go get something to drink actually.
Because I'm dehydrated.
I'll make gamer subs later.
No, no, make it.
We can take a break.
No, no, no.
I'm in the thick of it.
I'm panning over to you.
Wait, what's your name?
I'm in a fortress.
I'm in a fortress that I created.
I said the wrong one.
Don't say that.
You gave me hope for a second.
You gave me...
You gave me hope for...
Okay, while...
You go make your drink.
And then after you make your drink.
I entertain chat while you make drink.
And then after you make drink.
You come back and then I...
And then I need to walk my dog.
And then...
And then we go on.
Wait, how long is a dog walk?
It's like 10 minutes.
10 minutes.
He just needs to pee and poop.
And then...
You've never had a dog before?
I have, but like...
I just would...
My mom took care of him.
You're not responsible.
We would just let her out and...
They'd run around.
Go make your tea.
He's gotta pee and poop.
Okay, I'm going.
Oh my god.
Okay, guys.
Guys, how...
Oh my god, please.
Please stop.
Get away.
Oh, he's gonna hit him.
He's gonna kill him.
Oh, thank god.
Please kill that stupid pig.
Will you stop killing him?
Why did you stop?
Wait, I lost her.
Oh, there she is.
Okay.
I gotta grab more of these.
Sit in and grab my...
Where's the piggies?
Wait, is that...
Is that the...
Oh no, that's the gas.
When...
When will I find a fortress?
I'm gonna make my own house.
I'm gonna make...
My own little house.
I gotta make my house.
Gotta...
No.
No, I'm not a cheater.
Okay, I got my safe house.
Never give up.
Never back down.
I'm sorry.
Dad.
I know you wanna be in poop.
I'm sorry.
Give me a sec.
I can walk you soon.
Are fortresses normally this hard?
Are they normally this hard to find?
I don't understand.
Are they normally this difficult?
No.
What's wrong with us?
What's...
I don't know.
I don't...
I don't know why we can't...
We can't find a single fortress.
It's like the frogs all over again.
Look in open areas.
Okay.
There's so many people fighting.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, we're going...
Okay, we just gotta go in the open area.
We just...
We just need to go...
Okay, alright.
Now it's your turn to talk to the chat.
I'm gonna go walk him.
And then make my gamer subs.
I'll be right back.
Oh my god, a guy spawned on my...
I got some more mac and cheese, guys.
I've come to the...
What's the word?
Not the realization.
I've come with peace that this might ruin my sleep schedule.
I want to stream tomorrow, but...
It might be more Minecraft.
Give us the seed.
No!
I refuse to give you the seed.
I refuse.
Don't keep proposing this.
I thought we were gonna start in the morning.
What was he thinking?
Doki, I wake up at 10am every morning.
My sleep schedule is not broken like yours.
She had too much confidence.
Yeah, I think so.
I'm just eating my dinner.
Where even is she?
Like, where did she...
Look at this guy taking over my...
My bridge.
We don't mind a second stream.
If it comes down to it, we have to...
She's in the ground.
What is this hobbit...
What is she doing?
She's a groundhog now?
I'm gonna keep going.
But I need more.
I don't wanna waste all my deep sleep.
For these, you know?
These are good against like...
I can get more, I guess.
No!
She's six feet under.
I wish that were me.
Actually, can she and I trade places?
Can she and I trade places?
I guess I can drop here.
Did she go further than me?
I don't know.
Oh wait!
Oh my gosh, there she is!
Doki Birdo.
I found her.
That's so funny.
Oh my gosh.
More...
Okay, blue forest is fine.
We don't mind the blue forest.
Here, I'll even make the bridge over there.
I'll be productive.
While we wait.
Oh my god.
I'll be productive, everybody.
Doki stream, you may not be able to see.
But trust.
Trust in me.
That I'm making a bridge.
Across the sea.
I'm...
Almost there.
We'll find the fortress and we'll live.
We'll survive.
It's the two of us.
We can do it.
We have to be able to.
Oh my god, no.
Gassed.
I swear, go away.
Oh my god, I hear him.
He's like right next to me.
No.
Oh my gosh.
Believe.
Believe in magic.
Guys, okay.
I'm just gonna say it.
We've gone through every biome but the basalt.
We have to go through the basalt.
We've gone through every...
Oh my god.
I thought that was a...
I thought that was a fortress.
Oh my god.
I literally...
This I thought was the top of...
Oh my god.
I thought we had made it.
I made it myself so much.
We've gone through every biome but the basalt.
This is what we have to do.
Oh!
See, check that out!
Come here.
Give me magma cubes.
Why do they hurt so much?
Did that not give me anything?
Oh my gosh, everything is so stingy in this game.
No nether fortress November?
November?
Yeah, maybe.
If we never find one, just what do we do?
I think we should give ourselves a time limit.
And if we don't find it within the time...
No!
Don't give me...
Oh my god.
I literally was gonna say, if we don't find one in the next 30 minutes...
We do a new seed.
But then I literally just saw it.
Sorry, I need to drink so much more water.
I sent that before...
The funny and sad thing was that you two were making really good progress...
But the nether said no.
I sent that before.
That's so silly.
I know how to get to here, so I didn't really need to save the cords...
But I guess it's good to have it too.
Oh my god.
It was right here.
Oh my gosh.
She just has to cross from here.
She just crosses.
She's right up there, she crosses...
And then we just run right into it.
Oh my god.
What if I don't tell her that I found one?
What if I just didn't tell her that I found it?
I'm just kidding.
I mean...
Dragoons, I'm gonna tell her, don't worry.
We've been through enough.
We've been through enough, I'm gonna tell her, don't worry.
Alright.
Loot it and then don't tell her?
I'm not going in there by myself, I hate...
I hate fortresses.
I'm gonna make a little hideaway for me.
Don't go into the basalt, they said.
Oh my...
Doki's chat...
All the dragoons said don't go into the basalt.
You didn't have to prove me wrong that fast.
What did you do?
What did you say?
Thank you guys for all the donos...
And memberships and gifted and everything.
I really appreciate it.
Both of us.
Sorry we can't really acknowledge all of them on stream.
While we're...
Losing our brain cells.
But we are seeing.
As a dragoon, please don't tell her.
I would just snitch.
Yeah, you would.
Eragon, where are you?
Eragon the snitcher.
You gotta change your name, man.
So you found it, but like...
Doki guess?
This guy is really trying hard to get those.
I wanna get these.
This is perfect too, we can get lots of magma cubes.
Actually, I feel like this is a good...
Magma cubes are annoying, but they're not so...
Bad, you know?
This is a good biome for it to spawn in.
Why'd I say all of this?
And...
It's like a broken fortress and we don't get any blazes.
Oh gosh.
I think Doki stole one O from your name.
Oh, the Birdo?
Doki Birdo?
Yeah, she saw how popular Minto is.
And she's like, oh yeah, I'll be Doki Birdo.
Or she's trying to be Birdo from...
From...
Mario, but who would want to be that loser?
Don't jinx it?
I don't know, guys.
I'm feeling, I don't know.
I'm gonna hide in this cubby hole while I eat.
I always believed in you, especially you.
Thanks, Izzy.
Birdo is so scary looking.
And I like kimo kawaii things.
Like, seeing these things called labubus.
Have you guys ever heard of it?
You know how like...
These like...
These blind boxes of like...
These random characters have gotten really popular?
I've never seen a labubu?
I don't know how to spell it, but...
I keep just seeing people being like...
Who would want to buy a labubu?
Why are they so popular?
They're so ugly.
But they're kinda, I like them.
I think they're cute.
They look like little gremlins.
Labubu craze even in the west?
I think less so, but it's still popular.
People will line up at stores...
At like 5am for new labubus.
I don't understand it.
Got popular thanks to Lisa.
Like...
Blackpink?
Is she Blackpink?
They're cute though.
I like them.
Labubu.
It's fun to say.
Oh yeah, Lisa Blackpink.
Okay.
I don't know, recently...
The weirdest things are popping off.
Where people will like...
Have you guys heard about...
The ladies that stock TJ Maxx...
For Hello Kitty goods?
If you don't live in the US...
There's a store called TJ Maxx...
That sells kind of discounted...
Items and stuff.
It's like...
It's not Walmart.
But it's like sometimes you can find...
Designer brands in there that are...
A little...
Like...
Less expensive and stuff.
And so...
But recently, Hello Kitty blankets...
And like mugs and things...
Have become like...
The it item.
And so, these ladies...
Are going to TJ Maxx and like...
Scalping these Hello Kitty products.
They're not even that cute.
I don't understand.
Is it like a discount store?
Yeah.
It's like...
I don't know how to describe it, honestly.
It's like if Target was a thrift store.
Yeah, I guess that makes sense.
But they'll...
They'll go to TJ Maxx in the early mornings...
And like...
Fill their carts with all the...
Restocked Hello Kitty goods.
And then...
I'm back.
Welcome back.
So, did you get...
Did you...
Did you get any...
Intel?
On how to do this?
Did you cheat?
No, I didn't cheat.
No, I don't know.
Did you cheat?
No, I didn't.
Doki.
There's a guy...
There's a... Oh, he's getting beat up.
Doki?
I found it.
You.
I found one.
I built a bridge.
Come over here.
Hello?
Why did you leave?
What?
Come here!
Get out of your hole.
I saw your hole.
Why is my chat...
Huh?
Why is my chat saying many different things?
What?
Because they're not watching me.
They didn't see me discover it.
What?
Dragoons!
Dragoons, why are you being like this?
What?
Dragoons said you were cheating.
Oh my God.
No, literally, when I came back, the first super chat I saw was someone being like, give me the seed.
And I was like, no!
You don't even know the seed.
You can't even find the seed.
Yeah, I don't even have the commands, probably.
Oh, do you see me?
Yes, there's a pig in front of me!
Put down a mushroom!
I only have one!
That's all you need, come on!
But what if he hits me?
Put it down!
I have ten.
Put it down.
This is a block, it's not...
It's not grass!
What are you talking about?
This is another block, it's not the grass.
Oh, hold on.
Oh shit.
Oh, don't come for me.
Oh my God.
Use your shield.
They can't hit you if you have your shield up when they try to knock you back.
Oh, see?
You got him.
Easy.
Oh my God.
There's a gas!
There's so many things going on.
Oh my God.
There's so many...
I'm heading over.
How did you find this fortress?
Because I...
Said, I was literally to my chat, I was like...
Guys, the one...
The one...
Biome we haven't been to is the basalt biome.
And that's where we have to go.
And then it was...
Why did everybody saying you cheated?
Because they're assholes, they hate me and they're trying to sabotage me.
Fine, you know what?
You can find it then.
No, no, no, no.
I believe you.
I'll just check the bot later.
What?
You don't believe me?
No, no, I believe you.
I believe you.
I...
What's Hot Tourist Destination?
Do we just go through every single biome in this stupid world?
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
We didn't go to all the biomes.
Okay, come here.
We're going.
How did you go so...
How did you go so far?
I only went to here.
Yes, where is it?
And there it is.
You see it over there?
No.
You see that?
You don't see that?
No.
What do you mean you don't see that?
My render doesn't go that far.
Oh my god.
I need to get closer.
There's nothing there on my screen.
What?
Oh my god.
No wonder you wouldn't see anything then.
Square in the ground?
What's square in the ground?
I've never seen a fortress before, so I actually don't know what it looks like.
It's like just a bunch of brick.
That's supposed to be brick?
You see that big chunk of brick?
That?
Yeah.
Oh shit.
Oh, that!
Yeah!
Wait, that's a fortress?
It's just brick!
That's what I said!
It's just in front of us!
I know!
That's what it was supposed to look like?
Yes, what did you expect?
I thought it'd be like a fortress!
No, they're really lame!
Oh, maybe we, like, pass by a lot of these, because they are...
No, I don't think so.
They do not look very easy to see.
Oh, apparently it's very rare for it to spawn like that.
Oh, well, we're in it.
We're in it.
Alright, it's time.
Oh my God!
There's the blazes, there's the blazes!
Alright, time to take down.
Are you ready?
Oh gosh, we might actually fall in there.
This is it, this is what we've been working for!
We worked so hard for this.
For this, we have to live.
Okay, yeah, see?
That's what I was afraid would happen.
Hey, move, move!
We can maybe build a staircase like this.
Oh my God, we did it.
We actually did it.
Yeah, I know I did it.
We did it.
I fell down.
Okay, that's fine.
We do need a way out though.
Okay, is that enough?
No, that's not good.
What happened?
Wait, I don't like the sound of that.
Why did you say that?
No, I'm just trying to figure out a way out.
But it was like lava.
I'm just gonna...
Do you hear the blazes?
No.
Try to get them up close.
Don't get them from far away.
What if there's sickles?
Put down torches, put down torches.
What does the torches do?
They stop the wither skellies from spawning.
No, I'm not talking about that.
I'm just talking about what if I just encounter one.
Then don't fight it.
Don't fight it.
Because if it hits you, it'll like...
Oh my God, it's burning.
Oh, I see one.
He's right there.
Oh no, the wither skelly!
Oh shoot.
You can't get me.
It's a good spot.
Nice.
Wait, what's that in front of us?
That's just basalt.
What are they doing here like this?
Oh my God, there's a bunch of wither skellies.
Yeah, I see them.
We don't want them.
Not this time.
That's not our goal.
Wither skellies, you are not our goal this time.
Like, don't let them touch you.
Oh wait, we got the warts!
Oh yes, these!
We need these!
Some of them are not grown though.
Oh, maybe they are.
But I think the blazes are here.
No, that's a wither skelly.
Oh, where?
Over there.
No, I think I hear blazes to my left.
There's also a wither right here.
I'm making more...
Okay, I see them.
I'm making more torches.
Yeah, bitch.
Yeah, they're right here.
They're right here.
In front of me.
Okay.
They're not our goal.
Like the... Oh!
Diamond!
Let's go!
Oh, I think I...
What?
It was just a normal skelly, but I ran.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, I thought it was...
He freaked me out.
No, he freaked me out too.
Oh my god.
I got freaked out a little.
Alright, no, but the blazes are right here.
I hear them.
Yeah, I do.
They're everywhere.
Okay.
Oh god, they're breathing.
Oh, why do they sound so scary?
Breathing really hard.
I think they're upstairs.
Are they upstairs?
Maybe.
I hear a wither skelly.
Maybe they are.
Oh, no, no, no, no!
Oh shit!
You can block them.
You can block...
Okay.
I have a lot of experience with these guys.
Oh my god, you're gaming?
You're gaming?
I got nothing though.
No!
Next up!
Oh, nothing here, nothing.
Dead end, dead end, dead end.
Okay.
Dead end.
Yeah.
Are you sure?
Yeah, you go for it.
Oh, didn't trust me.
That's cool.
That's fine.
Yeah.
That's okay.
I was just double checking.
That's okay if you don't trust me.
That's okay.
It's fine.
Some people just don't trust others.
Where did you go?
I'm trying to see where they are.
I think they're all above us.
Yeah, how do we get above?
Oh, we probably have to dig up.
Okay.
But we got, we found this!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Oh my god.
This is where the real grind comes.
We don't even have enough for like...
Like...
Wait, do we go here?
Where?
Here.
I don't see you.
The other exit.
Below the stairs.
Here, here, here.
We didn't go this way.
Oh, oh, oh.
No, we didn't go this way.
Yeah.
Hold on, I'm grabbing the rest of the warts.
Did I grab some warts accidentally?
Oh, I did here.
Here's some nether warts too.
Okay, thank you.
Oh, we didn't go here.
Oh, this is scary.
Okay, we didn't go here.
I hear a magma.
It's above us.
I hear Wither Skelly.
Be careful.
Oh, there's more blazes here.
There's more blazes here.
Okay.
Watch me.
I'll get the blaze.
You get the Wither Skelly.
Where is the Wither Skelly?
I don't see him.
I heard him.
I got obsidian too.
I got rip armor trim.
Do we want that?
Oh.
No, we don't need it.
Is that netherite?
Are armor trims netherite?
No.
Come here, come here.
There's more wards here too.
Got him.
I don't see...
Okay, run, run, run, run.
What happened?
I got hit.
Where are they?
They're on the side.
They're to the right.
To the right.
Oh, there they are.
Alright.
JK.
Oh my God.
I don't see the other skeleton.
That's okay.
Oh, he might be up.
I see magma cube.
Oh my God, this...
This is so confusing.
I told you, never give up.
Never give up.
Someone almost gave up.
I found it.
Before they found it, before they found it, they almost gave up.
I remembered.
We're like locked in now.
We're like...
We're so...
We can't.
Oh, there's a magma cube here.
Kill him.
Oh, I see him.
I think this is not a bad spawn though, because honestly...
Like...
Okay.
I don't have any more torches, by the way.
Oh, there's another blaze.
Oh my God.
I don't know where he was.
I don't know anything.
Shoot me.
Oh my God.
I got blaze rod.
Get a blaze rod.
Okay, I got blaze rod.
How many blaze rods do we need?
I don't know.
That's a dead end.
That's a dead end right there.
Did you get the warts?
Yeah, I got them.
Alright, we gotta go up.
Oh, is this one of those that drops off?
Yeah, that's what I was like.
We can do that.
There we go.
Oh, there's another wither skillie.
Oh, he dropped off.
Oh yeah, the rib armor trim would be so cool again if only we did it.
There's so many rib armor trim.
Yeah.
Ten rods is... Okay, we need at least ten rods.
We gotta get the spawner then.
Wait, do you have any more torches?
Yeah, I have some.
Where are you?
Upstairs?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm here.
I guess I'll throw away the bone.
I guess.
You're a single bone?
No, I have six bones.
I guess I'll get rid of it.
Oh, there's diamond horse armor.
I wish they would come closer.
I have arrows.
Now we can't get the blaze riser all the way over there.
This is scary.
I think that's where the... See?
Okay, do you... Oh, you're...
You're what's it called?
You see... Can you see where it looks like a jungle gym?
Yeah.
That's where the spawner is.
How do we get there?
Maybe it's like over here to our left?
Maybe, but it'll be really risky running over there.
Oh, there should be a guy here.
Oh, there is!
It is Ash!
Oh, shit!
Why did I get hit?
How did he hit you?
Did you kill him?
I killed one of them.
Okay.
Ignore that guy.
It has to be this way then.
If we can even get to it.
Actually, maybe we can.
Oh, hello.
I looted that, I think.
No, not this way.
But...
The hardest part is avoiding them when they're...
Oh, come here.
Because they like to fly away.
He's not above.
How did we get there?
I feel like we already went through all the entrances.
Sometimes it's not connected.
Sometimes it's like blocked off, you know?
Okay, watch out for him.
Watch out for him.
Wait, do we go drop down from here?
Wait, maybe?
Oh, maybe.
It's like here, right?
Well, you went down here though.
Oh my God, I hear one.
He's breathing in my ear.
It's like around this general area.
Right?
No, it's not connected.
I don't think it's connected.
Unless... Oh wait, it's probably down this way.
Oh shit!
Oh no, Doki!
Doki!
I'm not okay!
Okay, I'm coming over!
I'm coming over!
I'm not okay!
Where are you?
You give me baby!
There's another one!
Okay, I got one of them.
I got one of them.
Are you okay?
Are you please?
There's a blaze!
Please, please, please.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I just heard dad howling.
I freaked out.
I heard you was howling and I was like...
Oh shit!
Shit!
I might not be okay.
Hold on.
Get behind my shield!
A tactical retreat!
Okay.
Oh my God.
Got him.
Oh, there's more!
There's more!
Yeah, there were two of them!
There were two of them!
Okay.
You got it.
Oh my God.
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
We're okay!
Oh my God.
It freaked me out because my dog was also howling.
He was... I don't know.
I think he heard us yelling and he's like...
I wanna get in.
He was like...
I was like freaking out.
I was like, why is he howling?
Everything was happening.
Oh, there's magmas.
Oh my God.
I think that was a good idea.
Why did they come at me like that?
Oh my God.
It's because you're literally killing them.
What do you mean?
No.
No, I would never.
What can I get rid of?
What?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
You got him.
I hate wither skellies.
Oh, there's a place.
Yeah, the spawn.
Wait, which one was the spawner again?
I already lost... I only got one bracelet.
I know where it was.
I don't wanna get rid of the string.
What if I need to make a new bow?
Well, I guess I don't need the bow.
Oh, the quartz.
Thank you.
I don't need the quartz.
Oh, I need to get rid of...
There we go.
Okay.
I need to keep my gold chest plate.
What if my gold helmet breaks, guys?
Watch out.
I think I heard a guy.
Nevermind.
I think it's just the magma cubes.
Wait, so where was it?
Okay, this way?
But it's gonna be really dangerous going over there, I think.
I think we gotta take the sip.
I think we gotta take...
I don't know.
I think it's safer to just let them spawn...
Where... When we... Okay, there's a... Yeah.
I don't know why he's howling.
I don't know why he's howling right now.
Is your dog howling?
Yeah, my dog's howling.
Yeah, see, we have to, like, go down here.
He never howls.
I think it's just safer to...
To...
You can block the skellies in the hallways because they're three blocks tall.
Oh, really?
Okay, good to know.
I don't know.
I just wanna eat my dinner.
I'm making a fucking wall.
I'm making a wall.
I need to check on my dog.
I need to know why he's howling.
We're back.
He's like, I don't know, check in here.
I was like, oh my God, why are you howling up your back?
Oh my God.
Oh, shoot.
I got hit by arrows.
I'm also gonna block this up.
Why do they keep spawning even though I put...
Maybe it's too dark here.
I thought that was one of them.
Hey, you.
Come here.
Blaze, blaze, blaze, blaze, blaze.
How many magma cubes we got?
Only one?
We have the one magma cream?
Torches don't work?
No, they usually work for the skellies.
Why do I hear so many things?
I hear blaze, breeze, blaze, crackle, wither, skeleton, crackles.
What's going on?
I don't know.
Is anything bad happening outside?
Okay.
I thought they worked in here for the skellies at least.
I thought the torches worked.
My dog's okay.
He's just...
He's being a little freaky.
Yeah, he's being a little freaky today.
Usually never... I think this is the second time I've ever heard him howl.
Oh my God.
Yeah, this is a big guy right here.
He's just like on his pillow.
Just chilling.
Get him, get him so we can get magma cream.
But watch out for the size.
Don't go so far out.
Oh wait, I forgot they like multiply.
Yeah.
And then again.
Yep, keep going.
Did I get any magma cream?
You got me one.
Got rid of the bones again.
Okay.
You can hand it to me.
I have the magma cream.
Do we need soul sand or soul soil?
None of... We don't need either.
Don't you need to plant the warts in the soul soil?
No, we have plenty.
Okay, so I'll get rid of that.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
Come here.
Come over here.
What if I kill him with my bow and arrow and then you...
Why did you just stand there?
I just wanna look at him.
I'm gonna kill him and then you parkour.
No!
How was our parkour?
He's too far.
No, he's not.
He's literally right there.
It was... There wasn't any rods anyway.
It doesn't matter.
You didn't find any lava probably.
No, I didn't.
There was no lava over there.
Yeah, yeah.
Likely story.
Oh my gosh, there's so many wither skellies here.
Just keep spawning, I think.
I know.
Wait, wait, wait.
There's a blaze rod right in front of me.
I'm gonna do it.
Blaze rod?
I mean blaze, blaze.
I'm gonna do it.
No, you're not gonna be able to get...
Oh my god, Doki-Doki.
I'm gonna do it.
Doki-Doki.
Doki.
I'm coming back.
I realized it was a mistake.
That was so fast.
Wait, hold on.
I gotta build a wall, because...
Oh, that's it?
That's it.
That's your wall.
Thanks.
I gotta check if my YouTube keeps freezing.
The chat's frozen, guys.
I'm sorry.
One second.
Just in case... Just in case, like, I get fucked over too.
I gotta make sure that I'm also safe.
Oh, I hear so many noises.
I hear so many noises around us.
Okay, are we safe?
Doki's counter says mint death 3.
No, it doesn't.
I'm gaslighting you.
Why are you in here?
What the hell?
I was scared!
Oh my god, you have to be able to handle yourself.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
We go like this.
Oh, okay.
What do you mean how do we get out of here?
I couldn't tell.
It was dark.
Okay.
There must be a Blaze right above us.
We should go get him.
Yeah, I hear him.
There's a lot of things right above us.
What the hell is going on up here?
It's a party!
Yeah, I wouldn't do that.
Yeah, what are you gonna do?
I'm gonna look for Blazes in other areas.
What are you gonna do, slam me?
Oh my god, don't give me a good time.
Other Blazes in your area.
Don't give me a good time.
We'll get the magma cream.
Yeah, I'm getting the magma now.
Wait, did we ever went upstairs like this?
No, because it's scary.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
I'm just...
Please get closer.
There's another magma cream right here.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Did you grab the magma cream?
Hold on.
Where is it?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's so many.
I know, I know, I know.
That's what...
They're multiplying.
I like how this one pig is just watching us.
At least there's no Blazes up here.
We also have to get rid of these guys because then...
It'll spawn like other...
Oh, we have been here.
Yeah, we've been up this way, yeah.
Yeah, you said we haven't.
No, I thought you meant like on...
In that little area room.
There we go.
How many...
I have only two.
I have one of them.
You got the other one.
This sucks.
They're not dropping anything.
They're so far away.
Why can't they spawn faster?
Put out some torches, Mint.
So mobs spawn inside.
Which is it?
Do the torches work?
Do the torches not work?
I just said that the torches don't work.
No!
What is it?
I got fucking sniped.
He's like all the way over there.
How did you snipe me?
That's why you don't go out there.
We know there's a spawner...
But the spawner is danger zone.
We can't get to there.
The spawner is really far, guys.
We can't get there.
It's like separated.
We can't cross.
Oh, gosh.
Right below where you were is a spawner thing?
Below us?
Below?
I think maybe they mean...
Oh my God, hello.
How did he get here?
He spawned.
We got two.
There's a much closer spawner.
There is?
I feel like we walked everywhere.
I feel like we walked everywhere too.
Yeah.
We went down here, yeah.
We're getting one guide.
I can't tell.
There's one guy that said we're getting one guide, but then there's three people said that...
There's a spawner that's closer.
I know, sometimes people will say one guide, but...
But multiple people will say the same thing.
So I don't know.
Oh, hello.
Um...
I'm trying.
It's next to the broken bridge?
There's a broken bridge?
I'm not okay.
Remember when I said I wasn't okay?
Yeah.
I got hit.
I got hit too.
Bye.
It's a pope.
It's a Skelly.
Regular Skelly.
Regular old Joe Skelly.
Come on.
Watch out.
On the top floor?
Right below the broken bridge?
What the fuck does any of those words mean?
On the top floor?
Right below a broken bridge.
There is a...
Blaze spawner.
This floor?
The floor I'm on right now?
The scary floor?
Right here?
Right before a broken bridge?
Oh my god.
In the middle of summer?
Make shops?
I just start spamming.
I forget to make the shops.
This is the top floor.
This is the very top.
Here?
This is a broken bridge?
That broken bridge?
Watch out.
There's a guy who's gonna start shooting.
There's 200 fucking things here.
I just left it?
Right here to my left?
This one?
Right here?
In the middle of the fortress?
Oh, there it is.
It's right there.
Look at the corner to your left.
I think it's the wither spawner.
There is no wither spawner.
Oh, wait.
Maybe it is.
I think this is the wither spawner.
Oh my god.
It's just a wither...
Wait, is that a thing?
A wither spawner?
Oh my god.
I'm pretty sure.
That's like three...
There's no...
It's a blaze!
Oh shit.
I was gonna say, I don't think blaze spawners exist.
I'm trying to get rid of the skellies.
Get rid of everything.
Oh my god.
We gotta build a bridge.
Okay, one of us has to build and one of us has to take out the guys.
Okay, I got you.
I got the arrows.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
You can actually...
Oh my god.
You need to defend yourself too though.
Okay, I'm gonna eat.
I'm running out of arrows.
I just need you to know that.
Oh, that's not good.
That's not great.
Don't do it.
Don't cross.
It's a bad idea.
I have my shield up.
I need to make bread.
I'm running out of food.
Okay, there's three guys now, so...
I'm making bread.
Just calm down.
I'm calm.
Oh my god.
And then there's a gas?
I don't think I will be able to make it enough, everybody.
Oh my god, please.
I'm gonna fail this.
Where's our gas from?
Oh my god.
Stop getting hit!
I killed two.
Oh my god, you're gaming right now?
I ran out of arrows, so it's up to you.
I killed three.
Alright, you did it.
You should be able to go now.
Okay, but...
Help me.
Here.
I give you half.
How?
Take it.
I need to know there's a gas somewhere.
Somewhere.
Okay, I'm gonna speed this.
Oh my god.
Come back.
I heard a blaze.
He's right here.
Build a wall.
You keep building the bridge.
He came back.
Gas came back.
I gotta eat.
I'm gonna drink it.
I'm gonna drink fire resistance.
I'm gonna die.
Actually, that might be the good...
Actually, this might be the good time to do it.
I'm gonna do it.
Keep building.
I need you to build for me.
What do you mean?
You have the fire resistance.
Will I still get hit?
Gas, you can get hit.
Won't I die?
I don't have...
This is bad.
I might die.
No!
Just spam attack.
The fire can't hurt you right now.
I'm getting hit by so many.
Please help me.
I don't have torches.
Where are they?
Oh my god.
I gotta drink my potion.
I'm hitting them.
Okay, I'm coming in.
He's still hitting me.
It doesn't hurt me, but why am I still getting hit?
Why am I still getting hit?
Wait, really?
With the fire even?
Yeah.
Wait, do you have torches?
Someone said she has full HP.
Hey, I have 6.
What the fuck, man?
Okay, I'm out of torches.
I have torches.
I'm okay now.
I have 64 here.
Here are some torches.
Please, come over here and die.
I'm just gonna put this here for now.
I can't.
I don't want...
I need these guys to get out first.
I need them to leave first.
Okay, hold on.
We'll let them spawn in when things start calming down.
He's on me.
Oh my God.
There's 26 on me, too!
Oh, they can do melee damage?
Wow.
Give them more stuff to do, I guess.
Blaze rod, blaze rod, blaze rod, blaze rod.
I have four blaze rods.
I can't pick it up.
I need you to pick it up.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
It's up here, it's up here, it's up here.
What's the point of attacking these bozos?
Oh my God, I'm getting a stomachache from all this.
Oh my God, I'm gonna freaking freak out soon.
How much is left?
Okay, a minute and a half left on my thing.
You probably have less than.
This is gonna be my fifth freakout right here.
Oh, I just fell inside.
Oh my God.
Oh no.
Alright, they're gonna spawn in again.
Okay.
I'm building our escape route.
While it's calm.
I don't have arrows.
Do you have?
Oh, I do.
How many do I have?
Try and kill them here though.
How many do I have left?
I can't see, I can't see.
Use your shield.
One second is gone.
I don't have fire resistance.
I'm waiting for the spawner.
I got another, I got another.
I got five.
Wait, you have six, right?
You have one, right?
I have one.
Okay, we got it.
Oh shit, oh shit.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
There's another arrow, there's another one.
Oh my God, these guys.
I'm gonna murder them, I'm gonna murder them.
Stupid skellies, I hate them so much.
Oh, there's another spawner in front of us?
Yes, there's another.
That's the one that I was looking at.
I was not looking at that one.
I'm gonna block, I'm gonna block this area.
I'm gonna block this area.
I need a heal before we go in.
I can, okay, I can.
Okay,
I have six.
We need...
Oh, I need ten, okay.
I'll break the torches again.
I needed it to calm down.
I needed things to calm down before they start spawning.
I'm blocking these walls.
Okay, I'm blocking...
Blocking these walls too.
Actually...
Yeah, like, make it so that when they spawn in...
They can't leave.
Oh my god, no!
Are you okay?
No.
Oh my god, hello.
Oh my god.
I'm not okay.
I need a heal, I'm not okay.
I'm not okay anymore.
How is there a guy here?
Okay, I need a heal.
Yeah, go heal, go heal!
I'm not okay, I'm actually...
I'm gonna fucking collapse.
Okay, I healed up.
I got two, I got two rounds.
Okay, we have A, we have A.
Oh, your helmet broke.
Oh, is that why?
Okay, that makes more sense.
That's why I was taking so much fucking damage.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Go back, go back, go back!
Throw a grenade!
Oh my god.
Imagine if I get...
Oh my god, when they're on fire, they're about to, like, attack.
So, like, attack when they're not on fire, and then, like, shield up when they get on fire.
Oh my god, how did that still hit me?
How did that still hit me?
I'm backing up, don't be a hero, Mint.
Don't be a hero, don't be a hero.
Okay, I gotta heal, I gotta heal.
Nade!
I don't have arrows, guys!
Oh, I do.
That was my last arrow.
Do you have arrows?
Uh, yes, here, spectral arrows.
There you go, there you go.
Give me all of it, give me all your arrows.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they're still spotting.
Put torches on it, put torches on it.
I killed three, I killed three.
I don't have any more torches.
I have torches, okay.
Okay.
Oh my god, how's it still hitting me?
I don't have any more arrows.
Ah, I don't have any more.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm going in.
No, no, I can't risk it.
I can't risk it, I can't risk it.
Get out, get out, get out.
We just...
We can't get out, we can't...
The thing is, we have to return home, but this is the only way we can go home.
Oh my god.
This is the only... I'm drinking the other potion.
I'm drinking the other potion, I'm going in.
I'm drinking one more potion, I'm going in.
I'm going in, I'm going in with these potions.
Live, just live.
I'm going in.
I can't live.
I got another rod though, that's cool.
How many do we need?
I don't know.
I went in, I went in, I went in.
Oh my god.
We have 10, we have 10, I have 10, I have 10.
We made it.
Get this guy.
Alright.
Okay, I think we can leave.
I made an escape route.
Yeah, we can leave now, yeah.
We did it.
Do you have enough food?
Are you good?
Yeah, I'm good.
Oh my god.
Now we go home.
Going home.
Alright, do you have obsidian?
I have two obsidian.
I have...
Alright, time to walk over.
Wait, is it really 10 is enough?
We have 13.
With you, we have 13.
I'm gonna give you my other three.
We'll just keep them all together.
10 is minimum.
We have 13.
We have 13, that's good, that's good.
13 is good.
People were saying 14 is like the absolute safe.
So 13 is good.
Watch out, watch out, watch out!
What are you looking at?
Why are you wearing a gold...
Because my helmet's broken!
I don't wanna get beat up by the pigs!
No, oh...
Okay, okay, I got you.
Okay, how do we get out of here?
There's a gold chestplate if you need this.
Oh, okay, I'll take it.
Just in case your helmet breaks.
Oh my god, it's almost dead.
Alright, how do we go home?
How do we get out of here?
What would be the easiest way?
How do we...
We traveled very far.
Very far...
Let's just get out of the fortress first so that we...
Someone said trade for more obsidian.
Oh...
We should.
I left my crafting table so I gotta make another one.
Oh, I can make one.
I just made it.
Okay, so I'm gonna make the...
I'm watching out for any guys to attack.
Alright, do you have any nuggies or no?
No nuggies.
Alright, so I have...
I have 16 gold for obsidian.
How many obsidian do we need?
We need 10.
Okay, we have 4.
Yeah, we have 4.
Give me your obsidian.
Okay.
That's fine.
We're so paranoid.
I know.
We are paranoid.
Alright, we gotta figure out...
How do we get here?
You gotta go back to...
How did we get in here?
How did we get here?
Did you go down here?
I didn't open that.
No, I did.
We gotta find the other...
Assault place.
Oh, no.
No, not here.
Oh my god.
I can't believe we did it.
We actually did it.
We didn't get one guide.
I know.
I can't believe there's a Ouroborealis right here in the kitchen.
It was right here.
It was actually right here.
Oh my god.
I have such a bad stomachache right now.
I'm gonna puke up all my mac and cheese.
From the stress?
Yeah, from the stress of it all.
How did we get out in here?
How did we get here?
I don't understand.
Oh, is it here?
No, I'm just seeing...
No, I'm just seeing things.
I'm just seeing things.
I'm just...
I'm just seeing things now.
I don't know anymore.
Everything looks the same.
How did we get in here?
I don't know.
From the top of the fortress.
So, up here, but there was like other...
Oh, shit.
Wait, here?
I found it!
Where?
I found it.
Look at my name tag.
I don't see it.
Everything is...
Right here.
It's here.
I remember we dug that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait a minute.
Did we not...
Oh, we came from above, remember?
Yeah, but there was an area that we dropped in.
Yeah, yeah, I built ourselves a stairs.
Okay.
Kind of.
Well, I was in the process of doing it.
Hold on.
Thanks.
There we go.
They actually do work if you...
You know, not use it as a staircase.
It's a staircase.
It's not a staircase.
There was one block that I couldn't go up from.
Hey, we wouldn't have found this thing if it wasn't for me.
Okay, so, you know...
Cut me some slack.
Oh, I hear a ghast.
I'm scared.
We just have to get to an area...
Oh, shit.
Hide, hide, hide.
Is that the ghast?
Yes, yes.
And you have no arrows?
I have no arrows.
I have two bones.
Oh, shit.
We gotta go through the forest.
That's okay.
The forest is fine.
It's just Enderman.
We gotta...
We gotta do it.
I have one arrow?
Oh, I do have an arrow!
Yeah, but this takes two arrows.
It takes two arrows to kill him.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, um...
How can we get over there?
There's so many Endermen.
Watch out for blazes.
The blazes...
The blazes are really far.
They shoot from everywhere.
It's crazy.
Is the ghast still there?
I don't see him.
Can we do it?
Did he despawn?
Maybe.
I don't see him.
Oh, shit!
Um, I'm in trouble.
I'm in trouble.
Make a wall.
I'm making a wall, Maya, too.
Keep making walls.
I'm a little stuck.
I'm making walls for us.
You head here.
Where are you?
Oh, I see you.
Flying higher.
They're flying higher.
Okay.
I've made a wall.
Come down here when you can.
Come down?
Yeah, we have to get to the forest.
We have to get down.
Why are you shooting?
Who can you even see?
Me!
That's who!
Who can you even see?
I'm literally behind you!
Hold on!
I thought you were...
I thought you were covered.
Okay, I'm almost really out of everything that I have.
I'm thinking...
I'm stealing stuff I had.
Oh, don't look.
Don't look at them.
Don't look at them, because we ran out of stone.
We ran out of stone, so don't look at them.
No, I still have a little bit of stone.
I still have a little bit of stone.
Yes, but the Endermen are right below us.
The Endermen are right below us, so don't look at them.
Oh, shit.
Here you go.
We're not safe.
Thank you, but we're not safe from the blazes.
Oh, no.
Please despawn blazes!
How are we supposed to...
Oh, gosh.
I think we might have to like...
Jump and just run into the forest.
Okay, let's do it.
And then dig into the wall.
Okay.
This is how we die.
Wait, have your pickaxe?
Well, I have mine ready.
Have your everything ready?
Okay, I'm gonna eat real quick.
Sword or pickaxe?
Pickaxe, probably.
Who are we fighting?
The Endermen?
I don't know, what if we accidentally look at them?
Okay, true.
Alright, I'm gonna go down.
Okay, we're safe.
For now.
Alright, let's go.
Just run.
Be careful here, there's a huge hole.
There's a huge hole right here.
Just run.
What if the Enderman slaps you?
What if he slaps you?
Just run!
Okay, I think we're safe from the blazes though.
Okay.
Oh my god!
We gotta find the pigs.
We gotta get back to pigs.
We gotta get back to the...
Wait, the red area is where we came from.
Oh shoot.
The ghast blocked us, so we can't...
We gotta find our own red area.
Let's just dig through here...
and we can dig to the right...
and we might make it back into that area.
It took us three hours to find a fortress.
Oh, thank you.
I thought...
For a second there, I was about to be like, wait, you didn't just dig...
and get lava?
This is good though, we're replenishing our...
That's good, we're replenishing our...
Our rock stuff.
Are you digging?
No, there's like literally holes underneath you.
There's holes underneath you.
Alright, I'm gonna dig here.
Watch out, watch out.
Okay.
I believe in you.
I won't dig to the side, because...
Yeah, don't dig.
What if there's lava?
Just let me dig.
I'll dig us out of here.
And we'll go to the red, hopefully.
I'm gonna make some bread.
And then we just...
Then we will be out, oh my gosh.
Imagine, we'll see sunlight.
Oh my God, and then we never have to go there again.
No, don't say that.
Don't say that.
We'll never have to go there again.
If we have the worst luck ever...
Unless...
Oh, it's okay.
I have my...
Unless...
It'll be so funny if something just happens.
I bet Chat is feeling so much more...
Like, confident in us now.
Wait, we have to make arrows.
We can make arrows with...
With regular materials.
Yeah, but we need...
What do we need?
Do we need...
We don't have string.
Wait, don't you need string for arrows?
I have 32 string.
Oh, okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
And then we can create lots of beds.
Yeah, we can do the bed strut.
Flint, stick, and feather.
Yeah, we don't even need string.
We need strings for bows, but...
Oh, watch out, watch out, watch out!
I'm literally 20 feet away from you.
Oh.
Of course you are.
What do you mean, of course you are?
You're taking...
You're taking lava!
Are you okay?
I'm taking sippy.
What the hell was that?
I don't fucking know.
Oh, that's the Enderman to your left.
No, but, like, something screamed.
Enderman...
Oops!
What is that?
I don't hear anything.
That has to be a gas, right?
It's not showing up on my thing as a gas.
I have no idea.
I don't know what that was.
That was weird.
I didn't hear it.
How long is this mountain?
Oh, uh, I spoke too soon.
We're still in the...
Oh my god.
Um...
I don't like that sound that you just heard.
Because we ran out of bows and arrows.
Yeah.
We have to, um, not...
encounter that guy.
Uh, we're, like, deep in the forest.
I think, um...
I think this didn't work.
I think this...
I think the red area is to our right.
I think it's...
To the right?
Yeah.
Wanna dig?
Follow the cords.
What cords?
We didn't take cords.
The coordinates back to our original...
Our very first portal.
The one that's a hundred miles away from us.
Is it this?
A little tiny spot right here?
Oh, I guess we were really close to the, um...
Oh, hello.
We were really close to the, uh...
That big forest that we came from.
Yeah, that's what I was saying.
We were really close to a forest when we got to just a little...
Yeah.
Regular guy area.
Wait, what was our coordinates for our original place?
Original portal.
Yeah, yeah, original portal.
Uh, hold on.
I wanna see how far we are from it.
Wait, there's a piglin!
Piglin snorting?
Where at?
Where are you, piglin snorting?
Can we go up?
He might be above us.
Yeah, I think he is.
You have all the...
I added all the netherite, right?
So I don't have what it...
Oh, uh...
He's behind us.
Who's behind...
Oh, hello.
Oh my god.
Yeah, he's behind us.
Let me get the cords from the original one.
Oh, okay.
Let me check.
Alright.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
What is it?
Um...
Are the... It's negative two thousand...
Oh, sorry, no.
Negative five hundred and five...
Uh...
195.
We're not making it back.
You wanna know what we are?
You don't...
Oh, I'm looking at what we are.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, we're not getting back there.
We gotta say goodbye.
Oh, we traveled that far?
Say goodbye to that lapis block.
I see a ghast.
I see a ghast floating over there.
Oh gosh, okay.
I guess we build up.
We gotta just build up.
We traveled.
Why isn't mine...
This is why the...
This is why the earth isn't round.
Because in Minecraft, it's clearly flat.
Oh my god, please.
Do you hear him?
Yes, I do.
I'm trying to not look behind me.
If you come up here, there's like a safe little area.
Oh wait, we're in the mushroom area again.
I know.
But come up here.
Come up here.
Where is here?
Where did you go?
I don't know.
I don't know anymore.
Oh, there you are.
Hey, I'm here.
Where are you?
Doki is a flat earth.
Turn around.
Oh, hello.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say in here is a safe little area.
Oh my gosh, what if we just set up shop?
What if we just lived here forever?
This is where we live.
We're just never gonna end stream.
We're just gonna be here like domestic life right here.
Domestic.
Wait, the red is in front of us.
It's literally in front of us.
It is?
Oh yeah, you're right.
It is right there.
Okay, thank goodness.
Okay.
We are putting all our...
all our gotcha luck into this right now.
But, oh...
Wait, how many pearls do we have?
Do we have enough enderpearls?
We have to get back there.
We have to get back there because all their enderpearls are there.
Oh my god, are you serious?
All their enderpearls are there.
I didn't bring them.
I didn't bring the enderpearls.
I left them all there.
We have to...
When we get out of here, we have to find our area.
We have to travel.
Okay, well...
What if we don't do that?
And we just farm enderpearls right here.
I mean, you...
I'm gonna find a piglet and trade.
Oh yeah, keep trading.
We gotta get the...
I put it there because I thought we'd come back.
I thought we'd come back.
How far did you think we were gonna...
You thought we were just gonna go for a little walk.
Like, just a little...
I didn't think we'd ever come back.
I thought we'd come back.
I really did.
I thought...
I thought we were just gonna travel there for a little bit.
And then we'd come back.
There's one more over there.
Alright.
Oh, he's looking at you.
Okay.
Yeah, I got him.
Yeah, you keep trading.
I'm carrying the brewing stand.
I have the brewing stand.
I have the brewing stand, guys.
Don't worry.
I have the brewing stand.
I brought it with me.
I thought I had.
Is that also black stone?
Wait.
It gives you obsidian.
Let me know.
I'll take it.
He keeps giving me corrupted obsidian.
What?
What if you went above ground and traveled 20,000 blocks back to the portal in the overworld?
Well, that's where our stuff is.
Wait.
That's where we...
That's what we did.
Wait, I'm confused.
Oh no.
Above ground?
It's like the world limit.
Oh, like...
It's like you can go all the way up...
for the world limit.
Like the world limit thing.
Like, wait.
Create a new portal and travel in the normal world.
That's what we're trying to do right now.
That's what we're trying to do.
We're trying to figure it out.
We're trying to do that.
But we just don't have obsidian.
We just don't have obsidian.
Yeah, we're trying to collect the obsidian.
I'm also just farming blocks.
I mean pearls.
Oh my god.
My gacha luck is not doing so well.
Man, my gacha luck isn't doing so well.
I've got everything but...
I have leather.
Wow.
Is that it?
Oh, I have one obsidian.
I got one obsidian.
We have five obsidian.
Okay, I can make...
I can make another...
I can make more gold.
Enderman.
I have five more gold.
I'm coming for you, Enderman.
Show me your sweet, sweet slender body.
Oh, come on.
Look at this.
Look at this juicy gold.
How much gold do you have?
I have...
Here, take my axe.
I don't need it anymore.
Take my axe.
I don't even want it.
Okay.
Come on, take it.
I heard a ghastly.
I got PTSD.
I know, I hear him too.
Unless we see...
How many enderpearls do you have?
I got five resistances.
Okay.
There's no enderman around here.
Uh-oh.
He sounds close.
Okay, here's one.
Here's one what?
Oh, thank you.
I managed to get one.
Do you have any nuggets at all?
No.
Okay, so...
Yeah.
That's it.
We gotta farm more gold.
We gotta find more gold.
There's some above us.
There's...
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna trade my axe.
This is the last axe off the back of my...
You can trade your axe?
Yeah, you can trade gold items.
Where is the...
Sir, sir, this is all I have, sir.
This is...
Please take...
This is all I have.
Hold on, we gotta look around for some gold.
I don't have any more.
This is everything I have.
What did he give me?
I don't know what he took...
What he gave me.
But what did he take from you?
What did he even give me?
He gave me nothing?!
Ah, he just puts it in his inventory?!
No, I'm afraid of trading my helmet.
Wait, wait.
My armor has way more...
My body...
Only don't give stuff for gold.
I got one guide!
Somebody...
Don't give him your stuff.
I got one guide.
Hold on, hold on.
I found some gold.
Hold on, I gotta create a little barrier for it.
So it doesn't fall into the...
Into the world.
He looked at me and just took it.
He just took it!
He just took it from me.
It was the last thing I own.
Is there anyone around here?
I don't think so.
He just took it from me.
That's so cruel.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, here we go.
Okay, now we're good.
I can't believe he just took it like that.
Really?
You can't believe it?
I can't believe it.
I feel like I just got robbed.
Dragoon did...
Dragoon did more mental damage than like...
I just got robbed.
He like looked at me and just...
Looked and just walked away.
Walked away with my golden axe.
I have 36 nuggies.
Wait, where are you?
Okay, I'm here.
I'm coming.
Alright, here's the crafting table.
I have like four on me too.
Oh, I saw an enderman, I think.
Hello?
There he is.
Okay.
I have four more.
Come on.
Come on, there's two of you.
Surely two of you.
Oh my god, he gave me so sad.
He gave me so sad.
Where is this?
Oh, I got an obsidian!
Nice!
We just need two more!
Two more, two more, two more!
I don't have gold anymore.
We gotta find some more.
We gotta find...
Back into the nether mines we go.
The nether mines.
We're like really far up.
So it's like hard to dig.
Okay, I'm just gonna dig.
I'm looking around to see if I can...
Find...
Find stuff in the nether mines.
Okay, right here.
The nether mines to get out of this hellhole.
We're doing it!
You found more nuggies?
No, but we're just, you know, we're doing something.
We're here.
I saw the enderman.
I'm looking around for nuggies for us.
I'm not gonna TNT, guys.
We're too high up.
It's too risky.
We can't.
Maybe here.
I'm just gonna block that guy up.
Okay, it's too risky.
Alright, I got some nuggies.
Okay, nice.
I'm digging for nuggies.
I have 51 on me.
I'm gonna make some now.
I don't know how I got up here.
I'm scared.
How did I get so high up?
I don't know.
What did I do?
You were blinded by the gold.
By the gold sickness.
We're literally like the guys in Pocahontas.
Gold, beautiful gold.
I don't know how the song goes.
I'm nummy nummy.
Alright, gold.
I have 5 more gold.
There's gas.
There's a gas right in front of us.
I'm in a cave.
Looking for gold.
There's a gas right here.
Just hide and he'll despawn eventually.
Don't rob me, little piggy.
Don't rob me, child.
He's like right there.
I don't have arrows.
Do you see where I am?
You can hide with me if you want.
Oh my god, he broke my crafting table.
No, I'm fine.
I got it.
I got it back.
I have wood, so if you do need another one...
Where did my other stack of wood go?
Oh, I do have...
I put some torches out in case...
Okay, this ghastly is like...
Cooking me from the pigs.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Just hide and wait until he despawns.
I tossed it back in the fortress.
Oops.
Why is he here?
I think it's really messed up...
that gas can spawn in all biomes.
I think that's probably...
I think whoever invented that...
just hates fun.
I seriously...
I think he just hates people.
It's actually the worst creature...
in Minecraft.
There's two now!
Two just spawned!
Instead of it despawning...
Two showed up!
We'll get bored of each other eventually.
Probably.
Shoot!
What arrows?
Somebody was like...
I have eight.
Time to use my eight arrows.
I have one arrow.
Alright.
Eight and a dream.
Let's go.
They despawned.
They actually despawned because I started crying.
Oh, good.
I cried too.
Where is the bug?
Why can't I get any gold?
Okay, you know what?
I give up.
I'm sorry.
I tried.
We're risking.
We're gonna risk it all...
on these five golds that I have.
Five golds left.
Five golds.
There's a lot of endermen now.
If you wanna come over to farm more enderpearls.
Yeah.
I'm looking around for them.
Oh my god.
Stop it!
Shut up!
You freak!
I don't have anything!
Oh my god.
It's just magmas.
Please.
Like the fire starters?
What is that?
What was this?
I got another splash potion of fire resistance.
Oh, that's good though.
I got a pearl.
I got another obsidian.
I got another one.
One more!
I don't have gold.
I don't have any more gold.
Come to my cave.
It's bad, but I started it.
So you can find it.
I don't trust myself.
What if I dig into lava?
Then you block it.
Then you block the lava.
Oh my god.
How many lavas did you block?
Wait, we need 10?
I thought we needed 8.
I guess it wasn't 8.
Oh, nevermind.
We need 10.
We need 3 more.
It's 3 on each side.
2 on top.
Oh.
I found quartz.
Look at that.
Look at that silly quartz over there.
What's 10 without the corners?
Oh, I thought it was 10 with the corners.
There's silly quartz over there.
Look at that.
It's so silly.
So silly.
Silly little quartz.
Oh, there's another ghast.
Somewhere.
What?
What happened?
Lava?
Just stay far enough back.
Are you sure there's going to be gold here?
Are you sure?
I don't know.
I'm saying you can just use my hole.
It's a used hole.
I'm sorry.
Do you want to go build your own?
Go get your own new hole.
I don't know.
I said that because I used it.
And I didn't find anything in there.
Then probably you would do it.
You would find it.
That's how that works, right?
I'm going to go up.
There must be...
I wish the ghast would disappear.
Please leave.
You're not welcome here.
You're kind of unwelcome.
Nobody likes you.
Even your mother hates you.
Yeah, nobody likes you.
Your mother put you up for adoption.
Nobody adopted you.
You were thinking the same thing.
I don't think I was thinking that extreme, that far.
Don't lie.
It was in your head.
I don't know.
The ghasts...
How do they...
How do they board?
Stay back, mister.
Are you okay?
What are you doing?
I'm getting gold.
But I'm doing the most risky shit to get this fucking gold right now.
Do you want TNT?
No!
That's risky shit, man.
I can give you the good risky stuff.
The TNT.
It's the real risky stuff.
Blow it all up.
Blow it to hell, Donkey!
Open air gold.
You gotta go to TNT Anonymous.
I got more magma...
Magma cream...
Will help us make more fire resistant stuff, I guess.
Okay.
You know, man.
I feel like we're gonna make it to the end and then we're gonna die.
Don't say that.
I've been thinking it this entire time.
Don't!
I've been literally thinking it this entire time.
I think we're gonna make it and then we're gonna die.
The Ender Dragon is not that bad.
All we need is the slow falling.
What if we get there...
We do this thing and then the Ender Dragon...
He sweeps up and then knocks us out of the thing.
And then it happens.
All we need is the slow falling.
How do we make it?
How do we make what?
Slow falling.
Oh, we need the phantoms.
We need to not sleep.
Okay, that's fine.
That should be fine, right?
That should be fine.
We can do that.
We can chill in a village.
When we don't sleep.
We just don't sleep.
What?
It's a good thing.
What is it?
I found netherite.
Oh, just one?
You know we need a lot more.
Yeah, but I found some.
Even at 78.
Oh, I found two netherites.
Okay, now that's the good shit.
I almost looked at it.
There's a ghast here.
Why is there a ghast here?
I have to use the arrow.
I'm scared.
Where did he go?
No lava.
I know, I need no lava.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe there was two.
Wow.
Okay, gold.
Can I pick it up?
Okay, I have six now.
I have six gold.
Alright.
All in.
I know the lava won't burn it, but I don't wanna die.
Okay.
Wowee.
Hordes?
Please, out of these six.
Just give me obsidian.
Please, not magma!
I gave you six gold!
Okay.
I got crying obsidian.
Crying?
That's literally you.
You gave me crying out of all the obsidians.
I'm so sorry.
I wasn't specific enough regarding the exact type of obsidian I needed.
How much...
How much diamond do you have?
I have eleven.
Okay.
My pickaxe is about to...
Actually, I'll just make a...
I'll just make an iron one.
Alright.
Back into the mines we go.
Back into the...
I'm mining too.
Oh, you got some gold?
No.
I haven't gotten literally anything.
Except the net.
I got the netherite.
That's literally the only thing we actually need.
There's gold, I know.
Oh, and I made it to the other side.
I wish I kept all that obsidian.
I wish I kept all that obsidian earlier.
There's so many...
So many endermen around me.
I wish you were here to exterminate them.
I don't trust myself making a little house.
Okay, I'm coming.
I'm coming.
It's just a little house.
I don't trust myself.
There's like four endermen right next to me.
I hear a ghastly though.
Alright, come to me.
Come to me and make a house.
Oh my god, you're still alive?
Yes, we've been in the nether.
Yes, yes.
We've been in the nether.
We have been in the nether for like maybe four hours.
Where are you?
Look up.
Hold on, I'm getting endermen.
Oh.
Come here.
Come here, Endy.
Endy.
One more.
One more again.
One more, one more.
Yeah.
I'm this guy too.
Where are you?
Um, you know, just...
Just here with all these endermens.
I'm with endermen too!
All of them right here.
You know, just hanging out, I guess.
You know, just...
I see gold, but it's kind of like...
No, they're very risky gold.
They are definitely very risky gold.
I've been enjoying some risky gold lately.
I've been risking it all.
The thrill of the hunt.
Are you feeling the thrill?
I feel it.
I'm feeling it, Mr. Krabs.
I'm fucking feeling it right now.
Oh my gosh, nothing.
I left for four hours.
What happened?
Oh, that's a good one.
That's a good one.
Oh, that's good.
That's rich.
That's real rich.
Where are you?
I'm fucking feeling really...
Really risky right now.
Just really risky.
Don't, don't, please.
Whoa.
It'd be so silly if something just...
Something happened.
No!
Oh my god, gas.
No, please.
I'm coming back.
I have more gold.
I got a stack.
Let's go.
Oh, I almost fell into this.
That would've been...
Pretty dramatic.
Okay.
Pretty bad, I'd say.
I have seven.
I have seven more.
Seven more stacks, let's go.
Seven more.
I thought I saw some gold over here.
I was just gonna...
Oh, there you go.
Oh, I see some up here.
Okay, I'll get that.
Alright, here we go.
Back in the... Oh, this might be risky, but...
We'll see.
There he is.
How many inner pearls do you have?
Three.
Yeah, that's three, so we have six.
Oh, here's the arrows.
I'm getting more gold.
What'd he give you?
Is that it?
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Is that it?
Oh, I got another one.
I got another one.
We got another one.
We need two more.
Yes, we need two more.
Two more.
Did I grab that?
Wait, where did it go?
Where did the... Where did it go?
No!
Where did it go?
We'll never know.
Thank you for the arrow, sir.
Alright, last one.
Last one.
Okay.
I like when people come in and are just like, how have they been up to this for eight hours?
It's gravel.
It's like... It's fucking gravel.
Here I have... I have fourteen pieces of nuggets.
Fourteen... Only fourteen nuggets?
I'm sorry!
It was all that I could get!
Only fourteen nuggets?
Okay.
That nugget could be life or death.
Alright, here's... Where are you?
Here you go.
Here's... Here's the obsidian next to you.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
He won't attack you.
He's aggroed on me.
Okay.
Where is it?
Did you give it to me?
No, no.
I took it back.
I'll give it to you later.
Oh, I got it.
Okay, come here.
I'll take it.
Alright, here you go.
Here you go.
Here's two more.
Two more!
We just need two!
Two out of two?
Crying obsidian.
At least he gave us two.
Quartz.
Hey, he gave us two though!
He gave us two!
There's a lot above us.
I'm fucking doing it.
It's life or death.
It's above us.
I'm fucking... I'm going for it.
I'm gonna go for it.
I'm gonna go above.
I'm going up.
I'm gonna go up and see the world!
Mom!
I'm gonna do it!
Okay, when you do it, build like a little bridge underneath it and don't walk underneath it, you know?
I'm gonna see the world!
Where is this?
Catch them all!
They're in the trees.
I got one of them.
There's more over there.
Okay, there's more over here too.
I'm gonna grab it.
Wait, I can't grab it.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, get rid of that.
Okay, there we go.
I grabbed some.
I don't know where the other ones are.
Okay, I got some here too.
How many you got?
Nine?
Okay, I got 21.
Okay, there's more over here.
I'm gonna fucking...
They're just like, yeah, take her tower.
No!
Do you know how much we've been through?
We've been through so much.
We are past sabotage!
We're past it.
We are so past it.
We can't...
You're like, haha, wouldn't it be funny?
I know you've been streaming for eight hours, but wouldn't you just kill her right now?
Don't worry, we'll just do it.
We don't have to kill each other.
The dragon's gonna do it for us!
No, it's not!
We'll just do the bed strut.
Catch it, catch it, catch it!
Catch what?
I don't even know where you are!
Okay, hold on, I see you.
I caught it, I caught it, I caught it, I caught it.
Oh, I see you.
Grab that one.
You got it.
Oh, no, you didn't get it.
There you go, you got it.
Okay, I have 37 here.
Alright.
I have nine.
Okay, pass it along, pass it along.
I'm getting mad.
I've got another seven rolls.
Another seven...
I think we could've traveled back!
I think...
No, we definitely could not have.
We could've died.
No, you're right, we could've died.
Yeah, we definitely could not have.
No, you're right, you're right.
We definitely would've died trying to travel back.
Where's the Enderman?
Enderman!
Please, my sweet Enderman.
Oh my god, I don't want the child to rob me again.
I know, I know.
Don't Akasupa with that.
What did he... Trying to bait me.
Oh, to kill me?
No!
You're trying to make me say something!
I know what you're trying to make me say.
I don't want your stupid iron nugget, please.
Oh my god, please.
Why do you keep giving me cries?!
He keeps giving me cries!
He's an idiot!
He's an idiot, oh my god.
I wish you could like, decry the Enderman.
He keeps giving me crying, I'm serious.
He keeps doing it!
He does!
I'm gonna fucking... I'm gonna shoot you!
I'm done, I'm missing!
I missed every shot.
I can't even...
I can't hit him!
I can't hit him anymore.
You did it!
I did the thing I can't fly again.
You did the thing!
You did it!
I did it.
There's an Enderman right behind you too.
Oh, I see him.
Thank you.
Come here, agros.
Come here.
Alright, time to go.
Drop your pearls, poop them out.
Poop out your pearls.
Time to look up again.
Oh, I got five!
I got five pearls!
Oh, hi.
Oh my god.
I believe in us.
I can't believe I wanted to start later.
That's what I said earlier!
I can't believe it.
I didn't know.
I was like, are you... I thought... I literally while you were gone, I was like...
I really thought when she proposed this that she wanted to start in the morning and like go all day.
But no, you were like...
Let's just do it.
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
I might be dead.
Oh shit, shit.
No.
No, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I'm coming down here.
Where is he?
Hold on.
No, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I dropped down.
Are you okay?
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Okay.
Back.
Back to hunting.
What the fuck?
Uh-oh, I'm not okay.
I'm not okay.
No, no, no, no.
I'm really not okay.
I'm not okay.
Climb up.
Can you climb up?
I got him.
I'm gonna die.
Just heal!
Calm down!
Heal!
Calm down and heal!
I'm calm!
That's why he attacked me.
I was like, why did I...
You don't have your helmet!
You got...
I know!
It broke because of the Enderman!
Oh my god...
Oh my god!
What was your heart?
What were your hearts?
I was at one and a half, I think.
Oh!
Yes!
I thought I was gonna die for real!
Oh my god!
What happened to your house?
I went underneath and then I got shoved out by the pig because...
Because I wasn't wearing the gold!
Oh my god...
I'm healing you guys!
I'm healing!
That was like some PTSD right there.
I would've all been over.
All that gold I found...
It would've all been over.
Oh my god!
There's no more gold.
There's no more gold in the wall, in the ceiling.
Okay, come here, Enderman.
Oh my god!
What?
There's seven Endermans right here.
In the corner.
Wait, I think this is a good farm spot.
Get over here.
Okay, hold on.
I'm getting this guy.
There's seven Endermans...
right in the corner.
They hit so hard.
Oh, he gave me soup.
Thanks for the soup.
Oh my god, I looked at them once.
Where are you?
Okay, I'll show you.
You gotta make a house.
Yeah, I'll make the house.
Just show me where.
Okay, come with me.
I'm coming.
I'm right behind you.
Okay, this is a little dangerous.
No, no, don't go here.
We go up with rocks.
Okay, okay.
How?
Here.
I made...
I made the wrong area.
Oh, just kidding.
Here we go.
It's in this corner.
It's very scary.
Just a warning.
It's a very scary corner.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm looking down.
You're gonna see it.
It's right in this corner.
It's right over there in that corner to our left.
You're gonna see seven Endermans.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I see them.
What the hell?
Okay, I'm going over.
I don't know what they're doing over there, but there's a party.
I hear them.
What the hell is happening?
Goodbye, my diamond pickaxe.
Mine is almost dead too.
Wait, where are they?
Oh my god.
You scared me, Enderman.
Make sure you make your thing.
I'm trying to make my house.
I think we have to leave here.
There's no way to farm anymore gold.
Oh my god.
I just found the last remaining gold block.
The final gold block that lives here.
The final gold block.
I'm gonna risk it.
No, I shouldn't.
This is way too risky even for me.
Oh,
I got seven Enderpearls now.
From all that?
From all of those?
Oh, I only got one.
Okay.
I was gonna say there was a lot of guys in that corner.
I hear the guys, but I can't get to them.
Safely, at least.
And there's a ghast.
Of course there is.
Oh, goodbye.
Okay, I have 18.
Goodbye.
Oh, I hear another ghast to my left.
Yeah, he's there.
We gotta leave this area.
There's this area.
No, ghast.
Was that you?
No, my crafting table.
This guy sucks.
This guy sucks so much.
And then he got my table.
He destroyed it.
Move to the left.
To the right.
Yeah,
I see you.
I'm going down.
What do we do?
I think we leave this cursed land.
We leave this cursed land.
I can hear all of them, I just can't see any of them.
For some reason.
Oh my gosh, there's another ghast.
How many?
Oh, there he is.
Why are they loud?
Oh my god, you're killing them.
There you go.
One of them is dead.
Are you getting arrows or are you getting...
Yeah, I mean...
I've been getting a lot.
Everything but obsidian.
Hey, whatever, that was work, I guess.
We need them for the fight, so...
Oh, thank you for the boots.
We have to leave.
We leave.
Oh, okay.
Alright, I think I can...
Thanks for the iron boots and the iron ingots, I guess.
I...
Okay.
I got it, guy.
I baited a guy.
Alright, time to make my other crafting table.
Come on, guy.
Where did he go?
Oh, what did I want to make again?
Oh my god, diamond pickaxe.
Come back.
Come back, please.
Oh my god, it's almost 2AM!
No way.
We can do this.
I believe in us.
Oh, there's another one?
The other angry?
What do I not need?
You want my stuff, little boy?
You want my little water bottle?
You want that, little boy?
Here, take it.
Take it.
Oh, why are you still here?
Why are you still...
We gotta leave.
Oh, here we go.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh, this is like an ender farm.
This is like an ender farm!
Oh my god, this is kind of awesome.
Yeah, I found a little hole.
I just hit them all at once.
Okay, I only got two pearls from that, but you know, great.
That's good.
Alright, let's leave.
Oh, hold on.
Come here.
There's three more over there.
Did I just hear you?
Yes.
Oh, hi.
Where do you wanna go?
I don't know.
You pick.
I don't know, I've been here so long.
I've been trading for gold non-stop.
Like, I don't know anymore.
I don't know anymore.
Okay, I have another concern because we're gonna run out of food.
No, I have a lot of hay.
You do?
Yeah, I have 20 more.
That's a lot.
Like hay bales?
Yeah.
I have 20 more.
I have 20 more hay bales!
Let's go!
I have melons?
Oh, I have 64 melons.
Okay, we're good.
I have a full stack of melons.
I didn't even notice them.
Let's go.
Do we wanna just go this way?
Alright, let's go.
We gotta get some gold somewhere.
Maybe we'll get more here.
Who knows?
Somewhere out there...
Beneath the...
What is that song?
It's from An American Tale.
The one about the mouse.
The one with the naked lady in the window, right?
There are no cats in America.
I don't know why I like...
That would suck if there was no cats in America.
I was really upset about that actually.
It's a terrible song.
I hate these cats.
Or these mice.
You know what?
They can get eaten by the cats.
All for all I care.
The mice are supposed to represent the American dream.
They're talking about no cats.
The cats are eating the mice.
The cats are the more important part.
Cats are cuter than mice.
Woah.
That's some cat propaganda right there.
Sorry.
Why are you not like just mining the straight line?
Oh, the naked lady is in the...
Oh no, the naked lady is on the...
Is in the Disney movie.
Yeah, the one frame where they're naked.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, just go on a straight line?
Okay, okay.
Why are you doing the netherite mining?
Yeah, that's the netherite mine.
Is it really?
Yeah, the way you were mining, that's how you mine for netherite.
Well, that's how I got to netherite, baby.
Yeah, and not the gold.
I've tried for the gold.
But I also was just trying to...
Bye, this is where my...
Are you mining?
Oh my...
I thought that was mine that was breaking.
No, mine broke.
I've just been making iron ones.
Because I don't want to use my diamond.
But now I have to.
It's too late.
You have to.
But it's precious.
It's precious material.
I had another one.
Was that...
That has to be an ender, right?
What?
The enderman?
No, I think that was just cave ambiance.
How deep is this hole?
How deep is this hole and how is there no gold?
See, that's what I'm saying.
How is there no gold?
I don't know.
Do you need iron?
I have iron.
Oh, you do?
I shouldn't have just one iron.
Here, take it all.
Take all the iron.
Yeah, I kept the iron instead of the enderpearl.
I'm just going to mine a straight line.
I'm not doing two anymore.
We're just going to go in a straight line.
I'll do the other side.
I got to the...
Oh, I see more.
I see more gold.
There's more gold.
More gold for you.
I see the gold.
She sees the gold.
Every gold is a gold.
The gold is the gold.
Maybe we should just slowly head back to our...
original spawn while we're trying to find gold.
It's like, who...
What are we going to get first?
Our original spawn point?
Or...
The gold?
At this rate, we would've been back.
We would've made it back.
I think we would've actually been back.
I honestly think...
I think we would've made it back.
Well, we're going the opposite direction.
Alright, which direction is the gold?
The gold.
Not gold, sorry.
Oh, no.
Lead the way.
Let's just slowly head back.
Let's see what we get first.
We need to literally go the opposite way...
that we just came from.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go.
Yippee!
Let's go!
I'm going to follow you.
You aggroed a guy?
Or I did.
I don't think so.
Did I aggro?
No, you did because I wasn't looking at anything.
Oh, I was on...
Looking at the coordinates.
My bad.
I was literally placing blocks.
Come on.
Are we not heading back?
I'm worried I'm going to fall.
Okay, I'm going to dig while you do that.
And look for gold.
Alright, which way?
Which way is the original way?
This way!
Our smile and optimism gone.
We have to also...
Hold on.
It's more like this way.
Negative Z.
We gotta go facing north.
So we gotta go like this way.
This way?
Like a diagonal.
So that's why the diagonal dig is good.
Do the diagonal dig.
What if I hit lava?
Then stand far away when you do the diagonal dig.
I wonder if I'm stupid.
Do you want me to dig?
No.
Actually, no, yeah.
Okay.
I'm gonna be slower though.
I don't have a diamond pick.
I'm gonna...It's just like 1% slower.
It's just 1%.
I'm just gonna sit here for a little bit.
Okay.
I'll just...
I'll just dig.
I'll just be the supervisor.
I'll be the...
I'll be the supervisor.
How am I doing, sir?
It's alright.
I mean, it could be better.
You know, you could put better form.
Your back could be more straight.
What's gonna happen?
Nothing's gonna spawn.
No, but I can't see.
You can't see?
I can't...
You don't have the right resource pack.
I have the shaders on.
Oh my god.
You got this.
Why are you tired?
It's 2 AM for me.
This is literally so past my bedtime.
I told you it took them 20 days.
And then we had one day.
We...
Get your gamer subs out.
I got my gamer subs out.
I had the gamer subs earlier.
By the way, guys.
You use our code...
Code DokiBird.
You can get 10% off.
My code will get you more percentage off.
I can't see.
What?
Okay, you need a torch.
I couldn't see.
Why is there no gold in here?
I think we're not in the right...
Alright, get out.
It's my turn.
Hold on, I'll make a new one and then I'll take over.
Oh, off-handed?
Oh, true.
It's off-handed, that's what I've been doing.
Well, other than the shield part.
Yeah.
Are we heading the right way?
Have you checked at all?
Yeah, we're heading the right way.
Okay, thank God.
I just have to be sure.
We just need to get over a thousand...
Z and...
2,000 X.
Okay, we're at the edge.
We're also searching for gold so that we can...
Oh my God.
What's happening?
Don't take down.
Don't...
Wait, is there lava?
Boat time.
Oh yeah, actually we could...
I heard a gas though.
Boat time!
She doesn't care anymore.
Let's go!
Yay!
Thank God.
I got my...
Boat time, it really feels like the next time we will miss.
Goodbye boat!
Why does the Enderman scream?
Hold on.
Oh my God, wait.
Did you aggro?
I didn't aggro anybody.
I think it's the guy from before.
Did you aggro?
Did you do it?
No, I think it's the guy who followed us.
Did you aggro?
I did, but earlier.
He followed me all the way here.
I think it'll be fine.
Just come down here.
No, he's gonna get me.
He's not gonna get you.
You're being paranoid.
I hear him right there!
You're getting paranoid.
I'm gonna dig for gold while he's...
Until he comes to see me.
You're getting paranoid.
How am I paranoid?
I almost died to Enderman earlier.
You're getting paranoid.
You're hearing the voices again.
What are you talking about?
He's right there!
He's not angry.
Which one?
I hear him screaming.
Oh my God.
Where are you?
I'm up here.
I hid as soon as I heard him screaming at me.
There's nobody screaming.
There's no one screaming.
You guys, you hear it.
He's underneath me.
Nobody is screaming.
I'm literally...
No one is getting you.
But you're paranoid.
Oh, I see.
Never mind.
I see him now.
He was literally right...
Right...
He is vibrating.
I know!
I hear him!
What did you do to him?
Don't stop!
Stop!
You're wasting your arrows!
He'll dodge.
I know, I wanted him to TP.
Oh, you wanted him to TP.
Hey, buddy!
Why don't you kill him?
You're right there.
I'm trying to make the house!
Oh, okay.
Just right above your head.
Okay.
There's three Endermans right here.
There's...
We'll just kill the one that's aggro on me.
There's so many!
There's four!
Okay, but you're in the house.
You're safe.
I don't know if I made it correctly.
Come down here.
I see him.
I got him.
He's dead.
Okay.
I don't hear him screaming at me anymore.
Alright, I'm coming down.
Alright, we can kill all these other Endermans in this house I made.
Yeah, come here.
Oh my God.
Nice house, I think.
He like brought the whole crew.
What was I supposed to do?
Okay, I killed one.
There's another one right here.
I'm literally looking at...
Get under the house!
I am!
Further, further!
What's he gonna do?
Hit me?
Alright, there's the other one.
Okay, that should be...
Right here!
I'm looking at the other one!
There he is!
He's coming, he's coming!
Where is he going?
Oh, there he is.
I told you he brought the whole crew!
I'm getting him!
Oh, there's the boat.
I saw the boat in the tree.
Yeah, I know.
I said there's the boat.
Oh, is he gonna come back?
I don't know, but I got the boat.
Hello, Enderman!
Hello, where did he go?
Oh.
He disappeared.
Oh my God.
Okay, that works too, I guess.
That works too.
I told you to get under the house.
I am trying!
I'm trying my best.
High five, high five Enderpearls.
My shield, I'll be okay.
Alright, let's...
Alright, tell me how to...
Where do we go?
How do we get to the other side?
Is it to the forest?
Just keep heading north.
Yeah, we gotta go into those woods.
Back to the woods we go.
Into the thick of it.
There was one guy I still hadn't killed though.
It's fine, it's fine.
Maybe he'll... He's not gonna get revenge on us, right?
Where are my mushrooms?
I don't have any mushrooms, by the way.
I have mushrooms, I have mushrooms.
I have zero mushrooms.
Wait, we're literally in mushroom territory.
Collect some, collect some.
I know, I know, I know.
I need to find some.
Turn around, over here.
Yeah, yeah, over here.
In here.
I found it, I found it, I found it.
But not the red ones.
You gotta get the blue ones.
I know, I need to figure out what to throw away.
Into the thick of it.
Here, I'll collect some and then I can give you like half or something.
No, it's fine, I got two.
I got five, I got five.
I got enough.
Alright, let's go.
I have... 15.
Alright, that's... I think that's way too much, but that's okay.
What?!
Oh, now I'm being...
Now I'm being punished for being over prepared.
Alright, do we just go straight?
Is that it?
Wait, where did you go?
Oh, there you are.
I'm in the forest.
Oh, I see you.
How did you get... Oh, you went that way.
That's right.
You're waiting.
Into the thick of it.
I wish we could've obtained that strider.
Oh, I should've got a saddle.
And then we could've just walked through the lava.
We could've just walked through the lava until we got to our place.
We could've...
But then the ghast would see us in the middle and blow us up.
Is it just straight?
It's more like...
Hold on, I have to check when I move.
Wait.
Huh?
There's like four of them right below me.
Wait, but X is going up.
Okay, no, it is straight.
Okay, I was gonna...
Yeah, let's just go straight.
Okay.
Just follow my one side bridge.
My one block bridge.
My one block bridge right here.
Into the thick of it.
Any gold around us?
No.
Nothing in the ceilings either.
What the hell?
Stingy.
Oh, there's some gold.
Where?
Get it.
Below you.
Okay, I'll get it.
Looking above me right now.
Alright, we go straight, right?
Yeah, but hold on.
Alright, I'm digging forward.
Hold on!
I'll put torches next to the hole.
Okay.
Oh no, uh oh.
Don't be mad, I'm sorry.
Do you have gold on you?
Oh shit, he's mad at me.
Place blocks in front of it.
Get over here and place a block in front of it.
Okay, or place blocks in front of him.
I mean, that works too.
He's still trying to get me, but...
Get over here, get over here a minute.
Close the door!
Okay, straight, right?
I'm just gonna go straight for now.
For now is fine.
We're gonna have to...
What do we have to do?
Change direction.
Well, no, I think it's...
Wait, no.
I don't know, it's so hard.
I hate this, I hate navigating!
But we are going in the correct Z.
We just have to also...
But what about the X?
The X is like the biggest one.
Oh my god!
And to the sake of it, we go.
This is why we...
Should have just...
Got straighted.
We got... I think I did a hundred gold pieces.
I think I've done a hundred, man.
Yeah, but we only need a two more!
I've done a hundred, man.
We've only need a two more!
I've done a hundred!
We only need a two more!
I've done a hundred rolls!
What was this about?
Gamblers, give up!
We're doing it while we explore!
I almost just got killed for trying to...
Okay, so that's why when people are like...
Oh, just go one way and then go another way...
It doesn't really work in the nether.
Because the nether is really special.
And just makes you have to reroute everything.
I think we... Hold on.
Look at all those striders over there.
Look at all those striders just chilling in the fire.
We need to go this way.
Which way?
This way.
Okay, here we go.
Let's hope there's no ghastlies here.
I'm holding down my shift.
Let's hope my shift key doesn't accidentally broke at the end.
That would be very...
That would be crazy.
I'm drinking this.
You have another potion!
I don't trust...
I can do this for three minutes.
I can do this.
I'll just chill...
Until we get to the other side.
You are the one that has the most...
I can do this for three minutes.
Are we...
Are we going the right way?
Just to be sure.
I need to know.
Positive X.
Mr. X, let me give it to you.
Is that a guy riding a strider down there?
We should kick him off.
Wait, you could do that.
You could drop him.
I'm not gonna drop down!
You have the potion!
We have other priorities right now!
You could do it!
You could steal that strider from him.
We have other priorities here.
We don't even have a saddle!
We don't even have a saddle.
We don't have a saddle.
That's why I'm saying you take the one from the guy riding it.
Where?
He doesn't have a saddle.
He doesn't even have a saddle.
He's just on top of it.
He's just chilling.
He doesn't even have a saddle.
No, I have more.
I have more.
My hand is cramping.
From pressing down the key.
We made it.
Oh my god, we actually made it.
We actually made it.
Watch out.
You have your mushrooms.
No, I have them.
Back!
Back, beast!
Which way do we go?
When I put one down...
When we get a little ways away...
Grab the old one, you know?
Back, beast!
Oh, now they're starting to attack him.
Nice.
Watch out here.
Oh my god, watch out right here.
Oh my god, wait.
This is not the way.
Don't follow me.
I'm scared they're gonna fucking hit us after that.
I know.
In fact, I'm just gonna kill this guy.
Nice.
Yeah, put that hog in the corner.
Easy.
And I'm gonna take his leather.
Nice.
Alright, which way is it?
Uh...
Why did you go ahead of me?
I don't know.
I just wanted to look in the open.
I just wanted...
I'm checking the coordinates.
Okay, we're just straight ahead.
Okay, just straight ahead.
Into the thick of it.
There's one here.
Yeah.
Back, beast.
Back.
Yeah, back.
Stay back.
Stay back, beast.
Be gone.
Be gone, you vile creatures.
Oh, there's another one.
Oh my gosh.
Where's the gold?
You wanna trade with these guys while we're here?
I don't have...
I have eight.
Oh.
Eight nuggies or eight pieces?
Eight nuggies.
Oh, okay.
We got five more gold, but there's no gold here.
We just head straight?
Yeah, just keep going straight.
Alright.
Wait, there's gold right there!
There's gold right there.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let's check the area first.
Is it safe?
I don't see any guys.
Alright.
I believe you.
I can't see over your area though, so...
Okay, nice.
Nice, nice.
Okay.
Why can't I build a thing here?
I'm trying to protect you.
A little house or something.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Nice, that was a good amount.
That was...
34.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
Remember, we're trying to get to...
negative 505...
and 195.
We just keep going straight this way.
This way?
Where are we at?
Oh.
Don't look.
That's why I said maybe we should...
I looked.
I...
Yeah.
We ran out of gold.
There were no more gold to farm.
We farmed...
We, like, demolished the area.
We've taken all the natural resources around us.
Like, it's over.
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Do you want to get this guy?
Hit him up.
He might have some good stuff.
I'm making the gold now.
Yeah, he might have some good stuff.
Come on, guy.
We can just get out of here.
Like, we can just leave.
Alright, let's see if we can get the...
Oh my God, why did he drop that?
Why is he running away from me?
He gave me quartz.
Okay, that's just one.
He gave me crying obsidian.
Hey, he gave me three crying obsidian.
He gave me three crying obsidian.
And then I got leather.
Okay, but you can give the leather to me.
That's all you got?
That's all I got.
Crying obsidian and quartz.
Okay, let's keep going this way then.
We're digging through.
We're gonna try for gold.
We're gonna try and get gold.
We're gonna get gold.
We're gonna get gold in these mines.
We're gonna strike it rich.
Doki bird, you and me, we're gonna strike it rich.
Wait, why are you guys backing?
We've never left.
We've never left the net there.
There's no why are we backing.
We just stay there.
Oh, there's some gold in here.
Oh.
Hold on, let's build a bridge over there.
Alright.
Oh,
my bad.
Whoops.
I don't want to hit you accidentally so you can get that off.
Oh my god.
Okay, stop placing blocks.
This is my job.
I'm the architect here, okay?
This is my work.
Okay.
God damn it.
I don't know.
You can get it.
I don't even care.
There's two.
There's another area right here.
Okay, okay.
I'm just trying to be efficient.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, I see.
I get it.
Yeah, you see?
There's one right here.
Uh-huh.
Look, see?
This is efficiency right here.
German efficiency.
I can't even grab it.
So you're gonna have to take the block.
See?
German efficiency.
Right there, right there.
So which way do we go now?
We keep going straight.
Straight?
Alright.
Let's keep going.
Oh, oh, another area.
There's so much quartz in here!
Why is there so much quartz?
The land of the quartz.
What can I say?
Oh, look, there's gold.
It's so far up.
There it is.
Is that cool?
The tiny two pieces of gold.
The two pieces of gold.
Wow!
Further onward.
Off we go.
Further onward, onward, onward.
Everybody.
Onward we go.
I think this is the worst sea we decided to stay on.
Oh, gold!
Oh my God, there's so much gold here.
Oh my God, thank God.
Oh, thank God.
Do you want me to grab it?
No, I can grab it.
Just be careful.
Oh, there's more over here too.
Oh, there's more!
I'll dig a tunnel over here to the gold.
Okay, we just gotta find some piglins now.
Come on, piglins.
Show thyself, piglin.
Come on.
It would be so cool if you guys just show up.
He's so funny.
It would be so funny.
Do you guys want to do something really funny right now?
But like, don't show up right now.
Because that would be like, kind of rude.
But it would be so funny though.
Oh, oopsie.
Ouch.
Got more gold.
There's more gold over here.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, it's...
Where are these little piggies?
This little piggy went...
Went, went, went all the way home.
All the way home.
Okay, I got seven.
How many did you get?
Grab these, grab these.
Oh, you didn't have inventory space, right?
No, I don't.
Okay, I think that is...
We got ten.
We have ten.
We just need to find...
We just gotta find them.
What are we at?
86...
We have to get a little lower actually.
We'll get lower eventually.
We'll get there.
We'll get there eventually.
We have a boat.
Oh, can I have my crafting table?
I have space.
I mean, just give two to me.
I have the space for it anyway.
Okay, okay.
Alright, I'm just gonna make a bridge over here.
Do you think we'll do this tonight?
Yes, Mint.
We're not clickbaiters, Mint.
No, but I mean if we have to fall asleep and then wake back up.
Mint, we're not clickbaiters, Mint.
We're not.
The stream doesn't end, Mint.
This is why we had that one day, Mint.
This is why.
Yeah, but they got to go...
The people who took 20 days got to go to sleep.
Do we not get to sleep?
They played for like two days...
Two to three days straight without sleeping.
And then they're like...
We gotta sleep.
It took longer than they expected.
If this is gonna take us more than a day...
Then like...
Maybe we do sleep.
But for now, we're in too deep.
We're in too deep, Mint.
We're in too deep.
Why did I agree to let you...
Let me do this?
I'm literally leaving town in like two days.
Why did I let you do this?
I don't know.
You said...
We were like...
We'll have that one day be like a free day.
But you wanted to start at five!
We started at two.
Oh, it was five for you.
Yeah!
You could've started earlier.
You could've asked for an earlier time.
I did!
You wanted to initially start at nine!
And then I was like...
Oh yeah, okay, let's just do two.
You could've started earlier.
You could've asked for an earlier time.
I'm gonna kill you.
You better go to those pigs.
And you better get that obsidian right now.
You think I didn't know?
I did 200 rolls.
I did 200 rolls, Mint.
I did 200 fucking rolls!
You better go to luck!
I'm gonna take a week off of streaming...
and everybody will blame you.
Next week we are gonna be gone.
Oh yeah, that's true.
I am actually gonna be gone.
It's practically a week.
And I blame you!
They'll have you to blame!
Watch out!
Put the rock!
I wasn't... I couldn't...
Oh shit.
I was trying to get there.
There we go.
Okay, hold on.
I'm blocking it up.
I'm watching you do it.
I did it, I did it.
I blocked it up.
We're safe, we're good.
Everything's fine.
Hold on, I'm gonna move my thing over though.
Alright, here's the torch.
Doki hates us.
What do you mean?
More like you hate the wisps!
You wanted to stop!
I was reading my chat!
Someone sent me a super chat and you expect me not to read it out loud?
That's so rude!
Thank you for the super chat!
The super chat said Doki hates us!
So now we're allowed to read the super chats out loud!
You've always been allowed!
You're not allowed what you think I just said!
Oh wait, let me check on her.
Hold on, okay.
We are going down...
Very too slowly in the Z.
But we are making it...
In the X.
Okay, and the X is where we're...
We're the furthest away.
Yeah, kinda.
Oh, I need you to put down the...
Oh yeah, I forgot.
That's why I'm...
Alright, you take that then.
You take that.
No, you're right.
I just wanted to...
I wanted to free your inventory space.
I have too much cool stuff.
You don't understand.
Oh, I don't understand.
Alright.
Alright, let me dig.
Alright, your turn.
Alright.
Yeah, I've been doing all the work.
Oh, go back!
Get out!
It's my turn.
No, no, no!
I've been doing all the work!
You're someone too afraid of the world!
Someone is just like...
What if I'm stupid tonight?
No, no, no!
I'm gonna be...
Oh, that's true.
My chat was like, she is called Maid Mint.
She is called...
Be a maid right now and fucking do your work.
Alright.
Thank you for the super chat!
Alright,
turn around.
Why are you digging it?
Because...
Alright, your turn.
Oh, typical maid.
Oh no, I was reading a super chat that someone sent me.
Oh yeah, what was it?
What was it, huh?
It was actually them asking something, but I don't wanna answer it now!
Oh, you don't worry.
I'm getting the boat.
I'm fucking getting the boat.
I'm getting the boat right now.
Yeah, you wanna jump?
No, we can just keep...
Let me make a bridge.
We keep going.
We keep going through the walls.
It's the safest.
What, you wanna experience more gassed activity?
I'm just thinking like...
Oh, why don't we bump into one of those pigs?
What about a pig?
It's fine.
Oh, you wanna see a pig.
No, I meant the piglings.
Oh, okay.
Hold on.
No, we don't need to see the piglings.
Let's keep going forward.
Oh, look!
There's a pigling right in front of us!
Build a bridge!
There's a pigling literally right in front of us.
On the other side.
The one that the hoglin?
The one that will try to murder us?
I don't know!
The fucking good ones!
I don't see a good one.
I'm getting the block right now.
Okay, you do it.
Do you guys see a good one?
Look to your left.
What's that?
Oh, now you see it.
I couldn't see him.
He was blocked by your big old head.
You were in front of me!
Oh, man.
That sucks.
Okay, it's okay.
He fell.
I saw you missed too.
Get your mushrooms ready.
I got my mushrooms.
You also have one right here.
I know.
He's over here.
Alright, ten.
We have ten.
Ten.
Alright.
I'll put a mushroom next to me just in case.
Yeah, I put one around too.
Alright, this is it.
The gacha.
This is it.
Stay away.
Stay away, ugly.
Oh my god, we got one!
Get over here!
We got one!
We got one more!
One more.
Oh my god, please.
Just one more.
Please be kind to us!
We got it!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, we got two!
We got two!
Wait, wait, wait.
Before I make these, you still have your diamond pickaxe?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I do.
Wait, what is it?
Two?
And then three?
One, two, three.
Six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
And then...
And then right here...
And then it's fire time!
Get your bed ready just in case, and a shield maybe.
I don't know.
Here we go!
Wait, how many enderpearls do you have?
What just happened?
What the fuck is subspace bubble?
Use the nether to travel seven kilometers in the overworld.
Yeah, that sounds about right.
That sounds...
By the way, I don't have my bed anymore.
What?
What happened to your bed?
It's at our old spawn.
Should we head to our old spawn?
Should we head to our old nether?
Yeah, let me get the coordinates.
Let's go.
Fine, let me get the coordinates.
Now we got it.
So literally me being like...
Prepare your bed, and you just didn't say anything.
Okay, do you want to know the damage?
Oh my god.
What's the damage?
So, look at...
Look at where we're at.
Okay.
We need to get to...
Minus 4,116.
Oh.
What's the Z?
1,000...
1,570.
Let's go traveling.
Let's find a sheep, right?
Well, we might as well...
I don't think there's... Wait, which way?
Which way do we go?
Let's um...
It's a road trip.
We gotta go to positive Z.
Negative Z.
We're not going the right way.
This way.
Alright.
Let's find the village first, so we make it home.
We'll find a village, probably.
Somewhere.
It's one or the other.
The lapis and the enderpearl.
How many ender... I have 10 enderpearls right now.
We had 10 at 5.
We have 15.
Is that enough?
Is that enough, you guys?
I don't remember.
I mean, guys, we gotta go this way anyway.
So, like, we gotta travel.
This might be a good time to get the phantom, right?
Because...
Yeah, exactly.
We could just walk around until the phantom appears.
Well, I mean, we have to not sleep for, like, three days.
Yeah, that's fine.
Okay.
Let's keep walking.
I love how we're, like, absolutely littering in this world.
It's fine.
We're never coming back to see the damages we caused environmentally.
It's true.
We're gonna defeat the ender dragon and delete Minecraft.
That is enough.
What the fuck?
Wait, hold on.
The sugarcane just killed itself.
We're not... You're not going the right way.
I'm not?
I barely...
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Hold on.
It's really confusing, because one is really...
Okay, I think we just need to go down the X.
Okay, this way?
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, I need to eat.
Let me know if you need food.
North...
Northeast is where we need to go.
Am I going the right way?
Well, I don't know.
Whoa, what is this?
It looks crazy.
Am I going the right way?
Just go around it.
What if we make a boat?
Make a boat.
Get in.
Well, I would've.
I'm drifting.
Okay, go, go, go.
Okay, give me a sec.
I need a...
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
I'm rowing.
Give me a second.
I need to get my...
Oh, village, village, village, village.
Where?
Oh, okay, nice.
Okay, what does F4 do, guys?
I accidentally pressed F4.
I don't know.
I feel like every function does stuff.
It's like half normal and half, like...
I think we should just stay...
awake in here, right?
Like, we can just camp out here, but...
Camp the night?
Camp out the night?
Don't you think the longest night cycle?
I know, but like...
We gotta stay up for several nights.
Well, we're gonna make the villagers turn into zombies.
No, they're asleep.
What if a zombie breaks open one of the doors?
Some of the villagers aren't even inside.
We're gonna cause a zombie apocalypse to these poor villagers.
Okay, then put down torches.
I don't know.
What do you want me to do?
We gotta stay awake.
That's so cruel.
I'm sorry, guys.
She doesn't care about you.
They're literally inside.
They can break doors.
That's what zombies do.
They break doors.
Zombies do not break doors.
What Minecraft are you playing?
Yes, they do.
I saw them break doors.
What?
Also, why do we care about them?
Oh, they do in hard mode.
They do.
Only in hard mode.
Aren't we in hardcore?
Yeah, but I didn't know that.
I've only played normal mode and I don't watch Minecraft YouTubers like you do.
I've seen them break doors.
Wow, I didn't know that.
I had no idea.
I learned something today.
Someone said make fences in front of the doors.
Oh my god, I don't care enough about the villagers for that.
I'm just a virtue signal.
I care about us.
Yeah, I'm just here to virtue signal.
I'll just put some nether rack.
That's fine.
I have plenty of it.
There, I make my own door.
There, they can't get in.
Stupid zombies.
Oh my god.
There's no zombies near me yet.
I put down some torches, so...
I should be okay.
There we go.
You're safe with me, sir.
Wait, there's a horse in front of me.
Yeah, there's a couple of horses here.
Yeah, if only we had a saddle.
We could steal the horse and just ride on.
No, horses suck.
No, not all horses suck.
Not all horses.
I'm gonna go take this time to get water.
Okay.
Wait, we gotta kill chickens for feathers later.
Yeah, we gotta...
Are you leaving the house?
Oh my god.
No, I'm not.
Someone said we can trade for feathers, but that's too much work.
That's too much work.
We'll kill them on our way to...
We'll find chickens.
There's gonna be so many chickens.
Wait, oh wait.
We've been awake for several nights.
So actually, maybe the phantoms will just normally spawn.
But we were trapped in the nether.
Does that count?
Does that count, you guys?
It should, right?
Does it count when we're...
Oh, it does count!
Oh, okay.
What are we doing?
Oh my god, so we need to go outside.
Okay, you go...
You go fucking...
You go outside and test it.
One of us, just one of us needs to...
No, there's none.
Oh, there's a chicken.
Oh my god, there's a zombie.
Jumbo.
God chicken.
You bust down doors.
I got a chicken.
And you also hit harder.
I don't like that.
I got a chicken.
Oh my god, I don't want to see another enderman ever again.
What the hell?
What is going on over there?
Oh, the iron golem.
I got a chicken.
Wait, there's no phantoms, you guys.
Let's just walk.
What are you afraid of?
Let's just keep walking.
We'll keep walking.
What are you afraid of?
We're losing time.
Get over here.
We have diamond armor.
We can't die.
We're decked out in diamond.
What are you scared of?
That's right, come on.
What?
You're not even going the right way.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm grabbing your bed.
You're gonna turn into a zombie and I don't care.
What are you talking about?
Where are you going?
I'm stealing this guy's bed.
Wait, are you going to sleep?
No, it's for the future when we can sleep.
Okay, for the future when we can sleep.
Where are the phantoms?
It doesn't work.
We gotta stay up even longer.
It doesn't work, you guys.
Alright, let's go.
These zombies don't hurt.
We have diamond armor.
Alright, let's go.
Which way?
The way we were going in the boat.
I got the feather.
I think, yeah, I got feather.
Oh, there's lots of chickens here.
There's so many chickens.
Get over here, chickens.
I don't even need you for your meat.
I don't even need you for your meat here.
Kill!
Kill them!
Actually, maybe I should.
We need magma cream, right?
I have three magma cream.
Okay, by the way, there's more magma cream on the area left.
Wait, where are we going?
Where did you go?
Oh, I see.
Is that the right way?
Yeah, I'm scared of the skellies.
Oh my god, we're diamond armor.
Don't nothing to be afraid of.
Just go.
There it is!
Okay, um...
Are you alive?
Yeah, I'm trying to get the phantom.
I'm just running.
I'm getting the phantom.
You're dealing with the phantom?
Yeah, I'm dealing with the phantom.
I don't have one.
Do I?
Oh, I see you fighting Norsh.
Oh my god, my demons.
Oh, my nightmares are here.
I got one of them.
Get over here.
What do I need from the phantoms?
They're membranes.
Collect their membranes.
Oh my god, there it is.
I don't need this anymore.
I got one.
Alright, let's go.
Let's keep going.
Wait, where did you go?
I went further because I was dealing with the skellies.
Oh my god.
I'm killing chickens.
Alright, I'm gonna see if I can find you.
I don't trust you.
Did you just go straight?
Yeah, I just went straight.
Alright, okay.
I gotta get my cough drops.
Oh god.
Alright.
Okay, look behind me and see if there's anybody behind me.
No, you're good.
Alright, let's go.
We keep traveling.
I do have a boat.
If I do the boat, we go that way.
Is it correct?
It should be, yeah.
Let's go on the boat.
It's boat time.
Boating time.
Alright.
I'm rowing.
Let me know if I'm going the right way.
Are you here?
No, you're not.
Okay, hold on.
Alright, what are the numbers?
Let me drive.
I'm okay now.
Hold on, I'm figuring it out.
It's almost day.
Okay.
But also not for the...
How do I get the Z to go down?
The Z is the scariest part.
I know.
Oh my god, I can only get the X to go down.
Okay, let me drive.
No, no, no.
I got it.
I had to go around this island.
Okay, we're good.
We're good, North-East.
We're going North-East.
If we're not going North-East, we're going the wrong direction, okay?
So every time, we have to be going North-East.
Okay?
Okay, alright.
Happy birthday, Mr. Kimchi.
Man, say it.
North-East, North-East.
Say happy birthday to Mr. Kimchi.
Who's Kimchi?
I don't know, he's my dragoon in my chat.
Say happy birthday.
Nice, okay.
Say his name.
Mr. Kimchi.
There you go.
Thank you for the super chat, Mr. Kimchi.
Thank you, thank you.
We're not going...
Oh gosh, okay.
This is tougher than I...
What are the numbers?
We have to walk.
What do you mean the numbers?
Okay, we just need to go down.
That's fine.
Get out of the boat.
Okay, let's go.
Okay.
Alright.
How many feathers do I have?
Oh, only eight feathers.
We'll find more, we'll find more.
We didn't fucking check for hay bales.
Oh no.
Okay.
I have...
I have 15...
15...
Okay, I have...
Wait, did you grab a bed yet or no?
Yeah, I've had my bed.
Oh.
How many membranes do you have?
I have one.
That's not enough.
Where are you going?
Come on.
This is the way.
Yes it is.
It's going down.
The numbers are both...
I'm going down too.
And I'm going up the mountain.
I'm at the...
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
I wish I had...
Where are you?
What?
What happened?
Oh my god.
Who did you tame?
The dog?
Actually, this might be really good.
Because we need someone to kill the skellies.
Yeah, exactly.
Where are you?
I lost you already.
I already lost you.
Yeah, because you're focused on dog.
Why are you going up the mountain?
It makes the Z go up.
No it doesn't.
Yes it does.
I'm literally going up the mountain.
And my Z is going down.
Where are you?
It's this way.
I'm across the mountain.
We lost each other.
I'll meet you on the...
We actually lost each other.
I'm going down the mountain.
Oh, there's water here.
We lost each other.
I'll give you my coordinates and you come to the water and then we boat.
I'm literally in the water.
Where are you?
Come to me.
What's your coordinates?
Oh, I see you.
Oh my god, we were heading the same way.
Wait, we can't take the boat.
Your dog.
He'll fall.
He'll TP.
Alright, go, go, go.
Nope, wrong way.
It's going down!
No!
The X axis is not going down!
Oh my god.
We gotta get off the boat.
We go this way.
Oh my god.
We go northeast.
Just follow me.
Northeast.
Northeast right here.
It's going down now.
No ghasts in sight.
This is a peaceful time.
It's just a peaceful day.
Yeah, we have piggies.
And dogs and sheep.
No ghasts, no lava.
I mean, sometimes maybe lava.
We just keep going down.
Look at that, there's my dog.
There he is.
A dog that is literally defying all physics and logic.
Oh my god, he's gonna start teleporting.
Our good little boy.
Be careful, there's a cave.
There's a hole here.
He's been teleporting?
We never stop.
We never stop going.
This is...
What we did to find the fortress.
We found the fortress though.
Isn't that great?
We found the fortress.
We found it.
Isn't that great?
Oh my god.
I feel like...
It's not going down.
I wish we had Elytra.
We need to go to the end for that.
Elysa's going down though.
I keep losing you, but I keep seeing your dog.
I'm just following your dog.
TP to me so I don't know what you're talking about.
How are you behind?
I'm right here.
I'm literally going...
I'm following the coordinates.
I'm following you.
Come on, make a path.
Jump.
What have I just made us jump to?
We have to do so much in this.
Oh my god.
We have to do so much.
Oh, the dog just shook off the water.
That's so cute.
That's why I've been trying to tame the dog this entire time.
Oh my god.
We need him for the night time.
I mean, we needed to farm other stuff anyway.
So it's alright.
We needed to farm the chickens.
We needed to farm the bookshelves.
We needed so many things.
It's alright.
Maybe we'll find another villager.
We found another villager.
We'll find another village somewhere.
We'll find it.
There's no way we won't find it.
Look, we're at 9k.
We're at 9k.
We're getting there.
Yeah.
But the 12k is scaring me.
Don't think about it.
It needs to be 4k.
It's not as bad as 4k.
Don't think about it.
It's negative 4k.
Yeah, negative 4k.
Don't go this way.
My coordinates almost blocked that for me.
Uh oh, you just trapped your dog.
It's fine.
He'll come.
He'll tp out.
There he is.
It'll be fine.
It'll be so fine.
We keep moving forward.
We had to find bookshelves.
We had to get chicken feathers.
We had to get so many things.
This is all part of the plan.
Yeah, this is all part of the plan, everybody.
We had to get so many other resources anyway, so we might as well make the travel.
But from here on, we did the fortress.
We did the most difficult part, probably.
Hopefully.
Maybe that's the most difficult part.
We just have to get to the...
What's the thing?
Oh my god, we should've been farming sheep.
We should've been farming sheep for the bed.
You have a bed.
For the Ender Dragon!
Hold on, I'm gonna kill this chicken.
Okay, we can farm beds when we find more villages.
I feel like it's easier to just get wool.
Because we don't have enough inventory space anyway.
I feel like it'd just be easier.
I feel like it's just farm the sheep.
Do you have inventory space for sheep, wool?
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
What can I get rid of?
I'll farm the wool.
I mean, we don't have to do the bed strat, but...
I mean...
It's the safest right now.
Wait, someone sent me something.
And people are like, she needs to read this.
Oh, YouTube Live Archive.
Yes, we know about the 12 hours.
We know, we know.
We're only at 10!
We're at 10 hours!
We're not even thinking about this!
We're fine.
It takes us literally 10 minutes to make another room.
We'll be fine.
Where did you go?
I don't know.
Wait, you're still going?
I thought you were hunting sheep.
No, I'm not.
It was in the path.
No!
I lost you.
I'm making a peepee tower.
I'm making a peepee tower right now.
Oh, I see you.
Look up!
Don't keep going.
Wait for me.
Okay, just follow.
I'm gonna put red blocks.
Follow the red block road.
I gotta eat my bread.
I'm eating my bread.
Say thank you to super chat.
I placed all my very important belongings back home.
For some reason.
Yeah, I thought we would go back.
Silly me.
We were never coming back.
We had several blocks of lapis.
And we also had...
But it's okay.
We had to farm other stuff anyway.
We had to farm the wool.
We had to farm chicken.
We had to get bookshelves.
And it's okay.
It's okay.
That was part of the plan.
Is there anything else you want to add, Mint?
Is there anything else about my mistake?
I just want to say, there's no point in putting things in a chest if we just delete everything when we die.
I thought we were coming back.
I legitimately thought we were going to come back.
That it wouldn't take us 20 fucking years to get to a fortress.
I legitimately thought that we were more competent than that.
Defining a stupid fucking fortress.
It's so easy to get to the fortress.
It's so easy to find a fortress.
But don't silly me.
It wasn't easy.
It wasn't easy at all.
I think we just hit the negative luck with the fortress.
Just keep running.
It's gonna be night time, but that's okay.
Sakura!
The cherry blossom trees.
Wow.
We don't need it.
It's not part of the speedrun.
Wait, oh my gosh.
There's another portal.
Broke another portal.
But it would be closer.
We're not gacha rolling 200 rolls.
I am not doing that again.
We don't have to.
We just have to find the original.
With all the ghasts.
Get out of here, sheep.
Get out of here.
How about you go to the nether and I'll stay out here in the overworld?
What?
This is a team.
What are you trying to split us up for?
Are we going the right way?
Oh my god, I just fell.
Hold on.
I just fell.
Oh, I'm okay.
No, I'm not okay.
I'm okay.
I think I'm okay.
Okay, because I'm heading straight.
I'm still... I'll wait for you here.
No, I'm right behind you.
All right, I'm gonna get the coordinates out of my screen.
And I'm gonna head this way.
It's still the right way.
It's northeast.
I haven't stopped moving northeast.
We haven't stopped moving northeast.
Why does my screen do that?
We haven't stopped moving northeast, so like it's gonna be the right way.
I fell into water.
It's fine, guys.
I never thought I'd catch a stream that started at 5 a.m.
Oh my god, you got the spiders coming after us?
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm going northeast.
There's the drowns.
I'm going in the water.
That's my dog because I didn't get hit yet.
Okay, now the dog's gonna do something.
There he goes.
Go, dog.
Go.
I'm stuck in the fucking dirt now.
That's fine.
My dog will be okay.
Where are you?
Come on.
Oh, there's my dog.
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
What?
There's a hole here.
Did you kill your dog?
No, there's a hole here.
My dog's gonna be fine.
I'm just making sure.
Okay, I'm gonna check the coordinates.
Phantom, phantom, don't go.
Phantom.
Phantom, come from the sky.
I call thee.
I don't think he's coming down from the sky.
I thought I heard a creeper.
I'm heading...
Oh, there's so many chickens.
Oh, jeez.
And spitter.
Okay, all right.
Going northeast.
There's more chickens here.
I'm gonna make sure we're heading the right way.
Watch out for this.
Oh my god.
Ouch.
That's fine.
Get killed, skelly man.
Okay, it's this way.
Okay, I'm coming.
We're going.
Eating real quick.
Eating my... Me too, me too, me too.
Oh my god, my last bread.
It's my last bread.
All right, here we go.
To the moon we go.
Oh my god, it's my last bread.
Here, here, I'll make more.
No, it's okay.
I have lamb.
We can make some in the morning.
All right.
Where are the phantoms?
I don't know.
I think it's because I killed them, so they stopped spawning for a bit.
Oh, maybe.
We just can't sleep for days and days and days.
It just makes this let this play through longer, because we can't sleep.
Just everything goes by longer.
Oh my god.
Where is it?
Oh, there's a village.
There's a village.
We can see there's bookshelves.
Bookshelves.
Kill.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
I just want to get rid of... Whoops.
I have... He's okay.
I gave him bone and he doesn't want it.
Yeah, because he's injured.
No, if you give him bone, you should... He can like heal himself.
Oh, feed me?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh, there we go.
I interrupted something really personal.
Okay.
All right.
I want to see this zombie break down the door.
That's messed up.
Bookshelves!
Wow!
What?
What happened?
He didn't do shit!
Wow!
I literally let this guy... Does it just need books?
How do I farm bookshelves?
Yeah, it's fine.
I'm fine.
Stupid zombo!
Up here?
Didn't do anything.
There's bookshelves right here.
Wait, do I need like... Okay, so to get bookshelves, we need silk touch to make it so that they break as bookshelves.
Otherwise, they break as books.
Okay.
And then we need... Then we need... That doesn't give us as many books.
Yeah.
So in the end... Yeah.
In the end, we just have to get the books.
Alright, let's just farm the books.
It's fine.
Just farm the books.
Who cares?
Yeah.
Oh, my dog woke him in.
Oh, that's the thing you need to read.
That's what you can do to read the... What do you mean you fucked it up?
You just already... Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
I got the books.
I got books.
Oh, I got the books.
We got the books.
How many books do we need?
A lot of books.
We need a whole ton of books.
Let's just... Let's just raid these villages.
Oh, and there's... And there's hay.
Let's go!
There's a lot of bread in this one, but I have no room.
You need the food anyway.
Oh, lots of potatoes.
Lots of apples.
Are there any more books?
Is there any more books?
Any more books for us?
We're... We're gonna grab the books.
We're gonna rob you.
We need it more than you.
What you gonna do with all these books?
There's another... There's another potion.
There's... There's a potion thing right here.
Do we need it?
Uh, yeah.
Just grab it if you have room.
Okay, let me see what I have.
Yeah, I do.
I do.
I'm gonna grab it.
Get in here.
Get in my... Get in my pocket.
Alright, are you ready to go?
Oh.
Oh my god.
This guy has four zombos and a little baby on a chicken attacking him.
I'm not dealing with that.
That's not my job.
I was gonna lead him to the...
That's fine.
To the golem, but...
I need the levels anyway.
I need the... Oh, let's go!
Let's go!
Okay.
Which way?
This way.
This way?
It's always northeast.
It's always northeast and we never change direction.
Never change.
We are one directional girls.
We got books.
We got fetters.
We got... We got everything we need.
We got ambition.
We have strength and determination.
Oh my
god.
Look at all these pigs.
We keep moving forward.
We keep... We're... We keep moving forward.
Well, we're just... Look at all these chickens on our way.
Look, we're... We're killing time.
We're... We're... Oh my god.
No!
My dog!
No, he's alive.
He's alive.
Watch out for the other one though.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Where are you?
I'm right behind you.
I need meat though.
Is my dog okay?
Okay, I need to give him more meat soon.
Oh, shit.
I can also get another dog.
Get another dog.
That's fine.
So if the other one dies, at least I have this one.
The dog army.
We got it.
It's at this point.
This is the only way.
Is this though?
Oh, breaking the... Oh, it gives all three books that went into the crafting.
Let's go!
Oh, okay.
Good, good, good.
That's good.
It's just... It's just the planks.
It's just whatever the wood...
It's fine.
We don't...
We're surrounded by trees.
It's fine.
Yeah, we're surrounded by trees.
We're not in the nether.
We can get everything we need.
We're... We're practically winning at this point.
I wish we had Elytras.
I wish we could just fly.
I wish we could just fly, and then all our worries will disappear.
And then everything we've all worried about would just...
Oh, phantom!
Phantom, phantom!
Oh my God, who is it for?
I think it's me.
It's you.
I heard you yawning.
It did hear me yawning, actually.
I think it's gonna go soon, so we have to kill it quick.
What took you so long?
Oh, no, no, it's good.
It's good.
He'll burn.
Okay, he'll burn.
Yeah.
Just let him die.
Come on.
Burn.
Come on!
Give me your membranes!
He didn't give you membrane.
We tried.
We tried our best.
It's 7000!
Oh my God, 7000!
Look at us go!
We have to kill it ourselves.
Oh.
Well, now we know.
Now we know.
Look at that.
Get that gamer subs in you, Mint.
Get that gamer subs.
We're so close.
Mint, we're so close, Mint.
We are so close.
We're not.
We're not even.
We are.
Like, we nearly...
We nearly need to get our lapis, and then it's like we just speedrun to the end.
Like, and then we're there.
And then we're there.
The moment we, like, get to the area, we have...
We have to kill the dragon.
We have nothing to kill it with.
What do you mean?
What do you mean we have nothing?
We have so many things.
What do you mean?
We need the phantom membranes.
We will get the phantom membranes as we travel!
That's what traveling is for!
We only have one.
What do you mean?
How many phantom membranes do we need?
How many do we need?
We need a lot of slow falling.
I don't know.
Actually...
Do we have redstone?
Oh my god.
We might need to grab... Well, some... It will make the potions last longer.
We have to go back to the...
You literally told me...
We threw away all our redstone because somebody...
Somebody...
We only need a little bit.
We don't need a lot.
Somebody was saying...
We don't need them.
All I was thinking of was...
Back to the mines we go, I guess.
Back to the mines we go.
Yeah, probably.
Why don't you go back to the mines?
You go back to the mines while...
You want me to do it?
You want me to go back?
We'll do it together.
We'll...
We'll work together to grab...
Grab the redstone.
Alright.
What does that mean?
Someone just said...
You guys are on a paper server.
Will things respawn more slowly?
Wait, what things spawn...
Doki, why did you choose a paper server?
I don't know what server we needed!
Does it really matter?
Does it really matter that things spawn in slowly?
Does it...
It's just the phantoms.
It literally is just the phantoms.
But those...
We need a lot of slow falling potions.
Oh my God.
Can you change it?
I can change.
I think I can swap it, but I don't know if we keep the thing.
Wait, the Z is going up.
There's a mountain.
There is a mountain.
I'm trying to place my blocks here.
Did you know about the paper thing?
Did you know about it?
No.
Exactly, so even if you made the server...
Why are people telling us this at like...
10 hours into the game?
Even if you made that server, we will never...
They should have been like...
Paper was the default.
When we first started the game, they should have been like...
Hey, by the way, things are gonna spawn a little more slowly...
Because you choose this.
Okay, we'll just redo it.
Since we're not very far in.
But now that we're 10 hours into the stream...
It's okay.
Everything will be fine.
We'll just keep going northeast.
Just keep going.
We have not encountered anything bad yet.
Nothing bad has happened.
We just keep going northeast.
Nothing bad has happened so far.
Just keep...
Stop saying that.
You're scaring me.
Stop it.
Stop saying it.
There's another dog.
You want another pet?
Oh, I'm at the top of the mountain.
Okay, I don't need it.
We'll find more.
We have 10,000 more blocks to go.
I'm pretty sure we'll find another dog by then.
I'm pretty sure.
I wish I had some bones.
I told you.
I told you about keeping the bones.
You're like, Doki, get rid of the bones.
I was like, don't.
It's gonna be useful, I swear to God.
We're gonna need it.
And I was right.
Are you done?
No.
Are you even following me?
I don't even think you're following me anymore.
I'm like in my own world.
I don't think you're even following me anymore.
I don't think... I think we've lost each other.
I think we've lost each other.
But we're gonna be...
We're going the same way, right?
We're going the same way.
Yeah, but I'm in like the snowy area.
I have not seen a single snow area.
I have...
I don't know what you're talking about.
There has been...
Oh, I'm going up a little on the Z.
But there... I'm in the snow.
I'm scared of the powdered snow.
There has not been snow at all.
Mine is going down.
I'm going correctly northeast.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
I...
I don't know.
There's a village.
I'm at a village.
I am at a village.
Yep, I am at a regular village.
I am here.
One of us went the wrong way.
No, mine is going down.
One of us is...
You missed the village.
Well, you can hang out at the village.
Somebody is trying to get books now.
Somebody is trying to get books for us.
I'm trying to get to our home.
I like how you call it our home.
When it's just...
We have no home.
I just want to drop down.
Okay, now I found the snow.
Now I know where you're at.
You're way behind me though.
No, no, no.
I know exactly where you're at.
You're in the mountain behind me.
What?
There's snow here.
I see a giant mountain filled with snow.
I passed the mountain.
Wait, there's several mountains.
Wait a minute.
How many mountains?
What is your coordinate?
Negative 10,000.
Where are you?
Negative 9,500.
You went through there.
You're behind me.
You're behind me in that past mountain.
That's where you are.
Do you want me to wait for you?
No, no.
Just keep going.
We're both going the same path.
We're going the same path.
We're going the same path anyways.
It doesn't really matter.
We're just gonna meet up.
I'm at negative 9,000 now.
By the time we get there, we'll have all our materials.
We'll have everything we ever wanted.
I don't think I'm strong enough.
We'll have everything we want.
This is why those other streamers have so many subscribers.
I'm not strong enough.
We'll have...
Just think about how good it's gonna feel.
Just think about that.
What if we die?
Don't say that.
What if we die to the dragon?
Please don't say that.
We want...
Don't say that.
I'm tired.
We have to go to sleep.
We already invested so much time.
What if we wake up and then we play more tomorrow?
We wake up in the morning.
We're gonna be sleeping for a very long time.
I can't sleep for a long time.
I have a flight to catch.
Then it'll make the sleeping so much more worth it.
When we beat the ender dragon, it'll make it so much more worth it.
Just think about how good it's gonna feel.
Just don't.
I'm gonna need this.
I'm gonna need this just in case I fall into snow.
Powdered snow.
Watch out for powdered snow.
Make sure you have an empty bucket.
Okay, nevermind.
You can fall in for a...
Get a whole face full of snow.
I'm in.
This is how I might die.
What are you talking about?
The powdered snow.
This might be it.
You don't have a bucket?
No, I don't.
I gave you all my iron.
Okay,
I'll wait for you.
No, I'm not close.
What are you at?
Get up, man.
I'm so cold.
Where are you at?
Tell me your coordinates.
I'm at negative 9,706,639.
Oh, you're like further on the Z than me.
Oh, yeah, I went to the Z.
I focused on the Z.
I'm focusing on the Z.
I might actually be able to find you.
Are you on the ice?
I'm on the ice area.
Just farming.
You're farming?
No, no, no.
I'm getting up on the...
I'm gonna get up on the trees.
I'm getting up on the trees.
Why?
So I can not die from snow!
What do you mean why?
No, you're fine.
It's not all snow.
There's a lot of snow.
I'm making a PP tower.
I'm just going through the snow.
I'm traveling through the snow right now.
I'm protecting myself for the night.
In case a phantom comes through.
I'm just making a bridge.
I'm just gonna make a bridge.
I'm gonna make a bridge.
If a phantom hits me, then GG's.
Where are you?
Come to 9152.
I'm just gonna make a bridge.
I'm just gonna make the bridge.
I'm just gonna make the bridge and head straight.
I'm just gonna head straight.
Wait, what's your Z?
6653.
Okay, I'm close.
You're gonna see me.
I'm a bridge.
I'm basically a bridge.
You're gonna see me.
I'm up here.
Come on.
I don't know.
I'm making bridges.
I'm not looking at anything else.
Sky bridge.
It's the real strength.
I'm making a sky bridge right now.
Yeah, sky bridge lives.
It lives on.
I'm at 9630.
Okay, I'm 500 blocks.
Okay, just look up in the sky.
You'll see the speed bridge.
I don't know if it's a speed bridge.
I think that is a little bit.
Just look up and you'll find the bridge.
Oh my gosh, I just got peach over.
If I fall, it's over.
I just need you to know that.
How tall did you go?
I went up the tree and...
Holy shit!
It's so over.
What happened?
Did you die?
If I fall, it's over.
If I get hit by the phantom, it's over.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, don't do it.
Don't do it.
It's too late.
The sky bridge is dangerous.
I have to push my dogs down.
If I want to live.
The phantoms are gonna knock you off.
The phantoms are gonna come.
The phantoms.
I have a boat.
Let's go.
Use your boat.
I built a little platform.
If I fall, I might...
I'll take some damage.
Goodbye boat.
Goodbye.
What do you mean goodbye boat?
I can make another boat.
It's fine.
Oh my God.
I have a skelly shooting at me.
How did he see me?
I'm gonna make another boat right now.
Just in case.
Freak.
Don't look at my house.
It's my sky house.
What do I have?
Okay, there you go.
I'm waiting to see you.
I don't know, man.
I'm 9500 right now.
It's because you're going so slow.
Because of your sky bridge.
Okay, I fucking...
I have more Zs.
What's your Zs?
Wait, it's this way.
It is at... Oh my God, there's a creeper right here.
Okay.
It is at 6680.
Okay, I'm at 6665.
So, if you just keep going...
Towards the positive X...
And you don't move much of the Z...
Then we'll run into each other.
Okay.
Well, you're gonna see.
Please, people, if you are trying to endurance this stream with us...
Do not do that.
If you need to sleep...
If you need to...
It's gonna be a while.
It's gonna be a while, guys.
You do not have to stay up with us.
Please do not.
We're still going.
We're still here.
It's fine.
I am 9300.
Someone said this was gonna...
They thought this was gonna be a quick watch.
Yeah, we thought so too.
It took us 30 years to find the fortress.
3 hours...
4 hours was stuck in the nether.
I think we had 4 hours of nether time.
Literally, 4 hours was just in the nether.
In hell.
Maybe we should start whispering for people who are going to sleep.
No.
Goodnight, everybody.
I'm at 9200.
Where are you?
9151.
Okay.
I should see you soon.
Unless you're higher in the sky than I am.
6500 is my other...
6500...
Oh, I might be a little off.
What's your Z again?
6665.
Okay.
I need to go this way.
Okay, we'll bump into each other.
Okay, I'll meet you there.
I'm on my boat.
I got off my boat.
Oh my god.
I can't move because skellies are targeting me.
There has been no skellies on my end.
I'm not as high as you.
I think.
No, I'm just in the ice.
No, dog.
Wait, I thought you were...
I thought you were in the air.
No, I fucking made a boat.
I lost my boat.
My dog got on the boat and I lost the boat.
What?
I lost my boat that I made.
Oh, you're on the ground now.
Yeah, I'm on the ground.
Where are you?
I'm in the sky.
I made a peepee tower.
I've been waiting in the peepee tower.
Okay, this is a little awkward because I am definitely not there anymore.
Wait, come over here.
I was looking at the sky for you.
I told you I got in the boat.
I'm in the sky.
No, why would I...
Why?
Okay, why would I do that?
Because if you fall, then you wouldn't take damage in the boat.
I've used the boat to fall.
We literally did that all through the desert.
I used the boat to fall off.
And then head...
I was in the ground.
I used the boat to fall off.
Okay, I'm gonna jump for it then.
And I'm gonna swim your way.
Okay, negative 9,041 and 6,581.
Oh, God.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I made it.
What happened?
You fell off.
I thought you were on your boat.
What happened?
I don't have a boat.
I'm gonna keep going.
No, wait for me.
I waited for you.
I don't have a boat.
I'm slow in the water.
Don't you have wood?
We had so many wood.
What?
What happened to the wood?
I guess I can make one.
I'm at negative 9,045.
Okay, I don't care anymore.
If you're not waiting for me, I don't care anymore.
I didn't say...
Oh, my God.
I have phantoms.
I hope you're happy.
I got the phantoms for you.
They're looking at me.
Good thing you didn't get them while you were...
high up in the air.
Whatever the hell you were.
And there's zombies!
Oh, my God.
I think one of my dogs is gonna die.
My solo journey.
Not by choice, though.
I think that's a signal of a new day.
Whenever my shaders do that.
You're funky.
Oh, my God.
Sorry, doggos.
I don't have meat for you yet.
Oh, my God.
Where are they?
Get down!
I'm gonna use my bow.
She's gonna use her bow.
I did it.
I used my bow.
I couldn't.
I cannot deal with this anymore.
No.
I think this one gives me a membrane.
I think only one of them gives you a membrane.
Oh, my God.
Leave me alone.
Wait, I have two more?
Oh, my God.
Please, leave me alone.
I don't care about your child.
What happened?
It burned to death.
Oh, bad luck.
Oh, my God.
No, baby.
Okay,
I'm okay.
Oh, my God.
It burned to death.
It's fine.
Why do all of these polar bears have babies?
I don't know.
Four, six, eight.
Okay, I have enough for a furnace.
I'm gonna make a furnace.
I'm waiting for you.
I'm waiting for you right here.
I'm making a furnace right now.
And then I'm gonna...
I told you my thing.
Don't worry.
Let me put stuff in here.
Oh, my God.
Please drown.
Please, please, please.
Leave me alone.
Do dogs eat chicken?
I don't know.
I'm not talking to you.
Negative 9,000.
46 and 6,500.
Okay, they do.
I'm kind of way beyond you.
Okay, that's fine.
I'll just keep going.
I'm just gonna keep going.
I only have 4,000 blocks left.
Oh, you do?
Okay.
How about you?
Alright.
Oh, raw meat is fine?
Fuck, I don't need to cook this meat.
Oh, my God.
Okay, are they fully healed?
Okay, they are.
Alright, that's fine.
I'm in the ocean pool, everybody.
Advancement made?
Oh, shit!
They made a baby.
Okay.
Wait, can I have him?
No, he's my baby.
Oh.
You said I could have a dog.
You can find your own dog.
Okay, I'm finally like...
out of the ice.
I was gonna say there's no blocking, but I think I just hit a...
Yep, I just hit a block.
Wait, how long did it take?
How long did it take?
I don't know.
I'm at negative 8,500.
Okay, what about your Z?
5,260.
Wait for me, Doki!
Wait for me!
I tried waiting for you!
I stood still!
I waited for you!
I dealt with the phantoms while waiting for you!
Wait for me, Doki!
Wait for me!
I was like, okay, I'll wait for you.
Okay, I'll wait for you.
Come to my location.
No, it's fine.
Just keep going.
Just keep going at this point.
It's fine.
I found the biggest cave ever.
What if I just dropped him?
Where are we dropping, boys?
In this cave.
Okay.
I'm at 8,600.
But I'm still in ice.
I'm still in ice.
Go to the 5,000 Z then.
And you'll get into the regular land.
Alright.
I'm waiting with some cows.
Oh, you're gonna wait this time?
Yeah, I'm waiting.
No, just keep going.
It's fine.
We're all going to the same place anyway.
We're going to the same place.
I'm waiting.
Oh, I think I...
Oh, I hear a zombie.
How?
I think he's underneath me in the cave.
The giant cave.
I think I see...
Is that a pirate ship?
What?
Polar bear.
Yeah, avoid their babies.
Yeah, I fucking...
Swam into the polar bear.
That's your kind.
You wear the polar bear.
You wear the bear outfit.
I'm a grizzly bear.
We're different.
It's still a bear.
Oh, yeah?
Just because we're bears, we're all the same?
Yeah, bear bears.
We bear bears.
It's just propaganda.
Oh, I thought that was you, but it was a cow.
Oh my god, we're losing it.
We're actually losing it.
I'm at...
Wait, what are the numbers?
I'm at negative 8,000...
No, not that.
I'm talking about...
What is the OG?
Oh, negative 4,116.
1,576.
Negative what?
4,116.
I'm in the ice.
And the Z is 1,576.
We're just a couple thousands away.
I'm in the ice.
I thought it was over.
I thought the ice stuff was over.
I was there before ice.
I'm on land.
I might die.
I actually might die.
Why are you gonna die?
You're just on ice.
I'm in ice.
My dogs are dying in ice.
I'm sorry.
Goodbye, doggos.
They can die.
It's fine.
Just as long as you stay alive.
Goodbye, my fellow doggos.
Goodbye.
I hear them dying in the ice.
I'm sorry.
How are they in the ice?
How are you in the ice?
I'm sorry.
I didn't know.
Goodbye, my doggos.
I'm like two steps away from the ice.
Where are you?
What's your coordinate?
We're gonna see a doggo die in the ice.
We're gonna see it happen.
I don't have any more meat.
Why is he dying?
Because he's dying in the ice.
What does that mean?
Why don't you just move and they teleport?
Oh, the baby died.
Okay.
Why don't you just move and they teleport with you?
Because I was also trapped in the ice.
What do you want me to say?
Why are you trapped in the ice?
How are you trapped in the ice?
You just go around it.
It's already too late.
The baby's dead.
It's alright.
Oh wait, no.
He's alive.
Hello there.
See?
Everything's fine.
Come to my location.
What's your location?
I'm at negative 8,559.
5,265.
Alright.
Anyway, I'm at negative 8,300 now.
Oh, you're in the powered snow.
See, I told you you needed a bucket.
You took all my iron.
What did you want?
You gave me all your iron.
You took all my iron.
What did you want from me?
I'm not there.
I'm not going where you are.
I'm gone.
Just go.
Fine!
I was here!
I told you!
I told you.
Just go.
Fine, I'm going.
It's almost night time and I'm scared.
No, you're not.
Where's the baby?
There you go.
I'm trying to give the baby some meat right now.
The last meat that I have.
This is why you're not supposed to have animals.
You have no attachments.
I did not want them to breed!
They just got close to each other.
They got close to each other.
And they just want me to stop love?
That's why you neutered them!
You want me to stop love?
You have to cut off their bones.
Where's the doctors?
We've been in the wilds for 20 years.
Where can I go to the doctors?
You do it yourself.
This is how cavemen learn.
Did you do it yourself?
I don't have pets.
You have cats.
No, I'm talking about in Minecraft.
What was I going to say?
You don't see your cat as a pet?
No, they're family.
That's why you don't neuter family, I guess.
Yeah, don't neuter your family.
Oops, I accidentally reloaded.
That's not what I meant to do.
I'm moving.
Guys, if I could find...
If I could find wild animals right now...
Wild chickens or lambs or whatever...
I would!
But I'm stuck here.
In this ice tundra.
We're so close.
I'm just rowing my boat until the end.
Just heading northeast.
Just heading northeast until...
Until it's over.
No, I used all the rhymes.
That's why my boat has to end.
Why?
What happened?
The water ended.
I don't know where you are or where I am.
I don't know anymore.
I'm just rowing.
I'm just rowing until we made it there.
I wonder if we're even close.
We're close.
We're getting there.
We're almost there.
Then we'll have all our stuff.
Then we'll be able to continue the game.
Then we're basically at the end.
We're basically at the end at that point.
That's what happens.
Why did the connection reset?
What happened to our server?
What happened?
Go back.
I'm back in the ice.
Where am I?
I'm back.
Before the ice.
Back in the ice?
I'm back in the ice.
How did I get back here?
Did you lose anything?
No, I didn't.
I have to row back.
I'm just running.
I don't care anymore.
I think I lost my dogs.
We have to run.
Where am I?
We have to just go.
We just have to go.
Where did the dogs go?
It's fine, I can row again.
I can row again.
I actually lost the dogs.
I went the wrong way.
The dogs just disappeared.
Where did they go?
Where did the dogs go?
They're in a better place.
In Java Wonderland.
That's what happens when the Minecraft server...
Everybody goes to Java Wonderland.
I found a village.
I was in a delirious dream.
I was in a delirious dream because of...
frostbite or some shit.
I had frostbite.
You never had the dogs.
You were just pulling two rocks on a stick.
The frostbite got me.
The day restarted too though.
What happened?
Because we were about to hit night time.
What happened to the server?
What happened?
You need to get a refund.
The dogs were never real.
I was going through some fucking shit.
But you saw them too.
You saw the dogs with me.
What are you talking about?
What do you mean?
You literally had two rocks on a stick.
Or on a string.
No, they were real.
You were encouraging the dogs.
You had always just two rocks on a string.
And you were like, my dogs.
I was like, just leave them.
They are rocks.
I don't want to go in there.
The dogs were never real.
I might die in here.
They were never real.
They were just in my head.
Just a dream.
Just like this fever dream that we are experiencing right now.
They were never real.
When does it end?
When does the minecraft end?
It's gonna end.
I don't want to play minecraft anymore.
Just keep on moving.
The moment...
The moment we get to that area.
We are done.
We are almost to the end at that point.
We are literally like...
All our stuff to make it to the end is in that chest.
We have to kill the dragon.
We have everything we need.
We just need the phantom thing.
And then the redstone.
When we get there, we're gonna get to the redstone.
And then I'll farm the phantom.
You go get redstone.
I farm phantom.
And then it's all over.
And we're free.
And we'll be free.
There's zombies in here.
I'm in the scary woods.
I'm still in the snow.
Where the hell are you?
How are you still in the snow?
I don't know anymore.
I'm still there.
Oh my god.
Woah!
Lush biome.
Anyway.
And I got dirt.
I got dirt.
Uh oh, it's starting to get dark.
Oh man, why did they go by so fast?
Server, you were supposed to break!
What happened?
I feel like I've been running for years.
She took my dog.
I've been running for years.
And running and running and running for years.
Oh my god, there's another dog.
Get over here.
I knew you were real.
I got dogs!
I got the dogs.
I'm in the trees.
I'm a fucking monkey right now.
How do I get down from here?
Oh god, how do I get down from here?
I'm camping in the trees tonight.
Oh no, I can't see anything.
I can't see anything.
I can't see anything anymore.
Everything is so dark.
Use your torches.
I can't see anything.
Are you dead?
No, I just...
It's so dark.
It's so dark and cold.
What's your coordinates?
I'm just curious.
Give me a second, I need to go up this snowy mountain.
How did I make no progress?
I had 4000 left.
And now I'm at 4000 still.
How?
I don't know anymore.
I don't know.
Oh no, I'm out.
I'm out of the fucking...
Oh my god, I'm finally out.
I'm finally out of this godforsaken night.
I'm just gonna sleep through this night, okay?
No, you cannot sleep through the night because...
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
I'm trapped.
I'm trapped in the trees.
I can't see.
Where's my torch?
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, it's this way.
It's this way, alright.
Alright, I can't see much.
But I know I'm going the right way.
I know I'm going...
I'm at 7,833.
4,060.
Oh, okay, you're further than me.
Wait, where are you?
7,995.
4,281.
Okay, your Z is further though.
Yeah, you have more Zs.
I'm at...
Oh my god, the night is lighting the pathway for me so I can't see shit.
Phantom, please.
Phantom, where the fuck are the...
I'm like trapped in the trees, you guys.
I don't know how to get down.
I don't want to be in the trees anymore.
I don't want to be a tree person.
Oh my god, that cow scared me.
I don't want to be in the trees.
I can't see anything.
It's so dark.
The things I do for a phantom.
I know, right?
Should we just sleep?
No, we're committed.
We gotta...
Oh my god, there's skellies in the trees.
How do we get around, you guys?
Burn it, burn it down.
I might die too.
Just burn everything down.
Phantom!
I have a phantom!
Nice!
Everything is going well!
I have two of them!
I hit them, I think.
Where are you?
There's a dog, there's a dog.
Get over here.
I hit him, I hit him.
Come on, phantom!
Come here.
Alright, my dog died.
That's fine.
Oh my god, there's creepers and zombies coming after me.
Oh my god, there's a zombie coming.
What can I do?
Membrane!
We got two membranes!
How many membranes do we need?
A lot, I think.
How much is a lot?
Chat, how many membranes do we need?
I got another one!
I got two membranes!
Nice, nice, nice!
Four.
Wait, four per potion?
One membrane equals three potions.
Oh, okay.
Then we're good.
Yeah, we're good.
We already got what we needed and we're fine.
Oh no, I think we can get a little few more, right?
Because I have one as well, so we...
Yeah, but I think we can manage...
I think we can, you know...
Oh gosh, there's creepers everywhere.
Please leave me alone.
I'm stuck in the trees, Donkey!
I'm stuck in the trees!
I need to make my bread, but there's too many monsters.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I'm...
What's your coordinates?
Where are we at?
I haven't moved!
I'm stuck in the trees!
You are stuck in the trees.
I didn't know when you said you were stuck in the trees.
I didn't realize you were stuck, stuck in the trees.
I'm stuck, stuck in the trees!
Alright.
This is so stupid.
We have feathers, we have chicken.
Nice.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna keep running.
I'm gonna keep running, too.
Run!
I'm at...
I'm almost done.
I'm at 47,493,4200.
We're at 3,000 C's away and 3,000 X's away!
Okay!
Oh my god, it's so close.
We're running, running, running, running.
We're so close.
Oh, that was a sheep.
Don't scare me, sheep.
I almost tried to kill you.
Okay.
Can I just get some water, please?
Like, that I can...
Oh my god, this is a bad area.
When it's daytime, I can fucking...
I'll be able to...
I'll be able to make more...
Make more bread.
I just need it to be daytime.
We can sleep, probably.
Oh wait, the day is breaking.
The dawn is breaking.
Oh no, that's a village.
That's good, that's good.
Find some books.
They're on the other side.
I can't reach them.
Oh no, it's falling apart.
Just find a way.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'll try.
Oh god.
I'm just heading over.
Guys, what was the coordinates again?
What were the coordinates?
I don't think I can make it.
Phantom swoops again!
That's good, that's good.
Where is he?
Hello, Phantom?
Phantom, where are you?
Oh, there he is.
He's stuck in the trees.
Idiot, Phantom.
Wait, I think...
Hold on, guys.
Hold on.
Phantom, where did he go?
What happened?
He bit me?
I don't know if you're gonna turn into one of them.
I am a phantom already.
I need to punch this.
The thing is spawning around me, but I need to kill him before...
Daybreak!
Oh no, daybreak is coming!
I need to kill him!
Thank god.
Don't hide there, you stupid idiot!
What do I not need?
I have so many... Oh my god, we don't need this.
Come on, come on.
Where is the wood I was punching?
Where is the wood?!
I almost had him.
Come on, come on, come on.
I can kill him!
You were fighting the phantoms on the cliff?
Yeah, I'm like...
I'm like...
In my own epic story time over here, okay?
Oh, he didn't give me one though.
He didn't give me a membrane.
Okay.
I can't, I can't move from here.
You told me to go to the village, I'm trying to get there!
I told you it was on the other side!
And you said go anyway!
I'm just going.
You said make it!
It's for your own good.
I can't see anything in night time.
Oh my god, please.
Get on there, okay.
Okay, I'm trying to get to the other side.
Okay.
Guys, oh, I don't think this is possible.
Sorry, just keep going.
Just keep going, just keep going.
I'm sorry village!
We'll raid you another time!
Yeah, I know there's a drowned you guys aside, I saw it.
I don't...
Hopefully he doesn't have a trident, or else I'm really...
Or else I'm doomed.
Oh my god, two thousand left for the X.
And two thousand left for three.
I can't believe we came from twelve thousand and ten thousand.
I can't...
I can't believe it.
I'm pretty far still though.
I didn't make much progress.
I'm at negative six thousand eight hundred.
We're at three thousand seven hundred.
Where are you?
Okay, I'm negative seven thousand five hundred.
Four thousand two hundred.
What do they mean?
What do the numbers mean?
I can't do this anymore.
We're so close!
We can't just stop at that moment!
Mint, yes you are!
Mint, I will drag you to the finish line!
Mint, I will drag you!
We're so close!
Mint, we're gonna do this!
We're gonna make it!
We'll have everything we need!
By the time we make it back, we'll have everything we need!
Mint,
you knew what we committed to!
You knew!
You knew the risk!
You could have suggested an earlier time!
I gave you a chance!
But you suggested so late!
I forgot!
I forgot how late it was!
You could have asked for an earlier time!
You knew how long it was gonna take in the end!
You knew this was the sacrifice we're gonna have to make!
We're almost there!
I'm at the sad file!
Remember the sad file!
Do you remember the sad file?
We can do this!
I believe in...
I'm almost there!
I'm almost there at the original!
And then when we meet up...
This isn't even the goal!
And we meet up, but we'll have everything we need!
We'll literally have everything we need!
When we get there!
That hurts so much!
I found the Mesa!
The original Mesa!
We're actually almost there!
I remembered this area!
Redstone is in the mineshaft, right?
Okay, it's time.
I'm going in.
I'm going into the Mesa mineshaft.
I have the warts, I have another warts.
Okay, I'm going into the Mesa mineshaft.
Do stuff while I'm, you know...
While you're traveling?
Yeah.
Oh my god, how many redstone?
I got redstone!
How many do we need?
Oh wait, is it redstone?
What's the one that makes the potions longer, you guys?
Oh my god.
Is it the glowstone or is it the redstone?
Wait, is it redstone or glowstone?
No, don't say that.
Redstone?
Okay.
Okay, I have a lot of...
What does the glowstone do?
The glowstone does something else.
Okay, I have...
I have eight.
Eight is enough.
Okay, I'm leaving.
I'm fucking leaving then.
We have...
Oh, more power.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, glowstone is for strength and then...
Redstone makes it last longer, the potions.
Okay.
I got... I got eight.
Eight is enough.
People are saying eight is enough.
That's good enough for me.
Okay.
I just passed by some jungles.
I'm almost there.
I'm actually almost there.
I'm in the mesa too.
We're in the mesa?
Oh, that's good!
Oh my god.
I gotta make the bread.
I almost forgot to make the bread.
Hey.
Bread.
I think that's mesa.
Isn't that?
I'm in the desert.
How come I can't make bread?
What do you mean?
Why you not let me make bread?
Turn the hay bales into actual hay.
Okay.
I made bread.
I didn't make bread.
Okay, I need to figure out my inventory.
My inventory is a mess and I'm trying to figure this out.
I'm gonna eat my last...
I'm gonna eat my last carrot.
I'm gonna start eating bread.
Oh my god, get your carbs in.
I'm getting my carbs in.
And then I'm gonna throw this away.
And then...
Okay.
I'm heading over.
I'm heading...
2954 for the Z.
And then negative 6000.
Wait, I'm walking the wrong way for X.
That's not good.
Alright, and then...
We're like probably so close to each other.
It probably is.
I found the original temple.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, we've been playing that same map for...
The temple just exploded.
Like, how?
What?
Wait, what?
The temple exploded next to me.
I wonder if something spawned in it.
And then it pressed the button.
Or the chunks loaded in.
And then it exploded.
Holy shit, that was freaky.
That was actually freaky.
Wait, are there bookshelves?
Oh my god, how did that happen?
Is that a peepee tower?
No, just kidding.
I didn't make any peepee towers here.
I made a peepee tower near the city.
That's the first village we went to.
Okay, nevermind.
I have to get around this.
I'll go this way.
Armadillo!
So cute!
I see the armadillos.
Man, I wish I had my three dogs.
Oh, could've used that, yeah.
What happened to them?
I don't know.
I guess I just didn't take my meds.
I guess that's it.
Oh, I found the original!
The...
The nether...
The nether gate.
Not that gate, but the other one.
The very first one we ever found.
Are you sure you're not confusing this with another server that we were on?
No.
I know what I saw.
I know exactly what I saw.
Okay.
I'll believe you.
I don't know anything anymore.
I just wanna sleep.
Okay.
The gamer says, I bet you we're gonna beat the ender dragon within two hours.
If you...
Within two hours?
The sun will be rising!
Within two hours, it's gonna be...
Trust me.
Within two hours, it's gonna...
We're gonna make it.
It's just...
We just get all the materials we need and we're there.
We're there.
If we don't make it, if it's not two hours, what do you owe me?
What are you gonna give me?
Then it'll be within three hours.
My calculations was just a little wrong.
Just a little bit wrong.
It was just...
It'll be within two to three hours.
How about that?
Two to three more hours.
Are you really gonna...
Are you really not gonna...
My stream title...
Make sure...
We're gonna be really stacked up.
We're gonna be so stacked up.
Guys, what do I need to do to make arrows again?
I have 15 feathers.
Oh, you need flint also.
Do you have flint?
No, you gotta get that in the...
What's it called?
In the...
In the mines.
In the gravel.
Oh my god, remember when we threw away all those gravel?
No, but we would have to mine...
We would have to place those gravels and then dig them.
It would be torture.
Just find some water.
Remember when we had all those gravels?
Yeah.
I had so much gravel.
What were we gonna do?
Just take stacks and stacks and stacks of gravel?
Yeah.
Yeah, that's what we were gonna do.
What else were we gonna do?
Just trade from the...
How do we get a Fletcher Villager?
How?
I have a Fletcher Villager.
I'm at a village right now.
I gotta trade some arrows right now.
Hold on, let me see.
Wait, the Fletcher is the map guy, right?
I don't fucking know.
I was just reading my chat.
The Fletching Table.
No?
What's the Fletching Table?
I don't fucking know.
Oh, I know what it looks like.
What's this guy do?
What do you have?
Oh, you're a cartographer.
Yeah, that's the guy that makes maps.
I'm starting to get a headache, man.
Why are there two cartographers?
Okay, I'm leaving this village.
You can make a Fletcher thing.
What do I need?
I don't know.
What do they need?
I need to become a Fletcher.
Hold on.
I'm putting down the crafting table.
Oh my god, I'm actually almost there.
For real this time.
Oh, I need flint!
I need flint!
We always need flint.
I'm actually there.
I'm legitimately there.
I'm actually...
When do we get a middle point?
No, I can't get all my stuff.
I'm only a thousand away on each side.
Okay.
So we're both very, very close.
Yeah.
What's the plan when we get there?
What do we need to make first?
Sleep.
I think we should make the potions first.
Because I have all the stuff for the potions.
There's a village to my right?
Oh, there is!
Oh my god, what is in that village?
What is that?
Wait, we can sleep now, right?
We don't need the phantoms, right?
Oh, true, true, true.
Okay, no more.
Even if we need it, we'll just stay up again.
Let's just sleep.
Alright, we're very good at that.
Alright, I'm sleeping.
I'm sleeping.
Please sleep, oh my god.
Okay, I'm heading to the village next to me.
To see if there's more stuff I need.
I'm so tired, I didn't even put the boat in the water.
I put it on the land.
I thought it was water.
Okay, this is a village we haven't desecrated yet.
Oh my god, I'm at another village.
Wait, that was just one house.
Oh no, the other village...
Oh my god, the other houses are over there.
I was gonna say, how is there one house?
Wait, are we in the same village?
No, I don't see your name.
I don't know.
No, we've farmed this house.
But we might have missed some stuff.
Maybe?
I don't recognize this one.
I don't know either.
They all look the same.
I don't remember if they opened the door.
Or if I fucking harvested this house already.
Maybe they just opened these doors.
No, I definitely haven't been here before.
No, I haven't been here.
There's a brewing stand too.
Oh, there's raw meat.
Oh my god.
Why do you refrigerate that?
Is there books?
Where are the books?
Taking their emeralds because...
They have emeralds, they have apples.
We don't need any of those.
Taking their emeralds in case we need to trade.
For arrows.
Oh, books, books!
Get them, get them!
Grabbing hay.
Checking if there's books here.
Guys, I need to grab the hay first.
Before I think of anything else.
Do I need gas tears?
I don't remember.
I keep asking if I need gas tears.
Oh my god, what did I accidentally click?
What does the gas tear...
I'm getting rid of the golden chestplate.
I can't remember.
Where's the gas tear?
Obsidian can go.
Yeah, you're right.
Oh, regen.
Yeah, we want the gas tears.
We want the gas tears.
I got the gas tear on me then.
I have one.
Is this a library?
What's over here?
Oh, it is stonecutter.
Alright, time to go back to...
The coordinates!
Oh, there's a chicken.
Get over here.
I need your feather.
Get over here, I need your feather.
Big boss, help me.
Oh my god, we're so close.
We're so close.
Solidus, please.
Solidus, save me.
Solidus is...
Solidus.
We're so close.
Mint can do this.
I believe in Mint.
Mint, stay strong.
We just need three more hours.
Stay strong.
Stay strong for me.
I found a lot more books.
That's good, that's good, that's good.
Oh, there's...
This is a good village, actually.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm in the jungle.
The mighty jungle.
The lion sleeps tonight.
Is somebody sleeping?
Oh, me.
Just think about how great it's gonna feel when we beat the Ender Dragon.
I won't have any reflexes to beat the Ender Dragon.
No, just think about it.
You're gonna get that last lock-in moment right there.
Right now.
Okay guys, what's the chords again?
What are the chords?
What's the chords?
I'm fucking...
I lost track.
What if we get to the end?
And then do the Ender Dragon tomorrow?
Mint.
What if we did that?
It's gonna feel so good, Mint.
Just think about how good it's gonna feel.
I'm almost out of food.
I have food for you.
How are you out of food?
There's a village.
I took a melon slice.
Okay, okay.
That's good.
I'm drooling on myself.
I'm so tired.
Mint, I believe.
Mint.
Just...
Final stretch.
We're almost there.
We're almost there, Mint.
Mint, we're almost there.
Me too.
I'm almost too sleepy to end.
We're almost there, Mint.
Just stay strong.
Stay strong.
The coordinates are...
Negative four thousand...
I don't even know.
Negative four thousand something.
Negative four thousand one hundred and sixteen.
And one five seven six.
Yeah, oh.
Wait, you're there?
No, I'm literally like two hundred away.
Or four hundred away.
I'm a little ways, but...
I'm making my way.
Making my way downtown.
Walking back.
The past faces past.
Okay,
I am negative four thousand.
Okay.
Am I going the right way?
I am, okay.
Just running through the forest.
Oh my god, another village.
How many villages are you finding?
A lot, apparently.
Hey, you're finding all the villages.
Where were they before?
Wait, you're right.
Where were these villages before?
Where were these?
Where did they come from?
Where did they go?
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, I'm actually almost there.
I'm so close.
What was the Z, guys?
What was the Z?
What did I just pick up?
Did I just pick up another gold chestplate?
I think this is where you were at just now.
Oh yeah, you were where I was!
You're almost there.
I'm almost there?
Okay, I'm leaving.
You're almost there.
That's literally my chestplate.
Yeah.
You picked it up.
It's where I left.
There's nothing there.
I already harvested.
No, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
Oh my god.
I think I almost just fell in a hole.
Okay.
Alright.
1,600.
I found it!
It's in front of me!
I did it.
I found it.
We traveled so far.
It's over here.
I found the baby tower.
I found her home.
I actually found it.
Oh my god, there it is.
There's the water bucket.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Okay, what do we need?
What do we need, Mint?
What do we need?
I'm gonna put the stuff.
Putting potion stuff here.
And then, I'm gonna...
Wait, is there flint?
We have flint.
How much arrow per flint?
I think it's one.
Okay, arrow.
Am I going the right way, guys?
I'm going the right way.
I'm almost there.
I'm just a couple hundred away.
I have 37.
I have 37 arrows.
I'm putting the redstone dust.
I'm putting the redstone dust here.
And then...
What am I doing still?
Mint, stay strong.
Stay strong, Mint.
Stay strong.
Stay, Mint.
I believe in you.
Stay strong.
Okay, I have the wood.
Okay.
I have the wood.
Oh, I need to go this way.
I need to get out of the water.
I'm grabbing...
Where the fuck is the wood?
Wait, do we have enough wood?
I do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have wood.
Don't fall.
Alright.
I'm running.
Okay.
I have...
I got you, Mint.
You can do this.
We're at the finish line.
We have everything we need.
We literally have everything we need.
Did you make arrows already?
Yeah, yeah, I made 37 arrows.
That is more than enough.
That's not enough.
I have 20 spectral arrows.
How is that not enough?
How do we need more?
Oh my God.
We have to hit the things to be able to kill the dragon.
I can hit them.
I can hit it.
It's so easy.
I can hit it so easy.
How are you hitting the thing?
I don't know.
I can hit it.
You can?
Okay.
I can hit it.
I've done it before.
Okay.
This is a fancy village.
I'm gonna go to sleep now in real life.
No.
Just make it here.
Make it to the last destination.
The last goal.
Just make it here, man.
Make it here.
At least make it to the end.
Okay, I don't get it.
Go to sleep.
Alright.
Let's see.
I refreshed that person.
Arrow.
They're sleeping in their bed.
Okay, I have 45.
I have 45 arrows now.
Oh my god.
How do I make beds?
Okay.
Bed.
That's fine.
That's enough beds, I think.
I can make one more bed for attacking.
And then...
Let's see.
I don't need bone.
We don't need coal.
We...
don't need gold.
Let's see.
Okay, we have...
11 enders.
We have...
This is a strong potion.
Okay, I'm putting potion stuff in your chest right now.
You're the potions person.
I don't know how potions work.
I don't know how they work.
No, don't do it.
Don't do it.
Please let me do it.
I put all the potion things in your chest.
You have all the potion stuff.
I didn't touch anything.
You have all of them.
And then I'm giving you 12 books.
And...
Make...
Find obsidian.
We need to make the enchanting table.
Enchanting...
1, 2, 3...
I'm harvesting this nether portal.
We don't need it anymore.
I'm harvesting it.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, nether portal.
We never need you anymore.
We don't need you.
Okay, I'm a couple hundred away.
I'm on my way.
Goodbye, nether...
Goodbye.
We're never coming back.
Oh, we have 4 in the chest.
It's okay.
I needed to break that anyway.
We're never coming back here.
We're never coming back.
Do you want to try and do a...
A pillager raid?
So we can get a totem of undying.
That's a good idea.
I have an omnispanner.
How do we get the pillager?
I think it's the...
I think it's the potion we got.
The ominous?
Yeah.
The ominous bottle gives you...
What's happening?
Oh, it's raining.
That scared me.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh yeah, enchanting table.
I mean, we don't have to get it, but...
Okay.
Enchanting...
I got the table.
I see the PP tower.
You see it?
Where are you?
I don't see you.
I see you too.
Everything we need.
We have everything.
I bought you the enchant.
We have everything, man.
We're so close.
We have everything.
I have beds.
I have arrows.
We have all the potion stuff.
We have red dust.
Everything we need is right here.
It's right here.
We did it.
We traveled so far.
We got everything.
We have everything.
Should we make a new stream?
We should.
Are we committing to the end?
I mean...
I don't know anymore.
I don't know.
This is your choice, Mint.
You're past your bedtime.
Like, you know I'm a night owl.
I thought we were going to the end.
You wanna go to the end?
Are we doing it?
Are we doing it, Mint?
Are we doing it to the end?
My second win.
Let's make our Let's make our stream.
Mint, I believe it.
Mint, you can do this.
I believe it.
I am.
Okay.
I'm making my room too.
I don't know what to do anymore.
Mint, I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Oh, I can't fucking remake.
Oh, I can't use the same settings.
I have to I have to copy everything over again.
Me too.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I always make a new one anyway though.
I didn't realize you gotta end your stream to be able to copy it.
I thought you could copy existing stuff.
We have one We have one one life to make this happen.
Is it night time?
I don't know.
I'm making my room.
We'll hear the monsters if it is.
We'll hear the monsters.
I think we're okay.
Okay.
We're making our waiting room.
We're doing it.
We're making our waiting rooms.
Oh my god.
Why can't I at you?
I don't know.
I won't let you do it.
It's so stupid.
I hate that.
It bugs out sometimes too.
4.20 AM.
Okay.
I'm just...
I'm not even gonna change the tags or anything.
I'm not even gonna change the tags.
I'm just gonna put...
I'm gonna put...
Minecraft.
Alright guys.
I'm waiting to my next stream as well.
We'll see you.
We'll see you in the second room.
Bye bye.
I didn't even finish making my room yet.
I didn't.
Bye bye.
Okay.
Alright.
You got the bye bye in?
I haven't yet.
Alright.
I'm ending stream.
Bye bye.
Okay.
I'm making my waiting room.
I'm making my waiting room so my thing is still up.
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting for it to work.
Redirect.
Let me redirect.
Please let me redirect.
It doesn't...
It doesn't exist yet.
It doesn't exist.
What time?
I have my bed down.
Alright.
I'm waiting to my... I'll see you guys in the next one.
I'll see you guys on my next one.
I'll see you guys there.
See you guys there.
Okay.
I'm starting my next...